hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor exam pro bringing you another
complete study course and this time it's
the microsoft azure developer associate
also known as the az204 made available
to you on freecodecamp this course is
designed to help you pass and achieve
microsoft issued certification and the
way we're going to do that is by doing
lecture content follow alongs a practice
exam and have cheat sheets for the day
of the exam so you can prove on your
resume your linkedin you have that as
your knowledge you can go get that cloud
job or get that promotion and tell you a
bit about me i was previously the cto of
multiple ed tech companies 15 years
industry experience five years
specializing in cloud i'm a nativist
community hero and i've published many
many free courses just like this one i
love star trek and coconut water
and i just want to take a moment here to
thank viewers like you because it's you
that make these courses possible and the
best way to support more courses just
like this one is to purchase the
additional study materials at az204 so
you can get access to study notes flash
cards quizlets downloadable lecture
slides downloadable cheat sheets
practice exams ask questions get
learning support but if you sign up
right now for free you'll get a practice
exam and cheat sheet there's no credit
card required the free stuff does not
have a trial limit so you do not have to
worry about it vanishing it's not a demo
uh if you have if there are updates to
this course they'll be in the youtube
descriptions on free code camp so watch
out if there are corrections additions
modifications to make sure you're using
the latest version of this course and if
you want to keep up to date on upcoming
courses the best way to find that is on
twitter i'm at andrew brown on twitter
and if you do pass i love to hear uh you
know your success story um or what you'd
like to see next so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're at the start of our journey
asking the most important questions
first which is what is the azure
developer associate so it's a microsoft
certification about the azure platform
focused on multiple ways to deploy web
apps to azure a deep dive into azure
functions i mean seriously deep a broad
look into application integration
services which azure has a lot of
to the point where they have ones that
cover the same purpose and lots of
hands-on with azure cli sdks or
programmatic interactions with azure
services so anything to do with the
azure api the course code for the azure
developer is the ac204 not to be
confused with the 104 but it is very
complementary to the other course which
we'll talk about when we talk about the
roadmap and i do want to point out that
microsoft azure is a very code and
script driven uh platform compared to
aws and gcp so it's better having
developer knowledge and i actually
consider it a must when we're working
with microsoft and i'll explain why here
in a bit so who's the certification for
we'll consider the 204 if you are a web
app developer looking to pick up cloud
skills or transition to a cloud
developer role you are a cloud developer
cloud engineer who needs to integrate
azure services into your app or deploy
your app to azure or you need to learn a
lot about azure functions to build
service workloads but as a note i kind
of feel that this is an essential
certification at the associate level and
so looking at a roadmap i always suggest
people to start with the az900 which is
the fundamentals because it's going to
really
help you get not just introduced to
azure but also the test taking
experience because it is a much
difficult and different
experience than the other two providers
and generally from that we usually
recommend to go with the administrator
the 104 because that is a broad amount
of services and that is the most common
use case why people are on microsoft
azure because they're usually i.t dev
shops
but as a complimentary usually after
that i would recommend to go to the
developer the az204 because the nature
of azure is that a lot of the ui it like
is script driven so when you are in the
portal uh you have to touch script more
often than not or you might run into
features that simply do not exist in the
portal so you have to use scripting so
really to be a proficient pers person
working on azure you need developer
programming experience and so i always
pair these two together now where you
want to go after that is up to you a lot
of people like to go the solutions
architect or the devops engineer expert
there's a bunch of other
associates and i consider these kind of
like uh like mid-level specialties where
you can do those there's of course more
certifications than we're looking at
that is actually here
but you know these are the most general
ones here so you know hopefully that
gives you an idea that you should
probably take the developer after your
associate
and then after that you go wherever you
want in terms of difficulty the azure
developer associate is i would say two
times harder than the aws developer
associate and three times more difficult
than the gcp associate and i'm talking
about the exams not necessarily the
application
of being a developer in the platform but
just the fact that the way azure makes
their exams is they really want to test
for practical knowledge so it's not
about conceptual or strategic
information not to say that there isn't
those kind of questions on exam but it's
a huge focus on do you know how to
actually set things up and do you know
the nuances of them so you're going to
see a lot more labs than normal in my
courses for this particular study course
how long does it take to pass well it
depends on you but to give you a general
idea if you're a beginner so let's say
you had the az 900 but not much hands-on
experience you've never written code or
attack role then you're looking 50 hours
even if you've taken the easy to 104
it's still going to take this long
because it's a different uh different
beast than the 104. if you're
experienced so you already have
practical knowledge working on azure uh
you've deployed apps to azure you have a
strong background in programming you're
looking at 20 hours and so i like to uh
set a goal of somewhere in between so 30
hours average study time so for lectures
in lab that's going to uh take up 50 of
your time so you know we're looking at
it's probably more uh labs and lecture
and then the other part of it is 50
practice exams so i recommend you study
one to two hours for 20 days and really
do spread that out because if you do too
much of it together uh you have a a good
chance of
forgetting information so you know make
sure you spread that out and make sure
that it's it becomes part of your
long-term memory so where do you take
the example you can do it in person or
test center or online from the
convenience of your own home so
microsoft delivers exams via two
different uh providers psi online
pearson vue and those are online proctor
exam systems both of these providers
have their own test center networks so
whether you want the online experience
or in person it's just to be up to you i
strongly recommend if you can to go in
person it's less stressful if you have
the opportunity if you can't you have to
do your home it's up to you which one
you want to choose they're more or less
the same
i like
pearson vue but some people like psi so
it just depends if you take a couple
you'll decide which one you like and if
you're wondering what the word proctor
means it means there's a supervisor
somebody is monitoring you as you taste
taste uh take the exam to make sure
you're not cheating that's the whole
idea behind it to make sure these are
legitimate uh scores so what does it
take to pass example you're going to
have to watch video lecture memorize key
information you have to do hands-on labs
and follow along within your own account
you i would recommend paid exams to
simulate the real exam i'm going to help
you out by giving your first exam for
free no credit card required just sign
up on exam pro and um you know you can
go get access to that and other free
additional content that i strongly
recommend that you do
for the content outline we got five
domains each domain has its own
weighting that determines how many
questions in a domain will show up and
azure is interesting because they do a
range of questions so it's not a
guaranteed of a certain amount of
questions on exam it's going to be
between ranges so the first developer or
sorry develop azure compute solutions
develop azure storage implement azure
security monitor troubleshoot and
optimize azure solutions connect and
consume to azure services and
third-party services in terms of the
grading you've got to get about 70
percent to pass
and they use scaled scoring so
uh you know it's not always exactly on
the dot but you for the most part if you
get 70 percent you should pass in terms
of um amount of questions is between 40
to 60 you probably see 55 questions so
you can afford to get about 12 to 18
wrong some questions are worth more than
one point there's no penalty for wrong
questions some questions cannot be
skipped and for the formatted question
you've got multiple choice multiple
answer drag and drop hot area case
studies all sorts of kinds
of questions that you'll encounter much
more difficult than the az 900 for sure
in terms of the duration you get three
hours so that's about one minute per
question but of course different
question formats are going to be
different uh you have 180 minutes for
the exam time your seat time is 210. so
you have about um 30 minutes um in terms
of the whole time that you said schedule
so even if you have 180 minutes you have
to consider the entire time to get
logged in and all that other stuff so
time to review instructions reading
accept the nda complete the exam provide
feedback at the end and i'm telling you
if you're taking this online
show up early because so often you're
fiddling around with your license to try
to get to scan properly and then they
don't like it so you have to scan it
twice so you know if you can show up an
hour early and make sure you block that
time
this exam is valid for i believe two
years before recertification so you know
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and before we dive into azure functions
we need to understand what is serverless
so serverless architecture generally
describes fully managed cloud services
and i say generally because um you know
that definition of serverless can be
highly contested about what can be
serverless and what can not be
serverless so it's not a boolean answer
of yes or no but some services are more
uh serverless than others to a degree
and so you know the way to help you
understand serverless is the way i
define it is i look at the following
characteristics one thing for a
cloud service to be serverless is that
it should be highly elastic and scalable
highly available highly durable and
secure by default another thing is that
it abstracts away the underlying
infrastructure and are built based on
the execution of your business task so
you're not really worried about how many
cpus and things like that maybe they are
abstracted into like
virtual cpus or
away from what the original
hardware software is using the idea is
that it's a simpler value then the idea
is that serverless can scale to zero
meaning that when it's not in use you're
not paying for anything and the most
important thing is you're paying for
value so you do not pay for idle servers
and just to kind of reinforce that idea
that um
that uh it's a degree uh my friend
daniel who's really big in the service
loves to describe it as like the energy
rating system so the idea is that uh
when you go to buy an appliance such as
um you know a washer or dryer they'll
tell you how energy efficient it is and
that's kind of the idea behind
serverless services and uh you know
we're going to be talking about function
as a service but function of service
does not necessarily guarantee that it's
a serverless service but we'll talk
about that in the next slide okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about function as a
service also known as fast so here's
kind of a diagram that i like to use to
visualize it but we'll get to it in a
moment here so what is function as a
service it allows developers to focus on
just writing pieces of codes also known
as functions and it has event driven
integration trigger functions based on
event data or to emit event data so it's
not just a matter of having a piece of
function or code that you write in a box
but the fact that it has to be event
driven
generally multiple functions are
orchestrated together to create a
serverless application sometimes also
known as microservices functions
generally only only run when needed and
so function as a service is not
serverless on its own
so fast function as a service it's only
serverless if it's fully managed and it
scales to
zero just to take a closer look at this
graphic here so the idea is that if
we're talking about the underlying
infrastructure it's of course running on
some kind of physical server
and from there you'll have a host
operating system and then you it could
be a hypervisor
and then from there you could have a
virtual machine running a container
runtime like the docker daemon um or you
know it could be
there are some
os's that are optimized to run a
container runtime without a hypervisor
but the important part is the idea is
that you're just deploying these little
pieces of functions and they generally
will go into a container so you might
have a
container runtime
that is specifically configured for
ruby or it might be configured for java
or python or net and then the idea is
that you're dropping that code and that
code's getting
scheduled into that container
but hopefully that gives you kind of the
general idea of what function as a
service is
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure
functions and this is a function as a
service fast offering that allows
developers to focus on writing code and
not worry about maintaining the
underlying computing infrastructure and
so here is our
visualization so we can kind of break
down the anatomy of how azure functions
work so the first thing you'll need is
an function app and this defines the
underlying compute for a collection of
functions so a function act defines the
hosting runtime and global
configurations then you have the
functions themselves these represent
code along with application runtime
configuration so the idea is you can say
i want this to be a python function a
net function
etc etc there's always going to be a
trigger so a trigger is the chosen event
data that will cause
the function to execute and you can only
have one trigger
you have input bindings these are one or
more multiple data sources that will be
passed to the function when a trigger
occurs so the idea is you can pull in
data from a variety of different azure
services at the time of trigger which is
uh quite nice
and then you have the output bindings
these are one or more data syncs that
will receive outputted data from the
function on successful execution they
say syncs you could say consumers if you
like
and also azure functions at least as of
today has four different versions you
really do want to just use the latest
version
there could be a version 5 out by now i
don't know
but you know just be aware that you're
always using the latest version but
in practicality you probably won't be
able to tell the difference between the
versions but just make sure you're using
the latest okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at storage
considerations for azure functions
because every function app requires a
storage account to operate and if that
account is deleted your functions are
just not going to work so kind of a
small visualization of your function app
linked to a storage account so azure
functions uses the following storage
types in the storage account it's going
to vary based on use case so for blob
storage it maintains binding state and
function keys for azure files file share
used to store and run function app code
in a consumption plan premium plan as
your files is set up by default but you
can create an app without azure files
under certain conditions for cue storage
this is used by task tubs in durable
functions we have a little section on
durable functions and then for table
storage used by task hubs and durable
functions as well so there you go
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at the
anatomy of a single azure function so
here is a screenshot of visual studio
code because this is where you're going
to be writing your functions you can
write them somewhere else i sure don't
know where but
they have really strong integrations
with visual studio code but the idea
here is that we have a
visual studio code plug-in installed
that allows us to
manage our remote functions and we have
local projects but let's take a look at
some of the files that are in here so we
can understand what kind of files matter
to our functions the first is
functions.json this is configuration of
a single function defining bindings and
we talk a lot about bindings uh in the
azure functions section of this course
there's the code itself in this case
it's a javascript file we have the func
ignore that's just like a git ignore
file but it's to ignore files like files
to be not packaged right so like
when it actually deploys the function
you don't want those files included but
you might use them in local development
we have host.json this is global
configuration of all functions at the
function app level
then there's the local project itself
this is just where the function is
stored locally and a lot of times you're
moving that code to uh to the remote
storage on azure and if we were just to
open that up you can kind of see the
same files being mirrored so we have the
name of the folder so host json function
json index etc local settings json
package json
things like that
so i'll just kind of erase a little bit
of this out of here but you get the idea
and it'll make a lot more sense when we
start
making functions which we absolutely do
in this course critical for the az204 so
but we'll do that
soon
[Music]
all right let's take a look at
authorization levels this determines
what key if any needs to be present when
making a request when a function is
getting invoked and the authorization
levels can be one of the following we
have nominus function and admin so
anonymous means that anybody can invoke
the function so if it's an
https request
in order to trigger it anybody can
trigger it
for function you'll need a specified api
key this is the default value when
you're creating your functions generally
recommended as the means to use or you
can have it so that it has to use a main
key
to be required yes it's called master
key i'm just going to use the word binky
and for integration if you're trying to
figure out how to
change the authorization levels after
you've deployed a function you're just
going to click on your https trigger and
from there you can switch the
authorization level now that's not
always the case there's some cases where
you're not able to change it via the
portal
um and that just has to do with you know
the type of runtime you're running
whether it's a custom run time
but yeah that's where you're going to do
it there and you can change it after the
fact after creation okay
[Music]
let's talk about how we would debug our
azure function well you have this
ability to turn on uh streaming logs and
this allows you to see near real-time
logging when errors occur and it's not
as simple as that because there are two
options for streaming a file log the
first is built-in logging stream
and so the idea is that you have the app
service platform lets you view a stream
of your application log files and then
there's live metrics stream so when your
function app is connected to application
insights you can view log data and other
metrics in near real time in the azure
portal using live metrics stream and log
streams can be viewed both in the portal
and in most
cases the local developer environments
such as visual studio code now when i
was doing this i was trying to turn it
on and i did not get any logs in near
real time but i think the reason why was
because the hosting that i had it backed
on wasn't on app service platform so i
think it really does matter where you
host it um and so you know maybe we'll
explore that in the follow along to see
if we can see your real-time logs
but yeah there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the key
concepts for azure functions these are
not exactly my words but i will uh
provide exceptions here as we describe
this stuff but the idea here is that we
want to get broader knowledge about
azure functions so azure functions are
lightweight and can be serverless and
they can be and this is only going to be
dependent on how you host them and we'll
talk about that in a moment azure
functions are easier to write and deploy
usually write deploy than
full web applications uh that can be
true the idea though is that you are
uh you might have to
do less
coding in some regards but then you
might have to do more in other places
like application integration so
i would say that it shifts the
responsibilities of what you have to
work on but you it is better i think
azure functions are fast execute because
there is no at large application startup
time initialization or other events
fired before the code is executed now
true that large applications there are
those downsides to them but the the
trade-off here is that if you're using
serverless functions then you will be
dealing with cold starts
um and so
cold starts just means that uh you know
when you're when you have a function
that hasn't been used in a while that's
going to have to boot up an environment
so
you know there is that trade-off
now in many cases you can
pre-warm or have continuously running
compute
but if you do that then you're not
necessarily leveraging serverless like
to be able to scale to zero but you know
you do get trade-offs azure functions
execution is triggered when an event is
fired that is true azure functions do
not need any infrastructure and it has
zero maintenance well they do have
infrastructure it's just that you don't
generally have to worry about the
infrastructure
in terms of azure's implementation of
functions you do have to think a little
bit more in general about the
infrastructure underneath as opposed to
google cloud or aws but at least you
have a lot of options on
azure and it has zero maintenance well
the infrastructure that's true but um
the your code itself you know if you're
using python 2 and microsoft says hey
we're going to expire or uh deprecate
the
python 2 runtime you have to use python
3 well then you're going to have to
upgrade that stuff so that is your
maintenance so there is management code
but
that's no different than any other
provider azure functions can be built
tested deployed in the azure portal
using a browser only if you're using
windows so uh if you are hosting on
linux there are definitely
lots of limitations in the azure portal
if you're using windows
then there's no problem in most cases
you should just use windows because
you're not going to be able to tell the
difference
in most cases
but if you want to take the full
advantage of being able to work in the
portal
absolutely use windows azure functions
are easy to upgrade and doesn't affect
other parts of the website again this is
subjective based on uh the code that you
have to upgrade right so
or functionality that they change so
you know generally it's true it can be
easier in isolate to update parts of
your application because they're all
little functions but there are
exceptions to that azure functions use
industry standard protocols probably
https here and communicate with other
apis databases and libraries that's true
you only pay while your functions are
running that is true if you use the
serverless model if you're continuously
running virtual machines behind the
scenes then you are going to be paying
all the time azure functions
automatically scale to meet the demand
of traffic that is true underneath azure
will provision more service containers
that is true azure function scale
scale to zero cost can depend on your
hosting azure function has built-in
monitoring via azure monitor which it
absolutely does and it can integrate or
has built-in ci cd via azure devops
which is very nice azure functions are
event driven and will be triggered based
on event data and emit event data
absolutely and if they didn't then it
wouldn't be functioned as a service but
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at use
cases both business and technical for
azure functions so for business use
cases you can use them for scheduled
tasks reminders and notifications
lightweight web apis sending background
emails running background backup tasks
doing back-end calculations there are
technical use cases such as sending
emails starting uh
starting a backup ordering processing
task scheduling database cleanup send
notifications messages iot data
processing so azure functions are best
suited for smaller apps that have events
that can work independently of other
websites originally i had some text in
here that said like azure functions were
not suited for large applications but
more of these menial
jobs around a larger application which
is not true you can build a whole
application out of functions
now whether that's easy to do with azure
functions is another story because it
has to do with cold starts and things
like that but
i i definitely think you can but this is
just kind of give you creative ideas of
how you can use azure functions outside
of the normal use case of just building
a web application so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at vs code
extension because this is going to be
the primary way that you are going to be
working with azure functions so in order
to productively work with azure
functions you'll need the visual studio
code
azure functions extension and so what
you'll do there is install that once
it's installed and you have an azure
icon
in your activity bar with the side bar
drawer you can look for functions i'm
going to get my pen tool out here so the
idea is you install this
and then now you have at the top here
the functions
tab so you can manage azure functions
it's possible to use azure portal to
create and update windows host hosted
azure functions but in practice it's not
an easy experience with linux it's
impossible
this is a very kind of different
experience compared to something like
aws or google cloud where you can do
basically
everything in the cloud
but with azure functions you really
really really rely on visual studio code
you can use visual studio for net and
c-sharp app functions i've never done it
myself but it is an option out there so
there you go
[Music]
let's talk about runtime so what is an
application runtime an application
runtime is a compute environment
configured with the necessary software
and system configuration to run a
specific type of application code so
here
uh if we were to create an azure
function we have some options and you
can see runtime stack so azure provides
multiple applications and runtimes for
popular programming languages just going
to highlight that out there because i
don't see my
my arrow but uh it has things for uh net
so that's c sharp java node.js that's
both javascript typescript
powershell core python there's my uh
there's my nice arrow there um
unfortunately does not have ruby at the
time of recording this i really would
like them to have it but if you want
something that's not there what you can
do is implement your own custom handler
i believe they have an example either
for rust or go in the documentation or
let's say you want to do ruby
that is something that's on the 204 exam
but in practice it's really really
really hard to get a working custom
handler and i say that by
i tried to make a ruby one it didn't
work i tried their tutorial it didn't
work i reached out to the person that
wrote the tutorial they couldn't get to
work i went to support they couldn't get
it to work so in theory custom handler
sounds great if you can figure it out um
so you know if there isn't a custom
handler uh follow along you'll know why
um but uh yeah that is an option on the
table the runtimes provided by microsoft
are just docker containers you can see
them on the docker hub um and you know a
lot of times you know containers and
functions are
strongly related because they're
generally almost always running on
containers okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at windows
versus linux hosting so when you create
an azure function app you can choose
either windows or linux as your host and
this actually it makes a big difference
based on the capabilities that are
available to you
and we're talking about things where
there could be performance differences
functionality limitations feature
differences but generally you know when
we're using microsoft it's always good
to attempt to use windows when possible
because their whole ecosystem is built
around windows and not so much linux
one example here
is that if you are using
a linux hosting for azure function apps
you cannot edit the function after it's
been deployed and that is a very major
inconvenience so just consider that
when deploying functions i usually can't
tell
much the difference between linux and
windows so i'll just choose windows so i
get that additional functionality if you
need to determine the exact os that is
being used what you can do is go to
docker hub repository because again all
these
uh all these images or
runtimes are stored on docker hub and
there we can see the windows images and
the linux images
and notice for linux there is a lot more
variation where windows is just the nano
server 1809 so that's the windows server
1809 whereas linux there's a little bit
more options and mostly debian but you
do have one down here that's ubuntu but
there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at templates
for azure functions so azure provides
function templates to get you started
with common functionality scenarios this
is going to happen when you first create
your function now you don't have to use
one but definitely this is the route
that you should want to go especially if
you're choosing http trigger which is
very common so
to choose the template you're going to
be doing that in visual studio code so
you don't do it in the portal but let's
just kind of walk through the templates
we have available so we have http so
triggered by http request and returns an
http request you have a timer so
triggered based on a schedule
blob storage triggered when files are
uploaded updated in a blob storage
container
cosmos db triggered when processing a
new modified cosmodb document
cue storage triggered by azure storage
queue messages
event grid so triggered by
event from event grid
so many azure services can be triggered
as a function through event grid
okay as we cover event grid in this
course
a lot of sources can be ingested into
event grid event grid is serverless
event bus integrated with azure service
as we do cover
at other parts intercourse uh event hub
so triggered by an event hub event so
this is for streaming service bus queues
are triggered by a bus queue this is
messaging service bus topics the
triggered by uh an event from a bus
topic so this is a pub sub model then
you have send grid so triggered by an
email event in a third party service
center if you ever send grid it's just
for sending out emails
and so there's a lot there does it set
up the bindings for you probably i never
really noticed or checked but i would
think that if you were to set one up for
blob storage you would get
the binding set up for you in your
function
json but we will
look actually next at function json
configuration because that is what is
next in the course
[Music]
so for every single function there is a
function configuration file called
function json and so there's the
structure there it defines the functions
triggers bindings and other
configuration settings when you choose a
template you're going to get some
default stuff there let's talk about
three main things under bindings so you
have the type of binding
which is just the name of the binding
which will affect the other attributes
that are underneath often that you'll
have a direction like in and out uh and
then there's the name and the name is
going to vary so for c sharp it's an
argument name for javascript it's the
key valued list but it's what is used to
bound data in the function
and we will definitely cover a lot about
bindings because bindings is super
important
but just so you know function
configuration file again is for trigger
bindings and other configuration
settings
[Music]
another file that you'll find in your
function is a hosts dot json and uh this
is for configuring global configuration
options for all functions within the
function app here is an example one uh
so
as extension for http you can see it has
a rope prefix things like that it's
setting a custom header and there is a
lot of stuff you can configure here for
options so we can do aggregators
application insights blob console
cosmodb extensions
and then you know http cues retry send
grid a whole host of things
and you know not super important for the
exam but definitely in practice you will
be
going this fall uh and configuring
things need be but there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at plan services for
azure functions and we have three to
choose from consumption function premium
and app service plan
very different very interesting uh
options for you to decide where you want
your compute to run and how your compute
to run for functions you do not see a
bus or google cloud doing that but the
flexibility here is very interesting so
the first is consumption plan and this
would be considered serverless and
because it's serverless
it can scale to zero and because it can
scale to zero that means that uh
generally we will have cold starts so
you only pay for the time your code or
application is running billing is based
on the number of executions and the
duration of each execution and the
amount of memory used just pay while you
have functions running and scale it
automatically even through
long loading times then you have premium
plan these are functions premium this is
where we have pre-warmed uh pre-warmed
compute underneath so the user has
designated a set of pre-warmed cases
which are already online and ready to
react instantly azure provides any
additional computing services that are
required when your function is running
you pay for the constantly pre-warmed
instances including any additional
instances needed to scale the azure app
in and out azure functions host
instances are added and removed based on
the number of incoming events so
um you know the idea there is that
you're not waiting for the container
runtime to spin up it's already running
but it's not going to scale to zero
and you know i mean you can still say
that it's serverless in some regard i
would consider that now being a fully
managed service but not necessarily
serverless
but you know that's debatable the last
here we have dedicated plan this is with
app service plan and this is where we're
doing vm sharing and this one is
extremely unique uh you do not see this
in any other cloud provider but
this is where when you use app service
for other apps your functions will run
on the same plan virtual machine at no
extra cost you may scale it out manually
by adding more virtual machine instances
for an app service plan you may also
have
auto scale enabled optional when you
have existing underutilized virtual
machines which also operate other
instances of the app service so i think
what happened was
um
people were using apps app service right
platform as a service and they just had
un under they weren't utilizing all of
the virtual machine compute and so a
customer must have said hey
can i just
take my functions and utilize or utilize
the unutilized
compute on my plan and that's azure's
like
sure and they made that a thing
so it's just like an interesting way to
save money but it is one of those things
where it is a little bit hard to
understand because it's not uh as
isolate or modular in terms of
functionality where we see other cloud
service providers but those are your
three plans so there you go
all right let's take a look at triggers
and bindings for azure functions we
talked about them before but let's give
them a little bit more attention so
triggers and bindings let you avoid
hard-coding access to other services and
abstracting away boilerplate code
keeping your functions lean
because the idea is that you won't have
to
add that code into your functions so
here is our graphic which represents a
function we have input bindings output
bindings we have a trigger there so what
is a trigger a trigger is a specific
type of event which causes the function
to run
it defines how a function is invoked and
a function must only have one trigger uh
triggers can have associated data which
is often provided as the payload of the
function and you know as we saw in the
introduction that we can have multiple
sources of inputs that that get added
there in this example here we have http
but we're bringing in data from
blob storage as well
and obviously the main trigger uh which
http is an input as well so you can have
additional inputs at the same time then
we'll take a look here is what is a
binding
um and so
my arrow's a little bit messed up but
the idea is binding is defined if your
function
is connected to another service so we
have input bindings and output bindings
so the data from bindings is provided to
functions as parameters bindings are
optional and a function can have
multiple input and output bindings
optional but often used
which we'll find out but let's take a
look at what supported bindings are in
the next video
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at what
supported bindings are available for
azure functions there's quite a few here
and we'll quickly go through them just
so you have a scope of idea so we have
blob storage azure cosmos db
um or cosmodb i always want to add that
s in there azure sql dapper which is
a
run time we cover it in the course it's
a runtime for
distributed applications for
microservices event grid event hub uh
http web hook that's gonna be the most
common one you'll use iot hub kafka
mobile apps notification hub that's for
push notifications queue storage
messaging rabbitmq that is an open
source um
viewing system sendgrid which is for
sending emails service bus which is both
queuing and pub sub signal r which we
don't really talk about much in this
course but it's an open source.net
library to send asynchronous
notifications to client-side web
applications table storage timer uh
twilio all right and so what's also
important to note and sorry i could not
make this graphic better i really really
did try
to present this better but it's just
there's so many here but um the idea is
that some don't support triggers so like
azure sql does not support triggers
mobile apps notifications don't table
storage and twilio does not then you can
see we have a big gap of inputs for
a bunch here and a bunch there
it's not super important to know for the
exam but the fact that that
you don't get triggers inputs and
outputs across all services and there
are some cases where the api version
matters so like if you are using
version one some things are not going to
be supported and even some cases version
two like mobile apps notifications don't
have
um uh don't have support so in some
cases you do have to use uh version one
functions
but most cases you'll be using version
four so hopefully that gives you kind of
a broad idea of supported bindings but
we're not done with bindings we'll be
looking at more of it okay
[Music]
let us talk about binding directions so
all triggers and bindings have a
direction property in the function json
file the direction of the triggers is
always in and the input output binds
either is in and or out and some
bindings support a special direction
called in out
which a little bit confusing but it's
nice to have a extra option this idea is
we have a direction and triggers again
are always in
and then you have in out and in and out
um the trigger is defined alongside the
input and output binding so trigger will
have the same as the input type but with
trigger appended so for example if we
have blob that would be our input
binding then we'd have blob trigger as
the trigger and that's how you would
know the difference right so again just
iterating see where it says
uh a type here if it was just http
then it would just be a
a binding but if it's a http trigger
then it's a trigger with a with also an
in binding
if you use the in and out
only the advanced editor is available
via the integrate tab in the portal just
so you know because there's a
visualization of integrations that we
see in the azure portal and so they're
talking about that in and out option
there okay
[Music]
okay so now what i want to do is just go
through a few scenarios of triggers and
bindings to help cement the idea of
their utility so we'll take a look at
our first scenario so every hour you
want to read a new log file delivered by
your application and you'll need to
transform the data to be ingested
in your nosql or sql database that
resides in cosmodb
so here is our visualization we have our
function which is python for fun
it's going to output the cosmodb so we
need a binding out to there
it has a
trigger um here that's just triggered by
an acp request to the timer and we got
the blob storage
so you use a trigger timer i guess
actually the http shouldn't even be
there i think that's just a mistake
but you use a trigger type timer because
it's a scheduled job that will run at a
specified time the trigger will be in
for the blob storage and out for cosmodb
because whenever function runs it'll be
on a timer and when it executes it'll
read data from blob storage process the
data from blob storage and then write
some data in cosmo db so the key thing
here is that this runs on a schedule
you're not you're not
even though it's there you're not uh
invoking it like with a an api request
this is invoked on schedule let's take a
look at scenario two every time someone
signs up to your application you want to
trigger an email so here there is an
http request coming in and it's going to
send out to sendgrid to send out that
email so you want to develop an api that
allows you to send an email after
request is received
and you'll use http trigger because it's
an api that will be triggered based on
this request for the bindings you uh you
won't be accessing any data well the
function starts so the in direction is
none
and you'll be uh you'll use send grid
for the out direction which allows you
to send messages via email looking at
our third scenario consider a scenario
in which you're using a cue service and
you want a function to process a storage
message in one queue and enter a new
message in another so the idea is you
have a queue again it's fun it's
triggering something and it's going to
output to something so in this case
you'll want to use um
into it says consider uh scenario q
service where you want to function the
storage message in one queue and enter
in another so probably
this this icon's old but we probably
should have this icon repeated twice
because this is the sendgrid logo so
just imagine that we have we took this
icon and we put it over here very sorry
for that uh graphical error but um the
idea here in this case you want a
trigger type of queue and a binding type
of cue for the direction out because
you're not accessing the queue in the in
direction you read the data from one
queue and process it to create a new
message and then to write to a different
queue which may or may not be connected
to another service or function so there
you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
bindingexpressions so in function json
file and the function parameters code
you can use binding expressions that
resolve to values from various sources
so most expressions are identified by
wrapping them in curly braces i say most
because there's an exception where you
do not use curly braces but the idea is
that
it allows you to have kind of dynamic
content within your functioned
json file and there are a variety of
different binding expressions we have
app settings trigger file name trigger
metadata json payloads
guid current date and time
let's go take a look at what those look
like the first is app settings so when
you want to change configuration based
on the environment you're going to use
percentage science this is the only case
where you use percentage signs
uh it's confusing because it's the first
example instead of curly so notice that
there's curly sorry percentage signs
there
um
and then for trigger file name this can
be used to change the path of a file
name works for both in and out
directions so here we have
the curly's here to say for the file
name
for trigger metadata many triggers
provide additional metadata values these
values can be used as input parameters
for c sharp f sharp or properties for
context bindings and objects in
javascript so for example if we're doing
azure queue storage sugar supports the
following properties q trigger dq
id etc etc
uh and then you'll notice that they are
available
here's the cq trigger is here q trigger
that's typed in camel case mode
for json payloads when a trigger payload
is json that means the the the data
being passes json you can refer to its
properties and configuration of other
bindings and the same function in the
code
so you know if the payload was blob name
and then hello helloworld.txt
do blob name and that would put that
here
okay um and
if some of your properties and your json
payloads are objects you can use the
dot notation so that's just a common
thing for json or
yeah json or javascript um for for if
you want a globally unique identifier
you can just do rand guid and you'll get
something that looks like that if you
want to have the current date and time
you do date time you're going to get the
current date and time in this format so
there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at local settings file
this is a file we saw uh when we were
looking at the anatomy
of the local files
and so the local settings file stores
app settings and settings used by your
local development tools this file is
called
local.settings.json is expected to be at
the root of your project folder because
the local settings json may contain
secrets such as connection strings you
should never store this in a remote
repository so make sure you add it to
your dot git ignore file here's an
example of one so first we have is
encrypted so when the setting is true
all values encrypted with the local
machine key
for values these are a collection of
application settings used when running a
project so notice we have function
worker runtime azure web storage uh or
job storage mybinding connections things
like that
the host customize the functions host
process when you run it locally
and then connection strings used only by
frameworks that typically get connected
strings from the connection
strings area there okay
okay so as your function core tools lets
you develop and test your functions on
your local computer from your command
prompt or terminal so it's a cli
uh and you type in func and allows you
to do a whole host of things so let's
take a look at the commands we have for
top level commands we have init so
create a new function project in a
specific language logs get the logs for
functions running in kubernetes cluster
new creates a new function in the
current project based on a template run
enables you to invoke functions directly
which is similar to running a function
using the test tab in the azure portal
start starts the local runtime host and
loads the function project in the
current folder deploy which was replaced
with function kubernetes deploy
then we have command groups
that contain their own set of sub
commands so we have
func azure so this is when you're
working with azure resources durable for
durable functions extensions for
managing extensions if you're doing
working with kubernetes
and azure functions you can do that if
you are messing with settings that you
do settings if it's with templates for
this available templates you can do that
so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about custom
handlers these are lightweight web
servers that receive events from
function hosts
and they can be written as long as it
supports http primitives and these are
really great in
situations where you want to have a run
time that is not supported for like a
language like go rust ruby
uh or a runtime environment for a
specific technology where you need a
bunch of libraries preloaded like ruby
on rails or deno
and so within your function
function json the idea here is you'll
have a custom handler section and this
is going to just basically define the
executional execution
path because it basically is running a
program custom handlers you can use
triggers and inputs and output bindings
via the extension
bundles
okay so let's kind of visualize that so
we really understand that this is like a
separate thing that's running
so the function will pass along the
payload to the custom handler the
communication between the function and
custom handler is via https requests and
response the custom handler runs on
white lightweight web servers
the underlying compute will likely vary
based on what service plan is chosen so
it's going to be other places i couldn't
really figure out where they were
the custom executable for the custom
handler is bundled along with your
function code
so there's that there uh some some
things about the application structure
to implement a custom handler your
application must have the following a
host json file a local settings json
file a function json file
uh a command script or executable which
will run on the web server
uh and then the following diagram shows
how these files look on the file system
for a function named myq and a custom
handler
so here you can just kind of see
it's not the prettiest but i mean it
gets the point across the idea is you
have a folder here's your function json
and this one happens to use an
executable in practice custom handlers
are super super hard to do
uh and i think i mentioned this before
but you know i was trying to set up a
ruby one
and it didn't work and i try to set up
the the tutorial one that's in the docs
for rust or go that didn't work i
reached out the person that made it that
didn't work i reset the azure support
they didn't know how to do it so um if
people running custom handlers if anyone
figures it out please tell me uh
hopefully i do figure it out and we get
included in this course if we don't just
understand if i couldn't do it then i
don't it's not a big deal if you don't
know how to do it okay but for me i
personally would have loved to
run ruby because that's my favorite
language to use
and that's what i would use on azure
functions
[Music]
okay so let's say you are making a
custom handler you deploy it and you end
up having an error that says runtime is
unreachable what do you do well not a
whole lot but i can i can tell you
that there are some things that you can
narrow down because a runtime could not
be running for multiple reasons
um so
uh you know the idea is that the runtime
couldn't start and so there are some
common reasons that azure suggests that
it could be so it could be storage
account was deleted storage account
application setting was deleted storage
account credentials are invalid storage
account is accessible daily execution
quota is full
app is behind a firewall so there are
your possible reasons for things to go
wrong uh i just wanted to share that you
know i ran into this and i i didn't
necessarily get through it but i i
wanted to share it to you possible
solutions okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at durable
functions
so durable functions is a serverless
compute extension of azure functions
that allow you to write stateful
functions the extension introduces two
types of functions so we have
orchestrator functions this defines
stateful workflows implicitly
representing state via control flow and
entity function which manage the state
of entity explicitly representing state
they define workflows in code so no json
schema or designers are needed but
honestly i would like one because other
providers like aws have like no code
solutions so it's kind of weird they try
to make it like sound like an advantage
but it isn't really an advantage
they can call out functions
synchronously and asynchronously uh the
output from uh
from the called functions can be saved
to local variables they automatically
checkpoint their progress whenever the
function awaits local state is never
lost if the process
if the process recycles or the vm
reboots
so durable functions currently support
the following languages so we have for
c-sharp javascript python
f-sharp
powershell and powershell seven to use
durable functions you need to install a
library specific to your language in the
root of your function app project such
as npm install durable function so there
you go
[Music]
all right so if we are going to be
having stateful functions we are going
to need a variety of different patterns
for
setting up
different kinds of serverless workloads
let's take a look at them the first is
function chaining so this is the pattern
of executing a sequence of functions in
a specific order often the output of one
function needs to be applied to the
input for another function
durable functions allow us to implement
this pattern concisely in code then you
have fan out fan in so this is this is a
pattern of executing multiple functions
in parallel and then waiting for them
all to finish fanning out can be
completed with normal functions by
having the function send multiple
messages to a queue fanning in is much
more difficult because we have to write
code to track when the q triggered
functions end
and store function's output the durable
function extension handles this pattern
with relatively simple code
we have async http api so this pattern
addresses the problem of coordinating
the state of long-running operations
with external clients a common way to
implement this pattern is to have an
http call trigger the long-running
action then redirect the client to
status endpoint then they can pull to
learn when operation
when the operation is complete durable
functions provide built-in apis that
simplify the code we write for
interacting with long-running function
executions the monitor pattern refers to
a flexible recurring process in a
workflow such as polling until certain
conditions are met a simple scenario
such as a periodic cleanup job can be
addressed with a regular time trigger
but it is interval but its interval is
fixed making managing instance lifetime
difficult durable functions enables
flexible recurrence intervals task
lifetime management and the ability to
create multiple monitor process from a
single orchestration a little bit more
here so we have human interaction so
many automated processes involve some
form of human interaction humans are not
always available and responsive
as cloud services which makes invoking
humans an automated process tricky so
automated process must
must allow for this and they often do so
by using timeouts and compensation logic
then we have aggregators so stateful
entities this pattern is about
aggregating event data over a period of
time into a single addressable entity
the data being aggregated may come from
multiple sources be delivered in batches
or may be scattered
over long periods of time the aggregator
may need to act on event data as it
arrives external clients may need to
query the aggregator data so there you
go
let us take a look at azure functions on
kubernetes now i don't think this is on
the exam but i just thought it was very
interesting a thing that azure functions
can do uh and so i just kind of wanted
to run quickly through it so you can
deploy any azure function app to a
kubernetes cluster running on k running
k-e-d-a if you don't know kita it is
kubernetes event-driven auto-scaling uh
service and allows you to set up
auto-scaling based on events from
various cloud native
services and third-party services so
in this case
it could be for azure azure function
apps
and so when we were looking at the core
uh core tools azure power tools whatever
you want to call it um
they had an opera they had the option to
deploy to uh kubernetes so i'm gonna
assume that you'd probably be running an
aks azure kubernetes service uh but
let's just read through some of the
things here so kubernetes-based
functions provide the functions runtime
in a docker container with event drive
driven scaling through
kita
kita can scale into zero instances with
no events occurring and out to n
instances so it scales to zero it does
this by exposing custom metrics for
kubernetes auto scaler so horizontal
autoscaler using function containers
with kita make it possible to replicate
serverless function capabilities in
kubernetes cluster these functions can
be deployed using aks virtual node
features for serverless infrastructure
i'm really curious like how they're
running and like other things there but
that's outside of the scope of this
course but you know if you're into
kubernetes and i do have a kubernetes
course um you know it's just interesting
to see that that is a functionality
there and so i just wanted to call that
out for our kubernetes fans okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure virtual
machines which makes it easy for you to
choose your own os compute memory and
storage and launch a server within
minutes
all right so let's take a quick look
here at vms for azure and this is a
highly configurable server that relies
on virtualization meaning that you're
running a server without having to
actually buy and maintain physical
hardware that runs it you will still
have to manage things at the software
layer so you would have to apply your
own os system patches and installing the
configuration packages but the nice
thing is that you're not dealing with
that hardware it's just going to work
for you and some things i want you to
know about azure virtual machines is
that the size of the virtual machine is
determined by the azure image uh and so
the image defines the combination of
vcpus memory and storage capacity the
current limit on a per subscription
basis is 20 vms per region i would think
that if you wanted more you could just
use another subscription i don't know if
they have service limit increase for
that but that might be possible as well
azure vms are billed at an hourly rate
an instance uh or a single instance that
you launch is going to have availability
of 99.9 percent when you're using
premium disk if you have standard disk i
have no idea what it is um but it's
going to be less than that if you want
to get 99.95
availability you're going to have to
launch two instances within an
availability set and you can attach
multiple manage this to an azure virtual
machine
now just to give you uh like a quick
visual of what's actually happening when
you launch an instance because when you
do launch a virtual machine there's
going to be other networking components
that are going to be created or
associated with you and you definitely
need to know all these components here
so i have this nice diagram we're going
to do a quick run through with it and i
want you to just know that when you do
launch a virtual machine it actually
does give you a list of all the
components that it creates this is
actually very common with most azure
services and sometimes what they'll do
is they'll put it within a resource
group for you so that they're all
grouped together which is very nice
but let's just run through these common
components that you need to know such as
the network security group and this is
going to be attached to your network
interface it acts as a virtual firewall
with rules around ports and protocols so
that is what's protecting our virtual
machine you have the network interface
that handles ip protocol so that's how
the virtual machine
talks to the internet or other things on
the network you have the virtual machine
itself or the instance that's a the
version or the
uh instance that is currently running
it's going to get a public ip address
assigned to it so that's how um people
from the internet can actually access
the virtual machine
and then you have to launch it within a
virtual network uh and so that's you're
going to have that v-net so you'll
either you'll either choose one or
you'll be creating one uh during that
wizard process so there you go
[Music]
so now let's take a quick look at the
options for operating systems on azure
vm and let's just define what an os is
uh so the os is the program that manages
all other programs in a computer and the
most commonly known operating systems
are windows mac os and linux and when
you want to
launch a virtual machine the way you
determine what operating system you use
is based on the image that you choose
okay
and
azure has a marketplace so they have
so many different kinds of operating
systems you're going to have every
possible option you want and microsoft
has also partnered with specific
companies to make sure that they're
providing you images that are updated
and optimized for the azure runtime so
let's do a quick run through of these
supported or partnered
os's so we have seuss we have red hat
ubuntu debian freebsd
then you have flat card container linux
rancher os which is for containerization
but nami binami is more like images that
have preloaded software on them they're
very popular for their bitnami wordpress
you have mesosphere
and then you have images that have
docker with it so you have a lot of
options open to you there and i always
forget about jenkins and jenkins is on
the end there now if you want to bring
your own linux version you can totally
do so all you have to do is package it
into a virtual hard disk or a vhd
if you've never heard of vhds uh these
are these are just uh virtual hard disk
formats that you can create using
hyper-v software which would be on your
windows machine
and just be aware that azure doesn't
support vhdx which is a newer format it
only uses vhd okay so there you go
[Music]
so let's take a quick look here at cloud
and knit and this is something that's
not going to be on your exam but it's
something you absolutely should know and
need to know because it's an industry
standard and it's just something that uh
you might like if i didn't show it to
you no one's gonna show it to you so
let's just get to it and so cloud init
is this multi-distribution method for
cross-platform cloud instance
initialization and it's supported across
all major uh public cloud providers so
azure aws gcp it's provisioning systems
for private cloud infrastructure
and bare metal installations so what is
cloud instance initialization well this
is the process of preparing an instance
with configuration data for the
operating system and the runtime
environment and so uh the idea is that
you're going to have cloud instances
that are initialized from a disk image
and instance data right so the image is
whatever the the the vm image is but
you're going to have data such as
metadata user data
and vendor data and i'm not going to get
into all the data i just want you to
know the one which is the one you'll be
working with is user data
and so user data is a script that you
want to run when an instance first boots
uh and so um
if you've ever used aws and you launch
an instance you'll see a box in the the
wizard that says user data and that's
what this is uh in azure i don't think
they make it as clear i don't think they
call it user data but if you're
pragmatically doing it with um arm
templates when you're doing
infrastructure as code
that is what you're doing you're using
cloud in it underneath i just wanted to
make that association to you so when you
see that word user data you think cloud
init
and so cloud in it really only works
with linux distributions so um
it should work with all the linux
distributions on
azure i'm pretty sure it's not being
used for windows machines but there you
go
[Music]
azure virtual machines come in a variety
of different sizes that are optimized
for specific use cases and the way azure
groups these are into types so that
would be like general purpose compute
optimized and sizes
and sizes is kind of a weird word
because i've seen in other places in
their documentation called series or sku
family so you'll see me using those
three terms interchangeably they
definitely confused me when i was
looking at it at first
but let's just go quickly through some
of them there's a lot of them so they're
not going to be all of them on the list
here
but we'll just quickly go through it so
the first is general purpose these are
balanced cpu to memory ratio testing
development small to medium databases
and low to medium traffic web servers
this is pretty much what you're going to
be using unless you work for a company
that has a lot of money and the one
you're going to see the most is called
b1 because it's super super cost
effective
and that's the one i'm always using when
i'm launching linux machines you'll see
me using it through
follow alongs here in this course the
next one here is compute optimize so
that's high cpu uh
uh to memory or ratio good for medium
traffic web servers network appliances
batch processes and app servers so this
just has more cpu here uh the most
common one is the fsv2 or the f series
then you have memory optimized so high
memory to cpu ratio great for relational
databases being able to hide large
caches and in memory analytics
and we have a variety of skus there
then you have storage optimized so these
are high a disk throughput and if and
ideal for big data sql no school
databases database warehousing and large
transactional databases and we just have
lsv2 for those
then you have the specialized ones for
gpu for heavy graphic rendering video
editing model training and
interferencing
with deep learning so available with
single or multi multiple gpus and so we
have a variety of skus there and then
you have your hpcs your high performance
compute and these are the the most fast
and powerful cpu virtual machines with
uh with optional high throughput network
interfaces all right and i just want to
point out that there are more here um
but uh i'm just showing you ones that
are occurring so there are previous
series um here like we're not showing
basic a all right like the a series is
not being shown here now when you want
to actually go see this full list here
it's very easy you just launch up a
virtual machine and uh you're going to
be able to choose two things you're
going to choose the first the image so
that's going to be
what do you want to run right so it's
going to be ubuntu or
windows machine and then you're going to
choose your standard size image i
believe that if you choose certain
images not all sizes will be available
to you
because some images have to be optimized
for
those uh
series sorry i'm just drinking some tea
here uh and so there's that b1 series
and you can see in canadian dollars it's
9.72 which is a pretty good price for me
and you can explore all the costs in
azure which is really nice you don't
have to go to a separate marketing
website you can just open it up and you
can just sort by the lowest cost which
is what i always do
and they have a lot of filters there so
there you
go let's quickly talk about azure
compute units so azure compute units
also known as acus provides a way of
computing comparing compute so cpu
performance across azure skus remember
we said skus is the same thing as sizes
or series
so you'll just see us varying the terms
on that
acu is currently standardized on a small
so standard a1 and you saw prior that a1
is a previous series so it's not
something that you generally be
launching but everything's based off of
that one and
those are given a value of 100 it's just
an arbitrary number to um give it a
point against other machines and all
other skus then represent approximately
how much faster that sku can run a
standard benchmark i don't fully
understand the math behind uh their
their stuff here but i generally get the
idea here and i'll just show you quickly
a quick comparison so here we have the
a1 to a4
series
against the d1 d14 series a1 is our
baseline at at 100 acus
and it has a ratio one to one from vcpus
to core and so you can see that for d1
to d14 it says 160 points to 250 points
and so if i did the math here right i
think i did uh it's going to be
basically 60 to 150 percent more
performant than choosing an a1 to a4 so
that's how that works so there you go
[Music]
so here's a neat feature that azure
virtual machines allows you to do and
you can actually do this with a lot of
different services with azure and it's
the azure mobile app and so what you'll
notice is that when you're using virtual
machines they might have this little qr
code and if you have the app installed
what you can do is scan that code but
honestly you don't even need to scan the
code if you just have the app installed
connect your account you can
log in on your phone and check out the
virtual machine how it's performing and
you can take basic actions there i
believe as well you can access the cloud
shell so it's pretty darn cool um and so
i just wanted you to know about that and
if you haven't just go ahead and install
it on your phone i think it's available
for
um android and ios i have an android
phone so i didn't check ios but um yeah
go check it out
so sometimes when you're launching a
virtual machine you'll have the option
between generation one versus generation
two when you're choosing images and i
want you to know about uh this stuff
here and to understand it we need to
know a little bit about hyper-v so
hyper-v's is microsoft's hardware
virtualization product and it lets you
create and run a software version of a
computer called a virtual machine and
each virtual machine acts like a
complete computer running an operating
system and
programs and so if you're still kind of
wondering what hyper-v is if you've ever
heard of virtualbox which is used for
running vms on mac and linux
this is the this is basically the exact
same offering it's just windows offering
okay and it already comes pre-installed
on windows 10. so you might have to
toggle something on i can't remember it
because it's been a long time since i've
had to configure it
but the point is you have a windows
machine you're already
ready to start using hyper-v and hyper-v
has two generations of virtual machines
so the first one was generation one and
this uh this will support most guest
operating systems and then generation
two supports most 64-bit versions of
windows and more current versions of
linux and freebsd operating systems and
there are these two here but
neither one or two is bad so they both
have their own use case so it's not like
you should always use two
and there's a big list online but we're
not going to get into that full list
but anyway so we see that hyper-v has
generation one and two vms but azure
also has them as well but they're not
one-to-one the same as hyper-v
generation so if you look up hyper v uh
like the hyper v generation um feature
set you might not have that in azure so
i wouldn't rely on that list but
what i definitely want you to know
between azure gen 1 and gen 2 that's a
key difference is that gen 1 is
bios-based architecture and gen 2 is
u-e-f-i
based boot architecture and if you've
ever built a video gaming machine you
definitely know the difference between
these two if you don't it's just the way
the machine boots up it's the first
screen you see
um and it's going to change what kind of
configuration options you have and you
you uh uefi has a lot of great features
in it so for instance it has secure boot
which verifies the bootloader is signed
by a trustee
authority and you can have larger boot
volumes up to 64
terabytes
and if you want to know more you'll just
have to look up uefi because i'm not
covering it in this course i just want
you to know that's the the key
difference there and hyper vvms are
packaged into virtual hard disk formats
so that's going to be either vhd or vhdx
files okay
one thing you might want to be able to
do is actually get into your virtual
machine and we have a lot of different
options available to us in fact we have
three ways to connect to our virtual
machines we have rdp ssh and bastion and
so if you don't know these things we're
going to walk through them right now the
first is secure shell and this is a
protocol to establish a secure
connection between a client and server
this is how you can remotely connect to
a
azure virtual machine via a terminal
ssh happens on port 22 via tcp port 22
is something you should absolutely
remember as ssh
and you will generally use an rsa key
pair
to gain access you can also use username
and password but most people don't do
that anymore
another way of getting access to your
machine is by using rdp which is remote
desktop protocol this is a proprietary
protocol developed by microsoft which
provides a user with a graphical
interface to connect to another computer
over a network connection basically what
it means is that it's going to open up a
window and you're going to be able to
see like another windows desktop in it
and control it remotely
so this is how you can remotely connect
windows server to a virtual desktop rdp
happens on port 3389 via tcp and udp i
think there might be some other ports
but this is the port that you need to
know
i just remember from aws because there
were some extra ports i had to configure
but
that's a different story
then you have uh your
bastion which is your third option and
so azure bastion which is actually an
azure service is a service that you can
deploy lets you connect to a virtual
machine using your browser and azure
portal
and so the reason why this is so useful
is that
if you have
let's say a chrome desktop
which doesn't actually
it can't actually use ssh
client or can't use the rdb client this
just gives you another way of using the
browser
so you don't have to install those
clients but we'll get into that shortly
here okay
[Music]
so let's take a closer look at ssh and
the most common way to access your vm or
to authenticate yourself uh so that
you're allowed to get into your vm with
ssh is by using ssh key pair
and so the idea is that you're going to
have to generate out two keys that's why
it's called a key pair there's two keys
and so you'd use that command ssh hyphen
keygen hyphen t rsa and that is
something that is definitely etched in
my memory it's definitely something you
want to memorize because it'll be with
you throughout your entire career and so
you're going to have a private key and a
public key and so the way these keys
work is that the private key
should remain on your local system and
not be shared with others and the public
key is going to be stored on the vm and
when you go ahead and ssh you're going
to provide your private key
as part of the ssh
command and it's going to try to match
it against the public key to
authenticate you and so that is what you
normally do ssh hyphen i provide the
public key see where it says dot pub
that's how you know it's a public key
and then there's the actual address of
the server um and that's how you're
gonna gain access okay
so let's take a look at the process of
using rdp
so the first thing you'll want to do is
download the rdb file so when you go and
try to connect to that virtual machine
you're going to go ahead and download
the rdp file that's going to download
this rdp uh
this file that has rdp extension you're
going to double click that file and
you're going to be prompted to fill in
your username and password this uh this
username and password is what you
specified when you created your virtual
machine and i just want you to know that
if you are on a mac
you can install the remote desktop
client from the apple store
but if you're on windows you already
have rdp client installed there's
nothing extra that you have to do
[Music]
so let's take a closer look here at
azure bastion and this is an
intermediate uh hardened instance that
allows you to connect to your target
server via ssh or rdp and it will
provision a web-based rdp client or ssh
terminal i'm going to tell you honestly
i never really thought of this use case
for bastions prior to this
but the reason
like bastions are good or have still a
utility these days is because some
people are using a google chromebook and
they're not going to have
a terminal so they can't use ssh or if
they're on windows they can't sell the
putty client or if they're on windows
they can't
they won't have the
remote desktop client and so the only
way is through the web because a google
chromebook's all a browser and so this
is one of those utilities for a bastion
now bastions don't necessarily are just
for this use case they're definitely a
very good and secure way to connect to
your virtual machines and having a way
of auditing who has access to what
but this is the use case that azure is
putting forward with bastion here and so
the idea is that when you want to create
a bastion you're going to have to add it
to a subnet
uh in your v-net or you're gonna have to
make a new subnet and it has to be
called azure bastion subnet and it has
to have at least a size of four slash 27
so 32 addresses so that's what you're
gonna have to do
so um you'll just have to go in and add
in that subnet there
and then once you do
uh you can go ahead and launch your
bastion so let's first take a look at
rdp uh and so rdp uh we saw how to do it
but let's see what it looks like with
with azure bastion so what you do is you
say connect with azure bastion for your
windows machine that's going to assume
that you want rdp you're going to just
put in your username and password as you
normally would and boom you're in your
machine that's all it takes let's take a
look at how you deal with ssh so
you know if you're using a linux server
it's going to obviously want to use ssh
because you don't have rdp for that
and so
you can actually use either the ssh
private key or the the username and
password
i
recommend using always ssh private key
let's take a look at that process so
you'll enter your username in and then
you can switch over to ssh private key
and then
the dot pem file which is downloaded
locally to your machine
which is your private key you can just
uh select it and then that will upload
it and use it in the comparison and boom
you're in your machine so
that's just kind of a cool service that
they have there
let's just do a quick comparison between
windows and linux servers this is going
to be
very obvious for people that are used to
running windows workloads but for those
who uh
grew up on linux i just want to make
sure
you understand some of the caveats of
windows that you might not be used to so
obviously azure allows you to run both
windows and linux
instances or vms
and so let's just talk about windows
first so when you launch a windows
server just like your desktop computer
it needs a windows license to run
whether it's windows 10 or
whatever windows server you're using but
i just want you to know that
when you launch your your server you
don't necessarily have to have the
license on hand and so if you launch a
server without a license
um all it's going to do is say windows
is unactivated and you're going to take
some manual step to activate that
license and i just want to tell you that
so that you're not afraid of launching a
windows machine because you think you're
going to get charged a license fee uh
it's not going to happen you have to
take some manual intervention to do that
so do not worry about launching that
windows machine
you can bring your own license via a
hybrid license so some people like
enterprises already own their licenses
and they just want to uh they already
made a deal with microsoft and so they
just want to reuse those instead of
using whatever azure provides because it
can be cheaper
you're going to set a username and
password because you're using rdp to
access the machine so you're not using
your ssh key pairs
um
windows machines require
larger instances okay so
if you're running windows 10 or whatever
it needs a lot more memory and so you're
gonna have to run it on a b2 which is a
lot more expensive than a b1 and that's
because it runs a full desktop
environment all the windows servers do
this
and so this is generally why i like
running linux so
just be aware not to keep your windows
server running for very long if you
don't have a lot of money and you're
just learning to pass the certification
let's talk about linux really quickly
here most versions of linux require no
type of license
so i think like you can get red hat you
might need a license for that if you
want support you set either a username
password or ssh key pair you can utilize
smaller vm sizes because you're not
running a full desktop experience
could you run
like a full desktop experience possibly
i haven't ever tried to do it on cloud
myself
uh unix and like space uh are unix and
linux-based systems traditionally are
terminal based environments right so
you're going to be sshinging into them
and you're not going to have something
visual okay so there you go
[Music]
so let's talk about update management at
the start of this section for virtual
machines i had said that there was some
uh
requirements ongoing software patches
and things that you had to perform on
your virtual machines
and so that is something that you have
to take care of but if you wanted to
automate that process this is where you
can use update management so that's what
it'll do it'll install operating system
updates and patches for both windows and
linux
and not only can it do it for your
virtual machines on azure but it can do
it on premise and even in other cloud
providers
okay
and the way this is going to work is
you're going to go to your operations
tab where it says guest plus host
updates and you're going to click on
update management
now update management looks like it's
its own service but it's actually using
azure automations under underneath
and so that's what is
installing the agent and the agent is
the
microsoft monitoring agent mma so that's
how it knows what to do you have to get
that installed on your machine so update
management will perform a scan for
update compliance a compliance scan is
by default
performed every 12 hours on a windows
machine and every three hours on a linux
machine
it can take between 30 minutes and six
hours for the dashboard to display
updated data from managed computers
and i just wanted to point out a little
bit about azure automation so because it
does more than just obviously update
management but azure automation you can
enable update management change tracking
inventory start stop vms during off
hours features for your servers and
virtual machines and these features have
a
dependency on
on a log analytics workspace and
therefore required linking the workspace
with an automation account so there is a
little bit extra that we have to have
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to be launching our own
bastion using azure bastion services so
there's two ways to set this up we can
go to bastions over here and create a
bastion this way or we can create one
after we've created a virtual machine i
prefer the latter so let's go ahead and
do that and launch ourselves a new
virtual machine and so we could either
use launch a windows server or a linux
server today i'm going to be launching a
windows server
and what we'll do is go down here i'll
make a new group we'll call it the
enterprise
and as we do that we'll just name this
uh enterprise
d
and we'll launch that in canada centra
or us or central us that's fine with me
uh 2019 data center gen 2 is totally
fine if you go here
you're trying to find it you go hit
select
and we'll choose gen 2 data center it is
expensive but uh we're not going to be
using this for very long
for the username i'm going to put
data
and for the i'll just make it azure user
to make our lives a bit easier and then
we'll put testing capital t one two
three four five six
testing one two three four five six
and we will go down below we're fine
with the settings here we're gonna go
next to disk we're gonna leave the disk
to premium that's fine uh we'll let it
create a new network that's totally fine
management is okay
and we'll just actually go hit review
and create
and now we'll just hit create so that it
will go ahead and do that
it'll tell us that it's in progress
and we'll just wait a little bit here
i'll see you back in a moment
all right so our instance is ready so
let's go ahead and go to this resource
here and then on the left hand side
you'll have connect and so i'm going to
show you and you don't it's not
necessary for you to do uh this step
because you're going to i'm going to
show you how to connect be the bastion
but i'm going to go ahead and download
this file the rdp file this will only
work if you're on windows by the way
well i guess it'll work on mac but you'd
have to install the um
uh the
rdp service for the users with windows
there and so here this is azure user
we're going to type in testing with a
capital t just double check that there
i'm going to log in make sure that this
works
uh do we'll do that one more time oh you
know it's testing one two three four
five six
there we go
we'll say yes
and we'll just make sure that we can uh
remote desktop into this just before
anything else and there we go so that's
all good to me i don't need to see any
more
we'll go over to bastian we'll say use
bastion and this is going to set up a
bastion service in order to use bastion
you need to have another
address space
defined for it it makes it really easy
to
make it here so i'm just going to go
10.0.1.04
and we'll go ahead and hit ok
and so down below it's going to choose
an address space
we have a security group um i'm just
going to put it for none
i don't think i want one on that
and if we scroll on down here we have
the resource group so we're going to put
in the same resource group
and we'll go ahead and create that
so now before this they didn't have this
really nice wizard used to have to go
and and create all those things
individually in your virtual network but
this is really nice it does take a bit
of time for this to provision so i'll
see you back here in a bit that took a
bit of time for that to create that
bastion but it is ready to go and so now
that we have it we can go ahead and
utilize uh this connection here and so
right away it i think it's setting up
for rdp here so what we'll do
is type in azure user
and then capital t testing one two three
four five six we'll go ahead and hit
connect
and so notice that i didn't have to use
an external application i could just
run it in right here
it's all in the web browser so that's
pretty much how the bastion works i
can't remember the pricing on bastion i
think it's a little bit of money so i
don't want to keep this laying around
here but this is great if you let's say
you're on a chromebook which are
becoming really popular where you can't
install native applications uh or you're
just having issues because you're on
like linux or something like that so
there you go that's all there is to it
we'll go ahead and clean this up
and so i'm just going to go here find
the resource group
and we'll go ahead and delete i'm just
making sure that bastion's within there
so it is good
and there we go
[Music]
so we just launched a virtual machine
for linux now let's go ahead and launch
one for windows i'm going to go to the
top here and type in virtual machines
we'll go to the first link i'm going to
hit add add virtual machine
and
what we'll do is we'll create a new
group the last one i had was called
bajor i'm going to call this one
cardassia
and i'm going to name this machine also
named cardassia
and this time what we want to do is is
we want to move over to a windows server
i find the easiest one to learn with is
the windows 10 pro server just because i
find these ones a little bit daunting so
i'm going to go windows 10 pro
and then what we're going to do is go
choose a larger size this is not going
to work we cannot run a windows server
on a b1 ls so we're going to have to go
a little bit larger
and we don't have to go too much larger
here but the idea here is that there's
going to be a more expensive spend here
so we're not going to be running to keep
this running for long but here we have
the b2s that is the appropriate size to
run this anything smaller i don't think
is going to work
and we are going to put in a password
here so i'm just going to put in
cardassia
and we'll do cardassio123
put a capital on it i guess
we'll just do this here
and i'm just going to go back and lower
case this one
and we're going to allow the inbound
port of 3389 because that is what rdp
needs i'm going to confirm that i have a
windows license i actually don't but the
thing is you can still launch one for
your test purposes it'll just complain
saying you're not activated so there are
some limitations but it's good enough
for us to learn okay and so now that
that is all great we'll go next to disks
we're going to go with premium or
standard ssd this time
uh we're going to go ahead and hit next
and go to networking it's going to
create us a new v-net which is a great
idea we're going to let it create a
a network security group on the nick
just like before we'll go ahead and hit
next
uh we'll leave all these options alone
this all seems fine to me
uh and we'll hit next
review and create
and we'll go ahead and create this
server
all right and so that's gonna go ahead
and create it so i'll just see you back
here in a moment when that's done
deploying all right so after a short
little while here it looks like our
windows server is now deployed so what
we can do is go to that resource if you
wanted to see what it's deployed it's
the same stuff as always you have your
network interface card your virtual
networks
nsg the ip address but let's actually go
to that resource now
and so let's see how we can gain access
to this virtual machine and so what we
can do is use rdp luckily i am on a
windows machine and so
i already have the rdb client that i can
use so all you got to do is download the
rdb file
and then once we have that file i can
just double click it
and i can open this up if you're on a
mac you can download the app in the app
store and so i'll go ahead and type in
my password so my username was cardassia
and then my password was capital c
a-r-d-a-s-s-i-a
one two three we'll hit okay
and then it'll give us another one we'll
say yes
and now we are in our virtual machine so
there you go how cool is that
i'll just give it a moment to load up
but this is a full uh windows 10 pro
uh and as i said before you know we
don't actually have a license so if
you're afraid of spinning it up because
you're gonna get charged a license fee
uh for windows you do not have to worry
that's not gonna happen you have to do
some manual intervention uh for that to
happen so we'll just wait a little while
here for this to load um it is not we're
not using the most powerful machine so
it does take a little bit of time and so
we just hit accept here
and here we are so we are on uh
we have our nice windows machine here
whoops
i don't know if it has any games let's
go take a look
maybe play minesweeper
um
no maybe maybe you have to download the
store i'm not that familiar with windows
machines but um so there you go so we'll
go ahead and close that and you know if
we were using the bastion it's the same
process you saw how we used it with ssh
but if we had the bastion and it's so
much work to set one up we already did
that before uh but all you do is enter
your credentials in on the page just as
we did and it and it's just a lot easier
that way uh so let's go ahead and just
tear down this machine we're all done
with it so i'm just going to hit um
uh
delete
and uh if we find that resource group we
should be able to easily delete them all
i find the easiest ways to go up here go
to all resources
and then there's the resource group
there and then hit delete resource group
and then i'll type in the name of it
which is cardassia and i'll delete all
those resources but after that's done
always just take a double check
on your all resources tab
and just make sure that those resources
are gone just because sometimes they
stick around but there you go that's as
simple as it was to launch a windows
machine
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's take a look here at virtual
machines which i consider the backbone
of most cloud service providers and
azure keeps it really simple by calling
it
virtual machine so we can go up here and
type in virtual machine and make our way
over here but right now i don't have any
options because i'm using a tenant that
doesn't have a subscription applied to
it so what i'm going to do is go switch
back to my original tenant and this one
has this subscription applied to it
and so what i'll do is just click back
up here and now we'll just type in
virtual machines
and i can now see uh i have options of
creating virtual machines let's go ahead
and go create a linux one first and then
we'll go ahead and create a windows one
and then we'll see how we can connect to
it all right so first we'll go to the
top here hit add we'll click on virtual
machine
and we're gonna be present with a lot of
options so we'll have to choose a
subscription and so there is mine i want
to probably create a new resource group
here i'm going to call this one bajor
and i will name this
uh bajor again
and i'm going to launch this in us east
i'll just set it to one availability
zone for the time being
then here we have what we can choose as
an image i can click on see all images
and choose from a variety of them so if
i didn't want to use ubuntu i could
launch something else like debian or
something like that
but really i just want to stick with uh
ubuntu because i'm fine with that
version with 18. uh then here's what
what really matters is the size because
that's going to affect our cost so if we
click on see all sizes we have this
nifty
table where we can sort the cost it's
just loading the cost here it's dynamic
this is going to be based on uh what
your base subscription is so if you're
in canada you're going to see canadian
prices in the us you can see us prices
etc etc
and i care a lot about cost here so i'm
just going to sort this by cost and here
we have the b1 ls which is very cost
effective
we have a ram of 0.5 gigabytes and some
other options there
so we'll go ahead and select that there
and we have a couple options we can use
ssh public key or we can uh utilize a
password and so i think what we'll do is
use an ssh public key because that's
pretty much the standard there we're
going to name the username beige or if
it lets us
probably won't probably want some
additional options there nope it's okay
oh great and we'll go ahead and generate
a new key pair
and i'm just going to name that one
bajor
and uh we have some options here for
inbound rules uh so you could set to
none this is just setting up the nsg for
you
but we're probably going to want to have
that port open for ssh because that's
how we're going to make our way back in
here if we're running a um
like an apache server we'd want to have
port 80 open so we can go ahead and do
that
we'll take a look at now disks
so here we have options between premium
standard and standard hhd
i just want this to be cost effective so
i'm just going to go with standard hdd
but generally you you want to have
at least a standard or premium ssd when
you're running real web development
workloads
then there's encryption here and so it's
always turned on by default which is
great they also have this option of
double encryption with the platform
managing customer manage key we're just
going to leave that as default enable
alter discompatibility that's not
something we need to do here because we
are not using ultradisc
and here you can see that you can attach
multiple uh disks here
so i can go and do that but that's not
something i need to do today
and some other advanced options which we
do not care about we'll go over to
networking and so it's going to end up
creating us a new v-net for us and we'll
create a new subnet for us and assign it
a ip address
uh it will also set up a nics
network security group so the next
security group is not going to be
applied at the subnet level it's going
to be applied at the nic which is
attached to the um
dc2 there and so we'll just leave it to
basic we're going to allow inboard
inbound ports for port 80
and 22 that was carried over from
earlier
we can put this behind a load balancer
but i don't think we're going to do that
right now
we'll go over to management uh we have
some additional options here for
monitoring uh this is all okay here we
can set it to auto shutdown actually
i'll leave that alone
you can also enable backups here
we'll go advanced
and now we have this option here for
custom data
i covered a section on cloud init and
they don't call this user data but most
other providers will call this user data
so we could provide
a bash script or additional information
here if we wanted to
then down below there's some host group
options we're not going to worry about
that in proximity placement group this
is really important if you need to have
instances nearby uh i think this is
pretty common with um
what's it called high capacity workloads
hfc i can't remember the initialism
right now but we covered in the core
content then we can tag our resource
here uh we'll just leave that alone i
don't care about tagging too much but
generally it's good to tag in practice
and then we will get to review and
create our server here we'll go ahead
and hit create
and then we'll have to download our
private key so we can utilize it later
and so that's downloaded there
and now we're just waiting for it to
deploy this and i'll see you back here
in a moment
so we had to wait a little bit there and
finally our deployment is complete
and we can go ahead and just review all
the things that it created
so notice that it created the virtual
machine it created a network interface a
nic for us
the nsg the network security group
the virtual network and also a public ip
address
when i do clean up a lot of things i
always miss are these ip addresses and i
know that azure gave me a warning that
said hey you're about to spend
uh 700 yearly on ip addresses because
you weren't releasing them
so when we do the cleanup step i'll
definitely emphasize about deleting
those ip addresses and how to go about
that
let's go take a look at the actual
resource now
so here we are and you can see we have a
lot of options the left hand side such
as the disk
so we can see the disk options there and
there's other additional security
options
let's go take a look at how we can go
ahead and connect to the server
and so there's different options here so
we have rdp ssh and bastion since we are
using a linux machine we're not going to
be using rdp that's really for windows
um but the trick here is that um
i would need to have a client on my
computer to connect like um
i think it's called putty if you're on a
linux based machine it's a lot easier
uh and certainly i have the linux
subsystem installed so i could probably
um connect that way
but i figured let's just go ahead and
connect via bastion because i think this
is a pretty darn cool feature so let's
go ahead and create ourselves a bastion
and this will take a little bit of time
here
but we'll go ahead here and just set up
subnet so to associate a virtual network
to a bastion they must contain a subnet
with the azure bastion subnet so they
actually have a special subnet for it
so what we'll do
is we'll just go back to our um our
server here
which we call bajor
and i think we can find the subnet
through here
so on the left-hand side if we go to
networking we probably could find it
that way um
so i'm just looking for that security
group
um in there
it should be
um maybe it's not there if it's not
there
um well you know we could just go over
make our way over to subnets it's not a
big deal
because it's called bajor it's pretty
darn easy to find to begin with and so
under subnets here what we need to do is
add a special one here
and just gonna remember how this works
um so you need to create a subnet called
azure bastion subnet with a prefix of at
least 27.
so we'll go ahead and add a new subnet
and we'll call it that
uh we'll take out the space there
and the range is 10 0 1 0 etc so we'll
just do it on two
zero dot um two dot zero four slash
twenty seven
uh
ten zero zero two is not contained
yeah it overlaps so we'll do two
let's not contain the virtual network
address space oh right so we have to add
the address space first
oops we'll just hit cancel here
that's okay we'll discard that we'll
make our way over to address space and
we'll go ahead and add 10.0.2.0424
they'll give us a pretty darn
large range there
and so now what we'll do is go back to
our subnet
and we'll go ahead and create that there
and it said it only needed 27 so we'll
just give it only 27. we don't need to
go bigger than we need
and that should be okay we'll go ahead
and hit save
and it shouldn't take too long so now
that we have that we can go back here
and we'll give give this another go here
uh it's there so it shouldn't be
complaining
maybe what we'll do is just start from
the the start here again
yeah there you go the azure portal is
like that a lot where you'll have
something set up and it has the old
state of it and so you just have to
trust yourself that you know what you're
doing and you have to go back if you
don't have a lot of confidence a lot of
times you'll get stuck and you'll think
okay i don't have it right but i always
just try again and hit refresh
because the azure portal is very
inconsistent so we're just going to wait
for this to create this does take a
little while to create so i'll see you
back in a moment
so after waiting five minutes our
bastion is now created and so what we
can do is without even using a putty
client or having to use linux directly
we can just connect through via the
bastion
so here we'll see we have some options
here so we want to do ssh
private key from local file
okay
and what we can do is go ahead and
select our bajor key
and then i'll just scroll down here and
hit connect
oh um and i think we made the username
bajor
and we'll go ahead and connect now
and it's complaining about a pop-up here
so we'll go up here and say
always allow
and we'll try that again
and then we'll say allow again
and so now that we're into our server
here let's go ahead and try to install
apache and see if we can get at least
the default page running um so this is
using ubuntu if my memory serves me
correctly it should be app get install
apache 2
and we'll just hit y for continue
and we'll just wait for this install
doesn't take too darn long
and after a short little wait there it
finally did install also if you notice
this little icon here we have a little
clipboard here
i don't seem to ever use that there so
that's fine
now when you install apache we might
have to go ahead and start it up
so let's just take a look to see if it
actually is in the running directory
here so we'll go to cd var www and so
that's where the default directory is
right
but we can just check to see if it's
running by doing a ps aux i think it's
httpd
or we can say apache here
and so it looks like it's already
running so that's pretty great for us
and since it's running on port 80 and
we've opened up port 80 we should
probably be able to access that
here so let's go back to our actual
virtual machine
so we'll go to virtual machines
and we have that virtual machine running
i'm just going to click into it because
i just want to find out its public ip
address
so here it is there and for lucky this
will just work just copy the clipboard
button right there
and look at that we have the default
page isn't that cool
so that's all there really is to it and
i could even update this page you don't
have to do it but i'm just going to
update it for fun
actually i probably have to restart the
server so maybe i won't do that
but yeah so we connected through the
bastion so that was pretty darn easy
we probably could have also used um the
cloud shell to connect um
but maybe we should we could give that a
go as well
since we're all done here let's go ahead
and do some cleanup the first thing i
want to do is the easiest way is
actually to go to all resources here at
the left-hand side
and this really gives you an idea of
everything that's running your account
so i actually have other stuff in here
that's not relevant
but the idea is that all of our stuff is
running within a resource group
and so i'm just taking a look there i'm
not saying this is all resources here
um see if you see resource group here
yeah they're all there right there so i
can go ahead and click that
and so everything more or less should be
self-contained within here see all that
stuff
you can even see the v-net is part of it
as well and so if i go ahead and delete
this resource group
it should delete all this stuff so i'm
just going to type bajor to confirm
and we'll go ahead and delete and that
should do a good job of cleaning up all
those files
i'm not sure if it'll delete the ip it
should right there but if it doesn't
what i recommend is after everything is
deleted
just go back here to all resources and
just double check to make sure they all
vanish
because when this is done they're all
going to start to vanish from this list
and if there's anything remaining you'll
know because it's still here right
so just be careful about that that's all
i want you to know
and so that's the linux part and so
let's go ahead and actually now set up a
windows server
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and it's really important that we know
how to monitor our virtual machines so
we can kind of check their performance
or do some diagnostics on them and so a
couple things we're going to look into
we're going to set up some virtual
machines and we're going to look into
automation accounts uh log analytics and
metrics and alerts okay
so the first thing we'll need to do
before we do anything else is make sure
that we have particular resource
providers enabled so go to the top here
and as always go to your subscriptions
and we will click into our subscription
go all the way down the bottom click on
resource providers and there's two in
particular we're looking for uh one is
for alerts so it's alerts management so
make sure that is registered if it's not
press that button
and then we want insights so make sure
insights is enabled as well they should
be by default but just in case they're
not uh you should go ahead and do that
so we're going to need some virtual
machines i'm going to set up three and
the reason i want to do that is just to
show you that there's many different
ways in azure to do the exact same thing
and sometimes when you do something it
just works and sometimes it just doesn't
and it can work again and not again so i
want to give you a few different options
available to you so the first thing
we're going to spin up is a virtual
machine
and this one in particular
we'll make a new group we're going to
call it dax and so we're going to choose
for this one an ubuntu linux i'm going
to switch it over i'm going to choose a
minimal install so we'll choose this one
over here which is the ubuntu server
minimal
and uh what i'll do is name this and
there's a bunch of different daxes in
star trek so we're going to go with
kurzon dax here
and we'll put all this in east us so
wherever it defaults here so if that's
where it wants to go that's where it's
going to be but let's pay attention to
where that is okay
let's make sure that we're using a very
inexpensive instance
i'll give it a second to load if you do
not see the cost just drag these over
until you do it just depends on your
screen right
um so
once this loads it will tell us that
this is probably the cheapest i think
that is the cheapest because something's
going to go lower than at 500 megabytes
of ram so i think we're already set to
it i'm not going to wait for the load to
take forever notice the red line there
is no error is that's just what it shows
and so i'm going to go for password
authentication here and what i'm going
to do for this account is i'm going to
type in um dax as the username and then
testing with a capital t e s t i g one
two three four five six because it wants
an upper case a lower case some numbers
and a certain length and that's what
works for me
so now that i have those filled in ssh
we're gonna keep that open we're gonna
go to disk you can leave it on premium
if you want i'm going to go to standard
i want to save some money just in case i
forget to turn this machine off it's
going to set up some networking for us
which is totally fine we're going to go
to management
and i believe so there should be guest
os install here
it is not here it's the next step i
believe
where is it i know you're in here
let's go back one step here i have a
feeling it's on this page because you
can install the um
guess os metrics right away
so i'm just seeing here i cannot seem to
remember where it is
i might have skipped over it because i'm
going so quick here
um
well maybe it's not set here so when we
go to do the other virtual machine we'll
see if it's actually there but for this
one we'll just launch it without it
which is totally fine i was going to do
one that way anyway
and so we'll go ahead there and create
that virtual machine okay now while that
is going
and by the way if you think you call
that number that's not me so
uh you know you can call if you want but
it won't go to me
so that's going to go ahead and deploy
that what i'm going to do now is go and
launch another virtual machine in the
same
uh in the same environment so this one
this time around is going to be again
it's going to be linux we're going to
choose dax here
and this one is going to be
[Music]
jadziadax
and we this time around are going to
choose
ubuntu server lts so this one's a
minimal install and this one here has a
bit more to it we're going to choose
gen2
uh this is now 4.86 which is strange it
looks like it was the same one before i
don't know why the other one was still
more expensive because where it said 40
dollars but maybe i was mistaking the
red means nothing as per usual it's just
as you're uh tricking us we're going to
call the username here dax testing with
a capital t-e-s-t-i-n-g
you know what i'm trying to say here
and i'm going to do uh testing one two
three four five six
and we will go next to disks we'll stick
with premium for this time it doesn't
really matter if we go to advanced here
there's no uh interesting options there
this is all fine this looks good
we go to management so now notice here
so we didn't have it for the minimal
install but for this one we do we can
actually put in the guest os
diagnostics and what it will do is it
will have to create itself a storage
account so that will be in azure storage
to store
our diagnostic data
and so that seems like a good idea to me
so what we'll do is we're going to go to
next but notice we didn't have it for
the minimal install probably because it
doesn't have the um the agent what's
called the wag agent installed
for it to do that by default so just
notice that it varies on some machines
we're going to go to next we're going to
hit review and create
and we're not done yet we're going to
create one more virtual machine and this
time it's going to be a windows once i
hit the create button here
uh we're going to go back to virtual
machines and this time i'm going to
launch a windows machine and i'm going
to use we're going to put in the same
group here i'm going to call this one
uh tobin or let's call it
little dax here
and this time i'm going to choose a
windows server so i'm going to go to
windows server here we have a lot of
options i'm not that great with windows
servers i'm going to choose a gen
windows server here it's not going to
let us get away with this b1 l it's not
big enough you need a lot more compute
and memory i think it's like two and
four uh but i just remember it always
choose ds ds2 v2
um which is pretty hefty it's pretty
expensive maybe i could choose something
cheaper like the ds1
no i need to i need two cpus so ds2 v3
that's when you're launching a windows
server if you don't do that they'll
complain
and that'll probably be pretty darn
expensive but we got to make sure that
we just shut this off and get through
this as quick as possible i'm going to
choose the same thing as always so i'm
going to i'm going to put in dax and
then for the password i'm going to do
testing 1 2 3 capital on that t
4 5 6
testing 1 2 3 4 5 6 because it wants 12
characters we're going to let it do on
the rdp that's totally fine
uh sure premium ssd we're not going to
keep this around for very long
we're going to scroll on down go to
management
and notice that you can enable os
diagnostics here i'm not going to do
that here just so i can show you show
you it in the other variation
we're going to go to next we're going to
go hit review and create
and we're going to go ahead and create
this instance whenever it lets us do it
there we go
okay we'll hit create
and now it's deploying so
we have these three virtual machines
we're creating and so what i'm going to
do is make my way back to virtual
machines here and so i have the two
there i'm going to give it a refresh
make sure i can see the third one
creating
we don't see it just yet but these ones
are running
so
what i'm going to do is open up kurzone
i'm going to open up jedzia and one has
the guest um the the uh the guests ins
or the
what's it called diagnostic settings
it's the guest metrics installed and the
other one does not so if i scroll down
here so i just want to show you there's
a lot of variation and sometimes you
know you do it one way it works another
way it doesn't so for jetsea it was
installed on default so that's the one
that is using ubuntu standard
and then this is the minimal install
where it's saying hey do you want to
install the metrics and you have to pick
a storage account if you didn't then you
would have the option to create one here
it's called dax
diag so i just want to show you
we're going to go ahead and enable those
guest
level monitoring metrics okay
so
we have a storage account and that's
where the data is going to go
um
and this will probably fail because i
don't think it has the necessary things
installed but i just wanted to show you
you could do it that way
but what another thing we're going to
need is we're going to need
um a log analytics workspace
so all a log analytics workspace is is a
place to store your logs it is
essentially a data lake for a lot of
different resources so you can put all
sorts of resources under here and that
way you can search across them see how
this failed
if you ever have a failure like this the
way you investigate this as you go in
here even though it says assass token
for the storage account couldn't
generate it's kind of a
misleading thing here because if i
actually click in up into my
notifications we go to our activity log
we can see kind of what something has
happened here so i know this failed
it might not show up here yet sometimes
it takes time to show up so we'll
revisit this later but it would show
red errors here and if we looked in
there it would tell us that python's not
installed on that machine because it's a
minimal linux install so if you run into
those problems that's the reason why
some vms are a bit easier to work with
than others but we're looking at log
analytics and again it's just a place to
collect your logs but i want to see
because i think jitsi is the one that
actually is the one that is working
properly but if we go down to
metrics or logs
it's going to say hey you if you want to
use logs you're going to have to go
ahead and create
you have to enable it but what it's
really doing is just creating a log
analytics workspace so if i click this
here
what's going to tell me is say hey you
don't have one we'll create a default
one for you
um i don't want to do it that way what i
want to do is create one myself
and then link it through there or what i
could do is make it through automation
so what i'm going to do
is i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to do through automation
so there's another service called
automation accounts and this particular
service is for configuration management
update management and it's a way for us
to keep our vms up to date
and so this one's going to be called dax
oh it's too short it doesn't like that
dax automation
and i'm going to choose the resource
group dax it's
e-s-e-s
and here it's going to say azure run as
account so this is going to give it more
permissions so that it can run as a
contributor role
and that way it will have access to
resources to do what it wants to do so
we'll go ahead and deploy that and then
once this is deployed we'll create our
our workspace through this because i
found an issue where if i made this and
tried to link it just didn't link and i
don't want to have those problems
so i'm just going to make my life a
little bit easier by making it through
here so under here if we go to update
management
it's going to say hey you need a
workspace in order to use update
management if you're wondering what
update management is it keeps your vms
up to date by applying patches
so if we drop down here we're just going
to go ahead and create a new workspace
and i'm going to do it that way because
it'll be automatically associated with
that workspace on creation
and uh we'll let that go there for a bit
but while that's setting up a new
workspace for us if you go over to
run books this is the power of
well i'm not i'm not
it wants to make that thing there so i'm
just going to click ok there don't worry
about that discard but the whole power
of
this is that it can apply patches it can
it can manage the state of your vms
but if you need to do something
like run something like a a series of
run commands
they have a bunch of different run books
here
uh so there's a variety of different
kinds and i think we can click into them
if there's something about sql that
sound kind of how to use an escrow
command on a automation runbook
so
that's just a runbook so runbook just
means like a series of run commands
something that you're automating on your
server and you do it through here um so
update management looks like it is now
working uh we didn't press that enable
button uh initially but it worked there
but if we wanted to have vms under here
we'd have to go ahead and add them
manually
um and so we're just gonna wait for
those to show up
alternatively if we go back to our
server or sorry one of our vms
we should be able to add it this way it
will just tell us to go that way anyway
um so there should be like update
management or something in here
could be configuration management
um
yeah that still would be through
something right so it'd probably be
still through automation
but i could have swore there was maybe
guest and host updates
yeah so here it's just saying go to
azure automation so you don't really set
it through here you have to associate it
through azure automation and so these
are ready to enable so i'm going to say
go ahead and enable those i don't know
where our windows server is we
definitely spun one up it's not a big
deal if we don't have it it's not really
crucial to this tutorial but it would
have been nice to show um the windows 10
there
i'm gonna go see what happened to our
windows server oh it is there okay
leela's there
so we'll take a look at that in a second
uh but we're just adding those there
we're not going to really apply any
patches i just want to show you how to
associate them there um and just to
highlight the fact that there are run
books which are pretty cool and you can
also do other things like if you need to
like install python packages or stuff
like that uh to to do stuff you could do
that as well
um so there's a bunch of interesting
things in there but it's kind of like a
side dish to the
follow along here so this would have
created our workspace so now let's go
over to our workspaces
and we have one here and if you're just
curious what it looks like if we go here
something super exciting you just put
the name and region in and it has the
default page you go
so you're not really missing out on
creating one uh by hand there
but underneath here
what we can do is see if our virtual
machines are actually associated uh with
this here so if we go under virtual
machine you're gonna see that these ones
are connecting
which is interesting because i didn't do
anything to connect them i'm not sure
why that's happening but i'm going to
hit connect here
and that will connect that a lot of
times i'll come in here i have to
manually connect them i don't know if
it's because we put them in the uh
what do you call it within the uh the
automation there if we go back to
automation
which ones did i choose i already forgot
update management
um
they're not showing up here now but i
know they're there
maybe we triggered it when we were doing
there but anyway the point is is that
you have to make sure that those are
um configured so that it's actually
sending data over to the workspaces so
that we can then use the logs and things
like that
so if we go back to our virtual machines
over here
you can see they're connecting and this
takes forever
while this is going let's go take a look
at storage accounts
and actually a better way would just be
to go look at the virtual machine
individually here
so we'll just go back to my virtual
machines and i go to the resource group
we scroll on down here we should see a
storage account within here
let's just type in storage
there it is
whoops
and uh the thing is is that we can
actually view some of the data in here
so if you go to open explorer you'd have
to install this it's for windows i don't
i think it's for mac as well but once
you have the storage explorer uh open
you can just click open here
and it'll open up once it's installed on
your computer of course
and what i can do
if we have any data it might not be
collecting any data yet but if we go
down to our storage accounts here
oh here it is down below
and expand it under tables see how this
wad that is the name of the um
uh the agent that is collecting data and
here you can see that it's already
collecting stuff
all right
and it's collecting for jet zia dax
and so i'm just kind of looking at the
data that's collecting nothing super
interesting
but the thing is is that
we're gonna make our way over to logs
because by default
azure
collects host metrics so things about
the instance like cpu usage but there's
things that it doesn't collect like
memory
and other things like that
so
that's why we need to turn on this
setting here the diagnostic settings
so we can collect those metrics these
are called guest metrics so we have
memory network file disk disk and
storage so if you wanted to know
how much storage was left on the on the
actual uh disk on with the with the
virtual machine or how much memory was
being used you'd need that uh set up
here
uh once this is enabled uh you can send
data over with uh into azure monitor and
other places um it's not showing app
analytics i think that's for
or log insight whatever the name of the
service is it's for uh
that one i think is for the windows one
so we'll see that when we go over there
but syncs just means we're gonna send
data uh from here to to um
azure monitor right
but we'd have to have preview to see
that
uh nothing that interesting here uh but
if we go over to logs now um this should
not be showing up here anymore so if
this is still showing an enable screen
then we got to go back to
our log analytics we'll click into here
we'll go down to virtual machines and
we'll see if it's connected yet so it
still says it's connecting right
this one's ready though and i haven't
even done anything with that one yet so
what we'll do while we're waiting for
these linux ones to uh to spin up we'll
go over back over here to our virtual
machines and we'll go find that uh
windows machine which i don't know why
it's not showing up here
there it is
and what we'll do is we'll go ahead and
connect to it
so i am on a
windows machine so i'm going to shape
here
and i'm going to click on rdp
and i'm going to download that file i'm
going to double click this file on my
windows machine
and i'll be able to open this up
instantly it was called dax testing one
two three oops
testing one two three four five six
looks good to me we'll hit okay
we'll say yes
because if you want to collect
um
uh particular metrics like guest metrics
you have to enable like when you're on
windows server you have to enable it to
uh to send performance counters
so i'll give it a moment here it doesn't
take too long
while that's going we should look to see
if we actually have um
the uh
the settings set up here the diagnostic
settings and so this is what i'm talking
about the enable guest level monitoring
so we want cpu utilization disk and
network so we'll go ahead and click that
there
and while that's going to go back here
and so this has now started up
i don't know much much about windows
servers but i do know how to turn on
at least last time i did i know how to
turn on the performance counter so see
here it says online performance counters
are not started so i can right click
this and then just say
start performance counters and that will
have it start sending data over to our
storage accounts assuming that this is
enabled here so this is going to go
ahead and install
wag into
the windows server so it can send back
metrics
uh and so we got a lot of things going
on here but let's go back to jadzia
and um i want to see now if i have any
if i can use logs now
there we go so it's now connected to the
workspace so it knows where to send that
data
and you can pull up when you go to logs
it'll show different types of default
queries if you're in the actual group
here you'll have the same screen but
it'll show you across all possible
resources so it's a little bit easier to
figure out like useful queries for
virtual machines when you do it through
here and there's some ones there's some
that we can run right away so if we go
over to
um
the diagnostics
we could or actually availability is a
good example so heartbeats will tell you
if the server is live so a server will
have heartbeat so every whatever second
or minute it's going to
say hey i'm still alive that's what a
heartbeat is
so we'll go ahead and run that
and we'll give it a moment here i'm not
sure why it's crying
that doesn't work i'll just click off
and try that again
so go back to availability we'll hit run
and it has the right scope if you're
wondering how it knows what to check
that's all based on scope there
and for whatever reason it just decides
that it doesn't really want to run right
now
that's a bit frustrating but if it's not
working for this one we can always check
our other one which is curizon
and we can go see if this one works
that's why i made multiple servers
because i knew one of these might not
work right away
so i'll go ahead and run this one here
it says no logs are configured so that
makes me think that
our workspace here if we go back over to
here and we go down to virtual machines
that they're actually not linked oh they
still are connecting there you go so
it's a bit misleading it looked like we
could query but we still can't
um let's go take a look at this virtual
machine here
our little one still
and let's see if we can do anything with
it yet
so we go down to
diagnostic settings
it looks like it's installed and so if
we go to performance counters these are
the counters that it should be
collecting data on you could do custom
if you want and change those values
but we're just going to leave it basic
for the time being
go ahead and save that
and i believe we can do logs over here
on this one so we'll go over to
availability i'm going to load that into
the editor this time instead of hitting
run i can hit run and it will return and
says that it has a count to seven so
seven heartbeats that's good
if you wanted to create uh rules you
could easily do that there's actually uh
some nice ones here if we go into here
um
this won't work unless our
our our metrics are working our guest
metrics
but there's a bunch down below here
i'm just trying to see one that might be
interesting for us to set
so you might go here
and
i don't think i like that one
say this one here i'm just going to
clear this all the way out
oops
so here they even say to create this
alert just hit the plus new button here
so we go here
and
sometimes it does this it doesn't
actually bring it over which is weird so
you have to go back
i told you like this the the ui for
azure is super super buggy
so if you don't have any confidence uh
don't worry it's it happens to all of us
um so we'll go back to our alerts
and i'm going to load that into the
editor and what i'm going to do is just
copy it
and um
we're going to go ahead and hit run
and so here we're getting some data back
i think it's going to complain about the
time generated but if we go and create a
new alert
oh man it just does not want to uh copy
anything over a
and so
it's like i can't even paste
we'll go back to here
i'm going to copy this i noticed this
because i had it double clicked maybe
just just
creates one what you have selected
and so it should complain about this but
it's not so that's great and so we can
go here and we can put a threshold to
five
i'm just putting any value here and that
gives you a monthly cost for that alert
so you hit review and create
please correct the following details
where
oh the alert name okay
my alert
and we will hit review and create
we'll hit create
and so there we can create an alert so
we could create alert like our memory is
running out of stuff and those are kind
of useful things to do
so
talking about metrics
we're going to make our way over here
and notice we have host metrics and
guest metrics so host metrics are
general ones that are available to us
and guest metrics are
memory and stuff like that
so if we have that you're going to
notice now we have like disk and memory
and things like that if we didn't have
that installed we wouldn't be able to
access this information
so what i can do is go ahead here and
try disk time i don't know if it'll show
us anything right now because it might
have not collected enough information go
over to virtual host
we'll have different metrics here so a
standard one would be like cp usage
okay so that one is
displaying there the poor performance
metrics always take a little bit more
time to collect so i'm not sure if i'll
stick around to show you that but
if we go over to availability sometimes
we need to go debug
performance like you can hit run and
this will tell you if it's actually
collecting information so see right now
it shows me nothing so it hasn't
collected anything for process memory or
processor but if it did then we could go
and use these other ones down below here
so we have
free disk space so that's a really
useful one to have which we can't get
metrics on that right now
but that's what we've been trying to do
is collect that information so let's go
back to our workspace
and what i'm going to do
is take a look
at our virtual machines that are
connected
and this one has an error um and that's
kurzon and i'm not surprised because
again it's a minimal windows
linux instance so probably couldn't
install the agent so that's expected but
i just wanted to show you that edge case
if we go into the jet zeo one which is
the one we were waiting for this entire
time
we should
hopefully be able to see some metrics so
if we go down here
and we choose yes metrics
i want something with memory here
uh like percentage
okay so it's still not showing me
anything and that's fine if we're not
getting any metrics what we can do is we
can go log into this instance and give
it some data so that it does something
all right
so what i'll do is go all the way to up
to the top here into my overview i'm
going to copy this public ip address
we're going to open up our cloud shell
and make sure that it's in bash all
right
and we're we're going to type in ssh
um
dax
and then we're going to paste
the ip address in we'll hit enter we'll
say yes
and the password is
testing123456 with a capital t
and what we can do here is we can
install a tool called stressng what that
tool does is it will
help us do stress testing and so that
allows us to
make some metrics
so we'll go ahead and install that via
snap
snap is the new package manager for
ubuntu used to be apt-get or apt
it doesn't take too long to install
and while it's installing i actually
have a pre-made uh line here
to check the memory
or to fill up the memory
i'm just going to go ahead and paste
this line in so this is stress hyphen ng
vm bytes and it uses awk it's going to
do memory availability and it's going to
fill it up to 90 percent so we want to
have 90 memory usage i'm going to go hit
enter i'm just going to let that run now
it's not outputting anything but it
definitely is running there we go and so
we're just going to leave it there and
so soon enough we should have some
information
and i think if i go there yep it's still
there so it's fine
so now if we go over to
um down to our
logs
and we go back to
performance
and we just choose this one here
we might see something now
again it takes time so you know it looks
in the 15 minute uh window here
but i just want to see that it's
collecting anything for me it doesn't
matter what it collects just collects
something for me you know
so i think it'll just take a little bit
of time while we're doing that we should
make our way back over to our workspace
because there's some other settings that
are kind of interesting that i noticed
if you go over to agent configuration
um you can collect additional
information over here so we have
performance counters for
windows and linux i think we have to set
the memory one here if we wanted to
actually appear here
so
i don't know if there's a way to set all
of them
but i'm gonna just choose some here so
i'm gonna do memory used
we'll do logical use space here
we'll go here and do free space i think
that might be the reason why it's not
showing up for us
maybe process time here
we did
use memory used percentage of use space
we will do um
do reads and writes
so here we have some for our linux
so i think if i we set that then we
should be able to see some information
uh syslogs is just a type of logs that
you can collect we're not going to look
into those today
but yeah that's the
management there
we could also try setting some here
maybe one for memory i can't remember
what the one for memory is called here
because they do all of this kind of
stuff
like windows has so much stuff i can't
make sense of it
i think we might want paged owls
and
page
so that went called there
bytes we'll give that a go
and we'll see if that starts collecting
information
i'm going to go back over to
uh here
and oh this is kurzon that's the windows
machine we're going to go to the linux
machine here and we'll give it another
go
see if we get anything this time around
so we'll go back to
performance
we'll say what is being collected run
okay
and so i think we're just going to have
to wait a little bit so i'm just going
to stop the video here and i'll see you
back in maybe 15-20 minutes okay
all right so i'm still waiting here and
i don't seem to be seeing any data but
that's okay because there's another way
we can kind of approximate this and we
don't have to wait
forever especially if you don't have a
lot of time like me
the thing is is that azure has a log
analytics tutorial and within here they
have a demo environment that i'm very
familiar with and so this can
approximate exactly what i'm trying to
show you here if you notice at the top
here
this is microsoft azure monitoring logs
demo
log blade
so if we go to queries
and we go down to virtual machines
and we'd look at what data is being
collected we can hit run here
and this is the kind of information we
are trying to see right this is what we
want to see what it's actually
collecting
that's okay we're not doing remote
desktop anymore here and if we go to
virtual memory available we'll just
clear that out there
and run that
this is kind of the information we're
trying to find all right so i just
wanted to show you that when you collect
those metrics that you can run these
queries and this is that language up
there with cousteau
and that's pretty much it that's all i
really wanted to show you so let's go
ahead and tear down all our stuff it's
all self-contained within a resource
group so what we can do
is go to all resources in the top left
corner there
and we called it dax so we can
search for
dax here whoops
actually it's all over the place we just
click here into the name
and we'll hit delete resource group
type in dax
we have a lot of resources created for
this one
and there you go so yeah hopefully that
helps you understand uh those
relationships between automation
accounts where we can run run books do
patching uh you know stuff like that
install python stuff um you know the
fact that
log log analytics is basically a data
lake for all your data that you can
create alerts uh that you have metrics
you have guest os metrics which collect
those three values the
memory the network and the additional
cpu information or disk space
and just the variance there so you don't
get stuck so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we're going to
learn about managed identities or system
managed identities so that we don't have
to pass credentials or hard code them
into our virtual machines or other
environments so what we're going to do
is launch ourselves a new virtual
machine this is going to be a windows
server so go ahead and hit create we'll
create a new virtual machine
and from here we'll say create new and i
say my
managed identity probably say id so i'd
have to spell the whole word and we'll
just say my managed id
and from here
central us is fine the zones are fine
but we're not going to use ubuntu we're
going to hit see all images
and from here we'll choose windows 10
and there's a lot of options here so i
want windows 10 pro
um
it's a bit hard to decide so i'll go gen
2 2 1 h2 hopefully you'll be okay doing
this as well um it's using standard b2s
46 so just make sure you're not
overspending so that should be fine i
think we need at least a b2s to run this
um but we're not going to keep it around
for very long so username i'm going to
go admin user and for the password
capital t testing one two three four
five six
i can do that again capital t testing
one two three four five six exclamation
mark just because of the requirements
such a pain that's what i always do in
these follow alongs
and we're going to use rdp to connect to
it because we do have to uh remote into
it we'll just say i confirm we'll hit
review create of course we don't
actually have a license but we'll be
okay because we're not doing anything
too serious
and we'll give it a moment here
and we'll hit create
so that is going to create while that is
going i'm going to
uh we'll actually have to wait a little
bit but we'll make our way over to the
resource group because this is where
we're going to be adding an im policy at
some point
so if we go over to
i am over here
and we'll wait we'll actually wait for
this to provision so this takes
quite a few minutes so i'll see you back
in maybe 5
10 minutes because we are launching
windows server they just take longer
so after waiting you know five to ten
minutes the environment is ready so
we'll go ahead and go to that resource
and we're going to want to go connect
and choose rdp this is going to be
remote desktop protocol i believe that's
what it stands for if it doesn't not a
big deal just know it's called rdp and
so we'll have an rdp file we'll double
click it we'll hit connect this is going
to open up the room remote desktop
client and so we will type in admin user
and then capital t testing one two three
four five six if you're on a mac you're
like how do i do this well it is in the
mac store just type in remote desktop
it can open here i'll just show you what
i mean
over here we do rdp mac
you can see that it's free to download
so it's just you download that and you
can open those rdp files
so we are just waiting for this to spin
up this takes a little bit of time so
just give it a few minutes
all right so after waiting a little
while the environment is ready so
hopefully you can see what is going on
here and so what we want to do is open
up powershell so we'll type in
powershell here
and we will right click and run as
administrator this does have an outbound
connection the internet so i know that
uh we are okay for our connection and
then this is where
you will need to install azure modules
because it's not
pre-installed and this part
really sucks because we have to wait
a lot more again so i hope you like
waiting a lot but anyway what we'll do
is right click this properties here and
we will bump this up because this font
is super super small
and uh we'll type in install
module
a z and i'll install all the commandlets
for azure or azure and we'll wait for
some prompts the prompts are a bit
finicky
hopefully we can just do a for all but
you might have to hit yes a couple times
but this part is just so so so slow
there we go so notice it doesn't let me
say all we'll just say y
and i know that it's going to prompt us
again so we'll just wait a little bit
here the progress will show up at the
top it's kind of glitchy um yeah so now
we'll do a for all
and so now we just wait a long time now
it seems like it's not doing anything
but you will eventually see something
appear up at the top here that shows you
that there's progress but you just have
to be very patient
yeah so it'll look like that i'm just
showing you what it looks like and i'm
gonna go back and pause till this is all
done because it takes forever
all right so i think it's done it's
sometimes hard to tell because it'll
just kind of like blank out here
and
it's not
doing anything so i'm not 100 sure but
what i'm going to do i'm going to see if
i can just open it twice
this is just the powershell experience
right and um
to test this we'll just do a connect and
see if it works so i'm going to do
connect i just want to close the old one
if it's actually still doing something
connect account
identity
and so if this prompts us with something
then we know that it's working correctly
so
identity not found and that's fine so
the thing is if we just just did this it
would actually prompt us to log in
so see it's prompting us to log with
microsoft so this this worked
um but we need to actually connect an
identity to this virtual machine so
that's what we're gonna do so we'll
minimize this we'll go back over here so
go into your
uh the resource group that we had before
under iem and we're going to add
a new role assignment and from here we
will uh choose contributor because that
will give us enough access for stuff
we'll choose manage identity
and we will
choose system identity
no no no no that's not what i want
because it should show the virtual
machine here
maybe it's because um we opened this
before it was done creating so that's
why it's not showing up so we'll try
this one more time we'll go to
contributor because it should show the
virtual machine manage identity and
select
and
[Music]
i want to see
the virtual machine
weird so i'll click way out i'll go back
in i'll go to i am again we'll go to oh
you know what
we launched this virtual machine we
forgot to check box something
so when you launch the virtual machine
you're supposed to checkbox manage
system identities here
so this would be
[Music]
where would it be
i only ever do it through the setup i
never ever have to retroactively do it
oh what a pain identity maybe
system managed so we'll just say on and
we'll save it
uh grant permissions do you want to
enable a system energetic yes
but normally when you you do the virtual
machine hold on here
we'll just go pretend like we're setting
up a new one we're not actually going to
set one up but when you are setting it
up
and we go over to advanced
no no management
we would check box check box it on uh
here
that's not what we did
so we forgot to do that but we turned it
on here so hopefully it works without us
having to restart the image if we go to
role assignments over here
i mean that's just another way of
getting to this page so it doesn't
really matter for the resource group
what we'll do is go back to our resource
group
we will find it here
and we will go to
[Music]
i am and we will add a role assignment
and we will add contributor we will go
next we will say manage identity we will
select we will go to virtual machine we
will select this one we'll hit select
we'll review and assign we'll review and
assign and then it will sign us
contributor access so now we should be
able to connect our identity and then
also get access to some stuff
um
because what we really want is to do get
a z like to just show that we can get
anything because right now we do this
get ac subscription
we're not
we're not um
connected in any way so we'll go here
and we'll do identity
fingers cross it just works yes it does
that was nice if we didn't have to
restart the machine
and so now if we do
get
ac subscription it should work
so i don't see it working do i type it
wrong the term is not recognized
oh i must have typed it wrong
subscription here
let's get this description so if we were
not authenticated that would not work
and so it does work now
so we are pretty much
all done here well we could probably set
some resources just to make sure this is
working properly so maybe go get
a z resource like that
there so list some resources and it's
only listing what's in the um
the resource group because that's all it
has permissions too it's not going to
show things outside of that
because that's the scope when we did it
at the resource group and that's why we
went at the im level there so we are all
done we will go ahead and close this out
okay we'll make our way back to our
resource group we're already on it we'll
go ahead and delete this resource group
say delete
and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at virtual machines
for azure cheat sheets so let's jump
into it so azure virtual machines allows
you to create linux and windows virtual
machines the size of the virtual machine
is determined by the image the image
defines the combination of vpcus memory
storage capacity the current limit on a
prescription is 20 vms per region vms
are built at an hourly rate a single
instance vm has an availability of 99.9
percent when all storage disks are
premium two instances deployed into
availability set will give you 99.5 95
availability
you can attach multiple managed disks to
an azure vm when you launch an azure
virtual machine other networking
components will be either created or
associated to your virtual machine
such as nsgs interface cards
ips and v-net you can bring your own
linux
by creating your own virtual hard disk
azure vm comes with a variety of sizes
that are also uh optimized for specific
use cases and there's a lot of different
ones here uh so it's not super important
but i mean you should know the broad
categories here uh azure compute unit
acu provides a way of comparing uh cpu
performance across azure skus and the
standard one that the one they're all
benchmarked against is standard a1 all
other skus then represent approxim
approximately how fast faster
the sku can run on the standard
benchmark you can install the azure
mobile app so you can monitor your vms
on the go
hyper-v is microsoft's hardware
virtualization product it lets you
create and run software versions of a
computer called virtual machines that's
how it all works there are two types or
two generations of hyper vm generation
one which works with most operating
systems and generation two that supports
most 64-bit versions of windows and
current
versions of linux and freebsc uh
operating systems
hyper v hyper vvms are packaged into
virtual hard disk formats such as vhd
vhdx files not on the exam but just
understand that uh hyper vm generations
are different from the azure hyper vm
generation so it doesn't have all the
features of hyper vm okay
there are three ways to connect to
virtual machines the first is via secure
shell it's not sure shell it's secure
shell
but yeah so that'll have it get fixed at
some point ssh happens on port 22
and rsa key pairs are commonly used for
authorized access then you have rdp
which is a graphical interface to
connect to another computer over the
network connection this is how you can
remotely connect to the windows server
via virtual desktop this happens on port
3389 on tcp and udp now i mark these red
because i want you to remember these two
so make sure you know them okay
azure bastions and we'll clear that
because now it's getting a bit of a mess
here
there we go so ask your
azure bastion a service you can deploy
lets you connect to a virtual machine
using your browser and azure portal
supports both ssh and rdp useful when
you only have a browser like a
chromebook or do not have permission to
configure or install software then you
have update management this allows you
to manage and install operating system
updates and patches for both windows and
linux virtual machines that are deployed
in azure on-premise or in other cloud
providers update management will perform
a scan or update compliance a compliance
scan by default is performed every 12
hours on a windows and three hours on a
linux machine that can take between 30
minutes and six hours for the dashboard
to display updated data from the managed
computer so there you go that is the
virtual machines chi chi
[Music]
so let's take a look at arm templates uh
and before we jump into it let's just
make sure we're familiar with
infrastructure as code because that's
what arm templates are all about and
this is the process of managing and
provisioning computer center
data centers such as azure through
machine readable definition files such
as a json file and in this case an arm
template because that's all it is a json
file and rather than physical hardware
configuration or interactive
configuration tools and just to simplify
that even further basically you're
writing a script that's going to set up
your cloud services for you and with
iacs they usually come in two different
flavors we have declarative that's where
exactly what you write is what you get
and imperative so you're going to
generally define what you want and then
the service will guess what you want
it's going to fill in the blanks to save
you a lot of time writing those scripts
and so
arm templates are json files that are
that define azure resources that you
want to provision uh and azure services
that you want to configure and with arm
templates they are going to be
declarative so you get exactly what you
define uh they're gonna stand up tear
down or share entire architectures in
minutes and they're going to reduce
configuration mistakes and you know
exactly what you have defined for a
stack to establish an architectural
baseline for compliance so you
definitely want to use arm templates or
iac whenever you can and try to avoid
using the console unless you're doing
development or test workloads but let's
just run through the big list of what
you can do with an arm template i know
this is a big boring list but let's just
get it get through as quickly as
possible just so we know what we can do
with arm templates
so with arm templates that are
declarative so what you see is what you
get you can stand up tear down share
entire environments minutes you can
reduce configuration mistakes you can
establish an architectural baseline for
compliance they're modular so you can
break up your architecture multiple
files and reuse them they're extendable
so you can add powershell and bash
scripts to your templates uh it has
testing so you can use the arm ttk
to test make sure exactly what what
you've deployed is what you wanted
you have preview changes so before you
create infrastructure via templates you
see what it will create built-in
validation so it will only deploy your
template if it passes track deployments
keep track of changes to your
architecture over time policy is code so
apply azure policies to ensure you you
remain compliant uh and then you have
microsoft blueprints which we we did
cover here uh which establishes
relationships between resources and
templates so it's just one step further
where arm templates don't have any
relationship with the resources where
blueprints is like a better version of
our templates and then you have ci cd
integration exportable code so exporting
the current state of the resource groups
and resources
authoring tools i believe is the last on
our list here so you can use visual
studio code that has advanced features
for authoring arm templates makes it a
lot easier to write them so there you go
[Music]
so now we were talking about what arm
templates can do let's actually take a
look at what one looks like and so just
to get a good snapshot or overview let's
just define what the skeleton is the
general structure of an arm template so
here on the right hand side we have json
and you can see that we have a structure
there so we have schema content version
api profile parameters variables
functions resources outputs and let's go
down the list here and see what all
these things are so the schema describes
the properties that are available within
a template
and so the idea is that you have that
json link there and it's going to say we
expect the schema the actual structure
to have these parameters then you have
the content version this is the version
of the template and you can provide any
value for this element it's totally
abstract it's just your way of keeping
track of the version of your current
template then you have the api profile
you use this value to avoid having to
specify api versions for each resource
in the template you have parameters
these are values you can pass along to
your template you have variables this is
where you transform your parameters or
resource properties using function
function expressions you have functions
these are user-defined functions
available within the template you have
resources these are the azure resources
you want to deploy or update and then
you have outputs and these are the
values that are returned after
deployment so let's go
more into deep into some of these things
[Music]
so let's take a deeper look here at the
a resource section within your arm
template and so a resource is an azure
resource you want to provision could be
a virtual machine could be a database
and so here on the right hand side look
at where it says resources and we're
going to take a a breakdown of the
actual columns or tributes that we can
set so the first thing is the type and
this is going to follow the format of
the resource provider and resource type
so there you can see that we are setting
up a storage account then we have the
api version and this is the version of
rest api that we're going to use for
that resource and each resource provider
publishes its own api version so you've
got to go look up each one because they
all could be different then you have the
name of the resource and so i believe
there that is using a variable so that
is going to be dynamic then you have the
location so most resources have a
location property and that's the region
that you wanted to be deployed in
then you have other properties and other
properties can
will be
based on different kinds of resources so
for a storage account you want to be
able to set the kind and within the
properties you're going to have a bunch
of other options there and it's just
going to vary okay
but anyway let's take a closer look next
at parameters
so let's take a closer look here at
parameters and these allow you to pass
variables to your arm templates so on
the right hand side
we have
our arm template and we saw before
resources but if you look above there we
have a thing called parameters and so
there we are setting a parameter and
then down below in the resource we are
accessing um a parameter
and so
let's just actually talk about some of
the parameter options we have so the
first thing you'll want to do is set a
type and on the right hand side you can
see that we're saying as a string and so
we could define that as a string secure
string in blue object secure object and
array
and there are some other things that we
can provide when we when we are defining
your parameters that we're not showing
in that diagram but we have default
values so this is if you do not provide
if there's no value being passed in this
is what it should use then you have
allowed value so this is where it's an
array and you're restricting it to only
the values that are there then you have
the min value so if you let's say it's
an integer you want to say this is the
minimum value so it can only like
nothing lower than 10 then you the max
value so nothing above 10 you have the
minimum length so if you're working with
strings you might say it has to be a
minimum of five characters
then you have the maximum so let's say
you have a maximum of five characters uh
then you have the description so this is
just going to be something that when you
are using the arm template within the
portal you know what it's for so if you
don't have a great
description for that parameter or name
and you want to provide more information
that's what you can do so there you go
[Music]
so let's take a look here at functions
for arm templates and these allow you to
apply transformations to your arm
variables and they come in two flavors
we have template functions which are
built in functions and then user defined
functions which are custom functions
that we're creating to allow what other
kind of functionality that we want so
the way functions work is you give the
function name so here it's called equals
and then you have parentheses and you
pass in uh what you want to transform so
if you see parentheses that's how you
know that is a function
so let's talk about some of the built-in
functions and so there are a lot
available for us and they're generally
self-explanatory so i'm not going to be
showing examples but let's just go
quickly to the list so you have array
functions like array concat contains
create array empty first etc then you
have comparisons like less equals less
lesser equals greater greater or equals
you have date functions uh you have
deployment functions
and for example parameters and variables
are actually functions
so that's kind of interesting then you
have a logical operator so end or if not
or
numerical um functions like add div
float int min max object so contains
empty intersection and then you have
resources so
extension resource id
providers references etc like that uh
and there's one more i think we have
string so we have base64
concat contains etc i'm not going to
show you how to do user defined
functions i don't think that's that
important
but i just want to show you that you
have a lot of functions available to you
okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at variables and
variables are used to simplify your arm
templates and the idea is that you're
transforming parameter and resource
properties using functions and then
assigning them to reusable variables so
under your variables section notice that
we have storage name and on the right
hand side we're just using a bunch of
functions and assign it to storage name
so the idea is that when we have to go
call them in our resources it's going to
be a lot shorter than if we had to
write that whole thing in there and
what's more interesting is that you can
nest your variables within a json object
so on the left-hand side you have this
variables environment settings test
instance sizes etc and then on the
right-hand side we have a parameter
that we're defined here and then down
below you can see that we're calling
that parameter and then we're calling
variables environment settings and then
using the square braces to then call
within that nested object i know that
seems really confusing but just take a
moment to look at it
and it will make sense and you'll just
understand that there's a lot of power
there so there you go
so last on our list here for uh arm
templates is outputs and outputs return
values from deployed resources so you
can use them programmatically uh this is
very simple the idea here is that you
have outputs and let's say you want uh
to output the resource id so you can say
that it's a string and in the value you
could use a variable or a bunch of
functions and the idea is that when you
use the cli
so imagine here you are using the cli
and you're saying show me this
deployment group and
i want to
see the output of value so see where it
says query says properties output
resource id value the idea is that now
i'm going to be able to pragmatically
access it after i've created the
resource and this is a great way of
chaining things so you might have a
bunch of arm templates you want to run
in sequence and you're going to need the
outputs to go into the next one and that
is what you're going to use outputs for
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure resource
manager templates also known as arm
templates and this helps you deliver
infrastructure as code meaning that when
you have a resource such as a virtual
machine or a storage account instead of
manually configuring it every single
time through
the portal what you can do is provide a
configuration file that defines all the
properties that you want it to be
configured with and the idea is that you
can
keep this file and share with other
other people so they can easily create
the same resources as you
and then you know exactly how your stuff
is is configured so what we're going to
do is uh launch a new template now you
can't go up here and just type in arm
because
these arm templates are managed at
different levels so at one level is a
script subscription or they're resource
groups so when you have a resource group
you have deployments within them and
that's where
these templates are deployed
but just to deploy one from here what
we're going to do is type in deploy why
they didn't make it so you can type in
arm i do not know but if you go down
here we have deploy a custom template
and so from here we have some common
templates so if i click into web app and
i go edit a template we already have
some stuff pre-filled in i'm just going
to go back and discard that go back to
select a template and we're going to
build our own and by default we'll have
that schema that content version which
is 1.0.0.0
our parameters and our resources so
today i want to launch a virtual machine
and what you normally would have to do
is go here uh and look up what is that
you want to create so if it's this uh
microsoft compute virtual machine you'd
go through here and you'd have to make
sure you have all these uh properties so
you define the resource here right the
type
and then you define the properties that
you want and down below you can go
through here and see them all that's a
lot of work i don't want to do that so
i'll go to add resource here drop this
down and click
uh where's it virtual machine where are
you there you are
and i'm going to call this one wharf
and then wharf and wharf because it's
not just going to create a virtual
machine it's going to create the other
things that i need with it as well such
as the storage account the network
interface and the virtual network
so you can see that we have a bunch of
parameters here so the name
the type the name the admin username the
password and the os version
oh you know what i think i chose a
windows one i do not want a windows one
i want a linux one
because that is easier for me to work
with here so we choose ubuntu so i'll
just fill this in again
all right and so um back up here you
know we have the ubuntu version between
some versions here and then there's the
type so that's for uh replication then
we have variables here so if we go to vm
size this is the vm it will it will set
here
variables are either you can have string
values or you can use functions to
transform other parameters into
other stuff that you'll reference
throughout your template then down below
we have those resources here so what
we'll do
is actually i'm going to copy this
because it's very highly likely we're
going to want to make some kind of
change and so i have vs code over here
on the on the left or right hand side
i'm just going to paste that on in there
and what we will do this is a json file
make things a little bit easier here
great and what i'll do is just move that
off screen and we'll go ahead
and we will save this and we'll see if
we can deploy this
so i'm going to type in wharf here and
we'll launch in canada east i'll name
this wharf we will name the username
warf but lowercase and then we'll do
testing one two three four five six
capital on the t
notice that it is hidden there
and then we will choose 14 which is
defaulted here and lrs we'll go ahead
and do review and create
and we'll hit create here
so this is going to fail i already know
because it has a misconfiguration it'll
tell us how but while that's going we'll
take a look at our input so this is the
values that were inputted these are the
outputs if we had defined any which we
have not
um and if we go back to our template i
just wanted to show you that we have
that secure string so when we were
typing our password that's why we didn't
see it
so just things like
that so i'll go back up here and our
deploy failed why what happened
so we open it up here the requested vm
size standard d1 is not available in the
current region so the template we have
is not that great
it needs some configuration because we
can't use d1 i think that doesn't exist
anymore and so what we really want to
use is the standard b1 ls
all right
standard b1 ls so i'm going to cut that
and for the time being i'm going to go
back to our original template
and this is one big template
i'm going to look for those variables oh
they're all the way at the bottom here
nice and so i'm going to just go ahead
and paste that in
b1 ls just double check making sure i
spelled that right standard
standard b1 ls looks good to me
so i'm going to move that off screen and
the question is what do we do
what do we do when a deploy fails so
let's go take a look at what has
happened here so this all got deployed
into a resource group and under here
this is where our deployments are
so when we look at this
template it we can see that it failed we
could click into here get the same
information
and if we click into here it just brings
us back to where we just were but if we
go look at what was actually deployed
under our resource group
under the overview we'll notice that it
created the virtual network the storage
account and the network interface so
when it fails it creates what it can but
it doesn't roll back
okay
so the question is is then how do you do
cleanup so you might think i'll go to
deployments and what i'll do is go ahead
and delete that template and we can go
ahead and do that which by the way you
can't edit this template all you can do
is
all we can do here see i just want to
show you that you cannot edit it
we can download it and stuff like that
but so you might think well if i go
ahead and delete that template
just making sure we're in the right
place here
you might think that might roll back
those resources but it doesn't it just
deletes the template so if you really
want to get rid of the stuff what you
got to do
is go ahead and delete all these
resources manually
so um
i wish it kind of had a rollback feature
but that's just how it is
but there are some nice things that uh
azure does here which we'll talk about
in a moment so i think we have adjusted
it to the correct value now so hopefully
this is going to be all we need to make
it work
so what we'll do
is go to our deployments here
and we can't do it here but so we'll go
back to the top here and type in deploy
and we'll go to custom template
and what we'll do is build our own
template in our editor and i'm just
going to
copy the contents here
okay we'll go copy
and i will go
paste
and we'll make sure that this is all
good looks fine to me we'll go ahead and
hit save
and we will choose wharf so we don't
have to make a new one and we will fill
in uh the name as worf
the username is warf i'll call warf2
just in case
helps us keep track of what we're doing
here
testing one two three four five six with
a capital on the t
14 l rls lrs and we'll go ahead oh we
have one issue here
cannot deploy a resource group
worth deleting
um we'll go back
and we will hit create here
i don't think i deleted the resource
group let me just go double check
i almost i'm almost certain i deleted
all the contents of it right
oh so there's already one here so we're
just waiting for that to delete
just gonna go delete for us please thank
you
it failed to delete we'll go take a look
as to why
resource is not found
uh we'll go back to our resource groups
give us a refresh here
okay so you know what i must have
deleted the resource group which is
totally fine
i i could have saw i only deleted the
contents of it
but we'll just call this worth regular
then
we'll go ahead and hit
create here
and so this time
i have better feeling about this
and so we will just have to wait a
little bit it won't take too long
i'll see you back in a moment
okay so after waiting a little bit here
our our thing seems to be deployed so if
we go to resource groups we can see that
our virtual machine is deployed so
that's pretty much all there is to it
one other thing i'd like to show you is
that whatever you have whatever is in
your resource group you can actually
export the template so
if you did configure something manually
all you'd have to do is find the
resource
go up here to up
it is export template
and there's your template
so it just has that single resource in
there i can't remember if
if i go into here if i select multiples
um and i go x exper where's it
export template
look it's gonna include all that stuff
so if you already have existing
resources that you provisioned and you
want to have them that's what you can do
notice that some things won't be
included in the template when you do
that but you can just go ahead and
download them and then you have them for
later so yeah that's all there really is
to
arm other than learning the uh the nitty
gritties of the actual language that's
just how you work with it there so what
i'm going to do is make my way over to
my resource group here
and i'm just going to go ahead and
delete this here
and we're all good to go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure resource
manager templates also known as arm
template so the thing we need to know is
infrastructure as code this is the
process of managing and provisioning
computer data centers through machine
readable definition files such as json
files rather than physical hardware
configuration or interactive
configuration tools iec comes in two
flavors we've got declarative which is
what you define is what you get and
imperative so you say generally what you
want and it will guess or it'll fill in
the blanks for you uh for arm templates
uh they are json files as we're
suggesting above there that want to
provision azure services you want to
configure they are declarative so you
get exactly what you define
an arm template is made of the following
json structure you should know the
structure pretty well because you might
see questions where they're showing you
that code so be sure you know all these
parts schema describes the properties
that are available within a template
content version the version of the
template you can provide any value for
this element api profile use this value
to avoid having to specify api versions
for each resource in the template
parameters values you can pass along to
your template variables uh things you
can transform parameters or resource
properties using functions and
expressions uh and i did include them in
this the cheat sheet but there is a
bunch of variations on variables and
functions but i think that's practical
skills you should just grab we don't
want this in a cheat sheet functions
used to find functions available within
the template there are so many functions
it wasn't even worth pulling them out
and putting some here
resources the azure resources you want
to deploy or update and under resources
you've got type of resource api version
the name the location other properties
which can be a bunch of different stuff
so there's no consistency there and then
outputs which are values that are
returned after deployment so you can do
things with them pragmatically so there
you go that is the arm templates cheat
sheet
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure container
instances also known as aci and this
allows you to package deploy and manage
cloud applications using containers or
the way i like to think of it as fully
managed docker as a service
azure container instances allow you to
launch containers without the need to
worry about configuring or managing the
underlying virtual machines and you're
going to be able to design isolate
containers for simple applications task
automations and build jobs let's talk
about some of the uh reasons why you'd
want to use containers over vms so
containers can be provisioned within
seconds where vms will take several
minutes containers are built per second
where vms are built per hour so you'll
save a lot more money containers have
granular
and custom sizing vpc
vpcus memory and gpus where vm sizes are
predetermined uh so those are the
benefits between containers and vms
aci can be utilized for both windows and
linux containers you can persist storage
with azure files using aci containers
and honestly if you have containers or
functions you have to have an external
storage mounted to persist
that's just the way you do it acis are
accessed via fully qualified domain
names which is one of the things i
really appreciate about azure services
because mostly services are like that
azure provides quick start images to
help you start uh launching example apps
but you can also source containers from
azure container registry docker hub and
privately hosted container registries it
looks like that the choice option there
let's just talk about container groups
because this is pretty much the only
major component you have to worry about
these are a collection of containers
that get that get scheduled on the same
host and the containers uh the
containers in a container group share
life cycle resources local network
storage volumes so the idea is that you
have these tightly coupled containers so
all of them act as a service within that
container group so here you can see an
example of a couple containers that are
mounting azure files on different
directories there and underneath all of
that is running on an azure virtual
machine
container groups are similar to
kubernetes pods
yeah and it says similar to but not
really the same thing multi-container
groups can currently support only linux
containers which is kind of a bummer but
that's just what it is and there are two
ways to deploy a multi-container group
you can use arm templates when you need
to deploy additional azure service
resources or just a yaml file when you
want to deploy
when your deployment only includes
container instances
[Music]
let's take a look at container restart
policies and what these do is allow you
to change how the policies uh restart
and there's three different ways we have
always uh never and on failure so the
first one here always means always
restart the container and the idea is to
keep your container running as long as
possible and the reason why you'd want
that is if you're running a web server
some other providers would call that a
service then we have never so run only
one time this is great for background
jobs and so other providers would just
call this a task
then you have on failures so containers
that encounter an error that's when it
should
restart
and so it's as simple as just choosing
that option uh when you uh are creating
that container
[Music]
let's take a look at container
environment variables also known as
nvars that allow you to pass
configuration details to your containers
and you can do this through the portal
the cli powershell which that's always
the case with azure and so it's as
simple as just putting in your uh key
and your value uh and one other thing i
want to point out is that you can also
pass in secured environment variables so
the idea is that sometimes you don't
want them plain text so if you have like
so you have that stripe secret key you
don't want anyone ever seeing that in
production so the idea is that through
and i don't think you can do this
through the portal but you can do this
through the cli or powershell is provide
the secure environment variables over
the regular one which isn't environment
variables and that way you can pass it
securely so it's never
exposed to human eyes
[Music]
let's talk about persisting storage and
we talked about that a little while
there when we were looking at azure
files but uh containers are stateless by
default so when a container crashes or
stops all i'll state is lost to persist
a state you need to mount an external
volume and there's quite a few different
things we can mount as azure files
secret volumes empty directory a cloud
git repo
so you got a few options there and to
mount a file volume you need to do this
via powershell or cli you're going to
give the following detail so when you
launch the container there's going to be
nothing in the portal so you got to do
it this way all right
[Music]
let's talk about some of the cli options
that we can use to troubleshoot our
containers a lot of this stuff is
probably uh accessible of the portal but
it's great to know how to do this via
the cli so the first thing is getting
the log so you can use azcontainer logs
and that's going to bring you logs back
then you can use az container attach
and this is going to give you diagnostic
information about when the container is
starting up probably with a cloud in it
information then you have a z container
exact and this allows you to execute uh
remote commands but what you can do is
use bin sh which actually will allow you
to have an interactive container it's
like having the terminal right to the
container which is very very very useful
and the last is just going grabbing
metrics
from azure monitor so azmonitor metrics
list
you could use the portal for that but i
just wanted to show you all those things
because they might show up on the exam
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at azure
container instances so here it is so all
we got to do is go to container
instances we'll hit add and the nice
thing is that azure provides us with a
hello world one so it's very easy for us
to get started
it's a linux machine and it looks like
it's pretty inexpensive there so we'll
stick with that i'm going to create a
new group here we're going to call it
banana
and we'll name the container instance
and east u.s 2 seems fine to me you'll
notice we're on a quick start image if
we wanted we could use something from
the docker hub and provide our own link
but we'll just stick with the quick
start image for today we're going to go
ahead and hit next to networking just to
see what we have as options you can make
it public or private we'll go to
advanced hold on here
yep those are just the ports you can
expose we'll go to advanced and for the
restart policy we can set on failure
always or never we can pass in
environment variables and i've covered
this a lot more in detail in the lecture
content so we don't need to really dive
deep into this
and we'll go ahead and create this
instance
and so we'll have to wait a little while
here and i'll see you back in a moment
okay and so after a short wait our
container instance is ready we'll go to
that resource there and take a look
around so on the left hand side we can
go to our containers and there we can
see it running we can see the events
down below of what's going on so you can
see that it's pulled the image
it successfully pulled it and it started
the container
some properties nothing interesting
there the logs if we wanted to see stuff
and if we wanted to connect to the
instance we could also go here and hit
connect which is kind of nice
i don't have any purpose to do that
right now so and it's also not going to
work the way we're doing it but i just
wanted to show you you had those
opportunities
uh you can do identity so that means
manage it with role based access
controls but what i want to see is
actually this hello world working i'm
assuming there must be a
hello page i've never looked at it
before so we're going to go here grab
the public ip address and paste it on in
the top and there we go so we have
deployed a instance onto azure container
instances or a container i should say
so nothing super exciting to talk about
here but we do need to know the basics
uh there
if we wanted to deploy other containers
it's just the one there so that's all
you really need to do
but yeah
so yeah hopefully that gives you an idea
there i'll just go back to the list here
so we can see it and we'll go ahead and
just uh delete that probably do it for
the view the resources on the left-hand
side like i always like to do
and we will go into banana here
and we will delete banana
and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure container
images cheat sheet and this is a two
pager so let's jump into it so aci
allows you to launch containers without
the need to worry about configuring or
managing the underlying virtual machine
acis is designed for isolate containers
for simple applications task automation
build jobs containers can be provisioned
within seconds where the vms can take
several minutes containers are built per
second where vms are built per hour so
you get greater savings when you're
using containers containers have
granular and custom sizing vpc memory
and gpu when vm sizes are predetermined
aci can deploy both on windows and linux
you can persist storage with azure files
acis
are accessed via fully qualified domains
so it's just like a domain name
then we have container groups these are
a collection of containers that get
scheduled on the same host machine
the container is a container group share
so you got lifecycle resources local
network storage volumes container groups
are similar to kubernetes pods
multi-container groups currently support
only linux containers this is one of the
cases where uh it's not windows it's
linux okay there are two ways to deploy
multi-container groups you have uh that
via an arm template and yaml file i
imagine you can do them via blueprints
as well a container restart policy
specifies what a container should do
when their process has been completed
aci has three restart policies always
never and on
failure okay
we'll go on to the second one here so
azure containers are stateless by
default when a container crashes or
stops
all state is lost to persist state you
need to mount an external volume you can
mount the following external volumes so
either azure file secret volume empty
directory or cloud git repo
for a container tribute shooting these
are just azure cli commands you should
really really know so i'm just going to
list them out here you've got ac
container logs ac container attached az
container exact
which is for execute at az monitor
metrics list so there you go that is the
aci images cheat sheet
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure container
registry also known as acr which create
and maintain azure canadian registries
to store and manage your private docker
container images and related artifacts
so azure container registry is a managed
private docker registry service based on
the open source docker registry 2.0 and
the idea here is that you can use
container registries with your existing
container development deployment
pipelines and it also has this thing
called registry tasks to build container
images in azure and the idea here is
that you can pull images uh from your
container registry to various deployment
targets like kubernetes
dc os which i forget what it stands for
but it's basically an operating system
for containers docker swarm uh and
there's also many azure services that
directly support acr so
aks azure app service azure batch azure
service fabric and a lot more so it's
just a matter of saying hey use this
from acr and it works right away
uh developers can also push to container
registry as part of a container
development workflow with delivery tools
such as azure pipelines and jenkins and
it's so easy to push
to container registry
there are many ways to work with acr via
the cli the power azure powershell azure
portal azure sdk and there's also this
really good extension called docker
extension for visual studio code
something you absolutely want to install
and maybe i'll make a full slide on it
because i like it so much
[Music]
let's take a look here at acr tasks
which allow you to automate os and
framework patching for your docker
containers and uh we have a few
different options here so the first is
quick tasks these allow you to push a
single container image to a container
registry on demand and you don't need to
be running a local docker engine
installation to do it so that's a really
good benefit
uh you can also trigger some automated
build actions so maybe you push some
source code updates you update the
container base image you want to do it
on a a timer that's on a schedule you
can also have multi-step tasks so you
have to go for the various steps to
complete that task
for each acr task it has an associated
source code context this is the location
of the set source files used to build a
container image or other artifact tasks
can take advantage of run variables so
reuse task definitions and standardized
tags for images and artifacts so there
you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this along we are going to be
working with acr or also known as
container registries so type in acr at
the top actually that doesn't work type
in container and we will go to the
registries and we'll create ourselves a
new registry now list to have multiple
container repositories or images hosted
here on azure so i'm going to just type
in my acr and we'll say ok and the
register name is going to be my acr i'm
just going to put a bunch of numbers
here so maybe 8080
[Music]
it probably doesn't like the hyphens
there we go
all the names are crazy you just have to
flip around to figure it out we're going
to choose basic because we can do
everything we want on basic
we'll go ahead and hit review
and create
and we'll give it a moment to allow it
to start deploying
and we'll just wait till this is done
deploying our registry
all right so that took less than five
seconds and we'll go ahead and go to
that resource
and so what we need to do is go to
access keys we're going to enable admin
users so that we can actually log in via
docker to our image so now what we need
to do is get some repositories going and
if we go over to repositories tab i
don't think there's much we can do here
i don't know if you can create
repositories directly here i always just
push
yeah so you don't you don't have a
button to say create a repository like
github you actually have to push to it
so i'm going to go to github and i'm
going to create myself a new repository
i'm going to call under the other
example we'll say my acr it's already
there so i'll say new
and
we'll go down below actually doesn't
matter we'll just go ahead and hit
create
and from there i'm going to open this up
in git pod all you have to do to open
something up in gitpod
is to attach this end here you can also
do this in your local environment but
you do have to have docker
set up and so that's why it's easier to
use git pod now cloud shell in azure
actually has docker installed but
doesn't run a docker instance so it's
not that easy to work with so it really
is easier to just work with git pod here
or locally if you have docker installed
so we're going to say docker login and
then we're going to provide the
login server
we'll hit enter it's going to ask for
our username so that is our username
there so i'm going to paste it in it's
going to ask for our password so i'm
going to copy that paste that on in
there hit enter and so now we can push
to that repository i'm going to pull
a image called hello world that's just a
standard
application to say hello world
if we do like docker run i t
d
um
hello world i think that's what it is to
type it whoops i can actually spell it
right
then we could probably run it over here
there's like a docker tab so we can see
if it's running notice that it exited if
we view the logs
it probably just says hello world
yeah hello from docker so there you go
that's a simple way of running a docker
container
and
terminal will be reused for other tasks
press any key to close it so i just hit
space there
i t d or t i think is for the tag name
so it's called hello world so we type
docker images it shows up there in i's
for i don't know interactive d is for
daemon so it runs in the background but
anyway we want to push this to
[Music]
azure so the way we're going to do that
is we're going to type in docker
tag because we have to tag this image
and we're going to choose the image id
here and then we need to provide the
repository name so i'm going to assume
it's the login
server
and then we just say example
hello world
hit enter and we can say docker push and
then copy
this here
and that should push it over to
azure
we'll go back over here give it a
refresh so repository is there
so
that's all it takes to push so this is
one part but we'll figure the other part
next here soon okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what we're going to do is use the
last um
follow along in order to reference an
image in our container here because we
pushed an image but what if we want to
reference one as an application in an
actual docker file because that is a
very common use case so in our gitpod
environment which we still have i'm
going to type in dockerfile
and in here what we can do is reference
our image i always forget what the top
line is export run import something so
i'm going to just look for example i'm
going to go to um
docker ruby
because i know how to use this image
pretty pretty uh pretty good so we'll
just go with it
and it's from i always forget that so
we'll type in from and the idea is that
we want to
reference something like this but i know
if we use the hello world one it's a bit
finicky to build so i don't want to use
this one but i'm going to say ruby
or um yeah ruby's fine here and so we're
going to pull the the ruby image so we
say docker
pull ruby
and we'll have to push this one
so we'll pull it
give it a moment
and now we'll type in docker
um
images
and we need to grab the ruby
image id and we'll say docker
tag
this one
and we gotta go up and grab this part
here
paste that in i could just say ruby here
and then we can do docker push
ruby
and while that's going i'm just going to
go here and type in run
echo
hello ruby because the idea is we just
want to build a docker image that's from
a remote location
so what i'm going to do is just save
this so we'll say uh save my docker file
it's like the only file we saved here
just waiting for that to finish pushing
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to uh you know close this
environment and then launch it again
because i don't want to have any of
those images there i don't have to
figure out how to delete them
it's like docker rmi it can be really
finicky about deleting images but the
idea is i just want to make sure they're
not there so that when we pull we know
that it actually is pulling from there
not locally
we will have to do a docker login here
in a moment
so type in
we'll type in docker login
and we'll go back over here and we will
log in
say allow
we'll go back
to here we'll grab the username
we'll go back over to here
we'll grab the password
so that's good and um
hey where's our dockerfile
our dockerfile seems to be
gone i guess we forgot to sync it and
that's totally fine we'll just type it
in again it's not a big deal from
here we'll say ruby and i'll say run
echo
hello ruby
and so now what i want to do is i want
to do docker build period
and so if we are logged in and we can
pull it so it's in great shape
so it's the fact that we are pulling
that image and that was the other part i
wanted to show you there so it doesn't
matter if this finishes because it
obviously is working but we'll give it a
second here to uh finish downloading
there we go
um and so that's all so we'll go ahead
and close this and we'll make our way
back over to azure
and we will go and type in resource
groups
and we will choose my acr
and we'll go delete resource group
and we'll delete that
we're done so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at azure
container registries cheat sheet so acr
is a managed private docker registry
service based on the open source docker
registry 2.0
it uses azure container registries with
your existing container development or
sorry yeah development and deployment
pipelines use azure
or use acr tasks to build containers
images in azure pull images from an
azure container registry to various
targets uh and targets could be
kubernetes uh dc os which is i can't
remember the name of the full name of
that operating system docker swarm uh
for acr tasks this allows you to
automate os and framework patching for
your docker containers you can trigger
them
you can trigger automated builds by
source code updates updates to container
based images triggers on a schedule you
can create multi-step tasks each acr
task has an associated code context and
tasks can take
advantage of run variables that's the
end of it there you go see you in the
next section
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure app services
which allows you to quickly deploy and
manage web apps on azure without
worrying about the underlying
infrastructure and specifically this is
known as a platform as a service
so azure app service is an http based
service for hosting web applications
rest apis and mobile backends and you
can choose your programming language and
it can either be windows or linux
environment and it's a platform as a
service so if you've ever used heroku is
basically the heroku of azure and so
azure app service takes care of a lot of
the underlying infrastructure for you so
it can do security patches of the os and
languages load balancing auto scaling
automated manager
and then um there's a lot of things that
you can implement
and so for integration such as azure
devops github integrations docker hub
package management easy to set up
staging environments custom domains
attaching uh ssl certificates so you can
see that it just basically takes care of
everything for you
if it's really hard for you or time
consuming for you to do all this on your
own in azure and the way it works is you
pay based on an azure app service plan
honestly i find these really confusing
um i really like how aws does elastic
bean stock because you're just paying
for the underlying services but azure
has all these crazy uh tiers here but
you have shared tier which is free and
shared doesn't support linux you have
the dedicated tier
which is basic standard premium premium
version two and three and the isolated
tier and so uh another thing i need to
note is that azure app services is not
just for traditional
vms for monoliths you can also run
docker single or multi containers
and when you set up a project you're
going to choose your domain name on the
azure websites.net obviously you can
override that with your custom domain
name but there you go
[Music]
let's talk about azure app services
runtimes and so let's define what
runtime is a runtime is software
instructions that are executed while
your program is running and so runtime
generally means what programming
language libraries and frameworks you're
going to be using and so runtimes for
azure app services are predefined
containers that has your programming
languages and probably some commonly
used libraries for those languages
installed and probably commonly used
languages for its web frameworks
and so the idea is that you're going to
choose your runtime
it could be net
net core java ruby
which i'm very disappointed in azure
because uh as of shooting this video
they do not support uh ruby for
application insights but yet they have
it here in azure app services node.js
php python and there's all the logos if
you like seeing the logos and so azure
app services generally has multiple
versions so they have like ruby 2.6 2.7
for php they have a lot of versions for
node.js they have a lot of versions
but i just want to point out uh that
it's pretty common for cloud providers
to stop or to retire the old ones at
some point to stop supporting them uh
you know that's just because they want
to keep things modern
and the other thing is like it also
helps you keep with your best security
practices because really you should
always be trying to upgrade to the
latest version uh for those security
patches and and things like that so
there you go
[Music]
now let's say uh you wanted to use a
language that wasn't supported on um
azure app services like you wanted to
use uh elixir what you could do is
create your own custom container either
for windows or linux uh and so uh you
just go ahead and create your own docker
container in your local environment you
can push it to an azure container
registry and then the idea is you can
deploy your container image to your app
service so i just wanted you to know
that you could do that um if there's
some languages or other things or maybe
you're using a language but you need uh
some
bundle or packages that are uh they're
just baked into the uh into the
container so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about deployment slots so
deployment slots allow you to create
different environments for your web
application and associate a different
host name this is useful when you need a
staging or a quality assurance
environment or maybe you need to like a
developer environment any kind of
environment you want so think of it as a
way to quickly clone your production
environment for other uses and so down
below here you'd have your deployment
slots and there's your slots to maybe
you have apps staging beta so that's the
different
host names there
and so the idea is that not only do you
have other environments but there's also
this thing called swapping and the idea
is like imagine
uh you decide like you make a clone of
your production environment and then you
deploy the latest version to it and then
when you decide that it's good it's in
good shape then what you can do is swap
it out with your current production
environment and then just retire your
old one this is called blue green
deployment
and so that is a great way to do
deployments and i just wanted you to be
aware of
that so i wanted to talk about app
service environment because i just
wanted to show you how
azure app service is not just for a
little toy apps or your small startup
but they can be really useful for larger
enterprises so
app service environment is an azure app
service feature that provides fully
isolated and dedicated environment for
securely running
app service uh at high scale and this is
going to allow you to host web or
windows web apps linux web apps docker
containers mobile apps and functions
and app service environments are
appropriate for application workloads
that require very high scale isolation
and secure network access
high memory utilization
and again you know when you think of
platform as a service you don't think at
this kind of scale so it's really
impressive that azure does this
customers can create multiple ases
within a single azure region or across
multiple azure regions making ases ideal
for horizontal scaling stateless
application tiers in support of high
requests per second rp rps workloads and
ase comes with its own pricing tier and
that's the isolated tier and ac can be
used to configure security architecture
apps running ase can have their access
gated by upstream devices such as a web
application firewall also known as a
waff
app or ssases
can be deployed into availability zones
using zone pinning i don't know what
that is a zone pinning but that sounds
good to me
and there are two deployment types for
ase we have external ase and ilb ase
let's go take a quick look at what those
look like so here's a big diagram
and look in the middle there that's
where our azure
service environment is it's in our own
v-net and a subnet and the idea is that
you if the reason it's called an
external ase is because it exposes the
esc hosted app on an internet accessible
ip address and then down below
if you wanted to connect this this is
generally what people are probably using
for but what you want to do is you can
connect it to your on-premise via a site
to site or express route vpn
so that's something you can do with it
and the other part is like you can
because the esc is within the same v-net
it also has access to resources within
the v-net without any additional
configuration so that's really nice and
then the second uh a second one here it
looks it's exactly identical but there's
one key difference and it has this ilb
there and an ilb stands for internal
load balancer uh and that is basically
the only difference
so uh there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at uh
deployment for azure app services and
let's just first define deployment so
that's the action of pushing changes or
updates from a local environment or
repository into a remote environment and
azure app services has a lot of options
for us and that's to me is the most
powerful thing about azure app services
because
it's easy to deploy a web app to a
virtual machine backed by a database but
figuring out deployment is a very time
consuming and tricky thing and azure app
services gives us so many options
unbelievable amount of options it is so
so great of them to do that for us so we
can run from a package deploy zip or or
rar deploy via ftp deploy via cloud sync
deploy continuously from like github or
use azure pipelines
deploy using custom containers
using docker hub azure container
registry deploy from a local git repo
deploy using github actions deploy using
github action containers or deploy with
an arm template so we're not going to
look at all of these how they work but
let's look at a few of them so we just
have an idea how robust of these options
are the first one we're going to look at
is running from a package and this is
when files in the package are not copied
to the www uh root directory instead the
zip package itself gets mounted directly
as a read only
www route directory so basically all
other deployment methods and app service
have to deploy to the following
directory if it's if you're on a windows
machine it's going to be home site wwe
root if you're on linux it's going to be
home site www root and so since the same
directory is used by your app at runtime
it's possible for deployment to fail
because of file lock
conflicts and for that and for that
reason uh the app might behave
unpredictably because some of the files
are not
yet updated so this is the reason why
you might want to create a package
um it's just because it it circumvents
the issue of just replacing files in the
folder
another method is the zip and rar
deployment this uses the kudu servers
service that powers continuous
integration based deployments and qd is
used for a lot of things but it's an
engine behind git deployments and azure
app services and it's open source
project that can also run outside of
azure
and so cuda supports the following
functionality for zip file deployments
and it supports a lot more than just
zips but it does deletion of files left
over from a previous deployment option
to turn on the default build process
which includes package restore
deployment customization including run
deployment scripts deployment logs a
file size of uh
was it two gigs two gigs and uh you can
use it with the cli the api uh vrs with
curl or the azure portal
uh so
by the way that's that's you uploading a
zip uh but you're essentially using kudu
underneath okay
uh and so let's go take a look at
another deployment method which is file
transfer protocol uh ftp has been around
for forever and this is pretty much how
people thought you were supposed to
deploy your apps in the late 90s and
early 2000s i don't think it's a really
great way to deploy but the point is is
that if you want to do it this way or
you have a use case that makes sense you
can do it so the idea is that the
deployment center you would uh say i
want to use ftp and you just you get an
ftp endpoint your username and password
and that's your credentials you use your
ftp client to connect
uh very old school but it's an option
for you which is really nice another way
which to me is a bit bizarre but it's
cool that you can do it is you can use
dropbox or onedrive to deploy using
cloud sync so the idea is that you have
dropbox it's a third party cloud storage
service onedrive's the same thing it's
just microsoft's uh thing
and so you go to deployment center
configure dropbox or onedrive and when
you turn it on it will just sync or
it'll just create a folder in your
dropbox drive and that will get synced
so that's the one for onedrive that's
the one for dropbox and this is going to
sync to that www route there
i would have loved to take in some
screenshots but i couldn't find how to
turn the service on but i know it exists
i just was i thought it was so bizarre
but yeah there you go that is the
deployment methods there
[Music]
so the way you pay
when you use azure app service is you
need an azure app service plan and
that's going to determine you know how
much you pay and what's going to be
available to you they got three tiers
which we're going to go uh through here
shortly and we did mention them earlier
i honestly do not like this whatsoever
this tells you this is a microsoft
product because it has these uh wonky
pricing tiers i hope in the future
they'll change it but that's just what
it is and so let's go learn it so
basically what you do is you have like
this big wizard uh that tells you all
the stuff that you can have it tells you
what's included and stuff like that
but let's work our way through it so the
first thing is the shared tier and
there's two types here we got free and
shared and so there's the free tier that
red one there it's called f1 it gives
you one gigabyte of disk space up to 10
apps on a single shared instance no sla
for availability and each app app has a
compute quota of 60 minutes per day so
there you go you get some free tier
there then there's the shared tier this
provides up to 100 apps on a single
shared instance no sla availability each
app has a compute quota of 240 minutes
per day
uh and the thing is is that i didn't
know where the button is for that so
like the next thing right beside it is
the dedicated tier and i thought that's
what it would be because it says 100
total acus
so
is it i'm not sure but anyway the point
is there is a shared tier where it is i
don't know uh and you can't use the
shared tier on uh on the on linux based
system so you're using windows i'm using
windows you gotta use bigger instances
anyway which i don't know i don't like
that too much but that's what it is
uh moving on uh over we're now into the
dedicated tiers and look it's right
beside the free tier that's the green
one it says b1
and if you expand it actually has a
couple other tiers there so i just
wanted to show you that there was uh
three uh there
and so uh for dedicated tiers we've got
basic standard premium premium version
two premium version three and we're
looking at basically that's what that is
more disk space unlimited apps three
levels in this tier that offer very
amount of compute power memory disk
usage it must be b1 b2 b3
uh and then the next thing over is uh
the standard and i we had we had to
switch tabs there onto the production
tab notice the terminologies don't
really match the tiers
uh and so uh with standard you can scale
out to three dedicated instances has an
sla of 99.95
availability and three levels in this
tier that are offering varying amounts
of compute power memory and storage disk
and so then
uh that's that tier there and we're on
to our last here which is the premium
tier
and this scales to uh 10 dedicated
instances it has availability sla of
99.95 percent and multiple levels of
hardware so that's the dedicated tiers
then we're on to the last thing which is
isolated and this is really only going
to be used i think for ase so the uh the
isolated tier has dedicated azure
virtual networks uh full network compute
isolation scales out to 100 instances
availability sla of 99.95 and again i
think it's just for those ases um but
there you go that is all the tiers and
hopefully it makes sense to you but it
is a little bit tricky to figure out
what to choose but you don't really get
to like pick at a granular level that's
what i don't like
but
it is a really great service azure app
service it does figure everything out
for you so maybe it's okay for you
[Music]
so let's say you're using azure app
services to host um one of your
applications you need to run a random
script how are you going to do that
that's where web jobs comes into play so
it comes at no additional cost and web
jobs is not yet supported for linux
which is of no surprise here because
microsoft is all about windows but i
hope one day they will support it the
following types they support as of today
are command files bat files executables
we've got powershell files bash files
php files python files javascript files
and java files when you go ahead and
create your job you're going to have
between two types you've got continuous
and triggered a continuous means it's
going to run continually until stopped
which is pretty clear
and this particular mode supports
debugging so if you need to bug in
that's the mode you're going to be using
for trigger this only runs when a
trigger occurs and you have different
kinds of triggered here so you notice we
have scheduled and we can enter a quran
job in and this will also expose a web
hook that can be called to enable
scenarios like scheduling i think that
would be like manual triggers
it doesn't support debugging though so
looking at web job scales and this is
for continuous only
uh we have a multi-instance and single
instance so multi is will scale your web
jobs across all instances for your app
service plan and single instance will
only keep a single copy of your web job
running regardless of the azure app plan
instance count so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to be learning about
azure app services in this follow along
uh and it's a service that's supposed to
make it easy for you to deploy web
applications i say supposed to because
it really depends on your stack azure
has more synergies with other
stacks than others so like if you're
like me and you like ruby on rails
you're going to find a lot of friction
with rails and linux but if you're using
something like windows servers or python
or net you're going to have a much
easier time still really great service
just wish they'd make it a bit more
broad there but let's hop into it so
before we can go use that service let's
make sure that it's activated and so
we'll go over here
and we'll go to azure subscription and
then down below we're going to go to
resource provider now you'd think what
you could do is just type in app
services
and you'd be wrong because the the
service is under a particular provider
so if you want to figure out what
provider it is we can go um azure
resource providers
and they have a page on documentation
here that lists them all
so if i search for azure app services
it's under web and domain registration
so we're going to make sure this is
registered if we're using a custom
domain which we are not today we need
this one activated so going back here i
will type in web and you can see it's
registered so if yours is not registered
go ahead and hit that i believe this by
default is generally registered with new
azure accounts so i don't think that is
an issue for you but we'll go back up
here close these additional tabs and we
will type in azure app services
and we will look for that service so
there it is and we'll go ahead and hit
add
and so i'm going to give it a new name i
just made it a moment ago but i'm going
to try again and try to use the same
name so we're going to call this voyager
great and then i'm going to go ahead and
name this voyager and i already know
that that is taken so i'm going to type
in delta flyer
and these are fully qualified domains so
they are unique with azure app services
you can run a docker container we're
doing code this time around and what i
like to use is ruby
but again you know if i want to use the
ci cd i'm not going to be able to use
the deployment center with ruby so that
is not possible
and so we're going to go with python and
run either a flask or a django app i
haven't decided yet i am in canada so
let's go to canada east
and
down below here we have the plans
generally the plans will tell you the
cost underneath look you'll notice that
it's loading but i just want to show you
that there are some discrepancies in
terms of pricing so if i was to go to
azure app services pricing
and we were to pull this up here we can
kind of see the pricing here
okay and if we scroll on down right now
we're looking at a premium v2
uh and oh no i don't need help i'm okay
you'll notice that it's 20 cents per
hour so if i go here and do
that times 730 because there's 730 hours
in the year that's 146 dollars i believe
this is showing me in usd dollars yeah
and and here it's showing me 103
canadian which is lower um so it could
be that because i'm running in a canada
east region it's the price is different
but you can imagine that if i had this
at this cost at uh what did we say here
at 146 usd
to cad i'd actually be paying
182 dollars so you got to watch out for
that kind of stuff but i'm pretty sure
this is what the cost is so just be
aware that if you look stuff up in here
it's not necessarily reflective so you
got to do a little bit more work to
figure that out
if we wanted to go here we cannot choose
the free tier when we're using linux if
we're using windows i believe we can use
it we're working with linux today so
that's just how it's going to be
for the b1 this is totally fine but we
want to utilize deployment slots
deployment slots is an advanced feature
of the production version and that's the
only way we're going to be able to use
it here this is 20 cents per hour again
so i don't want to be doing this for too
long but i think what we'll do is before
we do that we can just do an upgrade to
dev to prod so we can experience that
i'm going to go and just choose b1 okay
so go next
we do not need any application insights
for the time being and it will not let
us so it's okay
we'll go next review and create
and we'll go ahead and create this
resource here
and i will see you back when this is
done
so um our resource is now set up we'll
go to resource and now that we're in
here you'll notice if we hit browse
we're not going to see anything because
we do not have anything deployed which
makes sense right
so we're going to actually have to go
ahead and deploy something so we're
going to make our way over to the
deployment center
and it's just going to tell us that we
have yet to configure anything and
that's totally fine we're going to go to
settings
it'll give it a moment and so the thing
is is that we're going to need something
to deploy
i did not create an app but the great
thing
is in the azure documentation they have
a bunch of quick starts here all right
and apparently they have one for ruby as
well but today we are looking at python
uh and so they actually have an example
repository for us here
which is github.com azure samples python
docs hello world and i mean i can go
make a repo for you but we might as well
just use the one that is already
provided to us
so i'm just going to pull this up to
show you what's in it it's a very very
simple application even if you don't
know anything about building web apps
i'm going to walk you through it really
easily here okay so we're going to open
up app.pi so we are using flask if
you've never heard of flask it is a very
minimal python framework for creating
web apps uh very uninspiring uh home
page here but it gets the job done it's
going to create a default route for us
which uh we have there we're going to
call hello here and we're going to have
hello world so that's all that's going
on here
very very simple and we have a
requirements this is our package manager
i don't know why python uses txt files
it's very outdated to me but that's what
they use and here we have flask
all right
so we're going to use that repo it's a
public repo so it should be very easy
for us to connect so we'll drop down
go to github
and uh the next thing we need to do is
authorize github
all right so i ran into a bit of trouble
there because i could not uh
authenticate my uh github account but
you know what i just made another github
account so that made it a lot easier i'm
going to go ahead here hit github and
we're going to try to authorize it and
so now i'm logged into this new one
called exampro dev and we'll go ahead
and authorize this application and we're
now in good shape
this repository doesn't have anything in
it so
if i want to clone something i guess
i'll probably have to fork that repo
so we'll give it a moment to authorize
and while that's going i think that's
what i'm going to do i'm going to go and
fork the example repo if i can find the
link again here
myself
i believe
it is
that's still authorizing over there i'm
still looking for it so
it was like examples or something
samples or examples
all right so i found a way around the
problem i just made a new github account
so that's all i had to do
um and i just won't be using my primary
account until i get my phone back but so
what we'll do is go hit connect i'll hit
authorize
and it didn't prompt me because it
already connected to this new one called
exam pro dev you might have to put your
credentials in here and it's going to
ask me to select some things it's a new
account so there are no organizations
there are no repositories there are no
branches totally brand new so what i'm
going to need to do is get a repo in
there so we'll just go ahead and fork
the azure samples one
so that is azure samples
python
docs hello world
if i type that right we're in good shape
i'm going to go ahead and fork this
repository
i'll say got it
and then i'll move this off screen here
this is now cloned you should see it
cloned here
and we'll go back here and this probably
isn't live so there's no refresh button
here so we'll have to hit discard
and we will give this another go here
and we will select our organization
which is our name there is the
repository
uh should be main branch is kind of
outdated i'm sorry but it's called
master that's what it is
not my fault that's azure's fault okay
um and i think that's it
i don't know if we need a workflow
configuration file i don't think so
[Music]
i'm just going to double check here no i
don't think so and what we'll do is
we'll just go ahead and save that
and so now we are set up for deployment
[Music]
all right so now that that's all hooked
up if we were to go to browse we're
actually still seeing the default page a
deployment hasn't been triggered just
yet
so the way it works is it's using github
actions so if we click into our we call
it main branch i know they got the wrong
name but we're going to click into our
github workflows and then below here we
can see we have a yaml file
and this is for github actions
integration here and so what it's doing
is it's specifying the branch
what how it's going to build it's going
to run on ubuntu latest the steps it's
going to do is going to check it out
it's going to set up the python version
it's going to build it it's going to do
that stuff and so in order for this to
um take action we'd actually have to go
ahead and make some kind of manual
change which we have yet to do so eh
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
main here
and uh it should be as simple as uh just
changing something here
so it's not i'm not sure how it's
supposed to know that it's supposed to
be doing the hello oh i guess yeah sorry
so this means it's going to route over
to here
so i'm just going to make any kind of
change here doesn't matter what it is
just one space
we'll go ahead and give it a commit
and
if i go back to my latest commits we
should see that i made that change there
it is
we'll go back over here
and this should be deploying
so if we go over to logs
here you can see one's in progress right
now okay and so that's what we're
weighing we're just going to see that
finish there we could probably open the
logs and get some more information there
and so it just brings you back over to
github actions and so here's github
actions and it's performing the stuff
here so we're just going to give it time
here and i'll see you back in a moment
so we didn't have to wait too long it
only took one minute and 29 seconds if
we go back over here
um we might need to do a refresh and so
we can see this is reflected over here
and so if we go back to it doesn't
really matter if we go to settings or
logs here but i'm going to hit browse
and see if my page is deployed it still
is not so we do have a small little
problem here and it's really going to
just have to do with how the app is
served so that's what we need to figure
out next
all right so our app is not currently
working and there's a few approaches we
can take and the thing i can think right
away is we should go an ssh into that
instance if you scroll on down here from
developer tools you can go to ssh and
click this button and that's going to
ssh you right into that machine right
away you can also
access ssh via the um
cli command so i believe it's like
it's like a z web app
um
ssh it'll do the exact same thing you do
that from the cloud shell but that's not
what we're doing today
if i give this an ls in here and we're
in linux we can see we have our app here
and what i would do is i would see
what's running so i i would do a puma
uh or sorry not puma
ps ox grep uh python and you can notice
that we have uh g unicorn that's running
so that is where our python instances
are running so you're not looking for
flash you're looking for python here
and if we wanted to make sure that was
working we just type in curl
local host
um and so that is going to return a port
80. so that tells me that because like
curl just means like let's go look at
that page it should return some html
like print out the html to us so that
means the app is not running
so what you could do is run flask run
and it's going to start on
port 5000
right so what i can do
is i can go up uh back to my deployment
center here
and i'm going to go get that link here
and just ignore the fact that it's
working it's it's not working right now
i know for certain it's not
but if we do 5000 that won't resolve
because port 5000 isn't open so we can't
really just
put 5000 in there and the default server
here would be 5000 so if i stop this and
i specify port 80
right
then this will start up the app on port
80 and so now when you go here
okay it will work this is not a great
way because of course as soon as you
kill it here uh technically the site
should stop running um and so you'll run
into that step uh so what we need to do
is provide a configuration to g unicorn
which is a python thing again it's not
so important that you know how like what
these things are but the idea is that
you understand as administrator you want
to make sure you have an app that runs
after you do a deploy and so in this
particular one we need a startup.txt
and interestingly enough there is a
example code by the same author of the
other one we were looking at here i
believe it's the same person
or it might not be but they have a
startup txt right
and so in here you can see that it binds
on port zero zero zero it starts up four
workers starts up the app
all right
and so that's something that we can go
ahead and do
so
what i will do is i will go back to my
github repository
that we have here
and i can just go ahead and add a new
file so i'm going to say
add a file create a new file here
we'll call it startup.txt
i'm going to copy this command here and
paste it in there so g unicorn will bind
the workers and start up on the app
um startup app is being ran by
something here so if i go back here i
think they have a startup pi here
and that's all that it is doing um
i think i want to
i could do it this way i suppose let me
just see here
there's just a slightly different egg so
they actually have like a full app going
on here
and i just want a very simple flask app
so i think what i can do
is put flask run here
port 80
and that should start up the app there
i'm going to go ahead and commit that
file
okay and as soon as i commit that if i
go back to my actions
it created that startup file there so it
should trigger a build
it's queued up um and i'll just put this
tab up here so we'll be back here in two
seconds and if i give this a nice
refresh
yeah you can see it deploys in progress
so
this doesn't take too long we'll just
wait close that there we'll just wait a
few minutes we click logs it just opens
it back up here and we'll see how that
goes
all right so your deploy may have
finished there but the thing is is that
we're not going to really know if a
change has taken effect unless we
actually go ahead and update our code so
what i want you to do is go to your code
tab go to your app.pi we'll hit edit and
i'm going to go ahead and change this
to vulkan
and then we'll scroll on down hit commit
changes and we'll make our way back over
to our deployment center
and we'll give it a refresh here and
we're just going to wait until this one
is complete and we will double check to
make sure that that has changed if it's
not we will take action to fix that okay
all right so we just waited a little
while there for that deploy to happen
and if we go to our website here it is
taking effect so that's all we had to do
to get it working so that's pretty good
um so that is deployment
[Music]
so let's talk about deployment slots in
order to utilize this feature we're
going to actually have to upgrade our
account because we cannot utilize them
at this uh the basic plan here we got to
go to standard or premium so let's go
ahead and give that an upgrade
so here's the b1 we're gonna go to
production here um
and i think
yeah we're gonna have to choose this one
here uh very expensive so the thing is
we're gonna just upgrade it temporarily
unless there's more options down below
that are cheaper
yeah these are the standard tiers
let's go with this one here because it's
only eighty dollars again we're not
going to be doing this for long but i
want to show you how to do staging slots
and auto scaling okay so we'll go ahead
and apply that there
and now it says that it's applied so if
i go back to our app here and we click
on deployment slots sometimes it doesn't
show up right away if it doesn't that's
not a big deal you just wait a bit but
today it's super fast so we're going to
go ahead and add a new slot we're going
to call it
staging we're going to deploy from our
production branch here and i'm going to
go ahead and create that there
and we'll just wait until that's done
okay
great so we waited a little bit there
and our slot is created so i'm going to
just hit close there
and so now let's go take a look and see
if we can actually see the application
here so i just clicked into it i click
browse and we're getting the default
page so nothing is actually really
deployed to it
so how are we going to do that that's
the the main question here
so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to make my way over to the
deployment center
and you can see that it's not configured
for this slot so
we're going to have to set it up all
over again even though it copied over
configuration settings it didn't copy
over the code so we go to github we'll
choose our organization again i'm going
to choose the repository we're going to
choose
that main branch again there we're going
to let it add a workflow and notice that
this time it's going to call it
staging.yaml so there'll be a separate
workflow that gets created we're going
to go ahead and save that there
and what we can do is again click onto
our branch name there
and if we click into our workflows we'll
note now notice that we have a staging
example it's the same thing
but it should be able to now deploy so
the whole purpose of
these deployment branches is that it
helps us
we can deploy different versions of our
apps but also
it's just a place where we can
view things before we actually roll them
out so we want to make sure 100 that
they are working correctly
i don't think this will automatically
push out let me just go to my actions to
see if this is deploying notice that we
have two workflows now we have staging
here
uh and yeah it looks like it's going to
deploy here so we'll just wait a little
bit
but maybe what we can do is try to have
a slightly different version uh for each
one here okay
but we'll just let that finish and i'll
see you back in a moment
all right so our deploy finished there
so now if we go back to our website here
we go browse
we should see that application it says
hello vulcan and if we go and take out
this we still have hello vulcan so how
can we have a
a variant of this so that we can push
out to that so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go back to my application
here i'm going to go to code and i'm
just going to make a minor change um i
don't say also
does that spell right startup
doesn't look correct to me um
so maybe i'll go and adjust that file
but it doesn't seem to be affecting
anything which is i'm a bit surprised
there so what i'll do
is i'm going to go and edit that file
and give it the proper name can i rename
this file
yes i can so we'll call that startup
file
i thought we needed that for deploying i
guess it just works without it which is
nice
if we go back here i'm going to go and
actually just want to edit my
app here again
and i'm going to go and edit this
and we'll say
hello
pandoria
or hello and dorians maybe
and so if i go back to my actions the
question what is it deploying is it
going to deploy the production or the
staging
and it looks like it's going to do
both
looks like it's doing both here but one
way we could tell is we can go to our
logs here
and we can see that um so we did two
deploy so there's one change here
if we go back to our main application
our deployment center here
we go over to our logs
you can see that they're both deploying
so it doesn't seem like it's a great
thing that that's how it works so the
question is then how would we
um facilitate that deploy right how
could we do that i suppose what we could
do is just make a separate staging
branch
so if i go over to code here
i don't think we can just make branches
through here so what i'm going to have
to do is go ahead and
oh i can create a branch right here so
we'll just type in staging
and we'll go create ourselves a new
branch
and now we're in this branch and what
i'm going to do is go ahead and modify
this and we're just going to call this
hello klingons
okay
we'll go ahead and update that and so
this should be a separate branch so you
think what we could do is go in and just
change our settings so that it deploys
from that one
we'll go back to our deployment slots
we'll click into staging here
and we need to change our configuration
settings um
i think we could just do it from
here hold on here i could have swore it
specified the branch if we go to
deployment center here
i think it's set up on that other branch
there
i think we just adjusted here so yeah i
think we could just
adjust these settings
we can't discard them
but maybe what we can do is just go in
and modify that file
so we will go into our code here
and
we will go ahead and click into here go
into staging and we'll just change what
the branch is called
so we'll just say staging
and we'll hit start commit and we will
save that
and we'll see if it actually reflects
those changes there so we will go here
and hit refresh
we'll see if it picks up staging now if
we go to settings
it's not picking it up so um i'm not
sure i don't think perform a redeploy
operation we don't want to redeploy so
maybe what we'll do is just we'll have
to do a disconnect here because it's
collect it has the wrong one here so
save workflow file
um
okay we'll just go ahead and delete it
it's not a big deal we'll just have to
make a new one here
we'll go to github
we'll choose our
organization again or repository our
staging branch this time around
we'll let it add one see it says we
could use an available workflow so we
could have kept it there and added it
there
um and we'll go ahead and save that
so now we'll have two separate branches
there and we'll give that some time to
deploy because that will now trigger a
deploy off the bat and so i'll see you
back here in a moment
all right so after a short little wait
here it looks like our app is done
deploying so we'll go over here we'll
make sure that this is our staging
server is good and we want to see that
our production is different perfect so
we now have a way to deploy to each one
but imagine that we want to swap our
traffic so we're happy with our staging
server and we want to roll that out to
production and that's where we can do
some swapping so what we'll do is click
the swap button and we're going to say
the source is the staging and this is
our target production we're going to
perform that swap
right now we can't do a preview because
we don't have a particular setting set
that's okay
and it's kind of showing if there are
any changes so set of configuration
changes we don't have any so that's
totally fine as well we'll go ahead and
hit swap
and that's going to swap those two i
believe it has has zero downtime so
we'll be in good shape if that happens
there
and we'll just give it a moment to do
that
great so after a short little wait there
the swap is complete and so if you
remember clearly
this was our production right and so if
i was to hit refresh
it so now say klingons and if i go to my
staging server it should be the other
way around right
good so now imagine that i want to just
split the traffic that's something else
that we can do um so notice over here we
have these percentages here
i'm not sure why it won't let me change
those
so maybe i'll have to look into that so
i'll be back
so i'm not sure why it's not showing us
that traffic slot there but what i'm
going to do is just maybe try to trigger
a deploy back into our staging and maybe
that's what it wants to see
so what i'm going to do is go back to my
code here we'll be in our staging branch
here i'm going to go ahead and edit this
file here
and
we'll just change this to majoran's
and we will hit update
and we will let that go ahead and deploy
so if we go to actions here we can see
that it is deploying
um and we'll just give it some time okay
so we'll see you back here in a bit i
mean the other reason could be that
we're just not at the main level hold on
here
if we go back here to deployment slots
you know what i think it's just because
i was clicked into here and then i was
clicked into deployment slots that
they're both grayed out yeah it is so we
can actually do at that top level there
it doesn't hurt to do another deploy
though so um we'll just wait for always
for that deploy to finish and then we'll
come here and adjust that there okay
all right so let's take a look at doing
some traffic switching here so right now
if we were to go to our production we
have klingons and if we were to
go to our staging
we have bajoran so imagine that we only
want 50 of that traffic to show up so
what we can do is put in 50 percent
and uh what i'm gonna do is um
do i hit enter here or oh sorry save up
here there we go
um and so what's going to happen is this
should take effect i think right away
yep uh and so now we have 50 50 50
chance of getting something else here um
so i'm just going to keep on hitting
enter here if that doesn't work we can
try an incognito tab and there we go we
got the opposite there and so this is
serving up staging right
and this is serving up production but
they're both on the production url so
that's the way you can split the traffic
so
that's pretty much all i wanted to show
you for deployment slots let's now talk
about scaling
[Music]
all right so let's take a look into how
we can do some scaling with our app
service this is only available if you
have beyond standard and or standard and
beyond so standard and premium and etc
so if we just search for scale we have
two options here we have scale up and
scale outs the scale up is pretty
straightforward that just means to uh
make our instance larger and so we
already did that when we upgraded from
our standard our our b1 over to our s1
here right so if i was to go here i'm
not going to do that but if i was to do
that and upgrade um
that would be scaling up right
and notice that we're talking about
scaling so right now we're limited to 10
instances which is totally fine
but now let's take a look at scaling out
so if we go to scale out here
and go to custom auto scale
what we can do is we can scale based on
a metric so
we can add or remove servers based on
the demand of the current
web applications traffic so we're only
paying for servers when we need them and
so we have a minimum one a maximum two
that seems fine to me but we're going to
add a rule here and i want to scale this
on
the maximum time we're going to do on
cpu percentage i just want to have a
very easy way to trigger this so we can
see a scaling event in action here it
has a maximum of 16 i might just lower
that down even further well let me type
in there new so 16 is what it's going to
have to be it's not a big deal but i am
going to reduce it down to actually i
think sorry i don't know i was going
here the the metric threshold to scale
an action i'm going to put it at 10
sorry
okay
so here's that line and so we have a and
i like how you can drag it but you kind
of have an idea that we have a high
chance of having this um trigger i just
want to do this so that we have a
a good chance so if i was to put it here
you can notice that it's very easy for
us to spike our traffic and and cause a
scaling event now i'm gonna set the
duration to one minute so we have a much
higher chance of uh triggering that
there
okay
set a duration less than five minutes
may generate a transient spikes yeah
that's fair but i mean i just want to
show you a trigger happen
and we need a cool down time probably um
and it's set to five minutes that's
totally fine we're gonna add one
and that looks fine to me i'm gonna set
this to maximum okay and so now we're
very likely to trigger that there we'll
go ahead and hit add that
instance there and so now that we have
that we're going to go ahead and save
that
and so now that that's there what we
want to do is actually trigger a scaling
event and so
where we're going to see that is under
the monitoring tab
so if we go to monitoring
and what we're going to do is go over to
um it should be in
sorry i forgot the place where we need
to go take a look here is actually in
the run history here so if we go here
and check one hour we can see how many
instances are running
uh and i think if i dial it back here it
should show me over time as it changes
we do have a scale up event that has
happened which happened i guess four
minutes ago
um so it gives you kind of an idea of
how many instances are running which
right now are two
um so maybe our
maybe our scaling event is not in the
best uh use case there because it's
happening too frequently so what i'm
gonna do is go ahead
and modify that scaling rule
um and so i'm just gonna go back and
click here and maybe we'll just make it
so it is less aggressive so what i'm
gonna do is just change it so it's over
the duration of five minutes
and i'm gonna just put it right above
here so that it goes back to one
okay
and we'll go ahead and save that
and so now we go back to our run history
here
it still shows that it has
two
as you can see here but i want to see
this drop back down to one
so it's going to check every five
minutes or or within the span of five
minutes so what i'm gonna do is just uh
wait here and i'll see you back in a bit
until we see a scaling action happens uh
here okay
yeah i'm just sitting here waiting for
it to scale down and i don't see it
going so it makes me think that i need
to go ahead and set a scale
scale down action let's take a look at
the one that we currently have uh so
this one is set oh you can see it's
still spiked we don't even have anything
going on here but what i'm going to do
is just be really aggressive here
i'm going to say when it's
50 okay
and so here
we'll go back here and i'll save that
and i just want to see if it scales down
i shouldn't have to set a scale down
action should just go
um
and what i'm actually going to do is be
a little bit more aggressive i know i'm
setting a lot of stuff here but i'm
going to just set it to duration of 1
minutes
so we can see this a lot sooner
and we will go back to our run history
here and we'll see if we observe a scale
down
all right so um it's not scaling down
here but uh i think it's probably
because i need to scale out action so
what we'll do is go ahead and add a new
rule
this thing if we go here
and we just look at it
um
it's not going to decrease it unless we
have a scale of action
so
i don't think it's necessary for us to
set one here i think you get the idea
but that's for scaling so we're all done
here with azure app services all we got
to do is go ahead and go ahead and
delete it so let's go ahead and delete
our app here okay
so there's a few different ways we can
do it i'm going to do it via resource
groups
i believe we called it voyager here so
click into that
and i'm going to go ahead and delete the
resource group
and here is all the related services
and so i will type in voyager
and there we go
great and so yeah there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure app services
cheat sheet this is a two pager so let's
jump into it azure app services is an
http based service for hosting web
applications rest apis and mobile
backends you can choose a programming
language in either a windows or linux
environment it's platform as a service
so it's the heroku or aws elastic
beanstalk equivalent of azure if that
helps you remember what it is azure app
services makes it easy to implement
common uh common features
so for integrations and features such as
azure devops github integrations
docker hub integrations package
management easy to set up staging
environments custom domains attaching
tls and ssl certificates you pay based
on the azure app service plan so you got
a standard tier a dedicated tier and an
isolated tier notice
that this tier does not support linux
okay
azure app services uh supports the
following runtime so net.net core java
ruby node.js php and python azure app
services can also run docker as a single
docker container or multi-containers you
can also upload your own custom
container so you'd upload it or you just
deploy it so you create it upload it to
azure container registry and then deploy
you have deployment slots this allows
you to create different environments for
your web application you can swap
environments this could be how you
perform a blue green deployment onto the
second slide here app app service
environment asc is an app azure app
service feature that provides a fully
isolated dedicated environment for
securing or securely running app service
apps at high scale customers can create
multiple ases within a single azure
region or across multiple azure regions
making ase ideal for horizontal scaling
stateless application tiers or high
requests per second rps workloads ac
comes with some pricing tier which is
isolated tier ase can be used to
configure uh security architecture apps
running on asc can have their access oop
this should say granted not graded by
upstream devices such as a web
application firewall a waff
and app service ascs can be deployed
into an az using a zone pinning there
are two deployment types for ase you
have external ase and i r i l b asc ilb
would be internal load balancer okay
azure app services provides many ways to
deploy your applications and there's so
many i'm not going to listen here but i
i probably would recommend that you go
review the actual uh content for that
because it just they would have made it
would have made a whole cheat sheet here
uh then the last thing here web jobs is
a feature of azure app services that
enables you to run a program or script
in the same instance as the web app api
mobile app there's no additional cost to
web jobs so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at what a key value
store is so a key value store is a data
store that is really dumb but it's super
super fast okay and so they'll lack
features that you would normally see in
relational databases like relationships
indexes aggregation transactions all
sorts of things uh but you know there is
a trade-off for that speed okay and so
here is kind of a representation of a
key value store which uh you have a key
which is a unique you know key to
identify the value and i'm representing
the value as a bunch of ones and zeros
because i want you to understand that
there aren't really columns it's just
key and value
so the idea is that imagine that those
ones and zeros actually represent
a dictionary and that's usually what
they are is it associative array hash
dictionary underneath
okay and so even though it looks like
you know what i mean like if this was a
relational database you know you could
see these as kind of like columns and so
if we kind of did that that's how a key
value store can kind of mimic
um you know a tabular data right
but the thing is is that you know there
is no consistency between the the rows
hence it is schema-less but that's kind
of a way to get tabular data from key
values but due to their simple design
they can scale well well beyond
relational databases so relational
databases it becomes very hard to shard
them and do a bunch of other stuff with
them but key value stores are super easy
to scale but you know they come with a
lot of extra engineering around them
because of these missing features
[Music]
all right let's talk about document
stores so document store is a noscope
database that stores document as its
primary data structure a document could
be an xml but it's most commonly json or
json like structure and documents
stores are sub classes of key value
stores so the components of a document
store compared to relational database
looks like this so the idea is that you
have tables is now collections rows are
documents columns are fields indexes are
still the same name and when you do
joins they're called embedding and
linking so you know if a key value store
can kind of store this why would you do
it well there's just a lot more features
around the documents itself and so you
know how we saw key value store didn't
have like it had like nothing like no
functionality well document sort brings
a lot more of the functionality that
you're used to in a relational database
you know and so it makes things a little
bit easier to work with okay
[Music]
all right let's take a quick look here
at mongodb which is an open source
document database which stores json-like
documents and the primary data structure
for mongodb is called a bson so a binary
json is a subset of json so its data
structure is very similar to json but
it's designed to be both efficient and
storage
in both storage space and scan speed
compared to json and bson has more data
types than json has date times byte
arrays regular expressions md5 binary
data javascript code json's just strings
integers and arrays it's very very
simple but because it has all these new
other data types and it's stored in this
binary format it's not plain text it's
actually binary data
that's the what reason why it the
storage space and the scan speed is so
fast now if you did use javascript to
perform an operation like say insert
data this is what it would look like so
you have kind of an idea that you're
inserting items into a collection there
okay
just to list out some features of
mongodb
it supports searches against fields
range queries regular expressions it
supports primary and secondary indexes
it's highly available it's it's high
availability can be obtained via rep
replica sets so replica to offload reads
or access standby in case of failover
momentum b scales horizontally using
sharding mongodb can run multiple
servers via load bouncing mongodb can be
used as a file system which is called
grid fs with uh with load balancing and
data replication features over multiple
machines uh for storing files mongodb
provides three ways to perform
aggregation uh grouping dat and
aggregations just grouping data to
return a query so aggregation pipeline
map reduce single purpose aggregation
mongodb supports fixed collections
called capped collections going to
become claims to support multi-document
asset transactions so mongodb when it
first came out didn't do all this stuff
and people complained about it i like it
being very hard to scale but now it's a
lot easier to use so you know mongodb is
something that is uh more uh
a more popular option nowadays than it
was a few years ago so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at what
a graph database is so graph database is
a database composed of data structures
that use vertices nodes or dots which
form relationships to other vertices via
edges arcs and lines so some use cases
here fraud detection real-time
recommendations engines master data
management network and it operations
identity and access management and
there's a lot they're saying like it's
really really good for that i am
something i want to look into later
traceability and manufacturing contact
tracing
data lineage for gdpr customer 360
degree analysis like for marketing
product recommendations social media
graphing and feature engineering for ml
so let's just kind of break down you
know the little components here so what
you'd have is a node and a node can
contain data properties and then through
that it would have a relationship
through an edge and that relationship
can have a direction and also data
properties on it and so it's a lot more
um
verbose like in than a relational
database and also just how it can point
to stuff so
super useful for particular use cases
let's take a look here at azure
tinkerpop which is a graph computing
framework for both graph databases oltps
and graph analytics systems olaps so
tinkerpop enables developers to use a
vendor agnostic distributed framework to
traverse query many different graph
systems they always say traverse because
there's so many it's a tree right
so there's a lot of databases that this
thing connects to and so here they all
are but the ones i want to indicate to
you that are important is amazon neptune
cosmodb hadoop via spark neo4j which is
one of the most popular
graphing databases orientdb and titan
okay so the thing is is that this isn't
a
graph database
it is a basically adapter to other graph
databases and ticker pop includes a
graph traversal language called gremlin
which is the single language that can be
used for all these graph systems so
let's talk about gremlin gremlin is a
graph traversal language for apache
tinker pop and so it looks like this and
sometimes you know like even without
tinker pop and i think this is with
cosmodb that they'll support this
language by default so you don't
necessarily need to have tinker pop to
work with some databases but it's great
to have that service if you if or like
the framework if you need it so gremlin
is is designed to write once and run
anywhere w-o-r-a gremlin traversal can
be evaluated as a real-time query so
lltb or a batch analytics query so over
here it's just kind of showing you these
are the oltps graph databases over here
and then on the right hand side we have
olaps okay
and so gremlin hosted language embedding
means you can use your favorite
programming language when you write
gremlin okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure tables which
is a type of storage for nosql key value
data store within the azure storage
accounts azure table stores
non-relational structured data with a
schema-less design and there are two
ways to interact with azure tables
through the storage table storage api or
microsoft azure storage explorer which i
find is the easiest way to interact with
it so just kind of looking at storage
explorer there if you wanted to add an
entry uh you'd have to provide a
partition key which is a unique identify
uh fire for the partition with a given
table and a row key a unique identifier
for an entity within a given part a
partition and so you have all your data
types here so we see string boolean
binary data type uh double uh
guids 32 and 64. if we wanted a query
you'd have to query along the partition
and row key so you could also do some
additional filtering here so just notice
here that um you know you have your
partition key you put in your value like
klingon and wharf and then this is not
this is just additional properties you
added
a lot of time the way these key values
work is that
this will return the results like all
the results and then server side and
then client side these will be filtered
client side i don't know if that's the
case with azure table but that's
generally how these things work and so
there you go
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're looking at cosmodb which is a
service for fully managed nosql
databases that are designed to scale
and be highly performant so cosmodb
supports different kinds of nosql
database engines which you interact via
an api so we have the core sql which is
their document data store their azure
cosmodb api for mongodb their azure
table
and gremlin okay and this will be using
probably tinker pop um so all of these
nosql engines uh uh specify capacity so
you can do provision throughput for pay
for guarantee of capacity or serverless
pay for what you use so if you are just
playing around the service you can go
ahead and choose that serv
serverless option and so a lot of times
when people talk about cosmodb they're
usually talking about core sql so if you
say cosmodb it's usually document but
understand that there's a bunch of stuff
underneath it
now if you want to start viewing data
and making stuff and playing around with
it you'd use the cosmo db explorer which
is a web interface that you can find at
cosmos.azure.com so after you made your
cosm db cluster or container whatever
they call it
then you can go access your database so
here we have the sql api
and so that would be the document store
and you can just see here that
we have we've created a new item here
for that data okay
and so i just want to show you that if
you drop down here you choose container
or database so we create a new container
also if you are in
azure it looks like they just have it
here under the data explorer tab so it's
the same thing it's the cosmo db
explorer just in line okay so you don't
have to like go to that url you could
just click into your um your it's called
account cosmodb account and go to data
explorer i just wanted to show you here
like if you made a graph database that
you can do everything through this
explorer for all the different types the
interface will change a bit so here we'd
add a new vertex right and it's just
slightly different okay
[Music]
all right so the thing about azure
tables is that you can
use it within either cosmodb
okay or you can use it within account
storage and the thing is is that um
it's a really good comparison to look at
these two things because
this way we can really understand like
how powerful cosmodb is all right
so what we'll do is compare the two so
over here when you have azure tables in
account storage
it's fast but it has no upper bounds of
latency
for azure cosmodb it's going to give you
single digit millisecond latency for
reads and writes
for throughputs
it's variable throughput it's limited to
20 000 operations you get a guaranteed
uh backed by an sla and no upper limits
when you're using cosmo db for global
distribution it's a single region
and for cosmic db you have 30 plus
regions for indexing you only get the
primary index or partition and row no
secondary indexes and then for
cosmodb you get automatic and complete
indexing in all properties no index
management for querying you get query
execution uses index for primary key and
scans otherwise and for uh cosmodb you
get queries that can take advantage of
automatic indexing on properties for
fast query times for consistency we got
strong with primary region and eventual
with secondary regions and with uh
cosmodb there's like five you know what
i mean there's this uh the consistent
levels are a lot more flexible okay
for pricing it's consumption based and
then for uh cosmodb you have consumption
based or provision capacity for this
delays it's 99.99 availability and here
it it's backed by an sla but some
conditions it does not apply okay so you
know hopefully that shows you that
cosmic db like is very performant is
globally available uh single digit
millisecond and i i really feel like
this is to compete with um adabus
dynamodb because it sounds so
similar to dynamodb but um yeah there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on to the azure tables and
cosmos db cheat sheet for the dp900 i
want to point out something uh that i'm
sure you already know about but in the
course i spelt cosmos db without the s
like everywhere and i'm not going to go
back and fix that
but i know i'm going to hear like
never the end of it for like the next
year okay
so uh let's start at the top here azure
tables it's a key value data store can
be hosted on either azure storage
account storage it is designed for a
single region and single table can be
hosted on cosmos db
and when it's hosted here it's designed
for scale across multiple regions
cosmodb a fully managed nosql service
that supports multiple nosql engines
called apis why they didn't call them
engines i don't know
coresql api this is the default one it's
a document database you can use sql to
query documents and when people are
talking about cosmodb that's what
they're talking about the document
database the default one okay
graph apis a graph database you can use
uh
with gremlin to transfer traverse the
nodes and edges mongodb api a mongodb
database it is a document database
tables ai is just as your table's key
value but within cosmodb apache tinker
pop an open source framework uh to have
an agnostic way to talk to many graph
databases they probably won't ask you
about tinker pop on the exam gremlin
graph traversal language to traverse
nodes and edges you definitely need to
know what gremlin is and be used to
seeing what it is like identify what it
looks like mongodb an open source
document database and the way it works
is it has its own
data structure its document structure
called bson which is binary json
a storage and compute optimized version
of json introduces new data types cosmo
db explorer a web ui to view cosmos
databases and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cosmos db so
cosmos db is a
service for fully managed nosql
databases that are designed to scale
and be highly performant so cosmos db
supports different kinds of nosql
database engines which you're going to
interact via an api we'll cover them
more than once here but we have our core
sql which is a document data store
azure's cosmos db api for mongodb which
is another kind of document data store
azure table which is the old cosmos db
that still sticks around which is a key
value data store we've got gremlin uh
which is a graph data store based on
apache tinker pop that's why we were
covering it earlier in this course here
uh and all of these nosql engines uh
specify capacity so we have things like
provision throughput so you pay for a
guaranteed amount of capacity or you
have a serverless option so you pay for
what you use so that's an option that
you can choose
there let's just talk about some of the
main advantages of using cosmos db
because azure really likes you
uh
to use cosmos db because they consider
like one of their flagship
database products so it integrates with
many azure services like azure functions
aks azure app services integrates with
many different database apis like
coresql mongodb as we saw cassandra as
we saw gremlin as we saw
there's sdks for a variety of
languages.net java python node.js not
ruby so i'm not sure if i'm going to be
using anytime soon but there's a diff a
lot of different sdks there uh it has a
schema less service that applies indexes
to your data automatically resulting in
fast queries you get a guarantee of 99
to the
three nines of availability there
we have data replication between azure
regions and this is all automatic uh
data protect protected with encryption
at rest and role-based access controls
rbacs
auto it auto scales um it provides a way
to handle variety of different workload
sizes
so you can see that there's a lot of
advantages of using cosmos db
[Music]
so something that's very interesting
about cosmos db api is that it's kind of
like an umbrella service for a bunch of
different types of databases
um and this is a lot this can be
confusing for someone that's coming from
aws or gcp where like adabus has
dynamodb and all it is is a document
database where um cosmos db it like
supports a variety of different kinds
and so when you first create your cosmos
db database you have to choose an api
and so we'll just walk through the
different types of apis here and just
give you some information around them
so the first one and this is the default
one is core sql api so it is a document
database but it's interesting because it
allows you to use an sql or sql-like
language and so
this is quite popular because
one of the challenges of using document
database is that normally you don't get
to use sql
but with cosmos db
you do and so that is something that's
really nice then you have azure table
api this can be a bit confusing because
when cosmos db uh
before it came out there was just azure
table
um and so azure table
uh
basically is just a key value store and
you access that through azure table
storages
um
like through storage accounts
but then they decided to make azure
table to be more of a document database
and to make it highly uh
resilient and highly available and
highly redundant and so basically core
sql api is like the version two of azure
table api but this one still exists
because it's very cost effective so if
you don't need a lot of redundancy and
you just need a key value store you need
something very inexpensive you can use
azure table api but even though you
don't really access it through
cosmos db it still is
part of the cosmos db product because it
was the first
iteration or version of it you have
mongodb api and so
um this is uh at
it's not mongodb i don't think
underneath but it's uh it's compatible
with
mongodb so the idea is that if you need
mongodb this is where you're going to
spin that up same thing with cassandra
if you need cassandra you would spin
that up as well
and this is going to use the cassandra
queried language
and so that is something that is there
then you have gremlin api so this would
allow you to use a graph database you
can see these are really really
different things
and it is a bit confusing but uh that's
just how azure likes to organize their
services so hopefully that clears that
up for you okay
[Music]
so let's talk about the core components
for cosmos db because it is a bit
confusing to try to understand the
relationship of all the components
for a fully managed database it sure has
a lot of moving parts
and so the first thing when you go over
to the cosmos db
portal
you're going to spin up a database
and so the idea is that when you
choose a database the idea is that this
is going to be
a logical namespace for your collections
your users your permissions it's going
to determine the api that you do choose
uh once you've chosen
your uh your database then the idea is
that you need containers and normally
when you create a database it'll create
a container for you and a container is
just a unit of compute
but there is a lot of stuff that you can
attach to that container information
when you create it and then you also
have collections i find collections to
be a bit confusing but they map the they
basically map to a container and this is
the billable entity so this is the way
that you're going to determine the cost
um and this is where you're going to be
stating that information so when you
create a container it'll have a bunch of
information below it um and that will be
uh
stuff that will be attached to the
collection entity
so hopefully that kind of clears that
stuff up
i do find containers a bit confusing
because again when you create them
it's at the same time as your database
but we will talk about that because we
do we do come across that in the course
okay
[Music]
let's talk about how we're going to
access our cosmos db database with
cosmos db explorer so it's a web
interface to explore and interact with
your cosmos db accounts accounts
database you know basically the same
thing and this is at
cosmos.azure.com so they have a
dedicated
domain sub-domain for it so the idea is
you type that in and you would
authenticate with your account um
azure's always single sign-on so it's
pretty easy and then the idea is that
you can access
your database and interact with it
without having to write
any any kind of uh sdk code or interact
with cli you have kind of a gui to do
that so example here is for the core sql
and you can interact with all the
different types of database in here so
it's not just coresql but there's a lot
that you can do with it
and so the idea is you can create
containers from here create new
databases um so a lot of similar things
you can do from the
the um
the cosmosd portal with an azure portal
so there's some some stuff there it
doesn't matter where you create it it's
just where you want to do that there
there is an easier way to access this so
instead of going to cosmos
azure.com the way i like to access it is
that i'll just be in the azure portal
for my database
and uh what i will do is access it under
the data explorer tab notice here it
says azure cosmos db account it gets
confusing because they say like an
account can or like
can contain multiple databases but
really it's just one database it's so
confusing so you'll hear me interchange
the term account and database
because the documentation does not
clarify it but in the in the
gui you can see it says the word account
there but yeah this is the way that i
would recommend accessing that
information
um
you know you can also again access
different databases so like for example
we can see this is for gremlin so here
i'm creating a new vertex which is a
graph graphing thing there and so that's
how we can do it there so it's not just
for
the core sql okay
let us talk about partitioning schemas
in cosmos db because it's a very
important concept when we're talking
about new sql databases because
um you know it's all about scale and
when you're dealing with databases of
scale you're dealing with partitions and
this is where we have a lot of
information about partition keys so the
data stored among partitions in amazon
cosmos db indexes is grouped by the
partition keys in order to improve
performance main concepts of partition
schemas in azure's cause of cdb is
partition keys so these are used these
keys are used to group items it works
like primary keys if you know from
traditional relational databases then
there's the idea of a logical partition
this is a group of items that have all
the same partition key values you have
physical partitions
so this consists of a set of logical
partitions
azure cosmos db manages logical
partitions which can have
one to many relationships we have the
idea of replica sets these are made up
of a group of physical partitions that
are materialized as a self-managed
dynamically loaded balanced group of
replicas that span across multiple fault
domains so i imagine when they say the
word physical they're probably saying
like
it's the actual physical underlying
machine and then these are the virtual
logical partitions within those machines
and then replica sets just means
duplicates of that kind of stuff
so hopefully this diagram here will
maybe help a bit here to make sense of
it there's a lot going on here but maybe
we can break it down so each physical
partition consists of a set of replicas
also known as replica sets so over here
um we see partition set
and then we have partition physical
partition
um
and you can see that it's it's
represented over here so confusing but i
think this
yeah this thing this thing here is the
physical partition
okay
over there
um
then we have logical partitions so these
are mapped to physical partitions that
are uh distributed globally so notice
that it's these little boxes in here so
it was what i said so this is the
physical machine and then these are the
virtual partitions within them
and they're distributed globally
partition sets in the image refer to a
group of physical partitions that manage
the same logical partition keys across
multiple regions so hopefully that makes
things a bit more clear uh in
practicality you probably won't need to
remember all of this for the exam you
definitely don't need to know this but
it's good to just kind of go through it
so you have an idea of these terms so
there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about choosing a
partition key this is super super super
important to cosmos to be
so the idea is that a partition key is
made up of two components the partition
key path and the partition key
value so the idea is that let's consider
a document
or a key value that we need to try to
figure out what our prediction key path
would be so we have user id andrew works
for microsoft so in this case we're
trying to find something that is um
like a unique identifier for that item
and so
i would say a user id would be that
thing there so in this case our
partition key path would be forward
slash user id
um
so you know
that would be part one of it
and so the partition key path accepts
numerical or underscore characters you
could also use nested objects by using
the standard path notation of forward
slash so that helps there
um and so an example here would be
forward slash id or we do forward slash
user id
uh the second part of it is the value so
the partition key value can be either a
string or numeric types and so you can
see in our example it is a string so
that's going to be accepted
your partition key for all containers
should be a property that has a value
which does not change
you can't change the value of a property
if it's your partition key a property
that should have a wide range of
possible values that's why we said user
id because it's going to be pretty
unique
per
per person whereas works for you're
going to have a bunch of groups of that
like there might be a lot of people who
work for microsoft so it's not as unique
um
spread request units is something that's
important are used these are consumption
and data storage that will be evenly
across all the logical partitions this
ensures uh even ru consumption and
storage distribution across your
physical partitions so hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea
of
how to choose a partition key but now
we'll talk about unique keys
[Music]
so uniques provide developers with the
ability to add a layer of data integrity
to their database by creating a unique
key policy when a container is created
you ensure the uniqueness of one or more
values per partition key and the unique
key is scoped to a logical partition so
if you partition the container based on
the zip code you end up with duplicated
items in each logical partition so in
the example here you can see our
partition key is going or sorry our
unique key is based on the first name uh
the address
address zip okay so two different values
there so because if you had first name
there might be a bunch of andrews right
and if you want to guarantee that
there's only a single andrew you might
scope it based on a postal code or zip
code you can't update an existing
container to use a different different
unique key so you really do have to plan
ahead to make sure you choose the right
thing a unique key policy can have a
maximum of 16 path values path values
being
[Music]
i believe the separation of the comma a
each unique key policy can have a
maximum of 10 unique key constraints or
combination
combinations so
there's that
when a container has a unique key policy
the ru's charged to the create update
deletes an item are slightly higher and
we haven't talked about our use yet but
we will get to it in the course here so
just hold on your keys aren't case
sensitive so just consider that as well
so there you go
[Music]
all right now it's time to talk about
cosmos db containers because well
containers we don't have really any
compute to run these databases on and we
do talk a bit about containers here so
azure cosmos containers are useful for
scalability in azure cosmos db both in
terms of storage and throughput they are
beneficial when you need a different set
of configurations for each of your as
azure cosmos dbs
because they allow you to customize each
container individually so azure cosmos
containers have some container specific
properties and those properties which
can be system generated or user
configurable vary according on the used
api so the idea is when you first create
a database
um you actually have to create a
container with it so notice here we'll
create a new one and then we have a
bunch of options here which
that's what we're going to be talking
about is all these options around
containers
so the properties of contain cosmos
could db containers uh
you know there are ones that are system
defined properties and depending on
which api you use some properties might
not be directly exposed so uh the
example of those system defined
properties are here so you can see them
underscored like underscore rid i'm sure
etag underscore ts underscore self the
id and so notice here that these are all
system generated this is user
configurable and it's going to vary
based on these it looks like it's mostly
just that sql api and then the ids on
all of them there
um but you know just to read through
this quickly we have unique identifier
for the container the entity tag used
for optimistic
concurrency control the last updated
timestamp of the
of the container the addressable ui for
the container the user defined unique
name for the container and there's more
than these but these are the ones that i
just picked out to show you here uh but
next let's talk about capacity for
containers okay
[Music]
so let's talk about capacity for
containers but what is capacity capacity
defines the amount of underlying
resources that are available to support
consumption of resources such as compute
and storage i made that sound much
fancier than it is but it's just what is
available to you
so like how much compute can i use how
much storage can i use and cosmo cb has
two capacity modes this is no different
than i mean similar to
a dynamodb but there are other ones
called on-demand it's not called
serverless but we have provision
throughput and we have serverless and
you're going to choose between those two
options let's talk about what is
different here so for provision
throughput for each of your containers
you provision some amount of throughput
expressed in ru's request units per
seconds and so for workloads where you
you can reliably predict the traffic uh
or you have more flexibility of your
options that's where it makes
sense to utilize it okay
and for serverless this is where you can
run your database operations against
your containers without having to
provision any capacity this is great for
low or small workloads or for
unpredictable spikes in traffics
it's easy to configure but has some
limitations so
provision throughput makes sense at
scale
serverless makes sense when you are
getting getting started or you're just
finding that it's just easier to manage
but you're going to really have to
decide between those
two options which is what we're going to
look at here so just to kind of break
down some additional options between
these two
uh when we're talking about geo
distribution for project for provision
throughput you can run it in unlimited
regions where servers can only run in a
single region the max storage per
container is unlimited for provision
throughput but for service it's 50
gigabytes for performance we're looking
at uh sub sub 10 millisecond latency for
re point reads and rights covered by
slas service level agreements
uh point reads uh is under uh sub 30
seconds for rights covered by slos so a
little bit different there the building
model is
very different so for provision
throughput building is done on a per
hour basis for the ru's provision
regardless of how many rus were consumed
and serverless is billions done on a per
hour basis for the amount of our use
consumed by your database operations so
in theory serverless can be more cost
effective but it really just depends on
what your consumption models look like
we're not done with capacity we're going
to look a little bit more at
throughput okay
[Music]
so there's more to the story for
provision throughput because you have uh
different
throughput strategies that you can
choose when you create your database
container and we said earlier when you
create a database you always have to
create a container with it and the two
modes are dedicated and shared mode so
for dedicated mode throughput is
exclusive to this container and backed
by slas
for shared throughput
or shared mode the throughput is shared
across all your containers you cannot
create throughput strategies after
creation so you have to choose wisely
and to switch throughput strategies you
basically just have to create a new
database and migrate that data over or
sorry container and create migrate that
data over
so when you're creating your database
and your container there's this little
checkbox for shared throughput across
containers that's how you know it's set
for shared mode
shared throughput is not available for
capacity mode of serverless because it's
all about provision throughput which
makes sense so when should you share
when should you not share so sharing the
database level provision throughput
among its containers
is um anonymous i don't know why i chose
that word it's such a hard word but that
means to compare to compare things uh to
hosting a database on a cluster of
machines so because all containers
within a database share the the
resources available machine you
naturally do not get predictable
performance or any specific container
but you get better utility or usage of
your resources they're not going to
waste so i think it's most like a cost
like a cost strategy kind of thing
because if you have a bunch of
containers they're not being used you
want it evenly distributed but
yeah that's all there is about that
feature okay
[Music]
okay let's talk about reading data from
cosmos db there are two different ways
to do this we have point reads and
queries
and this is a little bit confusing and i
honestly don't know what always cost
points and what don't
but impracticality is not that bad but
let's take a look here so point reads is
a
is a key value lookup on a single item
id and partition key and queries
allows you to return multiple items
so let's break it down here so the idea
is that when you are doing point reads
you have a latency of about 10
milliseconds queries it just varies so
you know could be higher could be lower
who knows
uh in terms of the ru's that you're
charged and i know we haven't talked
about our use but that is the next video
so just hold on or come back to this one
to help materialize that information but
for point reads it's always one
request unit okay and so that is very
predictable for queries it's 2.3 are
used at least and it's going to really
vary based on what your query is the
number of items returned for a point
read is one item queries is unlimited
and the idea is that should you include
the partition key for point reads it's
required for queries it's recommended so
hopefully that gives you an idea but
those are your two options when reading
and i think in the the follow along we
will we'll look at these two types of
read options okay
[Music]
all right we keep mentioning request
units are used now it's time to actually
describe what they are so the cost of
all database operations is normalized by
azure cosmos db and is expressed by
request units so ru's abstract away
memory cpu iops iop standing for input
output per second
and it's basically right sizing all
these things for you mean like choosing
the right size
with a single value based on data
processed so database operations uh
include reads so the size of the item
retrieve so one kilobyte would equal one
ru 100 kilobytes would equal 10 ru's so
we're just looking at the calculations
for read operations for ru's
an insert uh is inserting one kilobyte
item without indexing cost so this is
around 5.5 rus this is interesting
because like dynamodb which is adabus's
product they have um they do they have
reads and writes so they're separate but
cosmos db just has read units
then there's updating so replacing item
costs two times the charge required to
insert the same item so there's some
math there i don't deletes cost i
couldn't find it for queries it's the
size of the items retrieved so it's
going to greatly vary because we saw
earlier that you can have unlimited
items retrieved so you're pretty darn
expensive to calculate capacity
it is very very confusing
so the idea is that there is a capacity
calculator and this is what you should
use on the exam they're not going to ask
you a bunch of math questions
i point that out because
on aws exams for identity b you have to
know the math for this not so much but
you have this sweet calculator that you
can use to
figure out the capacity that you'll need
okay
[Music]
so a very very important concept when
we're talking about fully managed
databases especially nosql databases is
consistency when am i going to see my
data what am i when is it going to be
consistent across
all the servers that it's replicating
data to
so azure cosmos db provides five
different consistency levels to maintain
data availability and creating
performance depending on your
requirements and so we have this nice
graph to kind of or graph um
yeah graph to help visualize
the five levels on the left hand side we
have high latency lower availability the
worst read scalability and on the right
hand side we have lower latency
a higher availability better read
scalability so it's going to be based on
what you need
and so we'll start with the first one
which is strong consistency level so
this is
linear realizability reads are
guaranteed to return the most recent
version of an item
so strong means a guarantee that
what what you read is what you get okay
but the latency is going to be higher so
it could be a bit slower for it to get
back to you
then you have boundless staleness so
this is a consistent prefix it reads
reads leg behind writes
by most k prefixes or t intervals so
just understand that it's a bit better
than strong we have session so it has a
consistent prefix it's uh monotonic
reads monotonic rights
read your rights write right follows
reads okay i know this might not make
sense but don't worry we're going to go
through all of these still we're not
done we'll go through the list and then
we'll go in more detail on all these you
have consistent prefix so updates
returns are are some prefix of all
updates with no gaps
you have eventual so out of order read
so
you might read something and depending
on what
partition it hits or what
a replica hits the data might not be all
up to date
and so the way you're going to set your
consistency is you're going to choose it
here and there'll be additional options
this is honestly really confusing again
i'm going to keep comparing aws aws
dynamodb but it was done by db
it's not it's complicated right or even
like a bus s3 where it's just like it's
it's eventual or it's consistent
um so you can see there's a lot of
options here but you know of that
flexibility you have more choices i
guess so let's talk about all these
again so strong consistency read
operations ensure that the most recent
data is returned read operations cost
the same as boundless staleness but more
than session and eventual consistency
write operations can only be read after
the data has been replicated by most
replicas when they're talking about
costs i i guess they mean like the cost
to retrieve information
i'm not 100 sure
again i didn't see on the exam about
costs with consistency levels but uh
this is the language that is being used
in the documentation so that's why i'm
bringing it over for boundless staleness
read operations are like behind write
operations due to time or version
differences read operation costs the
same as strong consistency and more than
session eventual consistency has the
highest level of consistency compared to
session consistency consistent prefix
consistency and eventual consistency
recommended for globally distributed
applications with high availability and
low latency so remember it's for
globally distributed applications
we have sessions so read operations uh
ensure that written data is consistent
with the same session consistency is
scoped to a user session while other
users may encounter dirty data if
another session has just written to it
uh it's the default consistency
consistency level used to uh when using
a newly created database reading costs
are lower than boundless staleness and
strong consistency but higher than
eventual consistency
we have consistent prefix so read
operations ensure that the most recent
data replicated among the replicas is
returned but it does not guarantee the
data is the most recent
uh the idea is we have dirty data occurs
when one replica changes the data state
but this data has not yet been
replicated they keep using the word
dirty just meaning like
when you replicate when you have that
piece of data and it's stored in
multiple places
redundantly some of them are dirty so
they're not all up to date
has a stronger consistency level of
eventual consistency but less than any
other then we have eventual read
operations does not guarantee any
consistency level lowest consistency
level low lowest latency and best
performance among consistency levels so
things are really fast least expensive
read operation cost compared to any
other consistency levels so there you go
there's all the levels um you know
hopefully that makes sense again it's
very confusing but there you go
[Music]
let's talk about a very useful feature
in cosmos db known as change feed so
change feed
is a service that monitors changes in
all containers and distributes events
triggered by those changes to multiple
consumers so change feed in azure cosmos
db is a persistent record of changes to
container in in the order that they
occur
and the utility of this
like this is not unique
to a cosmos db a lot of databases might
have like extensions or modules
dynamodb has something similar called
dynamodb streams but the idea is that
you have a data source and you have an
insert and update and the idea is that
that record
goes into the change feed and then you
can react to that chain to that record
and push it to other services and so the
idea is just it's like a way of
triggering something on an insert so you
say okay i insert this data
um and so then send this data over to
this other service
so it's just a way of triggering stuff
okay azure has an sdk for net java
python no js nothing for ruby they're
having lots of trouble with the ruby sdk
at some point they'll fix it
the change feed is supported for sql api
cassandra api db api gremlin api
basically all the apis the exception of
table api
so that's that in terms of its
implementation the change feed processor
is composed of four components we have
the monitor container this is where any
insert or update executes the operations
are
reflected in the change feed i can get
my pen out here so if we can see where
it is so the monitor
the container i guess collections are up
here um
we have lease containers see they're
saying collections because the
collection um remember a collection is a
mapping to a container so collection
container we're kind of just
interchanging right here
but it stores the state and coordinates
the change feed
processor which is down here
the host an application instance that
uses the change feed processor to listen
for changes so that's the way it's it
knows what to do
um the delegate the code that runs when
an event in the change feed notification
triggers it and so that's the code
within the consumer there the change
feed processor may be hosted among azure
services that support long-running tasks
such as azure web jobs azure virtual
machines azure kubernetes services
azure.net hosted services
so
we could have looked at the code it's a
bunch of c-sharp code that they have as
examples it's super not exciting
um but you know i just want you to know
about this feature
but again it's not unique to cosmos db
but it is a common thing that you should
know about
for these kind of fully managed
databases okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure storage
accounts which is used for containing
all your azure storage data objects such
as blobs files queues tables and disks
so storage accounts is one of those
services where it has a bunch of
different storage types within it so
it's a quite the multi-purpose service
and with each different type of storage
it's going to have different features
and their own pricing models let's just
quickly break down the type of storage
we have so we have general purpose
version 1
version 2 blob storage block blob
storage and file storage and so i just
want you to know that when you are using
storage accounts
i'm saying storage type but for whatever
reason the ui calls it account kind just
to be aware of that small little
discrepancy there
but storage accounts are going to vary
based on features and so the common
features we'll see across storage will
be
supported services so where can i put
the storage account
and so on the right hand side you can
see
like if you make a general purpose
version 2 what you have access to such
as containers cues tables or falsers
those options are going to change based
on what you're using all right
for performance tiers this is how fast
you'll be able to do reads and writes
you have standard and premium uh you
have different kinds of access to yours
so how often do i need to quick access
these files and then there's replication
how many redundant copies should be made
and where and the last thing is
deployment models so who should deploy
the supported service resource manager
classic and in generally most cases it's
going to be a resource manager
[Music]
so here i have all the storage types on
the left-hand side and we have the
feature set and how it's going to vary
based on the certain types let's just
quickly look through this to see where
there are some standouts and you might
want to actually review this at the end
of this section just so uh you're a bit
more familiar with all these types of
features so it clicks a bit better but
let's just quickly go through this so
you're gonna notice for version one this
is the only case where you're gonna have
a deployment model of classic everything
else is gonna be the resource manager
from a practical standpoint you're not
going to really notice because you're
just going to be pressing buttons but
underneath
that's the only case where it varies for
replication you're going to notice that
version 2 has the most options with
replication and if these don't make
sense don't worry we're going to cover
all the replication in an upcoming slide
for
blob block storage you can see it's very
limited same with file storage
so that's there when we're talking about
access tiers how quickly you can access
files you're going to notice that it's
only available for general version 2 and
blob storage where we're choosing these
different tiers for these ones it
doesn't really matter
um because well especially like a file
storage because the drive is as fast as
it's going to be right
for performance tiers you're going to
notice that with version 1 and version 2
we have standard and premium when you're
using file storage and block blob
storage you're always using premium and
with blob storage which is again a
legacy format there that's going to be
using standard
uh blob storage comes in three different
types and you're going to notice that uh
based on what you want to use there'll
be some variation there
um i don't know where page is i think
that they both support page but there
are three types in there i wouldn't
really worry about it too much uh you're
gonna notice that file storage only
supports file types and then you have
version two and this pretty much uh
supports everything so you can see
general purpose version two is a really
great
um
storage to choose
[Music]
so we were just talking about storage
types now let's talk about the actual
storage services that we can actually
launch
or utilize within these storage types
under storage accounts and there are
five core storages available to us the
first is azure blob this is a massively
scalable object store for text and
binary data it also includes big data
analytics through data lake storage gen
2.
um and so azure blob is really great
because you just don't have to think
about the file system you just upload
files and they're treated like objects
so well that's really nice then you have
azure files and this is a file share
and so
the great thing about azure files is
that if you want to have a bunch of
virtual machines
and have it so like they have um the
same file system sharing all the same
files that's what you're going to use
that for then you have azure queues to
me this really is a database but for
whatever reason it's under uh storage
accounts and it's a nosql store for
schema-less storage of structured data
this is another unusual one uh i don't
know why azure puts it under here but
it's a messaging store for reliable
messaging uh between application
components to me that's like an
application integration service but
azure categorizes it as storage and the
last one is azure disk and this is block
level storage volumes for azure vms and
so the idea is that when you want to do
the top four the above you're going to
be launching storage accounts
and for disks you're going to be
launching disks it's a bit unusual
because um one of the storage accounts
say that you can
use or store disks uh in i think version
or uh general purpose version two i'm
not really sure i understand that uh
maybe it's talking about like backing
them up or something like that but
anyway from practical standpoint and for
what we need to know is that this is the
breakdown here and we do have a full
section on azure disks so we will get
into that
[Music]
so now let's take a look at some of the
features that are available on account
storage the first being performance
tiers and generally this is going to be
for blob storage and we have two types
of performance tiers we have standard
and premium so it's as simple as uh just
choosing between the two
and when we're talking about performance
especially when we're talking about
storage we want to be thinking about
iops and that stands for input output
operations per second so the higher the
iops the faster a drive can read and
write so you can uh definitely assume
that premium is going to have
a higher amount of iops and so when
we're looking at the premium performance
these are going to be stored on solid
state drives ssds which we have in the
picture there it's optimized for low
latency higher throughput and the use
cases here is going to be interactive
workloads analytics
ai or ml and data transformation on the
other side for standard performance
these are running on hard disk drives
and you're going to have varied
performance based on your access tier
and we're going to talk about access
tiers very shortly
but the tiers would be hot cool and
archive and this is great for backup and
disaster recovery media content bulk
data processing
and things like that
and so the reason why ssds are
generally really really good for
premium performance is because they have
no moving parts within them and the data
is distributed ram uh randomly so if you
have to do a read and write the distance
for between the read and writes are
going to be a lot faster
uh and that's generally why you're going
to see solid sacrifice with premium
performance or things with higher iops
and then for
hard disk drives it does have moving
parts so you see that it has an arm and
that arm needs to read and write data
sequential sequentially to the disk
and so it's very good at writing or
reading large amounts of data that is
close together that is sequential
but you know the idea is that neither uh
format is good or bad it's just the the
use case that you need so you don't
always need to go with ssd sometimes you
want to save money and hhd's are
or hdds are really good for that
[Music]
let's take a look at access tiers and
there are three types of tiers for
standard storage we have cool hot and
archive and so you're going to have this
option between
cool and hot and archived archive might
not show up depending on how you
configure your storage account
so for example if you use a particular
type of replication that might not be
available
to use with archives so just be aware if
that option doesn't show up you might
have to change some of your settings
let's quickly walk through the three
options so hot is for data that's
accessed frequently and has the highest
storage costs and lowest access costs so
again it's for data that is frequently
accessed or in active use or data that's
staged for processing and eventual
migration to the cool access tier then
you have the cool tier this is data
that's in frequently accessed and stored
for at least 30 days lower storage costs
higher access cost
and the use case here is for short-term
backup and disaster recovery data sets
or older media content not viewed
frequently anymore but is expected to be
available immediately when accessed
and i think there's actually a third use
case which is large data sets that need
to be stored cost effectively while more
data is being gathered for future
processing then we have the archive tier
this is for data that's rarely accessed
and stored for at least 180 days
it's the lowest storage cost but it also
has the highest access cost
and so its use case would be long-term
backups secondary backup archival data
sets original raw data that must be
preserved even after it's been processed
into its usable form
and compliance and archival data that
needs to be stored for a long time and
is hardly ever accessed so just make use
or note of the cool is at the least 30
days and the archive is at least 180
days i should have highlighted those for
you i don't know why i didn't
and so just some other things you need
to know so for account level tiering any
blob that doesn't have an explicitly
assigned tier infers the tier from the
storage account access to your settings
so you can set blobs at different
storage levels
blob level tearing you can upload a blob
to the tier of your choice and change uh
change the tiers happen instantly with
exception from moving out of archive
the concept of rehydrating this is when
you're moving a blob out of archive into
another tier and can take several hours
uh you have the blob lifecycle
management so you can create rule-based
policies or transition your data to
different tiers so after 30 days we can
move it to cool storage and here is just
the option here you see where it says
30. i think 30 is the minimum days you
have to choose um but it could be wrong
and so you have the options down below
so move to cool storage move to archive
storage delete the blob
and just a few other things here when a
blob is uploaded or moved to another
tier it's it's charged at the new tiers
rate immediately upon the tier chains so
when you're moving to a cold a cooler
tier the operation is billed as a write
operation to the destination tier and
when the right operation per 10 000 and
data right per gigabyte
charges for the destination tier applies
when moving to a hotter tier the
operations billed as a read from the
source tier and where the read operation
again in the 10k and the data retrieval
again in gigabytes charges for the
source tier applies and early detection
charges for any blob moved out of the
cool or archived tier may apply as well
and just lastly here uh when we're
talking about cool and archive early
detection any blob that has moved into
the cool tier so this is only for
general purpose version two accounts is
subject to a cool early detection period
of 30 days and any blob that is moved
into the archive tier is subject to an
archive early detection of 180 days and
this charge is pro-rated so
you know access tiers aren't the funnest
thing to talk about but there is all the
information you need to know
[Music]
let's take a closer look at az copy and
this is a command line utility that you
can use to copy blobber files to or from
a storage account so the first thing
you're going to need is the executable
file and there you can see they have it
for windows linux and mac and then once
you download that file what you're going
to have to do is also make sure that you
have the right level of authorization
with for the user account they're using
with it so you might need to for
download you'll need storage blob data
reader for upload storage blob data
contributor and storage blob data owner
so just be aware that you need to have
those uh rules available to you
to your user account i think that i have
access to everything so i don't think i
even i set this it just works but if
you're in a larger company and you have
more permissive least permissive roles
you just need to know about that
and so you can gain access
via either the azure active directory or
a shared access signature so let's just
take a look at that right now so the
idea here is that we'll type in a z copy
login and this is going to ask us
whether we want to sign into the web
browser so that is uh that should be
azure active directory option one and so
what you'll do is you'll enter your
username and password and you'll then
have to enter the code displayed there
and so now you're ready to use uh the um
the cli and so all you have to do is
type in az copy copy and then you have
the file and then you give it the
endpoint to the storage account uh and
the container and the location you want
it to go in if you want to download
files it's the same command you just
reverse the order you say uh this is the
the location of the file and want to
download it locally
all right
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at lifecycle
management which offers rule-based
policies that you can use to transition
blob data to the appropriate access
tiers or to expire data at the end of
data lifecycle so
what you can do here is transition blobs
from cool to hot immediately when they
are accessing access to optimize for
performance transition blob blob
versions and blob snapshots to a cooler
storage tier if the objects have not
been accessed or modified
for a period time to optimize for costs
delete blob blob versions and blob
snapshots at the end of their life
cycles to find rules to be run once per
day at the storage account level apply
rules to containers or a subset of blobs
using prefixes or blob index tags as
filters so here's an example of adding a
rule and one few things here you might
want to read here is the fact that you
can apply the rules to all your blob or
all blobs in your storage account or
limit based on a filter you can choose
the blob type or the blob subtype
and then there's the actual rules
themselves so here you can see if last
modified by one day then delete the blob
if last modified in the two days then
move to cool storage so it gives you
kind of an idea of things you can do
there okay
[Music]
in some cases you'll want to be able to
retrieve properties and metadata or set
meta data for storage accounts so let's
take a look at some of the ways we do
that with the cli the first is for
container properties and so
the idea here is we have azure container
containers show so here's an example
where it is showing container show
information so that's
the property information here
and then let's say we want to get we
want to update that data then we would
just use the update command
and then the idea here is we can pass
along data that we want to change
then there's also the idea of showing so
here we're just showing that metadata on
that container
i have a little bit more here i suppose
so we can also
update metadata on a blob so very
similar process but that's for a blob
and as you can imagine there is a show
command as well so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we're going to
learn a bit more about storage accounts
and how to copy uh content back and
forth using az copy so what i want you
to do is go all the way to the top here
and we'll type in storage accounts
and then from here we're going to create
ourselves a new storage account
and we'll make a new resource group i'm
going to call this one fajo
we'll type in fajo here
and we can have it in any location that
we so desire we're going to stick with
standard here general purpose 2 seems
okay to me we'll go ahead and hit review
and create
and then we'll hit create there
and i'll see you back here in a moment
all right so now that our storage
account is ready here we'll go in here
and we'll create ourselves a container
so i'm going to call this one kievas
faggo we're going to leave it as private
because we technically don't want anyone
to have public access to it
and so there is a tool that
you should definitely know how to use
called a z copy so if i just type that
in there quickly here and we go and
scroll down here are some versions we
can download
so if you're on mac linux windows or etc
we can use it i want to try to give you
a consistent experience on how you can
utilize this so
i'm going to just try and stumble my
throat way through and use it via the
cloud shell because i think that would
probably be the most consistent way for
all of us to use it so make sure you are
in bash and we're going to need two
things you're going to need this az copy
tar file and we're also going to need
some kind of file to upload okay
so
the question is how are we going to get
things into our cloud shell well the
great thing about cloud shells when you
launch it it asks you to create a
storage account and we should probably
be able to place those files into there
so if we go back to storage accounts at
the top here
and uh we go here this is a storage
account so if we go in here if there
were containers we go back but i believe
what they do is they set you actually up
a file share here right
and so in here it this is what it's
doing so what i'm going to do is upload
two files so i'll just go here
and one is going to be
this which is the kivas fajo which is
just an image
okay
and what we can do is i will download
this linux here
and once that is downloaded what i'm
going to do is also
upload that okay so i just drag that to
on to my desktop
it's a bit easier to access
i might just rename it so it's a bit
easier to work with
so i'm just going to rename the uh the
tars gz to a copy here if you can see
and uh we'll go back here and we'll just
go ahead and upload that okay
so we will upload that as well
and it's only 11 megabytes so it
shouldn't take too long here
but what we need to do is find out where
these files are so what we'll do is make
our way back to our shell i'm going to
type in ls
and i think it might be mounted here so
we'll do ls and there's our file so
um what we'll have to do is untie the az
copy so we get the binary
so i have a handy dandy command over
here from
i just found one over here because i can
never remember this command the tar
command so we'll type in tar hyphen x
v
z f
and then the name of the tar so i'm
going to start typing a z and then hit
tab to auto complete
and that should uh unturr it
and so now we have our
oh we made it into a folder so i'm going
to go into that folder there
and so now we have our easy copy here
okay
um so just to make our lives a bit
easier i'm going to want to move that
easy copy back one directory so i'm
going to type in mv for move i'm going
to type in az copy and i'm going to do
period period backslash so it says go or
forward slash you'll go back a directory
if we cd and do an ls
just do clean again we'll do ls
we can now see that it's a bit easier to
work with i'm going to delete the
that long folder there because we don't
need it
when it's a folder you got to do a
recursive so hyphen r
and we'll also go ahead and delete the
azcopy.tar file
okay
and we'll do uh clear
and then we'll do an ls hyphen la
that'll list everything because what i'm
trying to see is whether this file is
executable appears that uh we can
execute it if we can't it's usually a
good habit to do uh chamod u plus x
a z copy here
and then if we run this again
um yeah it looks the same so i think
we'll be in okay shape here but uh yeah
now we're all set up to um go ahead and
use the az copy command so let's give it
a go
all right so there's two ways we can get
um
or authenticate with easy copy and if
you remember from my handy dandy az copy
slide
we have two options which is we can use
this login or use the shared access
signature we're going to give both a try
but we'll start out with azlogin okay so
we'll do type in az copy
login
and what that will do is it will
prompt us and ask us to sign into the
browser and enter this code so i'm just
going to
grab this link here and we will copy it
i'll make a new tab paste it in
and once here we'll go ahead and enter
in this code okay
and we'll just say yep andrew brown and
so now that is now synced so now we
should be able to use the az copy
command uh in order to use this again we
pull up my reference here we have a z
copy copy the name of the file and then
the name of the path we want wanted to
go to okay
so what we'll have to do is uh in our
container here it's called key vas fajo
so we'll have to remember that but if we
go here we're looking for that publicly
accessible url or that fully qualified
domain url
um i would have swore it was
here
um
oh sorry we're in the wrong storage
account by the way we have to go into
our actual
faggio one here just in case
just making sure we're in the right
place but let me just go find that url i
can't remember if we have to assemble it
by hand or if they just have it handy
here so just give me a moment
all right i'm back and i had to pull up
the docs for this one which is not a big
deal um but
the structure here is we're going to
have https the account blob or
windows.net the name of the container
and the path to the blob okay
so that's what we're going to do here so
let's give it a go and see if we can get
it to work the first time around here so
we are typing well before we do that i'm
going to type clear and then do ls so
we're going to type in a z copy
and the command is cp
or actually you can type in copy if you
want it looks like cp is abbreviation
and so the path to the file and so in
our case it's going to just be local so
i just typed in k and i tabbed and the
next thing we have to type is https
colon forward slash forward slash the
name of the account so it's fajo
and then blob
dot core
dot windows
dot net forward slash and then we named
the uh container here kivas
fajo
and then we'll type a forward slash
and then we can name the file however we
want so i'm going to name it the same as
the jpeg okay
and so hopefully this just works
and
i mean it looks like it worked pending
says the file transfer might have failed
here hold on
so it says we're not performed to other
we don't have access to perform that
there
so just give me a moment okay
all right so i figured it out um there
was one key thing we forgot to do so
the reason we're getting a 403 was as
plain as it was is we didn't have access
to do it so if we just go back to our
storage account there
um
and this is within the container so i'm
just going to go all the way back to
storage accounts we'll go into fajo here
and so on the left hand side you see it
says access controls
right so if we were to go into here and
we go to role assignments we can see
what what role that people have but in
order to access
blob storage you need to like to be able
to upload and download you either have
to be the storage blob data owner or the
storage blob data contributor so if you
want to do that you just have to go up
to add and do a role assignment and sign
yourself this role
it does take about five minutes to take
effect so even after doing at doing this
adding it to my user here i wasn't able
to do it right away but after waiting a
little bit here i was able to go and do
a test like with list
and it didn't print anything but that
means that there is no error right so
we probably do have access another
little thing i found out which was nice
is that if you go let's say into a
container here
um and then you just clear that out
we'll click into that container and on
properties here it actually gives us the
url so it makes our lives a little bit
easier so we have to type that whole
thing out and try to figure it out but
let's go back and try to actually do a
copy now so that's what we've been
trying to do this entire time so what
i'm going to do is type in az copy
and then we want uh
kivasvagio
and then i'm going to paste in the url
that i just got from there
and
[Music]
i'm just going to put a forward slash
here i'm going to type in kivas
faggot.jpg
um
oh you know what we got to put the word
copy or cp in front of it
and it looks like it completed that
looks good to me and so if we make our
way back
here to
um to our container we can see that it's
uploaded so there we go we were able to
upload it with um active directory so
now let's go give it a try with a sas
okay
all right so let's give this another go
here and this time what we're going to
do is use an sas
so it's as simple as attaching it to the
end of the url for the the destination
or the source depending on what we want
to do
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and delete this file here
just because we already have it and what
i'm going to do is go back to my storage
account
and what we need is a sas here so i'll
type it in here i wonder if we can type
it the oh yeah we can here that's great
so type it here at the shared signature
access and we'll say what do we need
access to well we're only using blob
storage so we get rid of file queue and
table
allowed resource types will be for
container because that's what we're
doing
uh and we aren't deleting we
don't necessarily need a list but we can
have that there read write add create
that seems okay to me enable deletion of
versions um
i mean we don't have to turn that off um
but
we'll just leave it in place
i think we will do http or https just
have some flexibility here
and this looks okay we have a few
different keys we're gonna stick with
key one and so i'm gonna go ahead and
generate out
an sas connection string
and so this is the token we want see how
it has a question mark it's going to
help allow us it's going to be creasing
allow us to put that on the end of our
url
so what i will do
is i will i don't know if we can write a
z
copy log out let's see if we can do that
oh we can great so just making sure that
it's not authenticating that way
and so what i'll do is i'll go back up
to uh this link here and this should
fail right because we don't have access
right and so what we should be able to
do is just take this string and place
this on the end as such and hopefully
just works
and it says done done done so if we go
back to
our storage here to see if that is uh
working as expected we go into that
container
um
[Music]
let's just move this down below here it
gets a bit hard to see when you have
that open like that
over in storage account right now okay
so we're going to type in container go
here
click into
uh
devos fagio and we don't see the file so
let me give it let me give a try here
okay
all right let's give it another go here
um
you know i just don't necessarily trust
url actually it says fail to perform
copy no sas token or oauth provided
which is fine but in this case we did
and we saw it done done done and so here
are the values it's printing out so
maybe what we should do is just
regenerate this out
and be a little bit more uh permissive
um and maybe that will give us an easier
time because we want read oh this is
slightly different a for the container
not sure why this looks different all of
a sudden but what we'll do is we'll go
back here
we'll just go close a bit we'll go back
into fagio i'm going to go look for the
container again
and what we'll do is click into the
container and then from here we'll do
shared access properties
um
we'll do account key which is fine so
key one
i want i'm just going to put everything
on here to make our lives a bit easier
the start date is fine the end date is
fine
will allow http or https
and we'll generate that token so
here we have it again
so we'll do is we'll just grab this
whole thing here
actually we probably yeah we'll just
grab the token
um and then what we'll do is make our
way back to
here
i'm going to hit up
and what i'm going to try to do is
remove the end here and give this
another go okay
so paste that in
i don't see the question mark on that so
this is not uh this is not an easy one
okay
we'll put question mark here hit enter
it just says stopped done done done done
so it makes you think that it's working
clearly is not um
let's just double check the container to
see what's there okay
no file still
well what if we uh grab this one here
maybe it's an encoding issue or maybe it
doesn't like the way we do the link
hit enter
still says stopped
i don't know
all right i'm back so you know what i
thought i was doing everything right and
so just as a sanity check what i did was
i opened up my command prompt
and i installed a just a different
version of azcopy it's the windows
version and using the exact same command
it worked so you know i just want you to
know like this is kind of
something i run into a lot with azure
whereas if you try it one way it doesn't
work but some other place it works no
problem just because azure tries to
support all use cases
sometimes you'll be spending a lot of
time uh second guessing yourself but
definitely the command i showed you was
correct um but uh you know it could be
that the um daisy copy version is out of
date so remember when we wrote an az
copy here for linux it was suggesting to
get a newer version but i had downloaded
the latest version so
you know it could be that um it's really
hard to say uh but i want you to know
like that's just how you do an easy copy
um and you know don't get frustrated if
you get stuck on stuff like this okay so
we're all done here and let's go ahead
and tear down our stuff
and uh we'll just go to fajo here that's
the one we set up there and we'll go
ahead and delete that resource group
and we're all done here okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to learn how to work
with azure's sdk so we're going to work
with a variety of different languages
and we're going to interact um i suppose
with a storage account so what i want
you to do is make your way over to your
portal here and type in storage accounts
across the top and we will create
ourselves a new repository here or sorry
a storage account and we'll call this
one my sdk playground
and we will say ok and i'll just type
the same thing by sdk playground you
might have to put some numbers on the
end there because these are fully
qualified domains yes east us is totally
fine standard is fine we'll go ahead
ahead and hit review and create so we'll
give it a moment there
then we'll go hit create
and we just have to wait about 30
seconds for this to finish
while this is going what we can do is
make our way over to github because
we're going to need a repository to play
around in so i'm going to create a new
repository
and we will choose whoops i don't want
to template but i want to go to my own
and this will be my sdk azure playground
putting the word azure in there so i
know what this is later on we'll say add
readme we're not going to choose a git
ignore file because we'll have to vary
it based on a couple different folders
and you should have get pod installed or
if you don't you can use your local
machine it's up to you
but it's a lot easier to use git pod
here it's free free to use so no reason
not to to use getpod all you're doing is
attaching this in the front of your url
if you want the button you can go get
the chrome extension i'm going to go
ahead and hit get pod and spin up that
environment going back to our resource
or storage account you can see it's
deployed so we'll go to that resource
and what we'll need here is a single
container so that is something that we
will grab here right away and then um
so let's just say container one
i'll make it private i'll just make it
one with no hyphen because i think
that's how i wrote the instructions
and so in here we will need to upload
some kind of file so i'm just going to
upload a data pipe and data stair
upload any files you like but you'll
have to change the names accordingly
what we'll need to do is make our way
over to access controls i'm actually
going to do this at the storage level so
we'll go back up a layer here
go back to that resource we'll go to
access keys
and we are going to need
our connection string oh sorry shared
access signatures
well we'll figure it out here in a
moment because we do need to i thought
it was under access keys that it shows
um oh it's right here connection string
okay so it is right here we'll be in
good shape so what we'll do is go back
to our git pod and we're gonna make uh
three folders we're gonna have ruby
we're gonna have python
and we're going to have
uh javascript so we'll just say yeah js
for javascript and in each of those
we're going to create a new file so so
say gem file
uh this will be the actually i want to
generate that out
so we'll uh cd into that directory and
i'll say bundle
um
bundle init so that will create a way
for us to manage packages in ruby for uh
for python we'll create a new one called
um
uh
requirements.txt
and then for uh javascript
this will be npm init and so these are
the three ways well i should have done
hyphen y on this here
these will be the three ways that we
bring in our external libraries of the
azure sdk into each of these programming
environments so first for ruby we'll go
through that one
so for this one we need to install a gem
called
azure storage
storage blob
so that will be for that one for python
it is called i'm just trying to find the
name here
it is azure storage
blob and we can give it a version here
we could also take the version out it
probably should still work without the
version there
and then for our package.json we'll just
install that there as well so i'm just
going to cd into
um python because it's easier to install
python packet or sorry yeah not python
packages but javascript packages
from the cli here so i'm just looking
for what it's called so it's mpm
install at sign azure storage
blob
all right so this one's installed we go
to package.json we can see it's required
uh the gem file in order to install in
ruby we have to do bundle install
and the reason i'm doing them all in
parallels i'm trying to show you there's
a pattern right you're installing the
package you're basically doing the same
thing over and over it's just that the
syntax is slightly different for python
is going to be python
or sorry pip
pip install
hyphen r requirements
and i generally remember all these
things you know what i mean like i might
not remember all the details but i know
that the patterns are the same and that
makes it a lot easier and we call this
cloud programming because you don't need
to know
everything in order to do this
so the first one that we're going to set
up is the ruby file so we'll make a new
file here and we'll just say main.rb
which is an okay name here
and we'll get coding with this one first
so what we'll need to do is require
and we'll do azure storage blob
and here we want the account name
and we want to have the account key
so we'll go back over to here and i'm
going to go ahead and grab the first key
so we'll say show
and i don't want to put an action here i
want to put it down in my environment
variable so i'm going to say export
account
key here equals
and then i'm just going to do double
quotations and paste it in and hit enter
and i'm going to do gp that's for git
pod environments account key
i'm just setting it twice so that if we
have to restart this environment that
these keys will persist
okay so
um
what we'll do here is just put in um
env parentheses
and this will be account key
so that'd be the way we um import it
into ruby because that's how you do it
well this one's account key this is
account name so let's say account name
and then here will be account key
and if we were to write puts account
name
puts
account key that should print those out
so we can see if they work so we'll do
bundle exect
ruby
main so this is a pretty common way and
i'm doing in the wrong folder we got to
make sure we're in the ruby folder
before we do that
so this is a common way in ruby to run
things in the context of the gem file
you'll see that's kind of a bit of a
trend for all these different uh
programming environments so we'll go
ahead and hit enter and it should just
print out the keys it printed out the
first one but not the second one we
didn't set the count a name yet so this
is the account name for it so we'll do
export account name
the reason we're doing export is that it
actually loads the environment variable
so if we go here and say grep
account you can see it's actually loaded
into our developer environment and then
getpod environment is going to persist
if we restart this environment so
there's that one and then we want to do
it
for
get pod there we go so they're both set
if i just double check here and we do
this
they both show up so that is good
and so the next thing we want to do is
make a client so we want to establish a
connection so i'm going to do blob
client equals azure
storage blob
blob
service
dot create if you're wondering like
where do you find these things you just
like search on google you say azure
azure blob storage ruby
like and maybe documentation and you
know through there you can kind of find
information there's probably like a
documentation page
if we go here
um
i know there's one
maybe here
and then you scroll down
blobs
so there's all sorts of way yeah this is
pretty similar code here so there's all
sorts of way to find it you just have to
kind of search around and eventually you
acquire that knowledge so we need the
storage
account name and then we need the
storage access key
so this will be the
account name and this will be
the account key and then down below
we'll just do blob client we'll make
sure that works so we'll go back and
oops hit up on the bundled exec here
and so it prints out some kind of object
so we know that is now uh at least
the the client's being created so now
let's go ahead and actually print
something out so we'll go blob client
list
containers parentheses each
do container
and so just kind of doing iteration here
and just do container name
and if we hit up
it will print out container one so that
container now does exist let's say we
wanted to go create a container that's
something we can do as well from here so
we'll say blob client
create container
i'll just say
sum container name
here and we'll do it again and if we go
over here and take a look at our
containers we should see
a second container called some container
names that one is working fine
let's say we want to print out the
content so we'll do blob client list
containers actually we already did this
up here i'm not going to print it out
twice we'll just do it in the interior
here might as well just print out the
contents of all the blobs we're going to
see what is actually in the containers
say container name dot each
do
blob
and and then we'll do puts
do interpolation blob
name
then we hit up
uh list blobs probably that's probably
what it's supposed to be here
you can see it's printing out the names
here so that's working out fine uh it
had a http error i don't know if it
actually matters we'll do it again
oh you know what it's because we already
created this one so we'll just comment
this out that was just like a one off
there
but you can see
so it's not gonna create the same folder
that's printing the contents of
container one there's nothing in
container two or some container
so that is pretty straightforward there
let's go take a look at python
so we'll make a new file here we'll call
it main.pi
normally like if you want to isolate
your libraries you create a python
environment i didn't do that um i don't
really always remember how to do it
because i don't work in python that
often but i know it exists but that's
the idea behind us doing the bundle exec
or if we do mpm start which you'll see
here is that it's in the context of our
isolated libraries that we want to use
uh but anyway we'll get started with
python here so
very similar process we're gonna do
azure storage blob
base blob service import base blob
service a little bit more verbose i'm
not a big fan of um
i'm not a big fan of python i need to
figure out how to get environment
variables i'll be back in a second
okay so to get environment variables is
just import
os
and then from here we can get uh os
and viron
squares
all right we could just do get i suppose
okay it's probably nicer and we can do
account name here
see the process a little bit different
account key
instead of puts it will be print
so account name
[Music]
account key
starting to look familiar right
just slightly different and we'll have
to be in the right folder here so we'll
make our way over to python this one's
going to be
python
main we don't have to uh
you know
do it in the context stuff because it's
already there no module name azure
storage blob
blob service line i don't know if we did
an install i thought we did so we'll do
it again requirements.txt
i mean it's totally possible i typed
something wrong
i'm just double checking azure storage
blob
base blob
service
looks correct to me we'll try this again
i'm just going to do a quick search here
just to see if i typed it wrong
just in case it's a versioning issue
because we did have a version in there
2.1.0 i just don't want this to mess up
so i'm going to go here and go to
2.1.0
and we'll try this again because you
never know if these requirements ever
change
i think it wants double equals
yeah it does
and we'll give this another go okay so
now it's working so the versioning does
matter we're not on the latest version
but honestly it doesn't really matter
because
you know
it doesn't
so now that we have those two printing
out we can go ahead and make our client
or i guess service in this case the
wording's a little bit different each
one i don't know why but it's just how
they do it
so here we will have account name
[Music]
equals account name
account key equals account key
and we will print out the blob service
as similar to before
we will go up
oh sorry i wanted to do uh python main
here
and so that prints out no problem
now we'll need to iterate through this
stuff so we'll say containers equals
blob service
list containers parentheses for
container in containers
and this is indent based so there's no
like closing statement we just double
like this
container.name
i wasn't trying to run it i think it
just ran there below by accident just
type exit down below here
we will hit um
go back to
thinks i'm in a shell i'm not in a shell
okay so we'll say python
main.rb again
oh i'm back in the main folder
so we'll say python main.rb
and it says can't open file or directory
python i do oh it's right there
sorry pi
and uh now it's saying these don't exist
so
let me just do
i think because we entered an
environment i don't know what happened
here but something happened where see
ran this
and it put us into the
python environment shell and that wasn't
something i intended to do so what i'm
going to do
oh i'm going to have to update our git
pod yaml file here i'm just going to add
a or ignore i'm just going to commit the
stuff to reset the environment because i
really don't want to be in a a
pi environment like that
it was just kind of a mistake
and
hit add dot get ignore
come on let me add this darn file
i'm just trying to commit this single
file here
get add.get ignore
so then when we go over here
it's a bit more manageable so i'm just
going to commit all the code here
um
ruby and some python
and what i'll do is i'll just close this
environment
and then reopen it
and those environment variables should
still be set because we did the gitpod
enamel
or getpod environment
so i'll just give it a moment here to
respin up the environment
all right so our environment is back up
so what i'm going to do is make our way
back into the python directory and we'll
do a
pip
install
our requirements
and so hopefully this time we don't get
that weird
problem we had before here i really
don't have to restart
notice it's printing the container name
so
pretty similar to what we did before
and so what we'll need to do now is just
print out the actual objects like we did
with the ruby script so we'll go back
here to the main
scroll on down
and we'll do blobs
equals blob
service list blobs
parentheses container name
for blob in
blobs
we'll say print
f
i think it's just single quotations i
always want to do uh doubles there but
it's a single
and we'll do um
curly's like that
blob name so you saw this in the ruby
one but it was like it said it was a
pound and double quotation so this is
called interpolations where you inject a
variable into a string each language
does it a little bit different so let's
take a look here at this point one
prints out the object same thing so very
similar let's go take a look at
javascript so that is our next one here
so we'll go over here we'll make a new
file we'll call it main.js
we will need to update our package.json
so we have a way of calling the script
so we'll just call start here and we'll
just say nodemain.js
and then we will go up here
and we will load the stuff in so we'll
say uh constant
curlies blob service client
storage shared key credentials
credential
you got to spell it right or it will
mess up for sure
equals require
at sign double single quotations azure
storage blob
and we'll do constant account name
constant
account key
and there will be this one and then
there will be this one so
um
how do we load environment variables in
javascript i'll be back in two seconds
actually i'm surprised i don't remember
because i did it in so many other
followings it's actually just process
it's a problem when you move from a lot
of languages you have to kind of look
things up multiple times but it's okay
because as long as you know what you
need to look up
env dot account key
so those are our two that we're going to
load here we need to create a credential
key so we'll say key
credential equals new
storage shared access credential
parentheses account name
account key and then down below we'll
create a blob client equals new blob
service client it's interesting like how
they're all slightly named difference
like in python it's just uh service
ruby's just client and then in
in javascript it is
service client so we'll do a url so this
is when i always say like things are
fully qualified domain name that's
that's what i mean is like you can
literally call us
services like storage
based on a fully qualified domain so
we'll do blob
core
windows.net
and we'll go down below here and say key
credential
here
and so we'll do console log
blob client i don't know if we'll get
anything intelligible out of this but
we'll give it a go i think like as long
as we don't get an error it should be
fine
because i don't know if it would return
anything in javascript we'll find out
here in a second so we'll make our way
over to node.js
or javascript we'll do an npm install
npm install
and we must have a syntax error here
there's a comma missing here
oops i didn't want to build lines it's
just being silly we'll go back here to
npm install so it's we have to do it
because i restarted the environment
because those did not persist
and
what we'll do is do npm start
oh we are getting data so there are no
errors which is good
and we're getting a object back so
this looks good these errors are all
errors
we'll go back to our main js
and we will do what we've been doing
which is iterating through stuff so the
first thing we'll need to do is create a
new function we're going to call this
async
function container inventory
i really really don't like
having to do asynchronous stuff when i
don't have to
but
that's like a
common feature i mean other languages
have it but that's something we do often
in
node.js or javascript so we'll say
408 parentheses constant container in
containers
curlies
console.log
container name
container
dot name
and then we will call this function
so hopefully this works
npm start
we we don't need this anymore here it's
gonna get our way so i'm gonna take it
out
uh it doesn't like the end it's supposed
to be of
if it's not in change of
we'll iterate through here and we get
our two containers now we need to go get
the
blobs within it
so in here what we'll do
i'll just think about this for a second
we need to
do constant container client equals
blob client get container client
parentheses container name
and we'll say
let blobs equals
container client
list blob flat
parentheses container name
we'll say 408
const blob of blobs
console log parenthesis
back ticks
is it back ticks yeah it's back ticks
dollar sign curlies again this is how
you know each one has different
interpolation right so like python it
was
single string you had to put this f in
the front to do interpolation ruby was
just double quotations with a pound
curly so they're all just slightly
different and hopefully this works
no uh container is not defined so
[Music]
what line is it complaining on it's
complaining on the list blob flat right
here so i must have spelt it wrong
we'll go ahead and paste that in there
it didn't paste right
we'll just retype it container
try it again
there we go and so that's all three of
them so that's all i really wanted you
to do
just go through the motions of using the
sdk
with some language and just to see that
there are some patterns to languages so
it's not as super hard as you imagine
we'll close that it doesn't really
matter if we leave it around or we
don't delete it but for the resource
group here with the storage account we
will go ahead and delete
i'll go in here we'll go into my sdk
play oh and
we'll click on the resource group here
lots of ways to get to the resource
group we'll go ahead and delete
our resource group and i'll also delete
the storage account so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this fall along we are going to work
with blob storage object metadata and
specifically with powershell in order to
set it and view that it's working so
what we're going to need is um an
environment in order to run powershell
so we're going to do it in cloud shell
we'll expand that and you'll have to be
on powershell mode if you this is the
first time you're running cloud shell
ever you might have to
accept for a storage account so it might
say like create a storage account for
this you just say yes
notice here that it's running uh install
module for you for azure
so you know if you're doing this on your
local machine and you can do this if you
have windows installed so the idea is
that you would open up powershell so i
type in powershell
all right click and run administrator
remote if you're on a mac you can
install powershell
on a mac but to be honest this is so
much easier if we just use cloud shell
but i just want to show you a couple
things so if you were to install
um
azure you do install module hyphen name
az and then this thing takes
forever
like i swear to you it takes forever and
that's why i don't really want to do it
this way
just bump up the font here to 24.
and so we just say yes to all
and we'll let that install in the
background
but i just want you to know that that's
how you install all the add azure
command commandlets
because it's very useful to know
and we do it a couple times i actually
do do it in one and we have to wait and
it takes forever
but while that's installing the
background we're gonna assume that we
did connect a z and install module and
now we are just getting some stuff so
it's a good habit to whenever you're
using type of clear hair whenever using
a powershell with azure to make sure
that you are on the correct subscription
um because it can be in the wrong place
so even though i know this is the one
we're on i'm just going to set it again
so we get the habit of doing it so it's
set
az context
here and we'll do subscription
[Music]
and we'll do azure sub
description one and so that will make
sure that that is explicitly set now we
want to
get access to the resource group and of
course we could easily do this
through
the console but you know i wanted to
learn some powershell so i'm going to
make a new tab here and what we'll do
is make our way over to storage accounts
because we're going to need a new
storage account for this
we'll go ahead and hit create
and we will make a new resource group
this one's going to be called
my blob metadata
and we'll say blob metadata
88 whatever it doesn't matter as long as
it's not used we'll hit review create
and we will
create it here
and we'll give it a moment here so we
can go to the resource group so there
are a few things we will have to type in
that thing will be done in a moment so
we'll need um just type clear here it
always messes up i'm going to expand
this because we really don't need
anything in the background so we want
dollar sign resource group
equals and then whatever we called it so
my metadata blob i think
or my blob metadata
my blob metadata
and we'll hit enter whoops that is not
what i want i want an a on the end there
and then we need the storage account
name
so here it will be called
go to the resource
that is the name right there
all we're doing is setting variables
here right now
and it's not copying properly because
you have to right click you can't
use hotkeys there why i don't
know uh we'll do storage
key equals and the idea is we are going
to fetch our storage keys we'll do a z
storage
account key
resource group name
dollar signed resource group
and then name
dollar sign
storage
account i just noticed that i spelled
that wrong i'm just going to hit enter
because i know that's not going to work
i just want to take this c and make it
smaller
go back here and do storage account
hit enter and so that will create that
then we need our context and we'll say
new a z
storage
context storage
account name dollar sign storage account
storage
account key dollar sign storage key
and it doesn't like something because we
need to actually get the value because
if we type in storage here
and by the way i didn't type this right
again
storage key but if we do storage key and
just see what was returned
notice that there's two keys so we'd
have to do something like zero dot value
here
so we'll go here and say
square zero
dot value
and it says cannot provide parameter for
name
um
[Music]
oh you know what that doesn't make sense
it's not it's not name sorry it's
because i'm going back to the wrong one
here so this is this one
and we really wanted the context
just have to be careful what we're doing
here there we go so now we have a
context
so it's just telling us
what we're kind of bound to and so now
we can do get a z
storage container
hyphen contacts dollar sign context if
you're wondering like where do you get
all these like all of these um commands
like once you find one you find them all
pretty much
see here there's like tons tons of them
you can read through them and they have
tons of examples so you can work your
way through and figure it out
uh so i was expecting
[Music]
i guess there are no containers so that
kind of makes sense so we'll go over to
here and we'll say container one
keep it all lower case to make our lives
easier
and we'll go back over here and we will
hit up again you can see there's a
container i think we can type in
container and then do container one
to specify even greater context there
except i just have to put a capital c on
here maybe oh lower case on this one i
think all these parameters don't matter
they can all be lowercase so those don't
matter
so we now have a reference to a
container
so now what we need to do is
um
reference a blob so
what i'm going to do is
type in blob
and i think we'll have to upload
something first but i'm just going to
type something for fun here
uh and so i'd probably do like an image
i have an image on our desktop that i've
been using for a while so data pipe
web p
is probably what it is
and we'll do container it isn't there
yet but we'll see what happens if we do
it and there's no image or uh thing
uploaded we'll do dollar sign context
and so it says could not recognize that
command this happens a lot but it always
has to be like something like a verb or
an action and then
whatever so it's just saying the file's
not there we know that's the case we'll
go into our container and we'll say
upload we will then go
and upload data pipe it's actually a png
which is a lot easier on us we'll go
back over here again you'll have to
upload your own file it'll have its own
name so you got to go find an image
yourself
we'll hit enter
and so if we now type in blob we have a
reference to that blob
so let's get some information about the
blob so we'll say blob dot
blob client get
properties dot value
and so we have a lot of information
about the blob notice that there is no
metadata right here um i think we can
just get the metadata if we type in
metadata
i don't think there is any metadata so
it's not returning anything i'm just
going to make sure i'm typing it right
i'll type something i know is there like
etag
yeah so it's just there's nothing set
so what we'll do is make some metadata
so we'll do metadata equals new
object system
dot collections.generic.dictionary
double quotation squares string string
so we are creating a new object that
expects a dictionary with a string
string hopefully that makes sense it's
because we have to add
a key and a value
right because that's how tags mostly
work even for metadata so we'll go here
and say author
exam pro
and we'll say dollar sign
metadata dot add
department
i t
and we'll just say blob dot
blob clients dot set metadata
and then we'll actually set the metadata
so let's say metadata
dollar sign null i don't know why the
second one is null i don't really care
if we wanted to look it up we could
doesn't really matter but it does set
the metadata because if we go back
to our blob
do this now we have metadata on it just
to make sure that it is working
correctly we're going to just null it
out
so if we go blob so and now we'll fetch
it again
just so that we know remotely it's not
like a local thing
we'll go here
and so there you go so that's all i
really wanted to show you and hopefully
you get a little bit more powershell
experience there what we'll do is go to
the resource group and clean up here
we will go into this one
we will delete it
give it a moment and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this fall along we are going to
copy a blob from one container to
another using powershell so what i want
you to do is go to the top here and
we're going to type in storage accounts
and we're going to create ourselves a
new storage account and the storage
account is going to be called
well the resource group will be called
my
uh
blob copy
powershell ps4 powershell and we will
say blob ps
okay a bunch of numbers because the
naming is always a pain because these
are fully qualified domains review
create
and wait a moment so you can go ahead
and create we'll hit create and we'll
wait a little bit
here it only takes a few seconds but
while it's going we might as well open
up our cloud shell environment if this
is the first time you've ever opened up
cloud shell you will have to
um
you will have to
accept it for storage accounts and by
the way off screen i was doing this in
another follow along i never came back
to it but like if you want to have azure
installed you have to install module uh
name azure the cloud gallery does this
but this takes forever and then once
it's installed what you would do is you
do a connect
and that connect command would be i'm
just trying to find it here
i think i would know it off the top of
my head i do not it's like connect
a z account
and then what it would do is it would
prompt you to log in with microsoft it's
not going to work here on my local
machine because i don't have
something authenticated
and so i just don't want to bother with
it but anyway we're going to do it here
because it's so much easier over here
and so we'll go back over to our oops
that's from an old follow along we'll go
here and open this i guess open it here
it's fine we'll go ahead and create a
new container so we'll say container one
and then we'll go and create container
two
and we will i guess expand this for the
most part and we'll get to it here
so now that our containers are created
we'll go ahead
and make sure that we are in the correct
subscription this is something you
always should do
just to make sure the right place so
this is the subscription we're currently
set i know it's already set correctly
but just to go through the habits of
setting it we're going to set the
context for the subscription to be
explicitly this one
because that's something that will catch
you off guard as being in the wrong
subscription and so we need to set up
some
variables we'll have resource group
equals and we'll have to find the name
of it
so we called this we'll go the overview
here
my
blob copy ps let's click off here i
don't know why it's doing this weird
select
sometimes it happens
there we go
so that is the name of that then we need
the
storage account
name and so the storage account name is
does it show me here no i can go up one
layer
go the resource this is the storage
account name
oh boy
i always forget
that you cannot
uh do command v there you gotta paste
manually and so we'll get the storage
key here
and of course we could just easily get
it by going to the left-hand side here
and clicking a couple buttons but again
we want to practice our powershell so
we'll do get a z
storage account key
minus or hyphen resource group name
dollar sign resource group hyphen name
storage account
okay and if i've typed everything right
we'll hit enter
uh
i don't think i typed everything right
did i
a parameter cannot be found that matches
the name resource group so that doesn't
look right to be
here
and if we do storage key we can see we
have the key
if we do zero we can get the first one
if we do value we can get the value
which is something we will have to do
and we set the context here for the new
azure storage context so we'll do new
hyphen az storage context
storage account
storage account name
dollar sign storage account
storage account key
storage key
and
oh we have to do zero
dot value here and so now if we do
context
it should show us a proper context here
there we go
all right so now what we want to do is
upload some kind of blob or actually we
don't need to upload one we just need to
store one so i'm actually going to use
an image
i keep using the same image
in the in my lab i might use a text file
instead but it's up to you what you want
to use so in here i'm going to go over
to the container
where are your containers
and we will go to the container here and
we will
click into it
and i will upload
a new file so we'll say data pipe png
upload
and now that that's been uploaded i'm
going to type in get
a z storage blob hyphen blob
we call that data hyphen pipe because
he's wearing he has a pipe in his mouth
in the video or in the image and we'll
say container one
context dollar sign context and
we'll hit enter
it's because we've got the hyphen here
and we spelt the blob name wrong
there we go so it's returning that so
that is good
and the idea is we want to download it
to our local storage so we can move it
to the other one so for that we will
still have the context
but what we'll do is set a destination
and say here
oh you know it's get azure
azure um
storage blob content that's how we get
the content
not context content
and uh we'll say yes because i've done
this one before so it's already here if
we do ls it's now in our cloud shell so
the file is right here so you have like
a test file and just remove that test
file and so now what we need to do is
upload to the other container
so we'll do is do set
storage blob content
we'll say file
data pipe
hyphen container container 2
context dollar sign context and we'll
give it some properties it's always good
to set the
content type
whoops
content type no hyphen i always try to
put a hyphen there because i always
think i'm doing um
a header and we'll hit enter and so it
says storage blob context is not right
because we messed that up it should be
content
and i forgot the hyphen over here
does not recognize set storage blob
content
set az storage blob content
um
content type is invalid
i gotta spell content right
could you tell i'm dyslexic i actually
am dyslexic so i type a lot of stuff
wrong like crazy
and i still am able to do cloud
az storage blob hyphen blob
and this is where we upload it so we
will
do data pipeline here
container
container 2
context
dollar sign context
and so it says it's uploaded let's go
verify if that is true
so what we will do is go over to our
storage here
we will go
to the resources we will go to the
containers
we will check container 2 to see if it's
there and it's there so we are all done
let's go clean up we'll go to our
resource groups
we'll look for the resource group we had
created here this one is called
what is it called
i forgot what it was called
that or it's just not showing up
so what i'll do is i'll make my way over
to storage accounts because i don't seem
to be able to find it and we will go
into
where'd it go
i'm so confused
what's our resource group called
refresh
i'm going crazy because it was here a
moment ago
we'll go to resource groups it's right
here again this is this is azure for you
sometimes
you think something's there but it's not
there but it is there it just it's the
fact that it has to propagate so it is
in our account and so you have to have
confidence about what is there
we'll go ahead and delete
and that will delete
and there we go we are all
done
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at azure active
directory and this is a cloud-based
identity and access management service
to manage users sign-ins and access to
ad-related resources so azure active
directory is microsoft's cloud-based
identity and access management service
which helps you your employees sign in
and access resources so that could be
external resources like microsoft office
365 azure portal sas applications or
internal resources so applications
within your internal networking or
access to workstations on premise and
you can use azure ad to implement single
sign-on so you can see that azure id is
basically like the the one solution to
log into everything and uh we actually
use it at exam pro we use it with
microsoft teams or uh you know for the
exam pro platform our emit is tied to it
so when we want to log into the mid
panel with credentials we have it there
we use it with aws to log into there and
we use it to log into azure so it has a
lot of flexibility and if you're
building out applications for
enterprises they're likely using a d and
so this is the reason why everybody
adopts it or needs to understand it so
it's a service i really really do want
you to understand and know azure active
directory comes in four editions we have
the free tier and by the way each uh
tier that goes up has the features
before it but free has mfa sso basic
security usage reports and user
management then you have the office 365
apps which is uh revolves around if
you're using that suite so you have
company branding sla two sync between on
premise and cloud and then the premium
tiers which really comes into enterprise
or
or on-premise hybrid architecture so
hybrid architectures advanced group
access conditional access premium two
identity protection and identity
governance only thing i don't like about
azure ad is that you can't really create
your
custom access controls unless you have
premium one in premium two but that's
just how they do it so there you go
[Music]
so let's take a look at the use case for
azure id and we basically covered it in
the introduction but i just want to
reiterate it in a different way with a
bit of a visual uh so that it really
helps it sink into your uh brain there
so azure ad can authorize and
authenticate to multiple sources so it
can authenticate to your on-premise id
to your web application allow users to
log in with
ipds
so identity providers could be like use
facebook or google login
you can use it with office 365 or azure
microsoft and so just a visual here
notice that uh we have azure id and
using azure ad connect we can connect to
on-premise through uh app registrations
we're able to connect our web
application to azure id with external
identities we can
use facebook or google uh a
login and then for cloud applications we
can connect to office 365 or microsoft
azure
[Music]
so active directory existed way before
azure and so let's just do a quick uh
rundown of the history so we have an
idea of what we're looking at so
microsoft introduced active directory
domain services in windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on-premise infrastructure
components and systems using a single
identity per user so it's been around
for 20 years and azure ad takes this
approach to the next level by providing
organizations with identity as a service
so i-d-a-a-s solution for their apps
across uh cloud and on-premise and both
versions are still used today because
they just have different utility and so
we have active directory which is for on
premise and then you have azure id which
is just the cloud hosted version and in
many regards these can also be connected
together
but there you go
[Music]
so i want to cover some active directory
terminology and the honest truth is that
for azure you're not going to be uh
too worried about these things but
they're going to come up in the
documentation you're going to kind of
wonder what they are and so i just
wanted to uh tell you about these up
front even though they're not core to
study uh so that it just really rounds
out your active directory knowledge
because active directory is such a core
service to azure microsoft products you
you should know these things uh so the
first thing is all about domain so a
domain is an area of network organized
by a single authentication database an
active directory domain is a logical
grouping of 80 objects on a network so
just think of it a way as you know how
you have resource groups to logically
group your azure resources domains are a
logical grouping for your 80 objects
then you have a domain controller a
domain controller is a server that
authenticates user identities and
authorizes their access to resources
very common to have multiples of these
because you want to have redundant uh
domain controllers so you can log in or
availability you're launching domain
controller nearby so people can log into
different places uh so definitely uh
very core to active directory then you
have the domain computer this is a
computer that is registered with a
central authentication database
and a domain computer would be
an id object
so then you have ad objects so this is
the basic element of active directory so
you have users groups printers computers
share folders etc then you have a group
policy object a gpo this is a virtual
collection of policy settings it
controls what an ad object has access to
you have your organizational units this
is a subdivision within active directory
into which you can place users groups
computers and other organizational units
so it's just another way of doing
logical grouping
then you have a directory service and
this is this provides a method for
storing directory data and making this
data available to network users
administrators a directory service runs
on a domain controller so there you go
that is the rundown of active directory
terminology and again hopefully when you
see it in the documentation you can
refer back to this or you'll have a
better understanding of all the
components i would have loved to have
made a diagram but i just couldn't find
an example of one and so uh i mean i
feel like there could be a really good
picture for all this stuff
[Music]
so let's talk about
the term tenant and a tenant represents
an organization in an active directory
and a tenant is dedicated to the azure
ad service instance a tenant is
automatically created when you sign up
for either microsoft azure or microsoft
intune or microsoft 365 and each
or azure ad tenant is distinct and
separate from other azure ad tenants and
so if you uh if you were in um
azure ad and you clicked on your tenant
information that's that's basically what
that is right so that's my exam pro one
and it has its own special tenant id
and we can see that it's licensed for
office 365 and so that tells you that
i'm using the office 365 uh tier of
azure ad
so remember that the domain controller
is the server that users are going to be
using to authenticate to the directory
service
and so when you create an active
directory azure sets one up for you but
there's some cases where you might want
to set one up yourself and the reason
why is that you could be like on like an
enterprise where you already have your
own active directory on premise but
you've decided that you want to move it
over to azure ad
because you just want a fully managed
active directory and uh you want to tap
into the cloud but the thing is that
some domain services those are features
on your domain controller just might not
be available and that's where you're
going to need to set up your own domain
controller and that's where azure active
directory domain services come into play
because these provide managed domain
services
and so they have managed domain services
such as domain joins
group policies uh ldaps uh
kerb b ross never can say that properly
ntlm authentication and so the great
thing is here you can have these domain
services but you're not going to have to
deploy them manage them patch them
they're just going to work so there you
go
so let's take a look at azure ad connect
and this is a hybrid service that is
used to connect your on-premise active
directory to your azure account so azure
ad connect allows for seamless single
sign-on from your on-premise
workstations to microsoft azure and
azure ad connect has the following
features we have password hash
synchronization so this is a sign in
method and it synchronizes the hash
of a user on on-premise ad password with
azure ad then you have password
authentication this is another sign-in
method that allows users to use the same
password on-premise and in the cloud
that's the one i like
uh then moving on from password
authentication we have federation
integration so this is a hybrid
environment using an on-premise adfs
infrastructure for certificate renewal
then you have synchronization this is
responsible for creating users groups
and other objects and ensures on-premise
and cloud data matches so you have the
same ad objects both on-prem and in
cloud and then you got health monitoring
and this is a robust monitoring
service and it provides a central
location in the azure portal to view
this activity and it's called azure 80
connect health
so yeah the big takeaway is that azure
ad connect is used to create a hybrid
connection
[Music]
so now let's take a look at some of the
80 objects starting with users so users
represent an identity for a person or
employee in your domain and a user has
login credentials and can use them to
log into the azure portal so here i am a
user and you can see it shows how many
times i've logged in and i'm part of
different
ad groups
and so you can assign roles and
administrative roles to users you can
add users to groups you can enforce
authentication by
like with mfa you can track user
sign-ins as you can see on the
right-hand side you can track device
devices users log in
and allow or deny devices
you can assign microsoft licenses
azure id has two kinds of users we have
users that's a user that belongs to an
organization and guest users this is a
guest is a user that belongs from
another organization and we'll cover uh
azure 80 roles
in the roles section here
because that is what's that you're going
to be using to apply to these users
[Music]
so groups in azure id lets resource
owners assign a set of access
permissions to all members of the group
instead of having to provide the rights
one by one and so on the right hand side
here you can see i have a bunch of
groups in exam pro and groups can
contain owners and owners have
permissions to add or remove members and
then the members have rights to do
things okay and so for assignment you
can assign roles directly to a group you
can assign applications directly to a
group and to request join groups so the
group owner can let users find their own
groups to join instead of assigning them
to them and the owner can set up the
group to automatically accept all users
that join or require approval this is
really great when you just want people
to do the work themselves as opposed to
having to do all that manual labor of
adding them to groups
let's talk about how we're going to give
users rights to access resources and
there are four different ways to do that
the first is direct assignment this is
where the resource owner is going to
directly assign the user to the resource
then you have group assignment this is
where the resource owner assigns a a
group to the resource which
automatically gives all group members
access to the resource then you have
rule base assignment this is resource
owner this is where the resource owner
creates a group and uses a rule to
define which users are assigned to a
specific resource and then you have
external uh authority assignment this is
this access comes from an external
source such as an on-premise directory
or sas application and i just want you
know that there's four different ways to
do it so
to get access to resources
[Music]
let's talk about external identities so
external identities in azure id allows
people outside your organization to
access your apps and resources while
letting them sign in
and use whatever identity they prefer so
your partners distributor suppliers
vendors or other guests can bring their
own identities such as google or
facebook
you can share apps with external users
that's for b2b stuff
if you develop apps intended for azure
ad tenants uh for singleton or
multi-tenant you can do that as well uh
you can develop white label apps for
consumers and customers this would be
like azure ad b2c
so there you go
hey this is andrew brown and welcome to
the az104 follow along uh and the first
video in our journey on learning on how
to be a good administrator is learning
about azure active directory tenants and
so tenants is the way
we are going to group all of our users
within an organization so this is like
the logical division of organizations
within uh
azure and so let's just make our way
over to where tenants are and they're
under azure active directory a.d
we'll click there and so the idea is
that when you first created your azure
account you already have a single tenant
and that is your organization so here i
can have i see i have one here called
the hush nook
and down below i have a license applied
to it so this is the azure 80 premium p2
but the idea is you can create multiple
ones and so these can act as different
organizations and really what a tenant
is it's just an instance of azure active
directory uh that's exactly what it is
underneath but let's go ahead and go
create a new one and we have two options
here we can create uh uh an azure active
directory and i think what really is
implied here is that it's a b2b uh when
you read the documentation they talk
about b2c and b2b b2b means business to
business meaning that you're joining
businesses and other businesses together
and then b2c means business to consumer
and so up here in the description they
say uh the b2c enables users uh to
access applications published by your
organization and share administration
experiences all right so what we'll do
is we'll go to the next step here and
we're gonna need to name our
organization um i'm gonna name it
starfleet
and
we need our initial domain notice it's
going to be
on microsoft.com so we will just lower
case that if it's already used it might
complain we'll see if i can take that
and it's already taken so we'll say um
uh the uss starfleet
uh oh it must be numeric
take that out there
there we go uh u and three s's that's
not easy at all but that's okay i'm
going to change my default location to
canada i think it still deploys in the
us anyway
so it's still going to say united states
where the data center is going to be
we're going to go ahead and hit review
create and give it a moment
it's saying i'm missing some information
there
already used by another directory so i
still can't call it that
boy oh boy so i'll just say starfleet um
uh 1984.
and i think we should be able to do that
and we'll go ahead and create it and so
you're gonna have to play around and
find the name that's gonna work for you
and then we'll just wait for it to
create this tenant shouldn't take too
long here
[Music]
and after waiting there a couple of
minutes down the right hand side it says
it created the tenant so we can just
proceed
back here and so i'm just going to go
back to azure active directory at the
top i find it just easier to always
search and go back this way
and so we'll just wait a moment for this
to load
but we're still in our our hussnick
azure active directory that's my default
one there but let's say i wanted to go
ahead and switch a tenant i can go now
and just switch and so here i have my
exam pro one hush nook and starfleet i'm
going to go ahead and switch it over to
this one
and so essentially now i have all these
isolate users so i can have different
users in my in these other tenants and
that's the way you would isolate them
out
notice that this one is azure ad free uh
and so the thing with
azure active directory is that the
higher up the tier you go the more
functionality you have and one that is
very popular especially with enterprises
is going to have the
the p2 tier premium two i just want to
show you how you'd go about upgrading to
that it does cost money but you also get
a free trial i don't believe that you
are billed uh during the the time of the
trial uh at the end of it then you have
to enter in or make an explicit purchase
of it let's go ahead here and see if i
can do it um it might not give me trial
because i'm already running another one
but let's go find out so i clicked on
licenses on the left hand side we'll go
to all products and then we have try and
buy and so on the right hand side it
says azure 80 premium 2 and we can click
on free trial and it's going to tell you
why you'd want p2 such as multi-factor
authentication policy driven management
and end-user self-service
and so i'm going to just go ahead and
upgrade that you don't have to do that
you can just watch me do that here and
so i'll just hit activate it's just
going to go activate that in my account
and now it's activated so if i go back
uh to azure active directory here i'll
probably click home but i'm just going
to go back this way
it's a lot more safe that way
eventually it should update here so it
says azure 80 free
but really i've upgraded it's just the
delay in the console
and so after a few refreshes it will
probably show up
but what that's going to do is it's
going to enable some additional features
they don't really matter so much for the
course i mean maybe i could show dynamic
role assignment if i try to remember how
that works um let me think for a moment
i think it's under rolls
but anyway uh so
you know that's how you do that um i
just wanted to show you how to create a
tenant and then just able to switch
between them there
[Music]
so we create ourselves a tenant let's go
ahead and actually create some users and
just before we proceed forward to create
a user i just want to point out you can
tell what tenant you are in if you look
in the top right corner so here i'm in
my starfleet tenant and there's actually
i think you can switch between here
yeah that's an easier way to switch
between your directories uh but
generally that's not how i do it
i'll go to the top here and just type in
azure active directory
and when i want to switch a tenant i
just click the switch tenant button and
click on what i want but we'll make our
way back to the starfleet tenant that i
have here here you can see my
information and i've obviously activated
azure 80 premium p2
but before we go ahead and create a user
we're going to have to create a group
and i'll show you why if i'm going to go
ahead i'm just going to speed through
this for a second if i scroll on down i
have this option where i need to create
a assign it to a group i guess i don't
have to but the problem is i don't have
one and so before i create my user let's
go ahead and create ourselves a new user
group and so we'll go ahead and create a
new group here
and we have two options we have security
and microsoft 365. it explains right
here the difference so 365 is really for
giving access to mailbox calendar files
sharepoint we're not doing that stuff
here we're just sticking with regular
security groups which is for azure stuff
we'll name this developers
and then we'll name this developers
and notice here that uh the membership
type i have a drop down if you're on the
free tier this is going to be grayed out
but uh this dynamic user is part of p2
and so this allows us to add a dynamic
query
and the idea here is that if i start
having users and i just say if a user
is from canada
then they'll automatically be added to
this group and so that's the query that
gets outputted but we're not going to
make a dynamic group today
we'll just make our way back here to the
new group and we'll just manually assign
stuff all right
i'll go ahead there and create that user
our that group there and now that we
have that group let's make our way over
to users so we'll go back here i'm going
to make myself a new user
and on the top here we'll go here
and we'll name this one kevin
and we'll have that lower case
and we will call them kevin uxbridge
all right
and you'll notice here it will auto
generate a password it's four letters
and four numbers i don't find this
personally very secure but the idea here
is that a user is going to reset that
password right away so it's not a big
deal and that's very easy to remember
and now i can go here and assign groups
and if i want to sign the role i can do
that here so we'll open that up we have
a bunch of different options maybe we
want these two roles here
and then we have some additional
information i'll go ahead and create
this user and so now this user exists
what's interesting is that i can go
ahead and delete users and then recover
them the groups have this as well where
if you go here and i actually have a
user i deleted previously
so it just takes some time to show up
but if you go ahead you can hit the
delete user here
and then uh
they will remain in here for uh 30 days
and then they'll automatically be be
deleted so if someone made a mistake
this is a great opportunity to bring
them back and so i can just go check box
on richaun here and we can just bring
her on back restore that user
all right and again you know this is
sometimes a bit delayed so we might have
to hit refresh
there she is and so
uh you know that is the whole group and
user stuff there
[Music]
okay now let's take a look at the
concept of guest users so let's make our
way back to users within our tenant and
there's this button here for new guest
users the idea between behind guest
users is that we're able to invite
other users from other tenants and this
is a much simpler process than using
federation federation is the concept of
joining active directories together so
if there is an on-premise or other
external active directory they would
somehow want to connect the two together
and there's a lot of administrative
burden with that but with if everybody's
already using azure active directory
it's as simple as adding a guest user so
what we're going to do is go back to
home here i'm just going to go back to
azure active directory and we're going
to switch tenants i'm going to go back
to my hush nook one here
and you probably won't see that that's
just showing up because it wants me to
use mfa
and i'm going to go here to users and
we're going to go ahead and create
ourselves a new user i'm going to call
this one a hush nook
and we will name it simply that
and let's make note of the actual uh
email there that's pushnuk
onmicrosoft.com
and we'll go ahead and create that
and now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to copy
that email there
okay
i think i got it yes i do good
and we're going to make our way back to
azure active directory we're going to
switch tenants
back to starfleet
and we are going to go to users and
we're going to add a new guest user i'm
going to invite a user
and i'm just going to put in their email
there
and we will say hush
and uh we'll just put that both
and we you here we we can assign them to
groups and roles it's all the same story
here i'm just going to go ahead and
invite them
and so now they've been sent off an
invitation notice that they show up
under as guest all right so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at bulk operations
let's say we needed to bring in a bunch
of different people into our actual
account here and so we have this option
of bulk create and if you look on the
right hand side we can go ahead and
download a csv template that's ready to
use i'm going to double click that i
already have excel installed here
and off the bat what you can see is we
have a bunch of options
and that we can fill in
and here we have one example there
and so i think that we could try to give
this a go here but we're going to have
to make sure we use the same
principle username or here thing here so
i'm just going to grab this here
and let's just make a few people
so we need our principal here
we'll just say picard
whoops
did not like that i copy that
and we'll do up here we'll say data
card
data
card picard
data data
just see what else i need we're going to
need a password i'm just going to use
the same one here
set that as no
i don't think any of the other things
there are
needed we'll go ahead and save that
and i'm just going to save this
somewhere convenient
okay
and what i'm just going to do is pull
this up off screen here
i'm just looking for where i saved it
just give me a moment
and there it is i'm just going to drag
it on in here i think i can drag it in
like that
maybe not as easy
just go back to uh it's under my
downloads
here we go
and we'll just hit submit
we'll give that a moment shouldn't take
too long
you can probably view the status here if
we click that there and now we're just
under bulk operation results i'm just
going to give it a refresh
you can see that it's not completed yet
i can click into it
and we'll just have to wait a little bit
here okay
oh it looks like it just succeeded i'll
give it a nice refresh it's going to
tell me how did it turn out to success
zero failures total requests
let's click into that so we can see what
it did that looks pretty darn good to me
so that is pretty good we'll make our
way back to our users
and you can see that they're on mass
imported so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at how we can enable
multi-factor authentication for our
users and so multi-factor stands for mfa
you're probably used to it where it's a
secondary step to confirm your identity
before logging in either via a phone or
a hardware device such as an ubi key
and so there's this button here this is
multi-factor authentication and it could
be disabled for you it very likely is if
you're on the uh the free version of
your azure ad just going back up here
one level
you can tell based on what that is here
so i'm using azure 80 premium p2 that's
definitely going to allow me to have mfa
so if you just don't want to turn on p2
or it's trying to charge you money don't
worry about it just watch me do it here
you pretty much learn what you need to
know so we'll just go ahead and click
that button it's going to bring us to a
different screen here
and here we have our users and you can
see multi-factor authentication is
turned off for all of them so we can go
ahead here and turn it on for a single
one if i click enable
and so that enables it for kevin then we
have some other additional options like
manage user settings and here you can
see we have some extra options so
require selected users to provide
contact methods again delete all
existing app passwords generated by the
selected users restore multi-factor
authentication on all remembered devices
so just some additional things another
thing you will want to check out here
it's not very obvious but we have a
service settings button up here
and this will give us more additional
options to enforce for our users so
first we have app passwords so this
allows users to create app passwords to
sign into non-browser apps so things
that are not part of the website here
and so you can white list some ip
addresses for them uh so that they are
trusted from those locations then for
verification options this is something
that's important we have some options
like call to phone so
it will actually
to do the mfa will actually call your
phone and and you'll tell you the
letters and numbers that you enter in or
it can send you a text message or it can
notify you through the mobile
application so you can install the
companion app
from the android or ios store or the
windows store i imagine there's a
windows store too um and then there is
the verification code and mobile app on
our hardware token so hardware tokens
could be with an ub key right
then you can say remember a multi-factor
authentication on trust devices for x
amount of days that way they don't have
to enter it all the time
because it might get annoying for some
users honestly for me i want everyone to
enter it every single time because
that's just how i am but let's make our
way back here and see how we can do some
bulk assignment so what i'll do is i
want to enable for a few people here so
if i go up to bulk update
i can download a sample file
and that's going to go ahead and
download that
and you can see i actually did this
previously here so i'll just copy it and
what we'll do is just paste that in
there
so we're just pasting in yeah that's
fine we're just pasting in
uh their their name right and the mfa
status you can always get the name from
here just back on the list there
and so once we have saved that file we
can go ahead and upload that
they're the same here so it's not a big
deal
and we'll just wait a few seconds here
this is pretty darn quick
usually doesn't take minutes sometimes
it takes seconds
but we'll just give it a moment here
and there we go so that was a long wait
i don't know why but i verified the two
there and so if we go next now those
will be now enabled there's also this
option to enforce so let's go there uh
after multi-factor authentication is
forced users will need to create app
passwords to use non-browser
applications such as outlook or links
and so that's a great option to have so
i'll just go ahead and enable that as
well
so now that's enforced and so that's all
you really need to know about mfa
[Music]
okay so we're back in our tenant here
and what i want to do now is actually
set some
abilities for users to reset their
password so they don't have to come and
bother the administrator all the time so
under your tenant on the left hand side
what you want to look for is password
reset
and now we have a bunch of options here
for resetting password
so we're going to have to go ahead and
enable it we can enable it based on a
per group level
such as developers but what i'm going to
do is set it for everybody here which i
think is a lot better option
and then down below we have a lot of
things we can do here so looking at
authentication methods we can choose the
number of methods required to reset
so maybe they need to use two options in
order to reset their password which is a
lot more secure
and then we can checkbox on
possible methods they can use then we
could require a certain number of
questions uh required here so three and
three you can see i was setting
something earlier here you can create
your own custom questions and then so
we'd go ahead here and just add a new
one so
um you know
what is the best um
you know song
we'll go ahead and hit add and the idea
is that you can add uh them there
there's also a bunch of predefined ones
so if you have a hard time think of any
you can definitely checkbox on some here
right
and so now we have a large pool of
questions that can be used there we'll
go ahead and save that
then under registration we can say
require users to register when signing
in
i think that's a great option to have
there and then you can have number of
days before users are asked to reconfirm
their authentication method and that's
defaulted to 180 days so i would
probably leave that as on
and we can notify users on password
reset notify all admins when other
admins reset their password very useful
this was probably turned off so i'd go
ahead and turn that on there
you can customize a help desk link so
the idea here is that uh when someone's
having trouble uh they might say contact
your administrator well how do you
contact administrator will you provide
that information either a url or an
email so i've just provided my email
there there's some on-premise
integrations never used this stuff
before because i'm never working with
on-prem
but you know that stuff is pretty
straightforward as well and you have
usage and insights so you can actually
see when people are resetting their
passwords and things like that and what
is being used um so that seems pretty
darn good but that's pretty much it to
it um yeah so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the azure active
directory cheat sheet this one's three
pages long so get ready for it and let's
jump into it so active directory just
active directory alone which is a d it's
microsoft's identity and access
management service helps your employees
sign in and access resources then you
have azure ad and this is the same thing
except it's the cloud-based version
and one term that you'll hear a lot with
this is identity as a service which just
means that it's like the serverless or
hosted version of this so you don't have
to think about it or manage servers
azure directory comes into four editions
you got the free one the office 365 apps
premium 1 which is also known as p1
premium 2 which is p2 it's good to know
the differences between
what features you have here so you
should know all the details in between
here so i highlighted conditional access
because that's an important one on the
exam to know azure ad can authorize and
authenticate to multiple sources so if
you're doing on-prem you're going to be
using azure ad connect if it's for a web
app you're using app registers
registration sorry if you're using
facebook or google you're using external
identities if you're
you can also connect to office 65 or
azure microsoft okay
for active directory terminologies uh
when we're talking about a domain domain
is an area of network organized by a
single authentication database an active
directory domain is a logical grouping
of 80 objects on a network then you have
domain controller
commonly abbreviated as dc domain
controller is a server that
authenticates user identities and
authorizes their access to resources you
have a domain computer a computer that
is registered with a central
authentication database a domain
computer would be an ad object then you
have 80 objects this is the base element
of active directory uh things like users
groups printers etc you have a gpo this
is a virtual collection of policy
settings
then you have organizational units this
is a subdivision of your ad which you
can place users groups computers etc in
you have directory service
such as active directory domain service
adds which provides a method of storing
directory data and making the data
available to network users a directory
service can run on a domain controller
that's only page one we're on to page
two so a tenant represents an
organization a tenant is dedicated uh
it's a dedicated azure 80 service
instance a tenant is automatically
created when you first sign up either
with microsoft azure
intune or 365. each ad tenant is
distinct and separate from other tenants
when you perform a lift and shift
of 80 to azure not all the features are
supported in that case you're going to
be using adds so adds provides managed
domain services such as domain joins
group policies lightweight directory
access uh and i never can say that word
so i'm not going to try
azure ad connect has the following
features it has password hash
synchronization pass through
authentication federation integration
synchronization health monitoring you've
got the concept of users so that's an ad
object remember so an identity of a
person or employee in your domain a user
has login credentials and can use them
to log into the azure portal azure ad
has two kinds of users we got a user
that belongs to your organization and
guest users a user that belongs to a
different organization groups let
resource owners assign a set of access
permissions to all the members of the
group instead of having to provide the
rights one by one and the group contains
owners and it contains members just a
moment here
there we go just want to make sure i'm
recording the videos that i don't end up
finding halfway i didn't do it so we got
assignments so you can assign roles
directly to a group and you can assign
applications directly to a group we're
on to the last
slide here in the cheat sheet told you
this one was long request to join groups
the group owner can let users find their
own their own group to join instead of
assigning them the owner can also set up
set the group to automatically accept
all the users or join to require
approval there are four ways to assign
resource access rights to your users
direct assignment group assignment rule
based assignment external authority
assignment know all four of these please
and so yeah there we go we're at the end
here and that's all there is
so let's take a look at the type of
azure roles and i was honestly first
confused with azure roles because i'm
from aws and uh we only have one kind of
role but azure happens to have three
clients and there's definitely good
reason for it so let's break that down
and the first one is classic
subscription administrative roles and
this is the original role system now
it's not something you're going to be
really using but you should know about
it because it still does exist then you
have azure roles this is the
authorization authorization system known
as role-based access controls or rbac
and it's built on top of azure's
resource manager and then thirdly we
have azure active directory also known
as azure ad roles and these azure id
roles are used to manage uh azure 80
resources in a directory so let's jump
into it
[Music]
so let's first talk about access
controls or iam so im stands for
identity access management it allows you
to create and assign roles to users and
so this is the general interface for im
in azure
and so we're going to have
azure roles which is part of that uh
role-based access system and so roles
restrict access to resource actions
known as operations and there's two
types of roles for the azure role based
access system you have built-in role so
this is managed managed by microsoft and
they are read-only and they're
pre-created roles for you to use and
then we have custom roles and these are
a role created by you with custom logic
and so the place you're going to find it
there is you're going to see
it says roles right there and that's
what we're looking at down below is a
bunch of roles so you see owner
contributor reader those are predefined
rules for you
and so then you have role assignment and
this is when you apply a role to either
a service principal a user group a user
and so that's going to be under uh the
tab there such as you applying a role to
somebody and then you have deny
assignment so these block users from
performing specific actions even if a
role assignment grants them access and
the only way to apply a deny assignment
is through azure blueprint so this is
just something where you're just setting
up like guard rails to make sure that
certain things are never used regardless
of a role is applied
[Music]
so now let's take a look at classic
administrators and this is the original
roll system and you honestly want to be
using the new rbac system whenever
possible uh but the idea here is that um
you're gonna go uh it's in the same
place that we just saw the access
control and there's a tab called classic
administrator and in there
you can set up uh
administrators here and so you have
three types of roles you have the
account administrator this is the
billing owner of the subscription and
has no access to the azure portal you
have the service administrator so this
is the same access of a user assigned
the owner role at the subscription scope
and they have full access to azure
portal and then you have the code
administrator so this is the same
access of a user who is assigned to the
owner role the subscription scope so
it's those very three simple roles and
we actually have one because uh when
baco who's the other andrew set up our
azure account i think it just sets you
up one so even though you're not really
going to be using it i do believe that
it still sets you up one when you make
your account
so that's just what it is but there you
go
[Music]
so let's take a closer look here at
azure role-based access controls because
this is something we're definitely going
to be using a lot and so role based
access control helps you manage who has
access to azure resources what they can
do with those resources and what areas
they have have access to and the idea is
that you have a user and you want to
assign them a role so you can use a role
assignment and a role assignment's made
up of three elements you have the
security principle the role definition
and the scope and we're going to look at
those three things in a little bit more
detail here in a second and there are
four fundamental azure roles which we
are going to learn and then azure rbac
also includes over 70 built-in roles
which we definitely do not need to go
into great detail
so let's take a look at
one of those three elements first which
is the security principle and this
represents the identity requesting
access to an azure resource and when we
say identity that's just like a loose
term for something and that something
could be a user in your azure active
directory a group which defines a set of
users in your azure active directory a
service principle so a security identity
used by applications or services to
access specified azure resources or a
managed identity an identity in your
active
azure active directory that is
automatically managed by azure so
service principle basically in azure
service and then managed identity is
something in your azure active directory
then we'll move on to scope and a scope
is just a set of resources that
access that assess
the role of the role assignment applies
to and so scope access controls at the
management subscription or resource
group level so what does that mean and
we we have another slide on this i can't
remember what section it's in but you
have this breakdown of scope where you
have management groups subscriptions
resource groups or resources so when
you're saying i'm setting a scope you're
saying what is the scope is it on a
management group is it on a particular
resource is it a resource group and
that's what we're trying to say there
and then last the last element there is
a role definition and this is a
collection of permissions so a rule
definition lists operations that can be
performed such as read write and delete
and roles can be high level like owner
specific or like a virtual machine
reader and so azure has uh built-in
roles and we said there were four
fundamental built-in roles and here they
are it's owner contributor reader and
user admin administrator so you want to
know those four and then across the
board you have those three
operations read grant
and then create update delete so you can
see the owner can do everything the
contributor can
both read and create stuff they just
can't grant access to other people the
reader just has read only access and
then a user access administrator is
granting other users
privileges but themselves are not
creating anything all right
[Music]
so now let's take a look at the third
type of roles and that's azure ad roles
and so azure 80 roles are used to manage
azure ad resources
in the directory such as creating or
editing users assigning administrative
roles to others resetting user passwords
managing user licenses
and managing domains and so on the right
hand side here
what we can do is go into azure active
directory in azure and under roles
administrators we can see there is a
bunch of roles predefined for us like
application administrator application
developer etc there's a lot in there
and a few important built-in roles that
you should know is the global
administrator so this gives you full
access to everything the user
administrator full access to create and
manage users the billing administrator
makes purchases
manage subscriptions and support tickets
and i want you to know that you can
create your own custom roles but
for whatever reason you have to uh
purchase this this to me is a bit
unusual because in the aws world uh this
is something you don't have to pay for
but i guess azure active directory has
been around for a long time and so they
have this whole big tier
in there and so if you want to be able
to make custom roles you have to upgrade
your azure ad to premium so premium
could be p1 or p2 and i'm assuming the
higher the number the more controls okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at the anatomy of
an azure role and as you
saw in the previous slide it does cost
money uh
to be able to have the privilege to
create
custom roles you'd need an um an active
directory premium version one or two but
it's still a good practice to go take a
look at what the contents of an actual
role is because you can actually look at
the manage rules open them up and and
see what they do
and you should really look at them and
not just take them
based on the uh face value of the name
of the role so i want you to know that
uh
azure rolled documents have two
different syntaxes whether using
powershell or cli and so for the example
here on the right hand side is gonna be
using powershell and it's very simple
and it's just the property name is going
to change so see where it says name uh
if you were using powershell i have in
parentheses would be role name okay so
if you look one up and it's using json
and the names are different you're going
to have to do that translation all right
so let's just quickly go through the
properties here so the first thing is
the name that's going to describe what
the role is then you have the id this is
not something that you're creating it's
going to be auto-generated for you then
you have is custom whether it's going to
be custom or not the description that's
self-explanatory and then the actions
this is what you care about because the
actions tell you exactly what you're
allowed to perform
uh
so
that's a big list there it's pretty
self-explanatory but then you have not
actions and this is basically you
explicitly saying you're not allowed to
do these things it's just a guardrail to
make things safe do you really need and
not actions i don't know that's just how
they designed it then you have uh data
actions this is an array of strings that
specifies data operations that are
allowed to be performed within the data
within that object and then you have not
data actions so things you're not
allowed to do with data and then
assignable scopes and this is an array
of strings that specify the scope for
the custom role
and you can only define one management
group for assignable scopes for a custom
role
i do want to just point out one other
things with these uh
these roles and really just has to do
with these asterisks just if you're not
familiar with them but that usually
indicates a wild card permission it's
like saying match everything
and so
when you're doing that it's going to
match things like
you can use it in actions not actions
data actions and not dated actions
and so again it just matches everything
in that sub thing because you might have
a bunch of options you can put there
and so for example uh
what it's doing like let's see see where
it says management or cost management
and it has action read write delete
run action all that stuff in red would
be matched with that asterisk and i know
it doesn't match the examples on the
right hand side but you just gotta
imagine that there's other things there
okay
now let's just do a quick comparison
between azure policies and azure roles
uh just to make sure that we're very
clear what the difference of these two
things are so azure policies these are
used to ensure compliance of resources
and azure roles these are used to
control access to azure resources so
on the policy side these are going to
evaluate the state by examining
properties on the resources that are
represented in resource manager and
properties of some
resource providers they do not restrict
actions and we call this operations
ensures that resource state is compliant
to your business rules without concern
for who made change or who has
permission to make the change even if an
individual has access to perform an
action if the result is a non-compliant
resource azure policy still blocks the
create or update
actions there okay
on the roll side it's very simple it
focuses on managing user actions at
different scopes and it does
restrictions
it does apply restrictions on azure
resources okay
so azure resource or azure roles
controls what you have access to azure
policies ensures compliancy
[Music]
all right just another comparison here i
want to compare azure 80 roles to the
azure roles the rbac versions so ad
roles they are used to control access to
a.d resources
and azure roles control access to azure
resources and here's a good
representation here where you have 80
roles on the left-hand side and azure
roles on the right-hand side
and the idea on the left-hand side that
actually represents like office 365 but
you can see azure ad
has
some coverage both inside and outside of
azure
so an ad resource could be something
like users groups
billing
licensing application registration or
etc
and then on the right-hand side for
azure resources this could be virtual
machines databases cloud storage cloud
networking and etc by default azure
roles and eight azure 80 roles do not
span azure and 8 and azure id and by
default the global administrator doesn't
have access to azure resources
so
that's just good to know and global
administrators can gain access to azure
resources if granted the user access
administrator role so the azure
role so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the azure roles
cheat sheet and when we say azure roles
cheat sheet we're actually talking about
all the roles not just the azure rules
okay because there's three types you've
got the classic subscription
administrator roles you have azure roles
which is also known as role based access
controls that's built on top of arm and
then you have azure active directory
roles okay
so yeah you need to know the difference
between the three when we're talking
about identity access management iam
that allows you to create and assign
azure roles to users roles restrict
access to resource actions also known as
operations there's two types of roles
you got built-in roles managed managed
microsoft roles are
read-only pre-created rules for you to
use and then you have custom rules a
role created by you with your own custom
logic for rule assignment is when you
apply a rule to a user and a role
assignment is composed of a security
principle role definition and scope
azure's four built-in rules are owner
contributor reader and user access
administrator i don't have the table
here but you should know the difference
between them but usually they're pretty
self-explanatory based on their name for
classic administrators we have three
types of roles we've got account
administrator service administrator and
co-administrator
for important azure 80 roles you need to
remember you have global administrator
user administrator billing administrator
and on the exam you might even see more
kinds there so i would encourage you to
go look up all the different kinds
or i might end up making a video going
in more in depth for some of them in
this course you can create custom azure
80 rolls but you're going to need that
p1 or p2 so there you go that's azure
rolls
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure key
fault so this helps you safeguard
cryptographic keys and other secrets
used by cloud apps and services azure
key vault focuses on three things so the
first is certificate management so
easily provision manage and deploy
public and private ssl certificates for
use with azure and internal connected
resources key management so create and
control the encryption keys used to
encrypt your data
secrets management store and tightly
control access to tokens
passwords certificates api keys and
other secrets and certificates contain
key pairs key and secret not to be
confused with key management and secrets
management i do have to list that out
here because
you'll notice here and i'm getting my
pen tool out we have certificates keys
and secrets but within a certificate it
can contain keys and secrets but just
understand that there are three isolate
offerings that um azure key vault has if
this was another provider such as aws
these would all be isolate services but
uh you know a common pattern with azure
is they like to group a bunch of uh
functionality under a single uh service
and so you know these things which which
should be three services or actually
under all azure key vault but there you
go
[Music]
let's talk about hardware security
models and fips because this is
important for azure key vault so
hardware security modules also known as
hsm is a piece of hardware designed to
store encryption keys here's an example
of one
called
gemalto i'm not sure how to pronounce it
but the idea is that these are pieces of
hardware that are extremely expensive
but are extremely specialized for
holding in keys in memory not even
writing them to disk so that there's no
chance of somebody stealing those keys
if they were to take the device and then
there's the standard of fips also known
as the federal information processing
standard
so this is a u.s and canadian government
standard that specifies the security
requirements for cryptographic modules
that protect sensitive information and
so hsms are
they can be multi-tenant uh and if they
are this is where uh we will be using
fips 140 hyphen 2 level 2 compliant so
you have multiple customers virtually
isolated on a hsm device that's kind of
a way of sharing the cost of one of
these very expensive machines and then
you have hsms that are single tenants so
this is uh where you if you need to
maybe meet level three compliancy where
you have a single custom customer
dedicated on a hsm so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at what a vault is for
azure key vault so a vault stores
secrets and keys that can be protected
either by software or by fips 142 level
2 validated hsm so an actual hardware
security module azure key vault provides
two types of containers vaults so this
supports software and hsm backed keys
and then you have hsm pools so only
support hsm back keys and to activate
your hsm you will need to provide a
minimum of three rsa key pairs up to a
maximum of 10.
specify the minimum number of keys
required to decrypt the security domain
called a quorum
and one key thing you know is you do not
choose the container on creation you
choose between standard and premium when
you choose premium and create rsa key
pairs you'll be able to begin to create
hsn pools because when i was going
through the follow alongs i was like hey
where are these hsn pools and so that's
where i found out about these
requirements
we're not going to do that because it's
just really expensive to do and it's out
of the scope of the exam but you know if
you are an organization and you're
thinking about using hsms those are some
of the requirements there okay
[Music]
all right let us quickly talk about the
key vault api so it's a rest api for
pragmatically managing key vault
resources allowing you to perform
operations such as creating a key a key
or secret important key or secret
revoking a key or secret deleting a key
or secret authorizing authorizing user
or apps to access its keys or secrets
monitor and manage the key usage so
here's kind of a diagram and the idea is
that uh via the api you'd use the cli to
access the api uh it would go into your
vault and you know if you had a
certificate there a certificate could
contain metadata key and secret and you
could operate on uh that kind of stuff
there so the key
uh the key vault rest api supports three
different types of authentication manage
identity so identities managed by azure
id this is the recommended practice
because it requires it introduces the
least amount of risk service principle
and certificate so this is where you use
the certificate service principle and
secret where you have a user and secret
key so there you go
so when setting up our vault we have
some very interesting recovery options
and so i just want to give this a little
bit more emphasis of these interesting
things and so here it is soft delete
days to retain deleted vaults and purge
protection so soft deletes allows you to
recover or permit delete a key vault and
secrets for the duration of the
retention period it's enabled by default
on creation
there is a way to not have soft defaults
and i think we discovered that during
the follow along i just can't remember
this moment here not that it's super
important mandatory retention period and
so the mandatory retention period
prevents the permanent deletion of key
vaults or secrets prior to the retention
period elapse so just keep them around
just in case then you have purge
protection so when enabled prevents
secrets to be purged by users or
microsoft
so yeah there you go
[Music]
let us take a look at pricing for azure
key vault so it comes in two pricing
tiers standard and premium so the key
difference here is premium allows for
both software and hms protected keys
where standard does not have hms
protected keys uh so let's just take a
look at the pricing in particular so for
rsa uh 2048 that's the size of the key
but keys uh you're looking at a cost of
.03 cents for 10 000 transactions and
that's the same thing for hmhs protected
keys if you have an enabled with
exception that you have a dollar per
month per key
for advanced key types so we're looking
at rsa
3072 4096 so longer ones or ecc
uh keys
we're looking at a a greater cost here
so um 15 cents per transactions
and you're going to still pay that 50
protractions but
in the hsf protected you're going to see
that it's going to have this kind of
tiered thing so for the first 250 keys
it's five bucks for the next range of
keys from 251 to a thousand five hundred
it's two dollars and fifty cents and it
gets lower and lower with volume some
more keys the more savings you'll have
some other things here would be things
like secret operations and this is this
is the same for both software and hsm so
there's no difference in cost here but
the idea here is that there's a cost for
secret operations at zero three cents
for certificate renewal it's three
dollars per request and then we have
managed azure storage account key
rotation one dollar per renewal manage
hsn pools is dollars and twenty cents
this might vary in terms of price based
on your region uh but you know i'm just
kind of want to show you that there is
an additional uh cost for just the keys
when you have hsn protected okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look at keys
for azure key vault one of the three
core offerings one being keys secrets
and certificates keys we use it to
encrypt things uh utilizing with azure
services so like if you need to encrypt
azure disks or apply it in a variety of
things where we have encryption at rest
um you know it's useful for this because
it'll just easily integrate with those
azure services so when creating the key
there are three options we have generate
so azure will generate the key import
import an existing rsi key restore
backup so restore a key from backup
for keys that are generated by azure you
can either use rsa or ec
sometimes we see people say ecc but uh
in the ui they called it ec rsa is an
algorithm and it's actually in a
combining of three names of
cryptologists or uh the people that made
the algorithm and you'll see there's a
few different lengths 2048 3072 4096
that's the amount of bits that's how
long it is then you have ecliptic curve
cryptography and then it says p hyphen
and we have 256 384 5
5 2 1 two 256k i'm gonna assume that
also has to do with length um i don't
know exactly how it translates over to
bit size but uh i'm sure that's similar
for keys generated by azure you can set
an activation expiration date probably a
good practice because that forces you to
rotate your keys after a period of time
you can create new versions of keys
so that's a cool benefit you can
download backups of keys backups can
only be restored within the same as your
subscription and an azure key vault i
think we do that in the follow along uh
so for
premium vaults you do have additional
options for hsm
and it's not that fancy it's just like
rsa and ec are repeated here but with
hyphen hsm to specify it's going to the
hardware security module you can
generate you can import for the hsm
there are microsoft managed keys also
known as mmk these are keys managed by
microsoft that do not appear in your
vault and in most cases are used by the
default for many azure services so even
if you don't think you're using keys you
actually are
and so the way
if you're using like aws you actually do
see them in a key management service but
azure decides not to show them and just
have it by default there for you
customer managed keys cmk are keys you
create in azure key vault you need to
select a key from a vault for various
services
so sometimes a customer manage
managed means that the customer has
imported cryptographic material uh uh
but when we're talking about azure when
you generate or import a key they
consider that a cmk and i'm pointing
that out because you know i use other
clouds like aws and gcp and for aws
cmk indicates imported cryptographic
material not um
not exactly how
azure describes it here
in order to use a key as azure service
needs an identity within azure id so for
permission to access the key from the
vault um for infrastructure encryption
this is sometimes an option by default
uh azure encrypts storage accounts data
at rest
infrastructure encryption adds a second
layer of encryption to your storage
accounts data and we'll talk about
double encryption because i was like
what's double encryption and so then i
had to make some slides here for us okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about double
encryption so if we're talking about
storage accounts there's this option
called infrastructure encryption so if
we checkbox that on uh this isn't
encrypt storage account data at rest
infrastructure encryption adds a second
layer of encryption to your storage
accounts data we just said that in the
last uh lecture here but i'm just trying
to cement that this is for storage
accounts for azure disks it's called
double encryption and so double
encryption is where two or more
independent layers of encryption are
enabled to protect against compromises
of one layer or
of encryption it's the same thing but
for one they called infrastructure
encryption and for the other they call
it double encryption
confusing i know but it's the same thing
uh
okay using two layers encryption
mitigates threats that come with
encryption data of course so i just feel
like we're repeating ourselves a hundred
times here but microsoft has two-layered
approach for data rest and transit so
for data rest you have disk encryption
using customer managed keys and then you
have the infrastructure encryption using
platform managed keys data in transit
the transit encryption uses tls 1.2 that
is the latest standard there's a
over the years it went between ssl tls
it's back in tls's court with 1.2 being
the most up-to-date additional layer of
encryption provided at the
infrastructure layer so should you
enable double encryption yes and always
every time you have the opportunity
utilize it okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
azure key vault secrets so one of the
three offerings that azure key vault has
so secrets keys and certificates azure
key vault provides secure storage of
generic secrets such as passwords and
database connection strings so here's an
example of the form we have uh the name
of the secret the value
um so pretty clear how that works key
vault apis return and accept or accept
and return secret values as strings
internally key vault stores and manages
secrets as a sequence of octets so 8-bit
bytes with a maximum size of 25k bytes
each yes 25k not 256. key vault services
doesn't provide semantics for secrets
accepts the data encrypts it stores it
and returns a secret id
or sorry a secret identifier so an id
for highly sensitive data clients should
consider an additional layer of
protection for data encrypting data
using a separate protection key provided
to storage
in key vault is one example encryption
data using separate protection key so i
guess you could encrypt the data and
then upload the encrypted material uh
there so i suppose that might be what
they're suggesting key vault also
supports a content type field for
secrets so clients may specify the
content type of a secret to assist in
interpreting the secret data when it's
retrieved a maximum length of this field
is 285 characters
all secrets in your key vault are stored
encrypted key vaults encrypts secrets at
rest with a hierarchy of encryption keys
all keys in that hierarchy are protected
by modules that are fips 140 hyphen 2
compliant the encryption leaf key of the
key hierarchy is unique to each key
vault encryption root key of the key a
hierarchy is unique to the security
world protection levels varies between
regions and we're talking about china
here so china uses fips 140 hyphen 2
level 1 and all the regions uses level
two or higher i apologize for that
spelling mistake there
we can apply secret attributes alongside
our secrets um and so we have exp that's
the expiration time
we have nbf not before so default value
is now the time before which the secret
data should be retrieved enabled whether
the secret data can be retrieved uh and
we saw some of these options in the
actual form itself uh there are also
other read-only attributes such for
created and uh created an update updated
i think it was supposed to say updated
there in order uh to access secrets
within your application code you would
use the azure sdk as an example so here
we're importing uh the key vault secrets
this looks like
um
c sharp
this is c sharp code sure oh yeah it
says over here net okay and so we import
azure identity
uh key vault secrets
we're defining our our options here so
delay max delay retries um i don't think
that really matters too much but the
idea is that we are providing a uri to
the actual vault
and then
we create our credentials we create our
client and this example is just getting
the secret so we're not um
we're not using this to uh
insert a secret but just to kind of grab
it programmatically
you can also use the cli so we have a z
key vault secrets show and i'm pretty
sure that's what we are using during the
follow along but yeah there you go
that's secrets
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at x
509 certificate so
before we can talk about those we need
to talk about what is public key
infrastructure also known as pki so pki
is a set of roles policies hardware
software and procedures needed to create
manage distribute use store and revoke
digital certificates and manage public
key encryption so if there's a cloud
service that manages certificates it's a
pki
so
what is x 509 certificates it is a
standard defined by the international
telecommunication union itu for public
key certificates
or certifications so x-509 certificates
are used in many internet protocols
extremely commonly used with ssl tls
for https
signed and encrypted emails code signing
and document signing
so a certificate contains an identity so
hostname organization or individual a
public key so rsa dsa ecda etc
and then there's the idea of a
certificate authority so this is an
entity that issues digital certificates
a
ca or certificate authority acts as a
trusted third party trusted both by the
subject owner of the certificate and by
the party
uh
relying upon the certificate so there
you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about uh chain of
trust for
509 certificates so a certificate
authority ca can issue multiple
certificates in the form of a tree
structure also known as a chain of trust
so here is an example for the exam pro
dot co website um and uh you know this
was issued by amazon and so amazon is
the root uh the root authority here and
then they have their intermediate
certificate which issues us the
certificate that is used for
our https tls communication
to keep
encryption and transit to the website
let's talk about what a root certificate
or root certificate authority is so the
root ca
is a self-signed certificate and its
private key is used to sign other
certificates so i'm going to talk about
self-signed just means that they've
generated a key and they've done it on
their machine there and that's what they
mean by self-signed because they're not
reaching out to anybody else in order to
say that the certificate is valid it's
important that the private key of the
roots are protected uh so like these are
the most important keys and to protect
them that's why we have this
intermediate certificate authority also
we like to call these icas so
intermediate certificates are signed by
the root private key and act as entities
that can issue certificates they protect
the root certificate because the root
certificate does not have to sign every
issued certificate then you have your
end entry certificate these are the ones
that we're going to be using so a
certificate issued by the ica used by
the end entity the entity in the case of
an ssl certificate for a website so ssl
tls
it's just common to say ssl even though
tls 1.2 is the common standard when we
were making the videos here but there
you go
[Music]
all right so we're taking a look at the
certificate format so here is the
certificate information for the
exampro.co
certificate that we used for
https for the
data in transit to make sure that our
information is secure if you open it up
you can see there's a bunch of metadata
and so let's talk about what's in here
so we have the version number the
version number is uh you know indicating
that it's an x509 standard
notice here it says three so we're using
version
three we have a serial number a unique
serial number assigned to the
certificate by the certificate authority
so it's this big long thing here we have
the certificate algorithm id used to
sign the certificate uh you know could
be rsa dsa in this case is suggesting
that it is rsa 250 uh with sha 50 shaw
256 with rsa the issuer so the name of
the civic authority the issued uh
issued the certificate to so that's the
issuer name up here
but this one is saying
organization amazon things like that so
it doesn't say my name might be down
below here somewhere
uh yeah i don't see my name in here but
you know there's something here uh
validity period so how long is this
certificate going to be valid for the
start and end date the subject uh yeah
that's what we want the issue would be
amazon because that's what is i guess i
was looking for the subject so the
subject is who it is to be issued to so
that's where we'd want to see exam pro
but it gets cut off here so we just
can't see it
the subject public key so the public key
that is meant
to be authenticated by the certificate
so this field is also named
also names the algorithm used for the
public key generation
then we have other fields like issue
unique identifiers subject unique
identifier extensions which allow you to
associate private information to a
certificate
but the clear thing to understand is
that all this metadata is publicly
readable so anyone can generally view it
that's uh the purpose of that is so that
we can have the means to validate the
authenticity of these certificates
so let's just talk about some things
that can package along with a
certificate so that there are ways of
validating it so we have this metadata
and this metadata gets produced in a
hash a hash is a means of taking a bunch
of information and basically
turning it into a thing that looks like
a bunch of random characters but it
actually is a fingerprint because that
hash if you take the same information
it'll always produce the exact same
patch so it is a fingerprint to identify
the information so
you know that's that there the that hash
or fingerprint is going to then get
signed with the private key the private
key that is generated by the
certificate authority and that way it
guarantees the authenticity of that
fingerprint
and then the idea is that when you are
signing
when you are signing
that hash it's basically creating a
signature okay so that's that
authenticity when you sign it you know
it's valid
so the certificate metadata the
signature and then the public key
provided by the uh the end user is
packaged there and with all that
information we have enough information
in order to validate the office
authenticity of the certificate okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at um the
extension name for digital certificates
because it can be crt cr pamper der
it there's so many varieties it's very
confusing so let's see if we can unpack
some of the complicated history here
and make it a little bit more clear so
we have the first is pem so privacy
enhanced mail and the idea of this
format is that it's base64 ascii you can
open them up and they're very easy to
read very easy to edit
and it's the most common format for x
509 certificates uh and for
certificate signing requests and
cryptographic keys so the pem format
normally have the following extensions
crt pamser and key key specifically for
private keys
but there's no hard rule about it so
just because something is pam doesn't
mean it's going to end with dot pem then
you have distinguished encoding rule so
dur this is a binary encoding so if you
open up the file it's a bunch of binary
code you won't be able to make sense of
it edit it do anything with it uh it's
used for both x509 certificates and
private keys der normally have the
following extensions so d-e-r-c-r
then there are certificate files that's
where we have sir and crt these are
base64 ascii so they're basically i
think they're basically pen and sir and
crts are interchangeable extensions so
you can either have they basically stand
for certificate file right so that's
what it's saying so it's like hey c-e-r
is a short form certificate file crt is
a short-form certificate file right um
so that's where they get confusing so
either cer or crt these are generic file
extensions
then you have the personal information
exchange pfx this is a microsoft
certificate format
uh this is the successor so pkcs
pound 12 is the successor pfx
and so pkcs hyphen 12 is uh we'll use
either
dot p12 or pfx extensions so there is a
lot of confusion about the variety of
formats
it's just because there was a lack of
standardizations early on and so
everybody was just trying to create
their own formats or their own keys and
they weren't being consistent
and that's why we just end up with all
these weird naming conventions so half
the time you cannot tell what something
is you have to open the contents of it
you have to know what you're using it
for
and just you know just be aware that it
is confusing even for me i've been doing
it for like what 20 years and i still
can't tell what's what so that's just
what it is okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at certificate
signing requests also known as csr is a
message sent from an application to a
registration so a certificate authority
of a private key infrastructure in order
to apply for a digital identity
certificate the most common
time you would deal with a certificate
signing request is when you need a ssl
tls certificate so that your website has
https so it's data in transit
so the idea is you'd submit a
certificate signing request to your
certificate authority so like if you're
getting your certificate from godaddy
amazon i'm just i'm thinking godaddy
actually has certificates but like
geotrust site or something you know uh
you know you have to submit a csr so a
csr contains a public key
and application information such as a
fully qualified domain name because it
like if you're getting a a csr for
a domain name they're going to need to
know the domain name and so that's the
two things that get packaged together so
the idea is you
create your certificate signing request
you request the certificate to the
certificate authority the certificate
authority will issue you a certificate
if it deems that uh it likes your
request but there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at certificates
in azure key vault so that's one of the
three keys secrets and certificates and
so if you're wondering why we did all
that x 509 certificate stuff it's
specifically so that we are prepared to
understand
uh you know the purpose of certificates
in azure key vault so azure key vault
allows you to import generate and manage
x 509 certificates so the idea here is
you can uh you know generate one you can
self-sign one you can uh you use one
with a um
a certificate authority but let's talk
about some other things here so key
vault partners with certificate issue
providers for tls and ssl certificates
so we have digicert and globalsign those
being
two very large companies you can
generate self-signed or through a
certificate authority there's no need to
manage the security of the private key
key vault takes care of it for you it
allows the certificate owner to create a
policy that directs key vault to
to the manage to the managed life cycle
of a certificate this allows certificate
owners to provide contact info for
notification about lifecycle events for
expiration renewal or certificate it
supports automatic renewal with selected
issuers so key vault partners 5x5 x 509
certificate providers or certificate
authorities so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about the
composition of a certificate with an
azure key vault and so we use this uh
graphic earlier to describe uh the rest
api integra uh interacting with just the
certificate part of azure key vault but
what it did show is the three components
that are part of certificate that it
will be stored in azure key vault so
there we have um azure key vault which
allows the operations
of keys okay then we have key vault
secrets so allows the retrieval of the
certificate value as a secret
certificate metadata so
x509 certificate data so if that's not
clear let's just get our pen tool out
here so we have the key
we have the secret and then we have the
metadata okay
so those are the three components that
are alongside the certificate and so
here we have an example of a certificate
that
i self-signed i generated in there and i
just want to show you that you can
download the certificate here and either
sir format cer or pempfx format and so
you see where i'm like is it ascii is it
binary what's it going to be because
you know when i downloaded it i didn't
really get the exact result that i
thought i would get but remember that
the pem can be used as cer so the format
format offering can be confused here but
what can help us understand
is what we set the content type when we
generate our certificate so
um like cer will be ascii format i
believe um but like when we're doing
with pemb or pfx
the difference is going to be based on
the content type that you choose there
so if you choose the content type to be
pkcs
pound 12 it will use that format if you
use if you choose pem that means that
it will download in the pem format same
thing with the cer so just realize it is
a bit confusing and there's that
additional option there and
um azure really really should have not
made these two buttons that confusing it
should just be clear what they are but
that's just one of those things that uh
azure trips you up on okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
certificate policies so typical policies
allow you to set and configure your
certificate such as the content type the
lifetime of the certification the key
type the key size and various other
options but it's calling it an issuance
policy so there's some inconsistency of
naming by azure between their
documentation and their ui which is no
surprise but we have a bunch of options
as we saw so the type of the authority
whether it's self-signed and things like
that the subject the validity period the
content type whether it's enabled the
percentage lifetime which i'm not sure
what that is we have advanced options
where we can say the key type the key
size things like that issuance policies
only effect certificates that will be
issued in the future so it won't modify
the existing certificate but the ones
that will be
generated in the future okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this fall along we're going to be
learning all about
azure vault so let's get to it so what i
want you to do is go in the top here and
type in key vault and here we'll have to
go ahead and create ourselves a new
vault
and so from there we're going to create
a new resource group i'm going to call
this resource group my example vault
and then we will make a vault key here
so i'll just say my vault example
which is kind of funny because this
one's slightly different so you've seen
i've done this before so i'm going to do
my example vault
as the name here
and for the region usc is fine for
pricing we'll keep it at standard soft
delete is enabled
and then there's the option for purge
protection
so we are going to enable purge
and uh this is going to play into other
follow alongs we'll explain that as it
goes but purge protection does not allow
you to
purge things uh easily once it's enabled
so what we'll do is go ahead and review
and create
and we'll go ahead and go review create
and we'll give it a moment here
and we'll just wait till it's done
deploying okay
all right so after a short little wait
our vault is created and so what i want
you to go to the resource and we're
going to be using this vault a little
bit in some of the follow alongs and in
some cases not so much okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this fall
along we're going to be doing some
things with
keys with an azure key vault so what i
want you to do is make your way over to
the keys blade on the left hand side
here we're going to generate or slash
import a new key we're going to choose
the generate option
in terms of naming we're going to call
this
my disk key
and we're going to choose
rsa2048 that seems totally fine to me
everything else seems okay so go ahead
and create that
key so give it a moment to create
doesn't take too long and then what
we're going to do is go on the left hand
side to im access controls
and what we want we're going to want to
do
is add a new role assignment so we can
go ahead and start using this key so
what i want you to do
is go and look for key vault
administrator which is here and we'll go
ahead and hit next and then for our
user we will choose ourselves so under
user i'm going to select the members i'm
looking for the account i'm using there
i am and you're around go ahead and
select that there
and so that is all we need to
assign it so that we can actually uh
work with that key
so i think a good idea is to use a key
to encrypt a disk so what we'll do is
make our way over to disk encryption
sets because before you can encrypt a
disk you need to have an encryption set
so go ahead and create ourselves a new
encryption set we'll call we'll use the
uh sorry the same
um a resource group so it's very easy
clean up afterwards we'll call this my
disk
encrypt
set
here
and in terms of the encryption type
we're going to use double encryption
because that's a much better you have
two keys that encrypted so that's a lot
better we are going to choose our vault
so we have my example vault there's only
one option here
and in terms of the key we'll just
select my disk key in terms of the
version uh we'll select the current
version we'll go ahead and hit review
create
and then we'll go and create that
and we'll give it a moment to create
that encryption set shouldn't take too
long here
and after a short little wait uh our
resource should be deployed only took
about a minute for me if we go here it's
going to have this message up here it's
very small but it says dissociated disk
image snapshot this disk encryption set
you must grant permissions to key vault
so all we have to do is click that alert
and we'll grant permissions and so now
we are able uh to use that key
um or like to to we're going to have the
permissions issues is solved so what
we'll do is go to type and create a new
disk and so we can apply this key to
that encryption so go ahead and create
we're going to choose the same resource
group here i'm going to call this my
example vault and
or sorry my example
disk because that's a little bit more
clear than that
and for the availability zone doesn't
matter for the source type
it doesn't matter as well in terms of
the size we
want this to be cheap we're not really
using this for real so we'll use
standard hdd
and we'll say okay in terms of
encryption this is where things get fun
we go to double encryption we choose our
key here we'll go ahead review and
create
and we'll just give it a moment for that
to oh we'll hit create and we'll have to
wait a little while here for the create
that resource so we'll just wait until
that is created okay
and after a very short while the disk is
ready so we'll go to that resource we'll
go to the encryption tab to see that
encryption is applied so that's all it
takes to use a key to encrypt
a disk so we are going to still use some
of these accounts there's no cleanup yet
i'll go back here and i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along we're going to learn about backup
and restore key so what i want you to do
is go back into the
resource group that we just recently
created and we're going to make our way
over to keys so i'm just sorry we got to
get into the vault first then we'll go
over to keys
and the idea is that we have this key
here and so
you can see that we have this current
version so you can add additional
versions but what's going to happen if
we try to back this up so when you back
this up you're going to get this file
here and if you open up this file it's
going to look like a bunch of gobbly
goop so i'm just going to try to open it
here
i have it up off screen here so i'm just
trying to open it up within uh visual
studio code so i'm just going to open up
visual studio code again doing this off
screen here
just give me a moment
all right and so this is the file
that we encrypted
and you take a look here and
it's
it doesn't look like anything but the
idea is that it is our backup of our
keys so that we can re-import that
and just taking a look at the key name
this is what it looks like so this is my
example vault my disk key then there's
this
date and that's key backup so just
recognize that's the format and the date
is very useful to indicate when you
backed it up so let's go ahead and
delete this key because the idea is we
want to
restore that backup and so we have
deleted that key
there
and uh what we're going to do is we're
going to attempt a restore so i'm going
to go ahead and go
occurred while restoring the key the key
you're trying
to restore already exists why would it
throw that error we've clearly deleted
it and the reason why is that we have
purge protection on we did that in the
first
first part when we set up this actual
vault here i'm going to see if we can
find the settings wherever that purge
protection is i'm trying to remember
where it is purge protection is enabled
so we can go here and once you enable it
you cannot turn it off it's going to
retain it for a certain amount of days
and so all you can do is soft delete
keys
so this key is not actually deleted yet
if you go to manage deleted keys you can
see the key is over here and if you try
to click on purge it is disabled because
we cannot remove the key because we have
purge protection on but we can recover
the key so we'll go ahead and recover
and so that will allow us
to recover
the key
and if we refresh here it's going to
take a little bit time for that key to
restore so we'll just have to wait a
little bit and then it will show up
there's one other thing i wanted to show
you was under policies because you know
um if you go under where's policies here
um or
access policies if you look under our
user here and we look at the key
permissions
there is an option to purge and we don't
actually have that turned on right now
but if we were to save this
and we were to still go to that purge
option it would still say the same thing
so even if you have purge permissions it
does not matter if purge protection is
turned on it still will not let you
purge but you would need a combination
of those in order to
uh you know be able to do things there
so to really show you how to do that
recovery i think what we should do i'm
just going to delete our old key here
because we don't care about it but we
are going to well i guess we could try
to import it into the other one so i'm
just going to undo that for a second
but we are going to go ahead and create
ourselves another vault
so i'm going to go and type in vault at
the top here
and we're going to be a little bit more
careful when we create this vault so
we'll go here and we will choose
my example vault i'm going to say my
vault no protect
and the pricing tier will be standard
one day we're going to leave it well 7
is the lowest and we'll say disable
purge protection because we don't want
to have that enabled
and we'll see if we can import the key
into another vault i'm not sure if we
can do that worst case we'll make a new
key download the key re-upload it but
i'm just curious what would happen if we
tried to upload the same key as it's
still in another
vault i'm not exactly sure
all right so this deployment is
successful i'm going to go to this
resource and go ahead to go to create
and we're going to
restore from backup and we're going to
take this key and see if we can actually
import it here so it looks like we can
take a key and it can exist in multiple
vaults i'm going to go ahead and delete
this key
and we're going to say are you sure you
want to delete this key i'm going to say
yes
and if we go to manage keys
and we refresh it takes a little bit of
time here so we'll just wait a moment
for this to persist
and after a short little wait like about
two minutes i refresh and the key is
here so if i go here you'll notice the
purges option is still not available we
can obviously recover
um but we don't have purge um
protection on so if we go to access
policies over here and we go ahead and
scroll down and select purge
and save our changes we can then go back
to keys we'll give it a moment to save
we go back to keys
we'll refresh it we'll manage our keys
and we'll go ahead and purge it and that
will permanently purge it there so
that's all it takes
to do that so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we are going to
learn about key rotation so what i want
you to do is make it back to the vault
that we were just in the no protect
vault and we'll go over to keys and
we'll have to create a new key so i'm
going to create a new key here called my
new key and it's going to be rsa 2048
and we're going to go ahead and create
that key so the idea of key rotation is
that if you have uh if you think your
key has been compromised or you have a
policy like a company policy that you
should rotate them for security purposes
after a while
you can easily rotate out keys so
in order to rotate a key it's as simple
as going to
your rotation policy here and we can say
rotate now and that will immediately
rotate the key as you'll see there is
now the current version and the older
version so that was the key we had
before this is the new key we can also
set up a rotation policy so if we go to
rotation policy here
we can set the expiry time to
let's put the lowest number in here one
so this has to be at least 28 days
and then we want to enable enable it and
then we want to automatically renew
after a certain amount of time
so here if i put seven i'm trying to put
the lowest number so it goes one
and i try seven
it says the value cannot be greater than
21 days because there's kind of a
minimum and maximum both having a buffer
i don't exactly understand the math but
i know
that um
if we change it to something like
i'm thinking here
expiry time 40 days and there's a larger
gap this should be less of a problem
so it cannot be greater than that 21.
i i knew the math here a moment ago i
could have swore it was 28 and 7.
so just
well i'm not sure that this is broken
let's go ahead and save that
try 40 up here
and hit save
value cannot be greater than 33 days
okay 33
oh boy
so let me
all right so the problem was i was in
months and we'll have to go to days here
so here if we put seven it works fine
but there is a bit of work to figure
this out and it will tell you so you'll
have to figure it out we'll go ahead and
save that um oh yeah it prompts again so
the uh the time before expiry cannot be
greater than 21 days cannot be greater
than
um okay so we
put the expiry to 40 we save so there is
a bit of work there i don't exactly
understand all the math there but i
guess it's a way so that you have less
problems but that's key rotation in a
nutshell so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we're going to
learn about secrets so go back to your
previous fault the no protect fault and
we'll go to secrets here and we're going
to go ahead and generate a new secret
and we're going to use this secret
within an application so we're going to
have manual we'll say my secret
and make sure you spell right so my
secret
there we go and for the value i'm going
to say hello mars it's a secret value
that's the whole point of secrets for
the content type we're going to say text
plain so it knows that it's text and
everything else looks fine so go ahead
and save that
and we will easily create our
cells a secret here so
the secret is now available
now we just need to use it in some kind
of application so what i'm going to
recommend is that we go use a git pod
template so we're going to say gitpod
template.net
core cli c sharp
c-sharp there we go
and from here we'll click into it
and uh what we want to do is use this
template
and we will have it private it's totally
fine i'm going to go to exam pro here
and i'm going to call it
i don't know azure
vault secrets dot net
oh did i use that before so we'll do new
if you don't have to do new that's great
i'm going to go ahead and create this as
a private repository from a template so
it's going to set us up with a base
core.net application i think.net 6.0
um it's just going to make things a lot
easier for us so you can click the
button down below actually probably not
because i'll go to the wrong repo
but um
what you'll want to do here is
uh if you don't have the chrome
extension installed all it's doing is
it's just putting this in front of it to
launch this get pod environment so get
pod is has a free tier so it's very
useful to use especially for net because
we do have to do a bunch of setup for it
so i'm not really good at net so this is
the approach i like to take um and the
idea is that we just close this and it
cleans itself up so it's really really
nice so we'll just wait for the image to
build
and for the environment to run and then
we'll get to the next step okay
all right so after a couple minutes this
environment is ready and i'm just going
to go ahead and hit the x there go to
terminal and we're going to make sure
this dot net app works we're going to do
net run and this is just a basic hello
world application so we can see that it
prints out so we're going to need a
couple packages we're going to use net
add package to add these here so azure
identity
and then we will do
dotnet
dot net add package azure security
key vault secrets
and the idea is we'll need to modify
this file in order to load some stuff
so i can't remember if i wrote this
myself or if i got it from an azure
azure documentation but we'll write it
out because it's not too much to write
out
as using azure core using
azure identity
using azure security
key vault secrets
and then under the program we want to
modify our static void main so we're
going to need a new string
and this is going to be called secret
name
so my secret actually we have a bunch
here and
i think this is where we probably should
set environment variables so key vault
name
and i'm just going to actually i don't
know how to set environment variables
in.net i don't want to look it up so i'm
just going to write it out
and hard code it because it's not going
to really matter if we do that so i'm
going to say my vault no protect that's
what we called it my vault no protect
yeah
and
for
uh the key value uri we're going to do
this so we'll say
https colon forward slash forward slash
my vault no protect
dot vault dot azure dot net
i think we need semicolons on the end
here otherwise it complains a bunch
um
he vault name
var
secret client options options equals new
secret client options parentheses
and
this
i think is a function so we'll open this
up here like that
and we will try we'll have to set this
to retry don't worry if you don't know
what's going on because it honestly it
doesn't really matter it's it's just
like you know you just need to get some
experience writing some code
and eventually it starts to sink in
because it really takes a lot of time to
learn code you just have to spend a lot
of time doing it
so that we're just going through the
motions without having to think about it
too hard
so from second 16 and i'll explain it
once we write it all up here
but yeah it's very good practice to just
write out code
max retries is five and we'll say mode
equals retry mode dot exponential
um and i feel like we have to put
semicolons in dot net otherwise it
complains so that is
that
part and then we'll need a client so
we'll say new
secret clients parentheses new
uri key
v uri
comma
new default
azure credential parentheses options
semicolon
uh key vault secret secret equals client
get secret parentheses secret name
semicolon
and down here we'll do console
console
dot write line
get secret
colon
plus secret value
uh value there i didn't mean to spell
vault capital v on the value it's giving
me some trouble here
semicolon and then the idea is we're
going to want to enter the secret yeah
i'm pretty sure i took this from uh the
azure docs i just
don't remember where because i know that
this looks very familiar and uh but i
think i reorganized it so that it was a
little bit more streamlined i think
there was a little bit more going on
with theirs
and so we'll say string
secret value
lowercase secret
value
equals console
read line parentheses semicolon
client set secret
secret name secret value
[Music]
and
we can do console
right
set secret
semicolon on there we'll do another
console log here this will be for the
key so let's give this a couple spaces
and we'll do plus secret uh name
i can spell this one right
and we'll do secret value
we'll do another console right we're
doing lots of these console rights here
actually it'll just be pretty much the
same lineup here so i'll just go grab
this one here
client start
delete
secret
secret name
console right line
start delete secret
start delete
secret
plus key vault name
and then we'll go get it one more time
so let's take a look at this i mean
hopefully we didn't introduce any
mistakes by typing this all up by hand
but uh the idea and these are supposed
to have semicolons on the end
because i can see a little red mark
there so the idea is that we are
importing
uh core identity and key vault secrets
identity so that we can get access to
stuff we're providing our secret the
name of our vault the url that it needs
to hit to do that um here it's going to
get the secret client options
and so it's going to have a bit of
retries here if it doesn't work out
properly down below we have the secret
client so we're passing in the key value
uri
and then we need our credentials here we
didn't type anything out for credentials
so i'm a little bit surprised by that
but maybe that's not an issue
and so what i'm going to do here is i'm
just going to go ahead and commit all
this actually before we do that we're
going to create ourselves a get pod yaml
file so git
pod init and it says it won't already
exist so i'm just going to say no there
but what we need to do here is install
the
cli the azure cli so i'm going to make a
new task here called azure
we'll say init
and then here it will be curl hyphen
s capital l https colon slash aka
at ms aka is like azure's microsoft's
short
um
shortener
so we'll say azure cli deb
just have install azure cli
deb
sudo
bash okay so that should install it i'm
just going to double check to make sure
this i typed this out correctly
and we will say allow and paste that in
there
yeah it's working so what we'll do is
we'll commit our stuff here
add that there
so
commit
code
and i guess we do want to run this line
so i'm going to go here and run it
because the way it's going to get the
credentials it's going to grab it once
we authenticate with the azure cli
because it'll set something locally and
that's why we didn't have to pass in a
key or anything
and maybe before we do that let's just
double check our permissions
so if we go to the im control here we go
to our role assignment
or actually um
access policies
we'll go to angie brown secrets
get lists
so we should be able to do it we have
all the permissions to do it so now that
that is done we're going to go a z
login hyphen hyphen use device
code
and hit enter
and so here we have this address here
that will help us log in so we'll go
here to this address we'll copy this
code
we'll enter the code in
we'll say oops that's not what i wanted
to do we'll paste that in again
and we will hit uh sign in here and
we'll say continue
and that is all done there
so now what we can do is try to run the
application so we're going to type in
net build to build this application see
if we get any errors
if we get errors i'm not really
surprised because we had done so much
typing here but we will go back to our
code and take a look here so on line 38
um
there's no semicolon
a very small mistake so i don't mind
that if that's all the mistakes we wrote
that'll be great
fix
semicolon missing semicolon
and we will commit nsync
dotnet builds
and
all projects are up to date so that
looks pretty good to me we'll do run and
if it works that'll be great
i don't know if we explained the whole
program but we'll just run this here
and it should run
oh you know what it's prompted us
probably
no there we go so we'll type in hello
world
uh hit enter
great so let's take a look at what this
did so the idea is that we have a client
and the id and we want to grab the
secret so that's the secret name we have
up there my secret and if we console log
it out it gives us hello mars because
that's what we set
and then we are prompted to enter our
own input
and we use this to set the secret and
then we immediately fetch and say what
is the key what is the value now if you
notice it says my secret here
hello world
and but when we go get the secret again
um down below let me just see here so we
have and the reason why it's not
printing out as expected is because we
don't have
this is something i'm not a huge fan of
in net but you actually have to add the
um
backslash end like that otherwise it
gets a bit confusing here as you can see
i'm a little bit confused about our
output
so we have set secret
key value my secret
hello world that's new value and then
it goes down below and we
print out the secret value again from
the actual value object so these are the
ones that are just locally that we set
right but this is the actual object but
the object is still saying hello mars
but we updated up here and the reason
why that happened is because it takes
time for those changes to propagate so
if we were to call it again it would
have the right value but you know it has
to replicate it and so that takes a bit
of time so sometimes
you have to wait uh for the stuff so we
go ahead and we delete it and then we go
start delete secret so we say that we
are deleting it and then we go get the
secret but we've deleted the secret so
how can we see the secret if we delete
it and again it just has to do with
propagation if we were to go into our
vaults and to go to secrets that secret
should not be there anymore so just
consider that you have to do that i
think the original tutorial had like
sleep commands i don't know what this
loop command is in um
in
net but it's something probably like
sleep
you know
dot net sleep
right so they were running those
in between that this that's like two
seconds a thousand milliseconds and so
they're doing that to make sure the
change is there but i thought it was
better to show you the fact that you
have to wait a little while um but
that's it there so we are all done here
so we can go over to our resource group
and we can delete
uh this resource script and all the
resources in it
all right and we can close that off
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at azure app
configuration this allows you to
centralize all your app settings in one
location is ideal for multi-environment
or multi-geographic geography
applications because it provides a
dynamic way to change application
settings without having to restart them
but in general if you're building out
any kind of application
it is actually really useful it also
integrates with azure key vault which
stores application secrets which we'll
talk about soon enough
azure app configurations main benefits
are a fully managed service that can be
set up in minutes
i would say seconds to be honest
flexible key representations and
mappings tagging with labels point in
time replay of settings dedicate ui for
feature flag management which is to me
the best part of azure app configuration
comparison of two sets of configurations
on custom defined dimensions enhanced
security through azure managed
identities encryption of sensitive
information at rest and in transit
native integration with popular
frameworks and when we say popular
frameworks we're talking about things
like net core asp.net net java spring
other javascript node.js python azure
functions.net core so
no rails no larvael so no next to so i'm
not sure what they're saying when they
say popular frameworks quotations but
you know you can still integrate them
because they do have language support
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the tiers
for azure app configuration and we got
to here we got free and standards let's
see what the difference is so the first
is resources per subscription one for
free unlimited for standard for storage
per resource 10 megabytes for free
versus 10 or sorry one gigabyte for
standard revision history seven days
versus 30 days for request quotas a
thousand versus 30 000 per hour no sla
on the free tier first security
functionality this stuff is important
you get encryption with microsoft
managed keys uh hmac and azure
ad so active directory authentication
role-based access control support
managed identity service tags so a lot
of stuff in the free tier but in the
paid tier you get customer managed
managed keys of cmks uh private link
support and then for the cost it's free
for the free tier of course and for
standard it's 120 per resource
with uh 0.06 per 10 000 requests with
200 000 requests are included in a daily
charge so you do get
you might like look at those requests
and say oh that stacks up but you get
that 200 000 uh free
uh daily um and for soft release is not
supported in the free tier pricing okay
so soft delete mean like i deleted
something and i didn't actually want to
delete it so let's bring it back it's
like putting in the trash can and
pulling it right back out but there you
go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at
configuration explorer this is where
you're going to be looking at your data
for the most part that you've inserted
and so the nice thing is that you go
here you can see the key and the value
even though it's hidden if you click
values it will show you them all which
for me doesn't feel super secure but i
guess that's how it works
again it just gives me a feeling of
not being secure but it is secure um and
the idea is that you'll be able to
create a key value but actually it's
either key value pair or a key vault
reference and this is the way that
you're able to reference uh secrets
within your vault
so there's not really much to it it's
not super complicated
this view is fine it does what it says
it does
but there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at feature
manager for azure app configuration this
is the meat and potatoes this is the
thing that you really want to be using
as your app configuration for it's for
feature flags so what is a feature flag
a feature flag provides an alternative
to maintaining multiple feature branches
in source code a condition within the
code enables or disables a feature
during runtime and this makes it easier
to roll back or do a to b testing for
new functionality so azure app
configuration feature manager allows you
to add featured flags which can be then
accessed via code so the idea is you say
enable a feature flag you name the flag
whatever you want so i called flash
cards assuming i need a flash card
feature
you can label them of course and then
you are providing
code now i didn't see
much for things outside of net and or
well c-sharp and java so i'm hoping that
their sdks or there's some kind of
library for ruby python node.js
things like that but
it might just be only for c sharp so net
apps and java now let's take a talk
let's talk about an advanced feature of
feature manager which is feature filters
this allows filtering of features so a
feature filter consistently evaluates
the state of a feature flag and a
feature flag supports three types of
built-in filters targeting time window
and percentage which is confusing
because when you go and turn it on it
says targeting time window and custom so
the thing is is that
both targeting and percentage is within
the targeting thing and then custom is
its own thing so that is those little
inconsistencies that microsoft likes to
present you in their documentation so
if we were looking at a time window and
i think this is really cool but you
could say okay this feature starts on
this date and it's between this time and
i guess starts on and ends on that time
so it's like if you just want to run a
feature for you know 10 days you could
do that
then there's a percentage thing so the
idea is that you say okay i'm going to
define two different groups and for
group a they're going to get 50 of this
feature in group b they'll get 50 of
this feature so it'll change
the amount the feature is available uh
per per group like how many in that
group will get it and then targeting
would be like you could say i want it
for these users so when they say
targeting it literally just says user
and you put a name in it's and it and
it's just a a text value it's not like
it's linked to an azure active directory
user anything like that and then they
have custom filters which can be created
based on different factors such as
device use types geography
location etc when i clicked on it it
wasn't very clear on how to do custom
filters but the idea is that you can go
beyond these ones if you want to uh you
know have different values so there you
go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
microsoft graph api which exposes rest
apis and sdks to access data from the
following microsoft cloud services the
first is m35 core services where we have
bookings calendar delve excel m365e
discovery microsoft search onedrive
onenote outlook exchange people planner
sharepoint teams to do
workspace analytics uh
so basically a lot of services for
enterprise mobility and security we have
advanced threat and analytics threat
protection which is atp azure azure 8d
identity manager intune then we have
dynamics 365 business central for
windows 10 services we have activities
devices notifications universal print
and for support sdks we have it for
android ios angular asp.net go
javascript node.js java php powershell
python and they had ruby but i i looked
into it and um they it doesn't work
anymore and they say they're going to
make a new one but i'm still waiting for
it so i always get the short stick when
it comes to ruby
and the data is accessible via the
unified endpoint at
graph.microsoft.com but how do we use
this stuff let's take a look here so for
node.js we would install the microsoft
graph client and then here as an example
we are sending an email so the idea is
getting my pen tool out here we create a
client we're defining uh some mail and
then we're calling our endpoint um via
the api that's basically how you're
always going to be doing it post that
message and that's how the graph api
works so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at microsoft
graph connectors so connectors offers a
simple way to bring external data into
microsoft graph and enhance m365
intelligence experiences so you might
want to build a custom connector to
integrate with services that aren't
available as connectors built by
microsoft using microsoft graph
connectors rest api and you can use the
microsoft graph connector api to create
and manage external data connections
define and register the schemas of the
external data types ingest external data
items and microsoft graph sync external
groups and microsoft search indexes all
your m365 data to make it searchable for
users with microsoft graph connectors
so your organization can index
third-party data so it appears in the
microsoft search results so you're like
okay
where's we have microsoft graph
connectors where are they and that's
where i ended up on the connector
gallery so microsoft has a gallery
website containing a hundred plus
connectors it's at microsoft.com for its
microsoft search forward slash
connectors and i was a bit confused at
first but now i understand what it is
but the idea is that they have a bunch
of different connectors from a bunch of
different third-party providers so
microsoft has some but there's a lot
from a bunch of different providers some
example connectors could be amazon s3 by
ba insights azure blob storage by
accenture google cloud sql by ba
insights ibm connections by
raytheon google drive iba insights azure
devops by microsoft and connectors might
not be free and their instructions
greatly vary based on the implementer so
this is not like a unified thing it's
you go there and it's like some other
app that's used for it so um
yeah it's kind of weird because it just
doesn't feel very standardized but i
guess it's just kind of a library of
services that can connect things kind of
like zapier but as if there was all
these specialized services
by individual third-party cloud vendors
but there you
go well let's take a look here at
microsoft graph data connect which
augments microsoft graph's transactional
model with an intelligent way to access
rich data at scale
so they're just meaning about getting
data out of
microsoft and putting it into some kind
of tool that can transform it do ai on
it things like that so microsoft graph
data connect uses azure data factory to
copy n365 data to your application
storage at your at configurable
intervals and the way this is going to
work is you're going to have to go to
the microsoft graph data connect
under your m365 admin center go to
settings work settings and services and
from there you will turn it on and the
idea once it's turned on then you can go
over to azure data factory and by adding
it as a data set to your pipeline you
now have the ability to access your data
and if you know how data factory works
then you know you can do a bunch of
stuff with it store it in
a blob storage send it to synapsis do
whatever you want
from there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at microsoft
graph so this is a gateway service to
programmatically access m365 windows 10
enterprise mobility plus security and so
here's the big graphic but it's composed
of three elements so microsoft graph api
the microsoft graph connectors and the
microsoft data connect so here in the
middle we have graph api this is where
you programmatically access various
microsoft services you have connectors
these are ways of getting external data
in to microsoft graph and then you have
graph data connect this is a way of
storing data
here so hopefully that makes it pretty
clear
i do find microsoft graph a little bit
confusing because there's a lot going on
here but hopefully as we work through
these slides here it will make more
sense okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure front
door which is a traffic manager traffic
accelerator global load balancer and
content distribution network cdn and yes
it does all those things and i think
that what creates a lot of confusion for
people when they first look at azure
front door uh but the idea here is azure
front door is a modern application
delivery network platform so the idea is
that it can do all these things so
provide a secure scalable cdn dynamic
site acceleration global https load
balancing for your global web
application that's the definition that
azure has
but uh yeah there are going to be
services that have overlap with azure
front door like azure cdn and things
like that
but just understand that this is a very
robust thing and something that you're
going to want to use quite often for
your applications so azure front door
features caching like cdns with rules
expiring policies resilience by
distributing incoming traffic across
multiple or different azure regions
cookie based session affinity for
restful applications when traffic needs
to be redirected back to the same uh
back end so that's for
stateful applications health probes
which are very common um at either the
dns level or the load balancing level
but since it is both here uh it has it
so to determine uh the healthiest and
closest back end to the client request
it can have a waf attached to it so
protecting your back ends
from malicious attacks and
vulnerabilities i believe that is using
azure's waf policy so you're just
basically attaching
a policy to that there your url redirect
so redirecting traffic based on a
variety of things so protocols such as
http or https the host name the path the
query string
not just that there's a lot of stuff in
there url rewriting so with the powerful
engine for rewriting incoming requests
to a different back-end request and so
in the simplest sense this is what azure
looks like you have a front you have
front-ends
or domains where you're bringing stuff
into
azure front door and then you have your
back ends
so that we can filter stuff there
there's actually a lot more components
going on there we will talk about them
or we'll have a diagram here to show you
but this is the basis of azure front
door
[Music]
well let's take a look at the core
components for azure front door uh and
the reason i specifically made this
graphic was because there was no real
uh representation or example that i
could find and so i thought it was very
important because when we start to talk
about routing the path looks completely
different from this it's similar but
it's different so there is uh i don't
know why there's inconsistencies there
there is azure front door classic but i
was using the latest version and so just
understand that if you're confused i'm
confused too but this
is uh the visualization of what i think
it works when you're actually using it
within the gui okay so the idea is you
have a profile and a profile as far as i
can understand contains all the other
azure front door components and then you
have this idea of an end point and this
is the pathway from the front end to the
back end uh and within your endpoint you
need to have some kind of origin so the
origin is saying what to point at so
what to point it at the back end and
even though it says origin
origin here
it's really origin group so you actually
assign origin groups to an endpoint and
so it can rotate to multiple origins
then you have a route and so the route
is where you can apply your rules and
rule sets to determine more routing
things then we have the ability to have
a waff policy before it reaches the back
end
and so hopefully that makes it a little
bit more clear um but uh one thing that
is interesting when we talk about
routing is that
when they talk about the order of data
coming in they actually describe it as
if the waf policies over here but then
when you look at the interface and give
me stuff they put it on the right side
so whether it is
um you know here or there i don't think
really matters in practicality but uh
you know i was trying to find that out
um and the way data gets into azure
front door is that it's going to uh hit
a edge location and then that edge
location is going to then uh trigger i
don't know why it says trigger but the
idea is to go to the front end it should
be more like match
uh but i have this kind of like
expressway or highway to kind of
emphasize that this is going to be very
very fast to get to
uh your azure resources so hopefully
that makes it uh pretty clear about the
components there but it'll be crystal
clear when we do the follow along okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at what
tiers we have for azure front door
because the different tier is going to
determine the feature set that is
available to us so azure offers two
tiers for azure front door the first is
standard or delivery optimized so the
idea is you have content delivery
optimize offering both static and
dynamic contact acceleration we get our
global load balancing our ssl offloading
domain name domain and certificate
certificate management enhanced traffic
analytics basic
security and capabilities and that
sounds like a lot but with premium we
get additional security optimized stuff
so we get everything we get in standard
uh but the idea here is we can uh have
extensive security capabilities across
our web application firewall you can
have bot protection
private link support which i believe is
for internal routing of traffic keeping
things within the azure network an
integration with microsoft threat
intelligence and security analytics uh
standard is really good for most use
cases but if you need that additional uh
security that's where premium's gonna
come into play okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about how routing
works in azure front door because there
are a lot of components and it's
important to understand the flow and
also the different types of routing that
are available to us so routing is the
path
an https request uh
from the user will take to reach a
backend service configured in azure
front door so at the start you have that
http request from the user coming from
their browser most likely and then the
idea is it'll go over the internet and
find the closest edge location edge
location is just a a point of presence a
data center or uh
software hardware that is on on the edge
of a network that allows you to enter
the azure network and so from there you
are now going to be in the azure network
and so you will be matched with a azure
front door profile from there it will
then uh if you have waf rules it will
evaluate the web application firewall
rules and if everything's okay it will
then match you to an azure front door
route and then from that route it will
then go through the engines rule to
evaluate where to route things if there
is cached information it will
immediately return that information
right away um but if there's not it will
just proceed to the next step which is
to send you to an origin group an origin
group is just a grouping of origins
and an origin is how you send a request
to a back end so you know hopefully
we'll see these components over and over
again so it's very clear how they work
together but let's talk about the four
traffic routing methods that are
available in azure front doors so the
first is based on latency so requests
are sent to the lowest latency back-ends
acceptable with a sensitivity range you
have priorities so requests are sent
based on a user-defined number you have
weighted so these are requests that are
distributed to back-ends according to
the weight coefficient and session
affinity so requests from the same end
user gets sent to the same back end so
these are for state full-back and
stateful applications this kind of
functionality for routing like if you're
using aws you'd see this functionality
in rough d3 but in the case of azure
we're seeing these within front door for
this modern application delivery stack
okay so you know hopefully that gives
you an idea but yeah there you go
[Music]
we are looking at azure front door and
it's time to take a closer look at the
origin component so the origin is what
azure front door will point at to serve
up to the end user and origin is the end
point that points to your back end so
here's the example of the form of the
information you'll need to fill out and
the most important field here is the
origin type because that is
what's going to say what are the
supported backends or supported origin
so here we have azure blob storage azure
storage for static website hosting cloud
service yes there is a azure service
called azure cloud service i cannot
remember what it does but
it is a service we have azure app
services that's a place where we
commonly deploy apps
static web app
api management
application gateway public ip address so
that would just be pointing to an ip not
necessarily a service
azure traffic manager azure spring cloud
spring cloud is for java applications i
believe azure container instances so aci
or custom so you just provide a host
name to other fields that are very
important for origin is the priority and
the weight so priority determines who to
send traffic to first and this is going
to be a number between one and five the
lowest number is the higher priority
back ends can have the same priority
number for weights this allows you to
determine the split of traffic
distribution between origins of the same
priority so if you had a priority one
and somebody was 50 50 then they'd get
50 50 split between them but this number
can between uh be between one to one
thousand the default value is 50.
and uh you know this is what it looks
like when you add an origin uh to an
origin group so you can see the status
is enabled the priority is one the
weight is one thousand uh but there you
go
[Music]
so we just talked about origins for
azure front door let's talk about origin
groups so origin groups are a collection
of origins and an origin has to belong
to an urgent group so you can't just
create an origin and let it float around
in azure it's always going to be
assigned to one
and
when you create an azure front door
profile by default you will have an
origin group called default origin group
and so here it is and here you can see
we have a default route for whatever we
set up for this um azure front door
so a few other things you need to know
because there's more than just grouping
it's the fact that you can apply things
to that group and the two things you can
apply are health probes to check the
health of your origins and load
balancing settings to balance uh
determine the balancing of your origins
and in order for inbound traffic to
reach an origin group an endpoint needs
to be associated to the origin group via
a route so there's a button in the um
in the interface so you'll see which is
the associated endpoint to route it's
that simple but we will explore health
probes and load balancing settings a
little bit more just understand that
they belong to the origin group and
those aren't just separate features that
are floating around in the azure front
door
ui or gui there okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
health checks also known as health
probes and that's what it will be called
when you look at it in the interface but
in the documentation they'll call them
health checks and this is a feature
found under origin groups and then it
will apply to your origin so this allows
you to ping a back end to determine if
it has a healthy response
if there is a healthy response which
would be determined by status 200 okay
things will get routed to it if it is
not healthy or considered unhealthy
then simply traffic will not be routed
but instead rather to other healthy back
ends if there are other origins
configured so you might be asking well
what is a http response code just in
case you don't know what it is but the
idea is that when a user sends an http
request a http response is returned and
so for http responses they will have a
response code to communicate how
back-end servers interpreted the request
and a response code is a number that
coordinates to what has happened and
there is a lot of them so but i'm just
going to show you the most popular one
so 200 for okay 403 for forbidden 404
for not found 500 for internal server
error i'm not kidding there's like 100
of these but these are the most common
ones that you've probably seen before
but they all mean something okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at load
balancing settings this is another
option that is available under the
origin group so this allows you to
define what sample set is needed to be
used to call the backend as healthy
or unhealthy so this is something you're
going to be using alongside with health
checks or health probes so the idea is
you have the sample size so how many
times
uh or how many times do we need to
consider how many of the sample size
have to be successful and the latency
betw uh between those okay so the
latency sensitivity with the value of
zero we're just talking about um this
last value here that if you set it to
zero it means that it will always send
to the fastest available backend else
front door will round robin traffic
between the fastest and the next fastest
back ends with the configured latency
sensitivity so there you go
[Music]
so one thing you can do in azure front
door is assign custom domain names and
actually you can assign multiple custom
domain names within azure front door
to show you the form it's not too
complicated but the idea is that
for dns management you can either use
azure managed dns or another provider
you are specifying the dns zone name for
the custom domain you're going to add
that custom domain and you do have a
couple options here for http where you
can have afd or bring your own
certificate for
enabling https and you can apply either
tls 1.0 or 1.2 of course 1.2 is newer so
that's what you should be using
but there's really not much to say about
that other than you can attach custom
domains
very straightforward very simple okay
[Music]
all right we're taking a look here at
endpoint manager so endpoint manager
provides an overview of endpoints you've
configured for your azure front door not
to be confused with microsoft endpoint
manager which is a security service
specifically for managing external
devices so devices to register your
company for organizations that are using
outside of your office so no relation to
that product just very similar naming so
this is an example of an endpoint that
you will see in azure front door and the
endpoint really
means like the entry point and so that's
going to be the domain name so if you do
not have a custom domain azure provides
you one azure fd.net it might vary based
on um capacity and things like that but
the idea is that it goes from domains to
the origin group to the routes to
security
there so you know hopefully that is
pretty darn uh clear endpoint manager
lists how many instances of each element
are created with an endpoint and the
associated status of each element will
also be displayed so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at routes for azure
front door so a route maps domains and
matching
path patterns to a specific origin group
so here uh the idea is that we can
define what domain that we want to use
for this route we can say what patterns
we're matching on so a wild card is
going to match on everything is it going
to be treated as a redirect to https
because if you have http you probably
want to go there and you're going to
associate that with an origin group and
you can provide an origin path
and define the
forwarding protocol routes can also have
caching and compression applied so this
is where you would uh start doing that
and routes from rule sets can be
associated to routes to apply
intelligent
routing so that's where you get that
routing association
but yeah there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at traffic
acceleration for azure front door
sometimes no also known as global
acceleration depending on your closer
provider but the idea here is without
any requirements to make any
modifications to your application code
azure front door can speed up global
delivery of your application so azure
achieves this traffic acceleration by
directing traffic to the nearest edge
location to on ramp the azure
to the into the azure network so the
idea is you have
somebody that wants to connect they're
going to connect to that edge location
and an education is just basically a
data center a point of presence
hardware on the edge of a network and
then once you're in there everything
from here to the uh origin to the uh to
the back end is going to be through the
azure network and it's going to be like
being on an expressway so traffic that
is following within the internal azure
network travels at accelerated speed
while also taking the most direct path
think of it as an expressway and think
of
these edge locations as on-ramps so
there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at rule sets for
azure front door and this allows you to
customize how http requests get handled
at the edge and provides more controlled
behavior uh to your web application so
the idea is that you have a rule set and
within this you're going to define rules
gonna get my pen tool out here so you
name it and you can provide a condition
and then an action and we have a lot of
options here
for things you can do so let's take a
look at what those options are for
conditions we have a lot of stuff device
type http version cookies arg strings
query strings a bunch of things we can
do with the requests such as the body
file name file extension etc so lots of
conditions available to us then for
operators we have equals contains less
than greater than and a whole host of
other even including regular expressions
for actions uh this is where you really
get a very interesting things but you
can do cache expiration so the idea is
that the action is to expire the cache
you can have a cache key query string so
the idea is you can cache every unique
url so it's just a bit more complex
caching you can modify the request of
the header or modify the response of the
header that might be useful for
something to do you can rewrite urls uh
so or sorry redirect urls so the idea is
that you can send it to different types
of redirects such as
a temporary
one or move like 301 or 307 or 308
you can rewrite urls
you provide a source pattern and then a
destination you can override the origin
group there so a lot of stuff you can do
within those rule sets
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this fall
along we're going to be utilizing azure
front door so before we do that we're
going to need ourselves a storage
account to set up some static website
storage so what i want you to do is go
to storage accounts
and there is a static web app host
hosting that we could use but we're
going to do the old school way because
it's always great to learn a few
different ways to do things in azure and
so there's probably another follow along
where we use this static static site
thing there so what we're going to do is
create a new
uh we're going to create a new um
resource group i'm going to call this
one
my
azure front door
and we'll say ok and from here we'll
have to name it something so we'll just
say my azure front door or sorry we'll
do static storage
storage eight eight eight eight if you
can't get the four eights because i'm
using it then just give it a different
um
number sequence because these are
treated like fully qualified domains
choose like a us region so that we're
all doing the same thing for performance
we're going to stick with standard it
doesn't matter if it's on geo-redundant
we're not doing anything fancy there so
what i want you to do is go ahead and
hit review and create and then give it a
moment and hit create and we're going to
wait for that to finish deployment and
from there we'll then have to enable
static website so it doesn't take
too long to deploy so we'll just give it
a moment
and while that's going we do need to
create ourselves a
index html file so you're going to need
some kind of editor so i'm just opening
up visual studio code on my computer
just give it a moment
there and i'm just creating a new file
here this is taking it taking a moment
to load
okay so and what we need to do is just
create an index.html file these are
really basic you can find them anywhere
online but this one's going to say hello
mars hello mars
very very simple so i'm going to go
ahead and save this to my desktop so
save as
and
[Music]
show local maybe there we go that's a
little bit more sane and we'll just say
index.html
and we'll now go to the resource
and we're going to go to website static
as a blade on left hand side so we can
do
a stack website stuff we're going to say
index html i think we have to set that
for it to work i cannot remember if
that's the case we have a primary
endpoint this is uh these matter for
later but we'll come back to that and
we're going to go over to our containers
and we're going to have to create a new
container so i'm just going to call that
actually we don't because we're going to
put it in web so when we turned on
static website hosting it already gave
us a blob or container a container for
us to add our ad or upload our files
there so we'll go to upload here and
then i'm going to go ahead and select
that index.html file and upload it in
place
we need to change our access level for
this uh
this uh container to
um i think just blob
so i'm just double checking here
yeah i think it's blob access uh can
only be anonymous request container data
is not available so we'll say okay i
believe that is correct
okay uh sometimes you can like we're
clicked into it but i think like in my
instructions i do it a little bit
different so i'm just going to double
check to see what the settings are there
just so you can see it if you're
following my instructions so change
access
private blob yeah okay so that's fine um
so blob access should be okay
and so now what we want to do is just
test that our our page is working so if
we go back to static website here
on the left hand side we can grab this
primary endpoint and we should be able
to post it anywhere here
because they have the old tutorial here
this is a moment ago so that's why it's
a bit confusing but
so hello mars is working but this is on
static storage this isn't in front of or
behind azure front door
which is what we'll want to do next
so what i want you to do is just close a
couple of these tabs out we're going to
type in azure front door
our front door should be enough front
there we go and we have a whole bunch of
options we'll just hit create that's a
front door we actually do use for the
platform we have azure front door we
have a quick create i always go custom
i don't think i've ever done quick
create i just
i just have more trust in custom and
from here we will choose front door
and east us is fine
i'm just wondering where our storage
account is that's why we should always
just kind of
set them to be the same place so let's
go to storage account
i don't think it will matter but i'm
just going to double check
storage account
and this one is in
east us so we're going to be okay
just make sure they match just so we
have less problems
and i'm going to call this one my azure
front door
now there are more functionalities in
the premium but standard is fine for us
we'll go next to secrets um
this is if we want to add a certificate
um like you could bring your own
certificate um
but uh we're not too worried about that
we're going to have to add a new
endpoint so we're going to say my end
point here
there's a lot of small steps in here so
this should be fun
hopefully we don't configure anything
wrong here and then we need to add a
route
say my route
and it's going to use the default domain
that's totally fine
we don't have to do anything it's going
to just be on the forward slash asterisk
there
we do need to create an origin group so
we'll go here and create a new origin
group so my origin group and then from
there we need to add an origin yes it is
very
squirrelly going through all this
my origin the origin type is going to be
azure
or sorry storage static website and from
here we need to choose the right one we
called it static storage
uh this is fine this is all fine we'll
go ahead and hit add
and down below we have some load
balancing we don't care about any of
that
so you can see status is enabled all
this should be okay the protocol here
for the health probe should be http um
actually
let me double check because remember
this is where i ran into some trouble
i believe
yeah http i think it's https okay i
think i read somewhere that's like
stack storage doesn't use http but
clearly it does because we went to the
link earlier it was https so i might
have the screenshots wrong but i've
corrected them in the actual
instructions on my site we'll go ahead
and save that i think it's https
and then the the protocol here um we'll
just leave it matching it's totally fine
origin path is fine we'll go ahead and
add that there
and we'll go review create
we'll give it a moment and we'll create
all right so after waiting about a few
minutes like two three minutes it looks
like as your front door setup so we'll
go to the resource i'm just hoping this
works sometimes you have to play around
with the settings but if you see the
endpoint hostname we'll go ahead and
grab that there paste it on in
and we get a 404 so something's not
working just right
so we'll have to go do some debugging
which i was hoping we didn't have to do
so we go the front door manager this is
the same setup we have here before there
are like different ways to get to it
but we'll have to just kind of go
through and debug it so we do have my
route my origin group so we can click
into our origin group and then from here
we'll expand it
and we have our route
so there's something
that is not correct and that's what we
have to figure out
so i'm just going to double check my
instructions because this was a bit
tricky to figure out
um and it really came down to like these
protocols here
so
let me keep checking and i mean i think
the probe is working correctly so if we
go in the origin
if this wasn't working correctly then it
wouldn't it wouldn't show green
so go back up a step here
you know what maybe we should just wait
a little bit because sometimes it takes
time to propagate
and i don't i don't 100 trust that it's
not working because i feel like we
configured it exactly right so i'll open
up a new tab here
it says 404 still
my origin group
that's fine
we'll go here
yeah so what i'm going to do is go back
to our storage account i just want to
double check
what that string was
for the static website i'm pretty sure
it was https
it is hps so there's no reason that
should not work
this is what i was trying to uh spare
you the uh the debugging of this
and it's very common it's not just azure
anything that has a cdn sometimes it's
it's difficult to
figure that stuff out we'll go ahead and
add that route
and we'll just carefully look at what we
have here so
patterns match that is fine
it's the correct endpoint
both protocols are accepted that's
totally fine redirect https that's
totally fine
match that doesn't matter
so it should
just
work
the only thing we didn't do was enable
caching which i think wouldn't hurt to
do
because it is a cdn we don't take
advantage of it if we don't turn it on
so we'll do that and say ignore a query
string i mean that's not going to fix
this problem if the routing's messed up
again i'm just hoping that maybe it just
has to do with propagation
i'll go back to the overview here
and we will open this again
oops
grab this
let's just make sure it's doing hps
we're working to restore all services as
possible right now what do you mean our
services aren't available right now
let's go look at azure status
page here
and we'll take a look at front door
as your front door it's saying that it's
fine
u.s east
there's no green beside it
good
so we go down here i guess it's a it's a
non-regional service so if it's green
it's green
so you know i'm going to play around
with this for a little oh 404 web so
this is better
right it's just saying it can't find the
content
well i mean i guess that makes sense
because that was there so we'll just
clear that out oh now it's loading so i
think it what the issue
is there was no issue it's just
propagating to all the servers and it
took some time so
i think that's what really threw me for
a loop um when i was originally doing it
so just give it some patience and it
will work eventually so we are all done
here so we can go ahead and clean this
up
and i'm just looking for the resource
group here we'll go ahead and delete it
and there you go that's azure front door
and i'll see you in the next one okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at application
insights and this is an application
performance management service so it's
an apm and it's a sub service of azure
monitor let's talk about what apms are
so these are monitoring and
they do monitoring management of
performance and availability for
software apps apm strives to detect
diagnose complex application performance
problems to maintain an expected level
of performance so why use application
insights will automatically detect
performance anomalies and includes
powerful analytics tools to help you
diagnose issues and to understand what
users do with your app designed to help
you continuously improve performance and
usability works for apps4.net node.js
java python hosted on on-premise hybrid
or any public cloud and i know that it
works for other ones that are not part
of the supported languages so there's
one for ruby but the thing is is like
azure's only providing official support
for a bunch of languages but you might
still have libraries out there for them
and it integrates with your devops
processes and can monitor analyze
telemetry from mobile apps by
integrating with visual studio app
center and if you're running an app you
definitely want to have an apm installed
if you ever use data dog or skylight or
new relic that's what apms are or what
those providers offer but let's take a
closer look here and this is kind of an
example of an application and what
you're going to see is that we have a
front end of backend and workers just to
kind of represent
how you can instrument your applications
and when we say instrument it just means
install like this piece of code that
runs on it to send data back to
application insights
and the idea is that when you instrument
it you're just installing the instrument
package sdk or in some cases you can
just turn it on where it's supported so
you don't necessarily have to install an
app you might just press a button and it
will
install it within uh azure services
and there's many ways that you can view
your telemetry data so the idea is that
the agents send that information to
application insights and then you're
gonna be able to leverage that in alerts
power bi visual studio rest api
continuous exports a lot of a lot of
services can ingest application insights
so apps can be instrumented from
anywhere so if you're running on aws you
can install it on your servers there
when you set up application sites
monitoring for your web apps you create
an application site resource in
microsoft azure so it's a physical
resource and you open this resource in
the azure portal in order to see an
analyzed telemetry collected from your
app and the resource is identified by
the instrumentation key also known as
the i key and i just got a big old list
here just to tell you all the things you
can do with it so what does application
insight monitor well request rates
response time failure rates dependency
rates response times failure rates
exceptions page views load performance
ajax calls user and sessions count
performance counters host diagnostics
diagnostic trace logs custom events
metrics
uh so there you go that's a big old list
and on the right-hand side is where can
i see my telemetry and we saw a little
list but let's go through the big list
and that's smart detection manual alerts
application map profiler user usage
analysis diagnostic search for instance
data metrics explorer for aggregated
data dashboards live metrics streams
analytics visual studio snapshot
debugger power bi rest api continuous
export and there you go so you can see
that it can collect and you can use it
in a lot of places definitely definitely
install if you're using are you running
a web application
[Music]
let us quickly talk about open telemetry
so open telemetry also known as otal is
a collection of open source tools apis
that's the case instrument generate
collect and export telemetry data
so otel standardizes the way telemetry
data metrics logs choices are generated
and collected
it uses a thing called wire protocol
which refers to a way of getting data
from point to point
um an application insight supports otel
as an alternative to azure analytics sdk
for instrumentation so open telemetry is
very popular in the cloud native space
and kubernetes um and it probably is the
future of metrics so
it's a standard and so we're seeing
adoption
top not not just by azure but by aws and
google cloud so
uh it is worth knowing about this
alternative method
will show up in the exam maybe not but i
definitely want you to know what open
telemetry is okay
[Music]
let's talk about instrumentation for
application insights because if you
don't do this you're not going to be
getting data to your application
insights so you instrument your
application by adding the azure
application insights sdk and
implementing traces it supports a
variety of languages.net java python
node.js javascript no ruby i really like
ruby support please
so you do npm install application
insight save that's the javascript
example here i'm requiring it we're
doing some setup and then from there
what you can see with the client
is we are tracking an event we're
tracking an exception we're tracking a
metric we're tracking a trace we're
tracking dependency we're tracking
requests so there's a variety of things
we can do but you know there is auto
instrumentation we'll talk about that uh
soon but um you know this is the idea
generally is that this is what
instrumentation looks like okay
[Music]
so wouldn't it be nice if we didn't have
to instrument our app that it would just
work and that's where auto
instrumentation comes in it allows you
to enable application monitoring and
application insights without changing
your code
and it's supported for
a variety of different things so
support's going to vary and you'll have
to just come back and check if this is
even true still
i mean i did just get this table but you
know azure moves really fast let's take
a look at what i'm looking at
right now so across the top we can see
net.net core java node.js python and
there is a term called
onbd which means on by default
so another thing is going to vary on
based on service so for azure app
services pretty good support across the
board except for python which is
surprising
for linux not for net because
it just doesn't let you have it and not
for python for azure functions we only
have it in public preview for java for
azure spring cloud
uh it's only for
java again which makes sense because
spring is a java thing so
it's these will never get supported here
they should really say n a azure
kubernetes service so only for net core
and maybe through the agent uh virtual
machine windows on-premise virtual
machine
um windows they're the same here and
then for standalone agent we have
generally available for java so uh not a
lot of support but i mean there is some
so you know if you're in the dot-net
world or in the java world looks like
you're going to be in really good shape
but there you
[Music]
go hey this is andrew brown and in this
follow along what we're going to do is
learn about using application insights
so application insights allows us to get
visible data about how our application
is running like distributed tracing and
so we're going to deploy some kind of
workload and then apply application
insights to it so what we'll do is go
ahead and go to app services and deploy
a new uh service so let's just type in
the top your app services
and we'll go here we'll go ahead and
create ourselves a new app service
and i'm going to make a new resource
group here so it's easy for us to clean
up later so my app insights
and then from there we'll need a web
name so we'll say my app insights 8888
if you cannot get this name just change
the values to something that works for
you because these are fully qualified
domains it's like registering domain
names so make sure it works for you
we're going to publish code here today
for the stack we're going to choose no
just to make our lives super easy i'm
choosing 16 lts if there's a newer
version should work
fine
no does not change that much
in terms of versions but you know
depends how far in the future you are
in terms of region uh canada uh sorry
central u.s is fine
it's always chooses by random i'm in
canada but i'm going to stay in central
u.s because i know that the things i'm
going to be using will be available
there in terms of the sku in sizes
greatly affects the cost we'll click
into here because we really do not want
to pay much at all
so we'll give it a moment to load it'll
take a few seconds not well it usually
doesn't but for right now it certainly
does so we'll give it a moment to load
i'm going to make my way over to dev
test and we're going to choose the
cheapest option here
which is going to be f1 so
you can see there's not a whole lot it's
just memory storage you know we don't
get custom domain we don't get manual
scaling we don't need that stuff we need
it nice and simple so we'll go ahead and
choose free f1 that sounds good to me i
like the word free we'll go to our next
step which is deployment
in fact i don't think anything has to be
changed under deployment but we'll click
it here
not sure why azure is a bit slower today
but that's just how it's going
so we'll give it a moment to think and
we will wait
wow it is really really slow here right
now okay so for deployment um i mean you
could hook hiccup hook up github actions
and things like that i don't think we
need to do any of that so i'm going to
make my way over to networking
and we do want to inject
oh sorry not networking monitoring
because we don't need networking
monitoring but we want to enable
application insights this is going to
set up some stuff for us um so it's
going to set us an application insights
what name space i think it'll set up
something for us so we don't have to
worry about that so we'll go ahead and
hit review create and hit review
and so now we just need to wait for that
to deploy so i'll see you back here when
that is done okay
after a very short wait maybe like a
minute or two that has been uh completed
so we'll go ahead and go to that
resource and i just want to show you uh
over here in the configuration tab the
environment variables that are going to
get passed
to our application so if you go here
these are the environment variables that
get passed along and notice we have one
called application insights connection
string instrumentation key and the
reason this is important is because we
don't have to um in our environment set
it so like since we're using
app services and we enabled
application insights it's already going
to set those values and the great thing
about the sdk is it's going to pick up
those values so we don't have to
explicitly set them at least i don't
think so if we do set them we'll use the
environment variables i haven't decided
as of yet for application insights um it
set us up a
i don't think they call them workspace
name namespace i don't really care what
the name is called
but the idea is that we have an
environment set up
in order to gather information so what
we're going to do is just go back here
and notice down below it says node is in
progress agent is enabled so just
indicate that that is working as
expected that's a good message to see
not that we'd ever see any other message
there
and so now that uh we
we know that everything is deployed or
at least our environment is ready let's
go ahead and create a new application so
what i'm going to do is make my way over
to github here and we are going to
create ourselves a new repository now i
don't know if i have an old one sticking
around here so hopefully i don't but
we'll see here i'm going to say my
app insights would be something i would
name it and so i already have one there
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
make a new tab here
okay i'm just gonna go to uh anyone here
this is my marketing website i'm gonna
go my app insights i'm just going to
rename the old one so it's out of the
way
so you can follow along exactly the same
way as me here i'm just going to do
settings we'll go down here we'll just
say old
all right and we'll rename that
and i'll close that out and so what
we'll do is go back here and this this
is fine now i know that it says it's not
but i know it is we're going to add our
email file we're going to go down to get
ignore and add node
i might add i might have done this after
the fact so i might have added the steps
out of order here but uh that should
improve that there i'm just going to do
hyphen old i'm going to
take that out there there we go and
we'll go ahead and create this
repository
so um
i want you to get getpod installed so
gitpod is a really great
great service
for having a cloud developer environment
it has a generous free tier so there's
no reason not to sign up
and really this is the future of cloud
development so make sure to go get a get
pod account but you really don't have to
because when you launch this environment
either launches it temporarily
or you can connect your account and then
persist that data but um anyway
if you install the getpolychrome
extension you'll get this button but you
don't need to install the chrome
extension all you have to do
is you just need to put this in front of
your address so this is the current
address we're at like this is the
current repository
whoops
this is the current repository link and
all this button is doing
uh copy link address is just putting
this part in front here okay so this is
going to open up a git pod environment
this launches extremely fast and we're
going to create a new node.js
application and deploy it to
app services so we'll give it a moment
here
doesn't take too long
here we go and what we'll do is we're
going to use the mpx uh express
generator to generate a new express
express application express.js
generator so we'll type that in there
we'll say yes
and it's going to create us a skeleton
app just say yes just say yes all the
way down we'll get a bunch of stuff in
here and then we'll do our npm install
you can do npm installer npmi if you
want to make it nice and short
we'll give it a moment there
okay and then we'll make sure this works
we'll type in npm start this is going to
prompt us to open our browser so we'll
say open browser
so express yes that application is
working up this link up here so this is
our application but it's not
instrumented to send any data so that's
what we need to do so the next thing
we're going to do is just kill this
control c
uh yeah control c on my keyboard
and we'll type in npm install i'm typing
application
insights hyphen hyphen save and what
that's going to do is install that
dependency for application insights so
if i go over to my package.json here you
can see that it is a dependency that is
installed so now we need to configure
that so what we'll do
is go over to our um
app.js file and so we got to insert this
somewhere here
um so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go all the way to the top that's
probably a good place to put it and
we'll say let i like how it says all var
var is really old
app insights equals require
double quotations or single it doesn't
matter it's not going to hurt either way
application insights and that will
define our variable here the next thing
is we need to set it up so we'll say app
insights
dot setup and then we need our
connection strings that's where we're
going to put this thing here
our connection string
and then we need a bunch of other things
so i'm not going to type these all out
because there's a lot of them so we'll
just say
application insights instrumentation
node.js
and i'm sure the documentation is going
to help us out there
so go here i'm just scrolling for the
usual configuration here it is that's
all i've been typing here this entire
time that's probably where i got it
originally so we'll go ahead and we'll
just paste that on in there allow
take out the first line that way there's
no spelling mistakes
and so we have auto dependency
correlation auto collect requests a
bunch of interesting stuff here it's
going to do distributed tracing we don't
need the semicolon we'll just take it
off there for fun and i'll save that and
so now the next thing we need is the
connection string in order to make sure
this application works which is going to
go here so we'll make our way back over
to this tab and the connection string is
actually in the configuration that were
earlier here in this blade so give it a
moment to load
there we go and so we want the
connection string so we'll click that
i think before that you could use the
instrumentation key but now connection
string is what is preferred
um i want to copy the value okay i just
clicked into it to make it a bit easier
for me and what i'm going to do this is
really dirty but i'm going to just paste
it in here and we're going to just do it
in a few different steps just to make
sure that this is working correctly
before we switch this over to
environment variables
and one other thing that we need to do
if we want to actually get any data is
we'll have to turn send live metrics to
true now if you are doing
instrumentation you might not want live
metrics i don't know if it costs more
but for our development purposes it's
not a big deal to turn this to true so
that is now enabled and uh you know our
dot get ignore should have a bunch of
stuff in it like node module so we're
not committing that stuff i'm going to
commit this now it does have the
connection string in here i'm not too
worried about it because we are going to
um delete it out
later on so we'll just say um
save my changes but i am pointing to
pointing out to you that we are
committing this
string here which is bad practice right
because if somebody got that then they
could mess with this but again
uh we're going to tear all this stuff
down so it's not that big of a deal and
so we should be okay
so now that this is
installed what we're going to do is do
an npm start that's going to start up
our application
and then we're going to go open in the
browser again so here's our application
now we'll go back to application
insights
or not application sites but into
our app service our actual application
on the left hand side there's going to
be application insights and from here
what we can do is click the view
application insights to go to the
workspace the namespace whatever they
want to call it and this is the way
we're going to be able to see some
information so live metrics on the left
hand side will show us data in real time
so now it says it's connected to your
app so we'll go back here
refresh so the app connects and we
should get some data
there we go so these are the requests
we're making right here so i hit enter
enter enter enter enter enter enter we
go back here here's those requests
coming in it's giving a 304 for the
css um so yeah mostly yeah there's our
stuff so we know that it's working
because we can see information there
so that's pretty darn straightforward
now let's go back to our application set
this up properly because we really
shouldn't be setting our string like
this this is pretty dirty so what i'm
going to do is just delete this out here
and i'm just going to type in um
process.env
and then we're going to say
we'll match the name of what it's
supposed to be called in our application
so i'll click back to make it back to
our actual application
we'll go to configuration
and from here i'm going to just go ahead
and grab that string string name i just
clicked into it i just don't want to
type it wrong and we'll go ahead and
paste that in there and so this is what
we are going to set and just did ctrl c
to kill there but this is what we're
going to set as our environment variable
so i'm doing gp gp stands for git pod
it's a way of setting environment
variables and we'll do double quotations
always do double quotations especially
with connection strings when setting
environment variables so part of the
string does not get cut off because it
will cut off at the first forward slash
and then you'll just end up with like
that and that's not enough right so i've
copied that i'm going to go back here
paste it in we'll hit enter and so
that's setting the key now if i do grep
or sorry env so this show like this
prints all the environment variables so
env
pipe pipe is just a vertical line
grep and i type in connection any part
of the string notice that it's not set
yet so just because we said gpenv does
not mean it's set uh what you have to do
is restart the environment but we can
temporarily set it export this is how
you'd set it in bash you type export and
you'd give it the
the name here like this and you do
equals double quotations
and this will this will make the
environment work but the only problem is
that if we restart this uh workspace
we'll lose that on the next time we
restart it so this will definitely work
but
let's just do it let's just restart the
environment anyway so we have process e
and v up here but we have to import that
as well so i'm going to say let
process equals require
process process is just a way of getting
access to the process
process being the application that's
running to access the environment
variables that are set which are getting
passed along to the application by
app services
so
that is good there
and so i think we are in good shape the
only other thing is i want to generate a
git pod file so i'm going to just do gp
for uh git pod and we'll just set some
things up this is going to save us some
time when we relaunch our environment so
i'm just doing uh pipes here
uh on the end here that allows us to do
multi-line even though we're only doing
a single line we could probably emit the
pipe if we wanted to but i'm just
putting it in anyway
and so
we'll just indent there coloring usually
tells us something's wrong and this
starts up on port 3000. i want it in the
browser
i don't want to do preview that means
opens in a little window here that's
kind of gross
and so this looks good i think i
accidentally removed a line here because
we'll say tasks up here and so now we
have our get pod uh uh yaml file so
we'll go ahead and add all these files
here so um
uh instrument
i think that's everything we need to do
there so we'll just go ahead and commit
that
we'll sync our changes
and i'll do a
get push just to double check double
check that this stuff was synced and
committed so if you go back to our
actual uh get or github if you go
context it just brings us back to the
github repository
that gitpod yaml file set so we know
that our changes have been committed
highlighting looks fine and this is
green this is this kind of looks blue so
hopefully that works but anyway what
we're going to do is go ahead
and
open this again sorry we'll close this
tab
and we'll reopen up and get pod so this
will launch a new workspace if you still
have the old tab open it might ask you
to physically press a button called new
workspace but generally it opens a new
workspace so it's setting up a new
container completely for us
so give it a moment it doesn't take
too too long
and
what we'll do here is
wait for the terminal to open
okay notice it ran the server did npm
install did everything for us i'm just
going to open a new terminal here on the
on the right hand side and bash whoops
well i did not mean to split it but
that's okay
i don't know how to unsplit it so just
drag it around that doesn't matter
yours will look a little bit different
than mine
and so all i want to do is do env grep
um
con
because i want to see that connection
with set we'll do two ends
so there it is application insights
connection string so i'll just go ahead
and close this one i'm getting a bit
confused here with that open and our app
should still work if we go on the left
hand side here to remote explore it
didn't give us the prompt here notice
that this little red thing says all
right you're blocking this pop-up
continue blocking no always allow us to
pop up on this
and i'll just click the uh a little
world button to see that it's running so
it's still working we're going to go
double check to make our
instrumentations working with our new
connection string that's being passed
through as an environment variable so on
the left hand side go back to
application insights
and we'll give it a moment here below
we'll go back to viewing the data on the
left hand side we're going to go to live
metrics
it says it needs to reconnect we'll hit
refresh here if it connects then it must
be working
so refresh refresh refresh go back the
data is coming in so therefore it is
working so we are in good shape here so
um our application is configured
correctly but it's not actually deployed
um because we are passing the invite
like we're passing our own environment
variables in so let's actually get it
deployed
to
um app services so what we'll do is
click back to get back to our app
services
which is here nope oh yeah this is it
says app service that's good on the left
hand side we want to deploy it so we'll
go to deployment center
and what we'll do is we'll choose the
code and we'll go to github and from
here we need to authenticate so omek's
my personal account that's just the way
i get to it and so i need to select an
organization it's exam pro i need to
select a repository
this is going to be my
app
insights that's the new one
we'll choose the main branch
it knows what the runtime is
and we'll go ahead and save that
so as soon as we do that it should
automatically start deploying
it's using github actions as the build
provider so if we go back to the
repository here we go to actions we can
see
we have one queued up and so this should
run on its own we don't need to do
anything
so all we're doing is waiting for this
to deploy
and once it's done then our application
should be
deployed to
the our url and then we'll check to see
if it works and if it works then we are
in good shape and we're done the basics
of application inside so i'll be back
here in a little bit okay
all right so it's done i was waiting
here for quite a while but i think it
was done in a few minutes you just have
to hit the refresh here so you know
don't be afraid to go up here and hit
enter and and see if it's deployed but
now that it says it's deployed i mean
this url's on git pod so that's no good
for us what we'll do is go back to our
application all the way top to the
overview tab or blade i should say we'll
go to browse and see if it's deployed so
we're hoping we see express
js the first load might be a bit slow so
we'll give it a moment to think
it sure is thinking hard
and we'll just close it again and reopen
it
we are using the free tier so i'm not
sure if it's like spinning up the
instance that's probably what it's doing
it's probably um
spinning up uh the whatever the
underlying environment is to get it
running so it is running here now the
next question is is it tracking so we'll
go over to application insights
and we'll go back to viewing our insight
data
and we will go all the way down to alive
metrics
it says it's not connected we'll hit
refresh
give it a moment here see if it finds
any data
we'll hit enter
there we go so we're having a couple
requests in there so uh we have
application sites working and it's
deployed so we're in pretty good shape
here we're going to keep this
environment around because we need it
for a few uh follow follow alongs here
but if you want you can tear this down
but you'd have to do all the setup again
but you can see it doesn't take too darn
long but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we're going
to take a look at sampling with
application insight so this is a very
short follow along but very useful for
you to know so we have this application
and what i want you to do is open it up
in git pod you should know by now how to
open things up and get pot and we'll uh
give it a moment here and we're going to
configure this to do sampling so
sampling is when you don't send every
single trace
to application and sites or every single
request information and the reason why
you'd want to do this is basically to
save money because if you had
all your data going there
it just it's just too much information
right so um and that cost will stack up
a lot faster so you know applications
might send only 50 requests only 22
percent of requests it's up to you to
decide how much data you need to have
something that's accurate but you
definitely don't need all of it so i'm
taking the start off the end of here and
i'm just going to have app
insights start here so it is set here
and then what i'll do is do app
insights
app insights i think we should do before
i think in my code in the code example i
have it in the wrong order but i don't
think it even matters but we'll do
client config it might matter actually
sampling
um percentage
equals 50. so we're saying only sample
50 of the time i'm just going to double
check make sure that spell right app
insights
default client config sampling
percentage equals 50 and so now if we if
we set that there
and i'm not going to uh i'm not going to
test it in the albums go test it and get
pod here but what we'll do is we'll go
back to our application
into the application sites tab
view that we'll go to the um
live metrics
and if we go back over here and
stop our application start it back up
okay
and we go here this should connect
and so what i want to do i don't know
i'd say it's not supported it's
definitely supported we'll hit one
two
three four and i'll go back
and notice that i hit four but i only
have two requests so
that's why we're only getting 50 of it
because it's going to cut out 50 50 of
the requests and i think yeah it should
always do that so that's all i wanted to
show you
because that is something that is a very
basic configuration that you should know
for application insights uh but we're
going to keep the environment around
because we have a few more things to do
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
going to look at usage analysis with
application insights so usage analysis
allows you to get more rich information
about the usage of your application so
i'm just here in application insights
for our app that we've been using if you
go to the left-hand side and scroll on
down you'll see this usage tab so we
have users sessions all this interesting
stuff it allows us to instantly create a
cohorts which are extremely useful for
visualizing information if you've never
seen a cohort before like user cohort
i don't think it matters what cohort we
look at but i just want to show you an
example of one
so this is a cohort and the idea is that
if you have an application you want to
be able to see whether users are coming
back every single day right so you go
okay this person was here on day one
and the same person came back or 23 of
people came back in the second day uh 18
of the people came back in the third day
and it gives you kind of a map of um
of course very or like information about
your user behavior so very very
important very useful for your
application and application insights
allows you to collect that information
now um what we're going to be doing here
is we're going to be instrumenting uh
the client side because
uh we never
we instrumented the server side when we
installed it into the our back end
server code but we never did in the
front end so that's the first thing
we're going to need to do so i just need
the the code snippet to do that so um
what i'm going to do i'm going to go
back to our repository because we're
going to need that open here so we'll go
back to my my app insights i'm going to
open that up and get pod while that's
going i'm going to type in application
insights
insights instrumentation node.js
and we should easily be able to find
the code for this here
i want a client-side though
i'm just looking for it so because
there's all sorts of pages here so it
can be a bit well let's say usage how
about application insights
um usage
usage analysis here's the page and
that's the code we want so it's on this
page here this is an analysis with
application insights so i'm going to
copy that code and that's going to go
into i'm going to make a new workspace
here
that's going to go into the front end of
our website so somewhere in the
index.html
or if they're called jade files and
it'll go into there so it is a
uh oops jade file it's just opening the
browser for us here so what i'll do is
go index jade is just this syntax
language that is used by um
this configuration of express.js i'm
going to go ahead and paste this block
in here and we actually have to format
this a bit because jade is not going to
like this so what we'll do is type in
script here at the top this is how this
language works for javascript tags we'll
do parentheses
type equals sql quotations text
javascript
okay
and then from here what we'll do is just
go ahead
and select this
okay
and i'm just looking where we should put
it so they probably want it in the head
so we'll put it right here
and
um yeah so that's fine that looks good
to me
we're also going to need
um
to create some kind of cohort so what
we'll do i'm going to just commit this
add client side tracking
okay and so we'll stop our app start it
back up
okay
and back over here i just kind of want
to show you where you can set up we're
not going to be able to see a real
cohort because we need multiple days to
collect information but let's just kind
of play around as if we do have the data
so over here on the left-hand side we'll
go to sessions and it should tell us how
many sessions we have now there was no
information showing it before but now
we're seeing two
okay so um i'm not sure if it's counting
both the server side and the client side
but we are getting data so that's good
and if we went up here to create a
cohort
we have a template gallery so we could
choose a variety of different ones so we
might want to try a blank sessions
cohort sessions are people that are
connected to the application users are
identified users
um and so you know we can add parameters
to filter things down but we don't have
to do anything we can also like run the
query to see what information we get
back but we'll go ahead and just save
this cohort so we'll just say
my cohort whatever you want to name it
doesn't matter because we're not going
to see anything interesting anyway
and so this is our cohort but you can
see there's nothing interesting so if we
want to see something
that kind of looks like a cohort what we
can do is make our way over to
workbooks
i think yeah over here
i'm not sure if this is just the same
thing uh but in a different place but if
you go down below here they have usage
like active users and things like that
i'm looking for retention so maybe
cohort analysis
and so down below you can kind of start
seeing a table here right of what that
looks like so i find the workbooks a lot
more useful than the usage tabs but
yeah i just want you to know about this
usage analysis because it's super useful
that logins or application insights has
that functionality so you know hopefully
that is good enough there but that is
all we're doing here
so i'm just going to go home close these
tabs
and i'll see you in the next one okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and this follow
along we are going to do a bit more with
application insights by putting in
custom events which is very useful for
tracking so what i want you to do is
open up application insights for our
project that we've been working with
we'll also have to go back to our get
github repository and open that up in
git pod as uh you should know how to
open git pod by now
and we'll give it a moment there to load
and we'll enter in some code
so we do have server side client-side
tracking we did the client-side tracking
in the uh usage
um the usage section there but if we
expand this here we're going to want to
put something in the index jade file and
so here what we will do is add a new
script tag so that's going to be script
this is jade language i don't care if
you learn it but you just got to follow
along for this purpose
coding is not the lesson here but we
have text javascript that allows us to
do some javascript there and i don't
know why it's saying tab when i type
that is not very useful for me but i'm
just going to hit do space space and
type in app
insights track
event we'll auto complete that there
we'll do parentheses curlies
name double quotations client count and
so every time this page loads it's going
to do track event with this name and
that's going to count up it's called
client count that's how we know it's on
the client side so that's the index page
there
and so now we need to do server side so
there's a few things we have to do here
we've got to go to app.js
and in here we need to set a variable
that's going to get passed along
so we'll go down below here and do app
dot set parentheses
app insights and this is specific to
express.js so again i don't care if you
remember how this works but just a way
that we can pass a variable that we're
going to access in our routes so we go
app insights default client
and
i'm going to make sure we have that yeah
it's up here so we're passing this in
here so that's good
we'll go over to our routes and in our
route center index page we need to
add
app insights we'll do app insights
and we're going to grab it from
that app variable we just set so we do
app request app get app insights and
then we'll track it it looks exactly the
same as the other one we are using
javascript on the front a front end and
the back end so it makes things a little
bit easier and this one's going to be
called name
double quotations single quotations
doesn't matter
server
count
okay so now we have it server-side
client-side i'm going to go up here just
commit my code
client and
server-side tracking
we'll commit that
and what we will do is we'll do an npm
start to restart up the application now
that we have both sides of it we do have
a problem here on line eight of index uh
index
index jade file so we'll go here take a
look at what it's complaining about
um
does not like something
so
i'm just taking a look at my my code off
screen here
it's lining it it's this line it doesn't
like
so
why not um
hmm
i mean i don't see a problem
so what happens i'm just going to copy
my my my oh you know what it's
indentation see where it says block
content
it's supposed to be this level here
that's probably the problem
so we'll stop it we'll start it
we'll give it a second
it's still crying it's a big old crybaby
here but that's okay we'll work through
it
now i hit tab it's actually tabbing
properly because i wanted to do tab
before i don't know why it was uh
doing that
still doesn't like it
so i do have the code off screen here so
i'm just going to copy paste it
i mean you'll have if you're on my
platform you'll have it
so you just say allow
oh there's a period on the end
of course can barely tell that was there
okay so we'll save that
again i don't care if you learn
j-templating it's
not a skill you have to remember so that
is there i'm just going to keep hitting
enter
because i want to observe this custom
event data so we go back over here into
app insights and we should be able to
see this
somewhere um
this would be under
where this would be under somewhere i'm
trying to find it
it would be under
which blade
huh i didn't write it out of my
instructions so we'll have to click
around here to find it
um
i
think
well it's event data so it's probably
under events
yeah that's where it is now i'm
remembering
and
we what we can do is filter this down
and say any custom event here if we
scroll on down we'll go view more
insights i don't know why they have a
little button there to get that
information but we scroll on down we
have server accounts the server account
is definitely working
we don't know why we don't see client
count so what we'll do is go back here
and we'll right click and see if there's
any errors
there is an error app insights is not
defined and so it should be defined in
the head because
we have this script from before
right
you know what we didn't put the
instrumentation key in
so that's not good because in the last
follow along we were supposed to do it
but it didn't really matter because we
didn't have any data to look at so
that's why we didn't notice so we'll go
back to our overview
and we'll grab the instrumentation key
here
go back to our code
and we will go
up to app.js
and this is client side so it's a bit
harder to
pass it in as environment variables
we're not even going to try to do like
to do that because it's the
instrumentation key it doesn't matter
and we're going to go back to the
uh
layout here and down below we'll just
replace that
okay we'll stop start it
hit refresh
right click to see if it's working now
let's give it a refresh here
still saying app insights is not defined
which is not true
but there is an error here we'll click
and do it
it's not showing me the line which would
be nice
okay so we'll go back here and there's
something wrong here it doesn't like
something you know what it's probably
missing the period
there we go
i can't believe we never noticed that
before
so fixes i'm very confident that is the
fix
so we'll go back here inspect
refresh
already lost that let's do inspect again
no errors here that's good we'll hit
refresh refresh refresh refresh refresh
refresh refresh we'll go back to
application insights
and
we will go back to events
if we can find it there it is
and i'm going to go down to any custom
event scroll on down
more insights
and it might just need some time to
propagate because we're not getting any
errors now so it must be working
if it didn't track it it would give us
an error
client client count so it is showing up
so it is counting now so that's how we
do custom event tracking so there you go
and for the most part i mean the only
thing we didn't look at was applica
application map
take a quick look here
this would show you like connections in
between stuff so here we have like the
web to the client if we set up other
things like a database and stuff like
that we would have something more
interesting that's more of advanced
thing
and you know maybe i'll do that in
another follow along but this one is
done so let's go ahead and clean this
all up you can delete this repository
it's no big deal if you're worried about
the connection string you can delete
that whole yeah the repository but since
we are tearing everything down it's not
going to matter and i know we replaced
it as an environment variable but
remember it's in the git history so
someone went back it got access to your
github repository it went back in time
they could find it but um what i'll do
is i'll go to resource groups
we'll look for our app insights here
and we will hit delete resource group
we'll say my app insights go ahead and
delete delete and there's our cleanup so
there you go that was application
insights
[Music]
so azure monitor is uh quite a beefy
service there's a lot going on in it and
so it's a comprehensive solution for
collecting analyzing acting on telemetry
data from your cloud and on-premise
environments so here's an example of one
of the things it can do which is provide
you a visual dashboard but it can create
smart alerts automate actions log
monitoring and a lot of different things
and many azure services by default are
already sending their data to azure
monitor so you can use it right away
[Music]
now i just want to introduce you to the
concept of the pillars of observability
this isn't a thing specific to azure but
it's something that in devops that you
need to understand and it's just going
to help you contextualize the offerings
of azure monitor and other cloud service
providers so what is observability that
is the ability to measure and understand
how internal systems work in order to
answer questions regarding performance
tolerance security and faults with a
system and application and in order to
obtain observability you need three
things you need metrics logs and traces
and you have to use them together using
them in isolate does not gain you of
observability so let's go define those
three things the first thing is metrics
and that is a number that is measured
over a period of time if we measure the
cpu usage and aggregate it over a period
of time then we would have the average
cpu metric then you have logs these are
text files where each line contains
event data about what happened at a
certain time and then you have
traces and this is a history of requests
that is
that
is that travels through multiple apps
and services so we can pinpoint
performance or failures and i like to
make the joke that it looks kind of like
the triforce of observability once
you've constructed it there at the end
[Music]
let's look at the anatomy of azure
monitor which is a little bit complex
but i'm sure we can work our way through
it so the first thing is that we need uh
sources of data so these this is what uh
what data can be sent into azure so you
probably want application data operating
system data uh data from azure resources
at your subscription level your tenant
level which is going to be associated
with active directory and custom sources
and once you get those into azure
monitor you have to store them somewhere
you're going to put them in logs and
monitors and these are just data stores
that are within azure monitor that
you're going to be able to work with
and once you have that data in there
you're going to be able to leverage
different services and do different
things
and so we will call these functions
so you can perform insights
visualizations
analysis response and integration so
we'd look at insights uh we're getting
insights into our virtual machines our
containers our applications uh for
visualization you might be making
dashboards you could be using power bi
or creating workbooks for analysis you
might be using the log analysis or the
metric analysis tools for responses
you might want to create alerts or start
auto scaling and for integrations you
might want to use logic apps or export
apis to connect things up so there you
go
[Music]
so now let's take a closer look at all
the different sources because this is
going to really help us understand the
utility at each level
and i think that makes everything very
crystal clear so remember that list of
sources where we went to application to
custom sources we're going to start at
the top of that list and look at
application code which is all about
performance and functionality of your
application and code so that's like
collecting traces application logs and
user telemetry
and so here is the visual representation
and so on the left-hand side we have our
sources in the middle we have our
storage and the right-hand side we have
our our services that we're going to be
doing things with that data so looking
on the left you're in your application
you'll probably want to go ahead and
install the instrumentation package this
is going to allow us to collect data
into application insights and
application insights is a application
for
getting rich data about our applications
then you have availability tests this
tests the response responsiveness of
your application from different
locations on the public internet
and that's really useful if you're
saying like if you have your application
you're running it in
the east of canada and the west of the
us and you want to make sure that the
response times are the same or lower
that's going to help you get there
for your metrics this is going to be
describing your performance and operate
and operations uh and custom metrics of
your application for your logs you're
going to be storing operational data
about your application such as page
views application requests exceptions
and traces and then the things you're
going to be putting in storage is you're
going to send the application data
to your azure storage for archiving or
what you'll do is you'll store your your
availability tests if you need to go and
analyze them further
or you could create a debug snapshot of
your data so that you can then go debug
that at a later point okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at how we're going
to monitor our operating systems and
this is for the guest operating system
not the host operating system uh so when
you're dealing with virtualization um uh
the vm has its own os but the actual
underlying hardware has its own os and
that's the host one and that's not what
we're looking at
you don't need to monitor that one
that's up to azure to do or your cloud
provider we're looking at the guest one
the one we actually can control
so the operating system is going to need
a couple of tools installed so or agents
so we'll want to install the log
analytics agent so we can use that with
log analytics we'll probably want to
install the dependency agent that allows
us to monitor processes on the machine
so those are the programs that are
running so like you know let's say mysql
redis maybe you have a ruby on rails app
whatever
um and so that's that
and i just want you to know that these
agents can be installed anywhere so it
can be installed on azure on premise or
even on other cloud providers like aws
if you want performance counters you're
going to have to install the diagnostic
extension which is i think a good thing
to do
and just to make note the log analytics
agent is going to store that data into
logs then you can use that log analytics
later
if you want to
have the or store store the health state
information then you're going to be
using the azure diagnostic extension and
they're going to put that in azure
storage
and if you want to use azure event hub
so event hub is a way of connecting your
app to other destinations
you're going to stream it but you're
going to need the diagnostic extension
for that all right
[Music]
let's take a look at azure resources and
how we're going to monitor those so um
you're going to have resource logs and
these provide insights to internal
operations for azure resources
and these logs are automatically created
for you but you will have to set up
diagnostic settings to specify
destination for them to be collected for
each resource
for
metrics you're going to get those
automatically you don't have to do any
additional work to configure them and
you're going to be able to analyze those
in metrics explorer
for your log data you're going to use
log analytics to look for trends and
other analyses
you can also copy your platform metrics
to logs for analysis
and uh your log resource logs are going
to be archived with azure storage for
long-term backup
if you want to uh
use um or or send or trigger uh or send
your data to other destinations you can
use event hubs that's generally what
event hubs is for so there you go
[Music]
taking a very quick look at how we
monitor our azure subscription this is
going to be for uh the the service
health
of different resources that you're using
like are they okay are they running and
things about azure active directory so
that's about it
[Music]
i'm going to take a look at
our azure tenant and how we would
monitor that and if you remember our
azure ad section that's where we define
tenant because tenant is
highly coupled to active directory and
so this is going to be for tenant-wide
services such as active directory so
reporting that contains history of sign
in activity audit trails of changes made
within a particular tenant things like
that so there you go
so last on our list here is custom
sources and basically if if none of the
other previous categories fit where you
want to collect data uh this is where
you can just collect data using the
azure monitor api and so basically you
are using a rest client and then it's
going to store it in analytics at log
analytics or azure monitor so it's just
really custom data custom storage
[Music]
so there's two fundamental types of data
that we care about when working with
azure monitor and that is logs and
metrics and so azure has two
services to deal with that one is called
azure monitor logs and so this service
collects and organizes log performance
data for monitored resources data logs
are consolidated from different sources
into workspaces which we'll talk about
platform logs from azure services is
something you'll collect it'll collect
also log performance data from vm agents
the usage and performance data from
applications also can be consolidated
and these workspaces can be analyzed
together together using a query language
which we definitely cover in this course
and you work with these log queries and
the results interactively using
a subservice called log analytics which
is something we'll definitely be
covering
then there's azure monitor metrics so
this is for the metric side so collect
uh numeric data from monitor resources
into time series database metrics are
numerical values collected at regular
intervals and describe some aspects of
the system at a particular time uh
lightweight and capable for of
supporting near real real-time scenarios
useful for alerting and fast detection
of issues and you can analyze them
interactively using metrics explorer and
we cover that as well so really these
two services are like the data stores or
the databases for the respected types of
data and then each of them have the sub
services which is for exploring and some
other additional services but let's get
into that more detail now
[Music]
so when you use log analytics you're
going to probably want a workspace and
this is a unique environment
for azure monitor log data each
workspace has its own data repository
and configuration and data sources and
solutions that are configured to store
their data in a particular workspace so
it's really interesting because if you
go over to azure monitor you can use uh
log analytics without creating a
workspace but i believe that if you want
to
isolate a lot of your data and
install like maybe like collect it
outside of azure services for other
things you're going to need a workspace
and it's going to also have a lot more
robust options so that's something
you're going to end up doing is creating
workspaces and it's a good habit to do
but there's not a lot to talk about
there but let's move on to actual the
query language which is really the meat
of log analytics
[Music]
i want to quickly touch on log analytics
and so this is a tool used to edit and
run queries within azure monitor logs
and so the idea is it kind of looks like
something you use to connect to a
database because it really is structured
like a database with tables and columns
and things like that and it has this its
own query language called a kql and the
idea is that you input
your queries and it's going to output
results for you and that's something
we're going to look at in greater detail
is that
kql language so that we know how to use
that panel let's go talk about
workspaces
let's take a closer look at custo and
it's query language so azure monitor
logs is based off of the azure data
explorer and along came with it is the
cousteau query language also known as
kql and this is the way we're going to
uh filter and uh sort and do things with
our logs so kusto is based on a
relational database management system
and it supports entities such as
database tables and columns there's also
this thing called clusters and uh kql
actually has a lot utility in azure
because it's not just in monitor logs
and data explorer you can use it in log
analytics log alert rules workbooks
dashboards
logic apps powershell azure monitor log
apis so it's definitely something you
can be using across the board in azure
and so they have some basic operators
they have lots of operators that you can
use so you can do calculated columns
searching filterings on rows group by
aggregates join functions and we're
going to be looking at a lot of the
operators in more detail after this
slide here
but anyway
the queries execute in the context of a
cousteau database that is attached to
acousto cluster and we will talk about
clusters database tables and columns up
next
[Music]
let's take a look at what makes up
something for cousteau and so we have a
bunch of entities here clusters database
tables columns and functions and so i
have this nice visual to help us uh kind
of see how they all work together so the
top we have clusters and these are
entities that hold multiple databases
you can also have multiple clusters
but it's just not being shown there in
that graphic then you have the databases
themselves these are named entities that
hold tables and store functions you have
tables these are named entities that
hold data and a table has an ordered set
of columns and zero or more rows of data
each row holding one data value for each
of the columns of the table then there
are the columns themselves and these are
named identities that have a scalar data
type columns are referenced in the query
relative to the tabular data stream and
that is the context of the specific
operator referencing them then we have
stored functions and these are named
entities that allow reuse of cousteau
queries or query parts
and then you got these external tables
and these are tables that uh live
outside of your cluster
i think that uh you're referencing them
from uh storage accounts and they're in
blob storage so they pro i think there
could be like csv files and stuff like
that but these external tables are used
for exporting data from cousteau to
external storage so storage uh storage
accounts
as for querying external data without
ingesting it actually into cousteau so
hopefully that gives you an idea the lay
of the land there
[Music]
let's take a look at the type of data
types that we can use in cousteau but
let's just define what scalar and data
types are so scalars are quantities that
are fully described by a magnitude or
numerical value alone
so the idea is that it just means like a
single value then you have data types
and a data type defines how a piece of
data is interpreted so an integer number
could be a data type if you've ever used
programming languages like data types
and stuff like that or an sql database
you should be familiar with those so
incusto data types are used for various
things so they can be for columns or
function parameters that expect specific
data types
uh
that they want them to be
and so let's just go through the quick
list of data types because there are
quite a few here and i've summarized
them quickly so the first is billion and
this represents a true false value then
you've got date times your date and this
represents a date and these are stored
in ut
utc time zones you got decimals these
are numbers that like are 12.88
or something with a decimal in them you
have integers which is like a whole
number
then you have longs which are also
integers but with a greater range you
have your guids or your uids and these
are
unique values so it's like a random
hash there that you have and the idea is
just so that you have unique values but
they're not like one two three four five
so people can't guess the size of your
tables then you have reels these are
double position floating point numbers
so these are really really big num
numbers something you probably use if
you're doing um
things with uh finance or numbers then
you have strings and these are unicode
strings and they're limited by default
to one megabyte and the way you do them
is you have them wrapped in quotations
we have that hello world you have time
spans these are interesting these are
little time intervals represented so
like 2d would equal 2 days 30 m would
equal 30 minutes one tick would equal
100 nanoseconds and they have a variety
of those
then you have dynamic and this is a
special type that can do a bunch of
things so it can accept primitive scalar
data types so the idea is it's kind of
like a
data type that can accept any value
or it can accept an array of any value
or it can accept a property bag which
you know if you're from the javascript
world looks like a json object so you
have a key and value and it can even be
nested and then last which is a data
type but you're not setting these as
your columns which is the null and
that's a special value that represents a
missing value and any of these data
types can be a null value so like you
look at boolean it can be true false or
null and date time can be a date time or
date or null and that goes for all of
them
[Music]
let's talk about cousteau control
commands this is really part of the uh
kql language but it's a way of kind of
working with the the databases and
tables and stuff like that if you've
ever used postgres and you've done like
forward slash
du or you have these commands that
didn't really have to do necessarily
querying but like managing the databases
and tables and stuff that's what uh
control commands are so i'll give an
example so here we have a control
command to create acousto table so they
always start with a period so period
create table logs and then it makes two
columns and that when you're using the
query um like log analytics and stuff
like that you just type period and then
start typing it
and it'll show you all the list of
control commands it was really hard to
find the documentation a full list
otherwise i would have picked some out
for you
but generally you can just kind of
explore that way or the most common ones
you're going to come across is all going
to be in the documentation
even though there's a very long list of
control commands a very common one
you're going to be using a lot is show
so for example we can do dot show tables
and then count the number of tables
there are and so i just want to show you
that if you type dot show
it'll show you what it can take as a
second parameter
and there's a huge list there so just an
idea like how you can work the control
commands
[Music]
take a look here at custom functions and
these are reusable queries or query
parts and kusa supports several kinds of
functions the first being stored
functions which are user-defined
functions and these are stored and
managed as one kind of database schema
entity
then just to define user user-defined
functions uh one step further they come
in two categories we have scalar
functions so these uh have input scalar
data types and output scalar data types
and then tabular functions so these
uh take input tabular data and they
output tabular data tabular data is just
when you're working with multiple rows
in a table
then you have query defined functions
which are also user defined functions
and uh that are defined and used within
the scope of a single query so very
similar to stored functions but
they're it's all based on scope okay
uh then the last on our list here is
built-in functions which are hard-coded
and these are defined by cousteau and
cannot be modified users and they just
give you a lot of utility let's take a
look at some of these built-in functions
starting with special functions so
select cousteau entities so you might
want to say i want to select a cluster
and then i want to select a database and
then that table
then you have aggregate functions which
perform calculations on a set of values
and return a single value so
maybe you want to do a count so you see
where it says count and parentheses
then you have windows functions and
these operate on multiple rows and
records in a row
in a row and so one really popular one
is row number and so this could count
the number of rows maybe you have to
figure out the row numbers in relation
to your query
and so that's something you could do
there
[Music]
let's take a look at some scalar
operators and there's quite a few here
and these are for working with scalar
data types to do comparisons
and there's a bunch of different
categories so let's just uh quickly go
through them here the first one one is
bitewise operators that's where you're
working with zeros and ones and flipping
them around to do different things so
you've got the binary end the not the or
the shift left the shift right uh the
xor and these make a lot of sense if you
know how to work with binary math if you
don't don't worry about them but i just
want you to know if you do they're
they're there for you use next are
logical operators so this is what you're
going to be more familiar with like
equality so equals in equal
and or or so this is pretty darn simple
then you have date time and time span uh
arithmetic
and so
we have add or subtract date times you
can do that you can add subtract divide
or multiple time span so add one day
plus two day makes three days
uh yeah then you have numerical
operators and these work on inch longs
and reals
so you can add subtract multiply and
divide you can do module where it's
determining whether it's a whole number
or not so or divisible by a whole number
so like let's say you have 17 and you
put it through there you say module
17 by like modulus 2
if it's not divisible by two like
perfectly resolves into zero it will
return either zero or one then you have
less greater equal not equal uh less or
equal than
uh greater or equal so you got the idea
there equals to one of the elements so
that's in so you do the in it's very
familiar if you're used to using sql
then you have the opposite where you put
an exclamation in front of it actually
there's a lot of extra operators that
just have the same thing with an
explanation to mean the opposite
especially with string operators
so here's a bunch of string operators
and they almost all have exclamations uh
a variant with explanation in front of
them then you have your between
operators this matches the input
that is inside an inclusive range so you
can say between 1 and 10 or between
these date times so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at cousteau tabular
operators and i really want you to pay
attention to this one because this is
where all the power of kql happens so
these perform comparisons against a
bunch of rows that's why it's called
tabular operators
and there's a lot of them and we're
going to look at the most common ones
because it would take me forever to go
through all of them and you're not going
to remember them all so let's just look
at the ones we actually care about
working with so the first is count this
returns the count of rows in the table
then you have take this returns up to a
specified number of rows of data you
have sort this uh will
take the rows of the input into the
order
by one or more columns you see buy
damage property descending so let's just
sort
then you have project returns a specific
set of columns and where filter a table
to subset of rows that satisfy
a predicate before we move on the next
slide i just want to point out like if
you've worked with sql
these are very familiar right like take
is like limit sort is like order by pro
project is like select okay
moving on to the next one here we have
top returns the first and records sorted
by uh specified columns this is kind of
like a shorthand i think it like makes
uh take and sort and just abbreviates it
to one line you have extend creates a
new column by computing a value so
notice that it says duration equals n
time minus start time and then we're
using duration somewhere else then you
have summarize aggregate groups of rows
that's kind of like group by
in
regular sql and then render so renders
results as a graphical output and to me
that's a really cool one
[Music]
moving on to metrics we're going to be
looking at metrics explorer so message
explorer is a subservice of azure
monitor allows you to plot charts
visualize correlating trends and
investigates spikes and dips in metric
values so the idea is you can create a
really cool graph like that and you can
make a variety of different ones based
on how you want to chart it out let's
talk about how would we define one of
these metric visualizations in metric
explorer so you got this cool bar and
the idea is you got to fill it all the
way to the end and then that will
visualize it for us the first is the
scope so you're going to open this up
and it's going to allow you to um select
resources so it'll show you like
subscription and stuff like that and
resource resource groups but always
makes you select a resource at the at
the end and some services you can select
multiple resources and some you can only
select a single instance so the storage
account there it's only going to be a
single one there so i had one called
davestrom institute i made
and then there you're going to choose a
namespace so this is a specific group of
metric data within a resource so notice
like it makes sense for a storage
account that would show account blob
file queue table it's going to vary
based on your service then you actually
have the metric you care about so we
have availability uh
aggress ingress etc and a bunch of other
things you're going to choose one of
those and then you choose how you want
to aggregate aggregate it so average min
max etc and again this is going to be
totally different based on what
resources you choose but that's
generally how it works
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure alerts
and this helps us be notified when there
are issues found within the
infrastructure or application and this
allows us to identify address issues
before the users of your system notice
them and so they come in three flavors
we've got metric alerts log alerts and
activity log alerts and when alert is
triggered you can be notified or have it
take action so here is kind of the
anatomy of an alert and we have the
alert rule this defines who we should
monitor like the the service and uh
uh
like the the definition of when it is
triggered which is going to be the next
part here so a resource such as a
virtual machine designated as the target
resource will emit signal so it's going
to be emitting a data payload and it
could be of the following types could be
a metric a log activity log application
insights you can kind of see how that
ties to the types of alerts then you
have the criteria or logical tests this
gets evaluated and determines are we in
a triggered state it could be like
percentage cpu greater than 70 percent
then you have your action group which
contains actions um and those actions uh
will be uh performed when it is
triggered and actions could be things
like run uh run an automation run book
use azure functions itsm logic app web
hooks or secure web hook
on the other side there we have um this
box over here and this is all about the
state of your alert
and so we have monitor conditional alert
state so monitor's condition is set by
the system an alert state is set by the
user but the idea that is there
is so you can define where it is because
you might want to
have a history of saying okay i've
resolved this issue so i'm marking this
as closed and that'd be like an alert
state there and so there you go
[Music]
this is probably not going to be on your
exam but it's super cool to show and
it's only one slide away so let's talk
about it which are azure dashboards
these are virtual workspaces to quickly
launch tasks for data for day-to-day
operations and monitor resources and
build custom dashboards based on
projects tasks or user roles so the idea
is you can go in here and you have like
this little tile uh editor and you can
drag stuff over so you can see i can
build like a video in and a link to the
help support and put a clock and some
metrics i care about and some markdown
so it's a really good way of building
out these customized dashboards based on
a user role to really help you focus on
what you have to deal with
within your infrastructure on azure
[Music]
let's take a look at azure workbooks
just because this is in the scope of
azure monitors so we should cover it so
workbooks provide a flexible canvas for
data analysis and the creation of rich
visual reports within the azure portal
to allow you to tap into multiple data
sources from azure and combine them into
a unified interactive experience
and so the key word here is story it
tells a story about the performance and
availability about your applications and
services
so this thing kind of looks like a
dashboard but it isn't and it's highly
customizable but it's not very clear in
here but really what it is it's like
it's like the form of a document and the
idea is that imagine that you have a
document and then you can embed
analytics in it
that are real-time analytics so that you
can visualize uh uh and and kind of
investigate and discuss performance and
availability and stuff like that you can
kind of think of it like if you ever
worked with jupiter notebooks but it's
really for performance and monitoring
um it's kind of like that okay and these
things are highly customizable and
really useful and uh if you ever use
datadog databa dog has its own thing i
think they call them notebooks as well
they have workbooks they're called
notebooks it's the same thing but it's a
really great tool for
really understanding your your
performance
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure monitor cheat
sheet this one's a three parter so let's
jump into it azure monitors
comprehensive solution for collecting
analyzing and acting as telemetry for
your cloud on-premise environments and
even though i don't have it in the slide
here it is an umbrella service i mean
there's a lot of things underneath this
and that's why we have three pages of
information and create visual dashboards
smart alerts automated actions log
monitoring
to obtain observability you need to know
metrics logs and traces you can have use
them all together using them in isolate
but that does not give you observability
metrics is a number that is measured
over a period of time logs as a text
file that contains event data which was
happening and traces is a history of
requests that that travels through
multiple apps and services
so we can pinpoint performance or
failures
azure monitor collects two fundamental
types of data from sources logs and
metrics which kind of matches up with
our
theoretical information here right so
azure monitor logs collects and
organizes log and performance data for
monitoring resources data logs are
consolidated from different sources into
workspaces platform logs and azure
services logs and performance data and
virtual machine agents usage and
performance data for applications can be
consolidated in a workspace you can be
analyzed they can be analyzed together
using a sophisticated query language
which we'll talk about here in a moment
or review i suppose um
work with log queries and their results
uh interactively using log analytics
azure monitor metrics collects and
that's the second part here right so the
two fundamentals azure monitor metrics
collects new numeric data from monitored
uh resources in a time series database
messages are new numerical values
collected at regular intervals and
describe some aspects of a system at a
particular time lightweight and capable
of supporting near-real-time scenarios
useful for learning and fast detection
of issues you can analyze them in
interactively via the metrics explorer
onto page two log analytics is a tool in
the azure portal used to edit and run
log queries with data in the azure
monitor logs login elixirs use the
language called q
kql
log analytics uh i think that's cousteau
right so log analytics workspace is a
unique environment for the monitor logs
data each workspace has its own data
repository and configuration data
sources and solutions are configured to
store in their workplace and i really
wish i put the word data like in here
it's not important for uh the associate
but for other exams it helps you
understand if you think of it as a data
lake azure monitor logs is based on the
azure data explorer and log queries are
written using the cousteau query
language
kql can be used in a log analytics log
alert rules workbooks azure dashboards
and all over the place kosovo is based
on a relational database management
system so you'll see database tables and
columns some query operations include
calculated columns searching and
filtering on rows grouped by aggregates
joint functions if you're used to using
sql you know what i'm talking about
cousteau queries execute in the context
of some cousteau database that is
attached to acousto cluster crystal is
generally composed of the following
entities clusters database tables
columns functions let's talk about them
quickly here
clusters are entities that hold
databases databases are are named
entities that hold tables and stored
functions stored functions are named
entities that allow reuse
queries or query parts tables are named
entities that hold data columns are
named entities that hold scalar data
types and then you have external tables
which are identities that reference data
stored outside the cousteau database
these both count as tables that's why
it's not in the list up here
but generally these are pretty
self-explanatory
metric explorers is a sub-service of
azure monitor that allows you to plot
charts visualize correlating trends and
investigate spikes and dips in the
metrics values to visualize the metric
you need to define the scope the
namespace the metric and the aggregation
we're on to the last page here
alerts and notify you when issues are
found within your infrastructure or
application they allow you to identify
address issues before the users or
system notice them azure has three kinds
of alerts metrics logs and activity
log alerts
sorry there is a diagram if you remember
our follow along i actually break down
all the uh
structure of
an alert you should go review that i
didn't put in the cheat sheet because it
just would have been too much here
azure dashboards are a virtual workspace
to quickly launch tasks for day-to-day
operations and monitor resources azure
workbooks provide a flexible canvas for
data analysis and the creation of rich
visual reports within the azure portal
it tells it and just to highlight what
azure workbooks are for it tells the
story about the performance availability
about your applications and services
then we have application insights and
this is an application performance
management an apm service and it is a
subservice of azure monitor that's why
all these things are under azure monitor
automatically detects performance
anomalies includes powerful analytics
tools to help you diagnose issues to
understand what users do with your app
designed to help you continuously
improve performance and usability works
for apps on the dotnet node.js java
python hosted on premise hybrid and
public cloud works everywhere basically
integrates with your devops processes
can monitor and analyze telemetry from
mobile apps by integrating the visual
studio app center to use application
insights you need to instrument your
application
to instrument you need to install the
instrument package sdk or enable
application insights using application
insight agents when supported apps can
be instrumented from anywhere when you
set up your application insights
monitoring for your web app you create
an application insight resource into
azure monitor
you open the resource in the azure
portal to
order in order to see an analyze
telemetry uh collected from your app and
last the resource is identified by the
information instrumentation key the ik
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure api
management so this integrates existing
back-end services into modern api
gateways and uh this service uh there's
a lot to it so we're going to be doing
quite a bit here maybe more than we have
to but it is a very powerful service
especially if you're trying to be a
developer on azure so we're going to
just make sure we spent a good amount of
time with it so it follows the api
approach of decoupling the front end and
back-end teams with the help of api
mocking
the azure api management handles the
full management of your apis it
centralizes
the securing versioning documentation
and compliance from your backend
services in a single endpoint so very
powerful tool but let's get to it
[Music]
so let's go over uh key concepts or key
components of api management i do not
have a fancy visual for this it's just
very hard to visualize but uh we will
learn all this stuff as we go through it
so let's talk about what we have here so
we have an api that represents a set of
operations
api operation which connects an api
endpoint to its back end we have a
product which is a logical grouping of
apis
a single or group of apis make up a
product so this is how your apis are
presented to developers so it can either
be public or private we have a backend
that represents backend services in your
api
there are groups these are used to
manage the visibility of products to
developers such as administrators who
have full access to the api management
developers for users with access to the
developers portal with permissions to
build applications guests users without
access to the developer portal portal
but with the reading permissions and
some services
there's the idea of developers so this
belongs to a product group and each
developer has a primary secondary key to
call that products api there are
policies uh
configurations and validations that are
applied
in progress to incoming requests and a
com responses which you will see
in closer detail in the upcoming slides
there are name values so these are key
value pairs used with policies values
can be a result of an expression uh
there are gateways so this is where your
api calls it and are received and
policies are applied to incoming
requests then there's the developer
portal so this is where developers can
access all the apis and products listed
by your apim alongside the api's
operations documentation developers can
also request access to your apis from
the developer portal but again uh we'll
figure this out as we go through okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
echo api service so when you create
uh apim gateway that's the first thing
you'll do you'll get by default uh this
thing called echo api and i was like
whoa what is this thing i wasn't sure
what it was
and i thought it was kind of interesting
that's why i expand upon it here which i
didn't really see much of it in the
documentation so i had to
piece things together but the idea is
that echo api provides a bunch of
existing endpoints and these are mocked
endpoints to a non-production azure
service used to test azure api
management so you know if you don't have
an api yet but you want to interact with
it it's going to go to the service
called
echoapi.cloudapp.net forward slash api
and again it's just a dummy a dummy
application to test against so that's
what that is so if you see it you don't
need it you can absolutely delete it but
you always get one when you create a
gateway okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
feature comparison for
apim because it's one of those services
where there's a lot of features but
they're not always available to you
depending on what plan subscription what
kind of user you are so let's take a
look at how the features change based on
uh what plan you're using so across the
top we have consumption developer basics
standard and premium red is what's not
available for that particular plan green
is what is
so for azure ad we do not have it for
consumption or basic
for virtual network support it's just
it's just not supported for consumption
basic and standard
for multi-region deployment availability
zones we're only getting that for
premium for multiple custom domains
premium as well and also for developer
developer portal the built-in cache and
built-in analytics are not available in
the consumption plan if you want a
self-hosted gateway better be on the
premium basically almost developer
always says yes because you have to play
around with things right
um so tls settings is for everyone
external caches for everyone client
certificate authentication policies are
for everyone which is very generous back
in restore you're not going to get in
the consumption
model and that's not all we got a few
more here so if you want management over
get direct management api azure monitor
logs and metrics static ip or web
sockets api you're not getting those in
the consumption model now graph api
graph graphql
api is available for all of them so
there you go
all right let's take a look at api
authentication so in order to
authenticate with their apis we
configure those settings under our
subscription setting so it's as simple
as doing a checkbox there so if this
description is required only developers
with a valid access key can use it and
so the idea here is we can configure
where the api will receive
those access keys which can be sent as
the header or query string
so there are some options there if this
thing is not checked then that means
anyone that is anonymous has request
requests will be allowed so it's as
simple as having that checkbox there and
having a key so there you go
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
groups for apim so groups are used to
manage the visibility of products to
developers and so we can break these
down into some broad categories we have
administrators so they manage api
management service instances and create
the api's operations and products that
are used by developers then we have
developers they are authenticated for
the developer portal the users that
build applications using uh your apis
developers are granted access to the
developer portal and build applications
that call the operations of an api then
you have guests so these are
unauthenticated developer portal users
such as prospective customers visiting
the developer portal they can be granted
certain read-only access such as the
ability to view apis but not call them
so administrators can also create custom
groups or use external groups in an
associated azure active directory tenant
to give developers visibility and access
to api products a user can belong to
more than one group so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
front ends and backhand starting with
front end so front ends to find the
route or end point and the documentation
configuration around that endpoint so
the idea here is we have front end and
we have a
single method here uh which is post
forward slash resource
and if we were to open that up you can
see that we have i'm just getting my pen
tool out here we have a description for
our documentation the display name the
name
of i can't remember what the difference
for the name is but it's called create
resource we can set its url that's
method and then down below we have
additional parameters so api
does not host apis but it creates
facades for your apis that's a key thing
to remember api so api management it
does not host apis it's created facade
for your apis
so let's take a look at the back end so
for back ends you can set the following
types you can set a custom url so point
to a server where your service is
running you can say to go to azure
resources integrate directly with a
resource such as azure functions app
service container wrap logic app i'm
just missing the p there but it's two
p's
so you have the idea up here where we
can see custom url azure resource azure
service fabric okay
we have some additional options here so
we can authorize credentials
that present requests credentials to the
backend service
there are options like headers so that's
http headers we can fetch
from named values we can query based on
query string you can fetch from name
values there as well
you have control of client certificates
so x 509 certificate certificates which
we do talk about in this course
which are stored in azure key vault
which is the section that we're talking
about there so you're just seeing those
options headers queries and client
certificates
but yeah there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
policies for apim so api management
policies allow you to change the
behavior in multiple stages of your
endpoints request lifecycle you can
update any part of the request response
message such as the headers bodies urls
and there are four areas where policies
can be applied we have inbound for
incoming requests backend before
requests reach your backend outbound
before sending responses back to the
client and error when a request
encounters an error just to kind of
visualize it we have our front end
incoming processing backend outbound
processing and so the idea is that
here
for the inbound processing that's where
we have policies apply that's the one
they're talking about right here
and then we have for the back end so
before requests reach your backend
fbm processing and then uh error is not
visualized because it would be whenever
an error would occur
here okay azure has a collection of
policy groups which contain many
policies you can apply and we got a big
list here we have access restriction
policies advanced authentication caching
cross-domain transformation dapper
integration validation policies graphqls
there's a lot of great policies
that we can already utilize
when an error occurs no other policies
are applied except the error policies
however other policies were in effect
prior to the error they will not be
removed
product level policies apply to all api
operations within a product so now let's
go take a look at an example of a policy
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a quick look here
at a policy example so you're going to
see uh this policy here
and we're doing it right on the echo api
so this is for an outbound policy to
cache the response in a get operation
i believe that all those
policies are in the documentation you
can easily copy and paste them in uh we
do do a follow along for policies that
was something i definitely covered i
just don't remember if it was part of
the system or
i mean it must be because it says here
retrieve resource cash but anyway the
idea here is that um this policy stuff
is in an xml language
um not super important to learn what it
is but the fact is is that there is a
lot of available policies available for
us so we can pretty much copy paste and
figure it out from there
if that is clear and here is kind of
another visualization that i just want
to show you
relating to our policies here uh just
because it kind of maps up my little
graphic where we have the front end the
inbound processing the outbound
processing here but if you notice here
it says policies i know it's really
small but you can see it says base cache
lookup rewrite url and here it says base
and then cash store so the idea is you
can see what policies are being
applied there so there you go
[Music]
all right so what we're going to do here
is look at all the possible
policy groups that are provided by
azure uh it might say policy groups i
mean the policies within those policy
groups so you get an idea of what kind
of policies you can do to transform
manipulate
filter
during a transit of a request from a
response through apim and we're not
going to look at all the code examples
but i'll pull out a couple per
policy group here
we're starting with access restriction
policy so the first is check http header
so enforce existence or value of http
header then we have limit call rate by
subscriptions that prevents api usage
spikes by limiting call rate on a per
prescription basis that's pretty cool
when you look at other providers like
aws where they have api gateway there's
like a fixed limit on there i don't
remember there being any kind of policy
to do that so i like how you have the
flexibility there to choose hopefully
it's on there by default in that base i
don't know limit call rate by keys or
prevent api uses spikes by limiting call
rate on per key basis restrict caller ip
so filter so allow deny calls from
specific api addresses or add an address
range
that could prove very useful set usage
quota by subscription so allow
use allows you to enforce a renewable or
lifetime call volume and or bandwidth
quota on a per subscription basis set
usage quota by key so allows you to
enforce a renewable or lifetime call
volume and or ban with quota on a per
key basis validate jwt so enforces
existence and validity of a jwt
javascript web token yeah extracted from
either a specified http header or a
specified query parameter gwt is very
common for authentication of
client-side applications validate client
certificates so enforces that a
certificate presented by a client to an
api management instance matches
specified validation rules and claims
let's take a look at that restricted
caller ip
very very simple we define ipfilter we
have an action the ip address that is
allowed in this case or a range so that
one is again very simple these are not
hard to figure out we have validate jwt
um so there
there is some stuff there and uh it is
what it is okay um so we'll go on to
advanced policy so here we have control
flow so
conditionally applies policy statements
based on the evaluation of bool
expressions
forward request so forwards the request
to the backend service
limit concurrency so prevents enclosed
policies from executing by more than the
specified number of requests at a time
log to event hub so sends messages in
the specified format to a message target
defined by a logger entity
emit metrics so send custom metrics to
application insights and execution mock
response so aborts pipeline execution
returns a mocked response directly to
the caller retry
retries execution of the enclosed policy
statements and if
and until the condition is met execution
will repeat at the specified time
intervals and up to the specified retry
count return response so aborts pipeline
execution and returns the specified
response directly to the caller let's
take a look at limit concurrency that
seems like a good one to have
so here we have an inbound
then we define our back end we set our
limit concurrency it's setting the
forward request to a timeout of 120 so
preventing close policies from executing
by more than specified number of request
time we have mock response that one
would be very very useful uh you know
like you just want to you know you don't
want to have a real response you just
want to put whatever you want in there
so it gives it back a status 200 for
application json
more more advanced policies here so send
one-way request send a request to a
specified url without waiting for
response
send request send a request to specify
url
send http proxy so allow you to route
forward
forward request via http proxy set
variable persist a value in that name
context variable for later access so
here's an example one where we're
setting that variable so we're saying is
it mobile and we want to know is it
mobile so the idea is it'll take that
value from that agent and then we'll
have that variable available for us to
determine was the request mobile
we have wait so wait for enclose send
requests get value from cash or control
policies to complete before proceeding
set request method allow you to change
the hp method for a request set status
code changes http http status code to
the specified value trace adds custom
traces into the api inspector output
application insight telemetries and
resource
blogs
looking at authentication policies and i
don't know why that's highlighting oh
you know i probably have a graphic above
it that's why um so we have authenticate
with basics so authenticate with basic
service using basic authentication very
common for test environments
authenticate with client certificates so
authenticate with a back back end
service using client certificate
authenticate with managed identity very
popular use case um for
for azure services so authenticate the
backend service using managed identity
so there's an example basic auth that's
a username password you've probably seen
it if you've ever got a site where they
just give you like kind of like an alert
you have to enter those two in and for
this one you can see that it's going to
vault
for the managed identity
caching policies so get from cash
perform cash look up and return a valid
cash response when available probably
very popular policy to be used store to
cash cash response according to
specified cash control configuration get
value from cash retrieve a cash item by
key
store value in cash store an item in the
cash by key remove value from cash
remove an item in the cash by key so
here the examples obviously very big for
get from cash but here it says uh
um vary by developer cash key lookup so
i guess you're performing you're giving
it these things
now sometimes they're not always very
clear when you're reading them but
that's fine
uh for cash store values the store value
you provided a key
there is the value how the duration i'm
assuming is how long it lists for maybe
the ttl
cross-domain policies
so we allow cross-domain calls
this is something you probably really
really would want to enable especially
if you're building
applications that are not on the same
domain so i could see people using this
quite a bit makes the api accessible
from adobe flash microsoft's
silverlight browser-based clients did
not expect that as a description of
course i was thinking of cores that's
why ad cross origin resource sharing
support and operation or api allow
cross-domain calls i feel like this
one's going to happen a lot i didn't
know microsoft silverlight still existed
if people don't know silverlight is a
competitor adobe flash open i guess
adobe flash probably does html5 now i'm
just thinking of old fash flash players
jsonp adds json with padding support to
an operation for an api to allow
cross-domain calls from javascript
browser-based clients
so that is the cross-domain one very
simple
there's cores and if you've ever seen
cores this looks the same if you're on
aws if you're anywhere else it's the
same xml it looks the same
so it looks big but it's not as scary
and you'll come across it quite often
especially with apis
transformation policies convert json to
xml converts requests or response bodies
from json to xml convert xml to json
you get it find and replace a string and
a body mask url in the content
set backend service
set body these are very clear set http
header
set query string parameter
if you want to read these you can but
they're very straightforward rewrite url
that's probably a very popular one but
maybe the example is too large so i
don't show it here transform xml and x
xslt let's look at uh xml json because i
thought that one was kind of interesting
so you say xml to json
and i guess it just turns it into json
http header is something very common
that you'll be doing
you can just set a header for whatever
values need to pass along
we have zapper integration policies so
send requests to a service
send message to pub subtopic
trigger output binding and there's an
example of a trigger output binding
validation policies this last group
validate content validate parameters
validate headers validate status code
validate graphql request
so we'll take a look at parameters so
here's an example where
we have a parameter and it says prevent
prevent
um
detect detect
uh prevent ignore ignore ignore so i
guess the idea is it's just saying like
if those parameters are present allow
them if not ignore them validate status
code i figured this would be like a
little bit more interesting this one but
it's not
status code so prevent
unspecified status code action so do not
allow it to have an unspecified
code action
i i didn't know that that's possible i
thought you all status codes are always
returned but uh you know i guess you're
learning something new every day but
those are all the policy groups and
hopefully you get an idea of policies
you can apply because that's what that's
the greatest power of api is those
policies okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at different
ways we can define apis within apim so
the idea here is that you're ready uh to
create an api you have a gateway you
want to create an api
so you hit that add new api button you
got a bunch of options here so you can
define one
manually the http endpoints web sockets
graphql
of course that's going to vary what you
want
sockets is great for real time stuff
maybe you're making a video game maybe
you're making a chat app graphql is
becoming a popular alternative to
rest based applications like standard
endpoints so graphql
allows you to define a query to query
data
um you know personally it's not my
favorite but i like the fact that it's
all rolled up under one
api gateway in api in azure
the next thing is we can define based on
a schema standard for importing defining
apis we have open api version three
wadl wsdl
and the the latter two i don't know much
about and so um following this
uh video we're gonna go talk about these
three standards here um because i do
think it's important to know all those
three because that's the real way you're
gonna really get uh apis into here
you're not really gonna be doing it
manually
and the last one is really great if you
want to spin up an api that you know you
want to integrate right away very common
ones would be
app service
actually i guess all three of them
really to be honest logic app or app
service or function app and i'm pretty
sure in this we will show you with
function app in the follow along there
so those are some options there just to
get quickly started but let's take a
deeper look at these um
open definition standards for defining
apis and then importing them starting
with open api
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at open
api so here is an example of one written
in yaml i have a feeling that it can
also be done in json but just taking a
quick look here you can kind of get an
idea you have paths
that is an endpoint or uh yeah a method
if you want the method that to be used
would be posts here you can provide a
summary description the contents should
it be application json schema
information
and what responses should come back so
pretty straightforward it gets a little
more complicated than that but that is
the best snapshot i can provide to you
of that language so open api
specification oas defines a standard
language agnostic interface to restful
apis which allows both humans and
computers to discover and understand the
capabilities of the service without
access to source code documentation or
through network traffic inspection and
open api is really the leading one this
is what pretty much everybody uses
nowadays no matter what cloud service
provider you go to they're going to have
an option for their api gateway to
import open api swagger and open api
used to be the same thing but as of
version three of open api swagger and
open api are two different things so
open api is a specification swagger are
tools for implementation
for the specification if you want to use
i think it's like swagger it's by
bearsmart and bearsmart i believe is the
one that came up with open api to begin
with
um and so open api can be represented as
either json or yaml as i said earlier
but there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at wadl and wsdl
they're very similar that's why we're
giving them one slide together so web
application description language wadl
and then web service description
language wsdl these are specifications
defined by the web consort consortism
uh was it w3 w3g w3 something w3 w3c
probably and i believe that wadl was
originally made by sun microsystems i
don't know who made wsdl but it
definitely is under the w3c and here's
an example of wsdl
very
very very heavy because it's all xml
most people like json yaml that's why
open api is so popular but just take a
look here at wadl and wsdl the idea is
that you will have some things that are
similar so
with wadl you define an application for
wsdl
the equivalent is definition here we
have grammars here we have types here we
have resource here we have interface
method operation
request response input output param
element param simple type to me wadl
looks more
like a uh
like how we would describe in terms of
terminology i cannot remember
which one is more advanced because one
has more capabilities than the others
but to be honest you're not going to be
using any of these you're going to be
using open api but i just wanted to show
you them and the fact that you can
translate their xml over
to that there in this table so hopefully
that gives you kind of an idea there you
go
let's take a look at the developer
portal so the developer portal is an
automatically generated fully
customizable website with the
documentation of your apis it's where
api consumers can discover your apis
learn how to use them request access to
try them out so here is an example of
the default one that you get to be
honest i did not know how to use this
i tried really hard because i thought it
was a very cool idea this is actually
the second iteration of the developer
portal so there was an older one
that was different from this but this is
the new one and i like the idea but in
execution i'm not sure exactly what to
do here but the idea here is you need to
publish you'll need to publish for the
developer portal to be publicly viewable
you can save revisions of the portal to
quickly roll back to previous versions
you can apply custom domain for your
developer portal so idea here is uh you
know there's
on the portal overview to see it there's
a link there that you click and that's
how you view it
not available in the consumer plan
available in all the other plans i guess
the idea behind the developer portal is
like if you're trying to sell a cloud
service but it's api driven and they
just pay access the developer portal
or i guess it's also to read the
documentation for people that need to
utilize it
but yeah in theory i like the idea
execution i don't know
[Music]
all right so uh there is authentication
for the developer portal that you can
set there's a few different ways to do
it you can do active directory b2c
identity providers like google microsoft
facebook basic authentication which is
the default version if you're not
familiar with basic auth the idea is you
can enter a username and password that
gets prompted to you
um so not super complicated there's also
delegated authentication which allows
you to use your own web app sign in sign
up process product subscription instead
of the built-in developer portal
built-in functionality
and just to figure out where that is
under the developer portal you have
identities you could add those you can
see there's delegation down below
so not super complicated
but yeah there is authentication for the
api and then there's authentication for
the developer portal so just make sure
you understand the distinction of those
two because it does get a bit confusing
[Music]
let's talk about caching so we have a
built-in cache and an external cache so
api and operations in the api management
can be configured via response caching
we were looking at policies we had an
indicator as to how caching works
response caching can significantly
reduce latency for api callers and
backend load for api providers so we're
gonna just provide a caching policy to
the outbound or other places built-in
cache is volatile and is shared by all
units the same region in the api
management service so for that reason
you have the ability to set an external
cache via redis
so that would be using
azure's reddit cache service
so using external cache allows you to
overcome the few limitations of built-in
cache so avoid having your cache
periodically cleared during api
management updates have more control
over your cache configuration
cache more data than your api management
tier allows
using cache with the consumption tier of
api management enable caching in the api
management for self-hosted gateways you
simply need to provide a connection
string to your redis cache
so there you go
[Music]
all right so after a really really
really long wait like 40 minutes and i
was able to do like so many other follow
alongs while waiting
um this is ready so
very long time 30 40 minutes we'll go to
the resource here
and so we have this environment set up
and we're gonna have to uh actually have
something to route to
and so the idea is that we want to set
up a container app and so
before we can uh go ahead and do that
we're going to need to create a
container app so what you'll do is open
a new tab
all right and we're going to search for
containers and then we have contain oops
container apps and so what we'll do is
go ahead and open that
and then from there we'll go ahead and
create ourselves a new container
application
container app is a little bit better
than container instances i don't know if
this came afterwards it just serves a
different purpose but
container apps is pretty nice so what
we'll do is say uh we'll create or
actually we don't need to create one but
we'll use the same namespace
so my apim
and we will call this one um
my container
doesn't really matter what we call it
for the region of
does this have a region or is this a
global service feels like it should be a
global service
i don't think we chose the region so
central u.s i'm just going to stick to
the same thing just in case
just a good way when you're doing labs
and we're gonna start with a simple
hello world container so we're just
gonna make it super easy for us
don't have to do any coding to get an
application running we're gonna go ahead
and do create
and so now we just need to wait for that
to deploy it shouldn't take too long so
i'll see you back here in a moment
all right so after waiting i don't know
like four or five minutes it looks like
our environment is set up or our
container is deployed so we clicked into
it and there should be uh there it is
application url so we just open that a
new tab you should see this and that is
what we're going to try
to route to for
apim
so what we'll do is make our way back
over to apim we'll go ahead and create a
container app and here we can go browse
and select our container
so to make it super super simple for us
super easy as you can see i'm going to
look at full for a second to see if
there's anything interesting there
nothing that i care about we'll go ahead
and hit create
so yeah they make it really really easy
and so once the that's configured we
just need to observe that this api
actually works
so we'll give it a moment
okay there we go so after a few minutes
there it is so let's just test that our
api is working now this web app is an
html page so it's not really what we'd
want to return but it's the easiest
example that we can set up here uh so
i'm going to go to the get request here
and from there i'm going to go to test
and we are going to see it's going to
send a request here notice that it's
sending the subscription key so this is
what we normally have to pass along
which is over here we'll do that in a
different follow along here we'll go
ahead and hit send
and we'll give it a moment
and we get some data back so it's the
html page it's what we're looking for
welcome to azure container app so that
is great so we're done here we'll keep
this environment around for the next few
follow alongs but there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown and we are
continuing on with apim and uh this time
around what we want to do is actually
work with some subscription keys because
here
we are just hitting the button that's
not how we're going to use our api right
so um let's go over and set up a new
product before we do that i'll go over
to subscriptions let's just show you
that we do have some keys here and
notice there's one called service we
came with a product and unlimited one
but the service one is actually being
used uh in our apim so when we were
testing that was the key that it was
using so if we go back to apis
and we could click into our here my
container and we go to get
somewhere here
if we go around click around here
settings
test down below
send i think gives us some information
so we'll know what key it's using
so here
we can see the key somewhere
or it should tell us i do know that's
using the service key
i can't remember how i know that but i
know it okay
and so um the idea is that we want to
create our own key i guess at some point
but we'll go for product and we'll make
a new one i'm going to call this
developers
actually call it junior developers
because originally was developers but
i'm just going to do junior developers
just so we're not conflicting we'll hit
publish so that's okay
and we need to add our api so here we'll
choose my container we'll go ahead and
create it so we'll just say for junior
developers even though it's going to
really have full access
and this is the way that you can like um
catalog out your apis or or assign them
to different groups so it's a good way
to organize your stuff is to create them
in products
and so if we click into here you can see
that there's apis that's assigned we can
assign policies if we want globally for
everything we can change we have some
settings for access controls and we have
um subscriptions
so we do already have the subscription
key we don't have to go and create a new
one
um but we should probably look at access
controls because right now it's just set
up as administrator access we're gonna
go ahead ahead here and add another one
called developers i believe you can add
or create your own groups
but it's not super complicated so
there's no point in really talking about
it we do want to go get the primary key
for this so here what i want you to do
is click into here
and oops actually that's not what i want
there was nothing to change i don't know
why i hit save there that was pointless
but what we'll do is go back to junior
developers here back in the products
here we'll do the subscription side here
because we need to see
the key which is here junior developers
so if we go here and say show keys now i
can get the primary key so we need that
key because we actually want to make an
api request and this time we're going to
use powershell for fun so i'm opening up
cloud shell up here in the top left
corner make sure it's set to powershell
it always doesn't hurt to learn some
powershell
we could do it in bash but let's do
powershell it's a bit easier to do that
and we'll give it a moment to spin up if
you're doing this for the first time it
might ask you to make a storage account
so you might have to press some buttons
here so just press whatever buttons it
wants to get to this part okay
and it doesn't normally take that long
to spin up there we go
so the first thing we're going to set is
a url i'm just waiting for it to give me
some
more information yep still going
there we go so we're going to set a new
variable whoops we'll type clear first
we'll type a new variable
and this needs to be well first we'll do
a subscription key because we already
have it in our clipboard subscription
key double quotations paste that in
it didn't actually grab it
so that's fine i guess we'll go grab
instead
from apim the
gateway url so we'll get the gateway url
that's the uh url that we need to get to
notices of the overview blade and their
apim app in order for us to uh
that's like the api endpoint you'd hit
right so we'll type in url
and we'll paste that in
it really doesn't like the right uh that
so we'll have to right-click paste
probably was working before for the
subscription url we just probably had to
right click
so we'll do subscription url equals
double quotations and we will grab this
key here again so i'm just going to
scroll on down here grab the primary key
you can use the secondary key but you
really
really don't need it so let's just paste
that in here
so there we go that looks like a key so
we'll hit enter
and now we need to set some headers
so i'm going to do at sign
uh
curly's
o
o p a p i m
subscription key
equals dollar sign subscription key
you're wondering what is all this stuff
here well um in powershell i believe
this is called a dictionary another
language they might call it a hash you
might think of a json object but it's
just a data structure that we need to
utilize in order to pass this along i'm
just double checking to make sure i
named it all correctly we'll hit enter
and now we'll use the powershell command
called invoke
web requests i'm hitting tab to
autocomplete it's really nice that it
does that it'll do that even for the
flag so i'll do url here we'll do method
i think we don't have to specify the
method because it'll already be get but
we'll do it anyway to be verbose we'll
do headers here we'll do headers and
we'll hit enter and we have access and i
do the missing subscription key
so
here we have a small little problem
uh so i just got to double check to see
what the mistake is you know what
i was staring at this thing like there's
something wrong here it's ocp
what ocp stands for i have no idea
well we'll hit enter and we'll try again
and maybe we'll just print out the
headers to make sure it's correct
there's no value in there so
we'll print out subscription key to make
sure that is correct
oh because i wrote subscription url
this is what happens when you don't type
okay so not a big deal
just learning a bit more as we go
and i just want to set that again and
then i'm going to print it out to make
sure it's correct there it is
and we'll invoke this and we should get
back
html
with 200.
so it says welcome to azure container
app so that's how you can do requests of
course that's with powershell
traditionally you might use postman or
you use your api like an api to do that
uh but there you go so yeah that is how
uh we work with a key we generate our
own subscription key and work work with
it to make a request
not in the ui
okay so i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
still working with apim and this time we
are going to
create a policy because policies are
some of the most powerful things that
api allows you to do so what i want you
to do is on the left hand side in our
our gateway that we created we'll go to
apis we'll go over to my container
and what we'll do is we'll just click
onto any of them like get container
actually i want to make a new one i'm
going to call a new one called mock
because we're going to do a mock request
so do forward slash mock
and if we go there and go ahead and
create this
so if we were to use this right now it
shouldn't do anything if we test this
what would we get back
we got a 404 not found because there's
no page there so what we'll do
is we'll go here
and we are going to go back to the
design and we're going to add our own
outbound process process so it doesn't
matter what comes in we're going to
always have a mock response come back
we're going to do that by adding a
policy so go add a policy you can see
there's some basic ones like setting
headers and things like that we're going
to go to other policies i'm going our
policy structure back and this is for
the outbound i don't know why we click
through that to get to this
but the idea is that we're going to add
a new policy here so what i'm going to
do is type in mock response apim policy
and i'm just looking for all the let or
all the ones here so here's a bunch of
policies and we're just looking for the
mach one
it's not a very uh um verbose or sorry
like very flexible one just basically
set the uh code but it does work so what
we'll do is just paste that on in there
and we'll say we want this to be a 200
and we can say whatever we want to get
back so like if we want a different type
i type like um
i don't know uh
csv file content type
it'd be text csv it doesn't matter we
can do whatever we want application ms
word right like
i'm not sure what would happen but let's
do it for fun
we could have just done javascript but
no let's make it complicated
and so now
if we were to go to this mock request
we're going to test it
and we'd send it let's see we get back
it says 200
mock and
i mean it doesn't complain about the
content type but let's just do this up
in cloud shell just to make sure that we
know what we're doing
so we were doing that before so we're
going to do it again
okay
it's good practice so we'll just test
our new endpoint make sure it works this
drag is sometimes weird so i clicked it
and then it's just like it's still
dragging it's very frustrating sometimes
you have to
freaking open it up like that so silly
but um yeah what we'll do is we'll just
do a bit of uh powershell again and uh
get this working so i'm just double
checking on how to do that so the first
thing is we need the url what if we hit
up oh we still have our stuff from
before so yeah you want to set a url for
the gateway you want to set
a subscription key from before to then
the last follow along and then we need
the headers
but it's slightly different here because
the url needs to be forward slash mock
and then what we can do is invoke a
request we get back at 200
so no issues there
so
there you go
uh that's all it takes to set a policy
there's obviously more complex policies
there but this is a simple example
because you really got to go digging
through these here and it's not really
worth it to do that unless you actually
do it for real
but there you go so what we'll do is
clean this up we're all done
with apim
look for that there
delete this
and
there you go so that is apim
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
something throughout this course that
keeps getting mentioned at least for the
az204 is distributed application runtime
or also known as dapper
and uh you know it's not going to show
up on any of the exams but the idea is
that uh it's good to know what it is it
is a microsoft thing that they had built
its
distributed application runtime short
for dapper provides an api that
simplifies microservice connectivity so
dapper is a portable event driven
runtime that makes it easy for any
developer to build resilient stateless
and stateful applications that run on
the cloud and edge and embrace the
diversity of the language and developer
frameworks and it's interesting they say
uh diversity of languages because it
doesn't support my favorite language
which is ruby yet it supports php kind
of explain that one to me but dapper
provides basically a bunch of
functionality so the idea is that you
are going to write your application code
up here like whatever language you want
and then the idea is that you can
communicate via a grpc or http
http ai or api to a bunch of standard
[Music]
services so like services service
invocation state management pub sub
resource binding triggers actors
observability secrets configuration and
allows you to connect to edge
infrastructure now
basically these are just basically
wrappers
so to speak for um uh you know
standard functionality that you'd want
to have alongside a microservice
application
dapper is not taking off as you would
think it is um i don't know anybody
that's really like that interested in
adopting it because it is
like
this thing is more in the cloud native
space like like kubernetes cncf
and the thing is is that unless there's
buy-in with that community and that this
is truly agnostic um you know
you're gonna have a hard time to see
adoption unless it meets those things it
just does not it's very interesting i
think it'd be really cool to build an
application on top of dapper for your
micro service applications but i
strongly doubt anyone would be using
this because the future of this project
is debatable but it is mentioned
throughout this course so i just wanted
to give you a little bit more attention
there we're definitely not going to dig
any code with dapper but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure event
grid which is a service that allows you
to manage event routing from any source
to any destination so event grid
provides a simple and strong
customizable event delivery process that
allows you to manage at a minimum level
which type of events will be received as
well as which subscribers will receive
those events so here is an example
graphic uh you can see event grid is
kind of sitting in the middle there
where um events are being captured and
being uh managed by event hub and it's
routing to other places
so event grid is ideal for event driven
architectures where you can subscribe to
azure resource events and publish them
to an event handler or web hook you can
also use custom topics to create custom
events that will be published in your
event grid
and it supports event fan out with
24-hour retry
reliability to ensure that events are
delivered it is a low-cost serverless
product that supports dynamic
scalability so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about event source and
handlers so azure event grid is divided
into two categories events sources of
services that emit data and event
handlers services that receive data and
in between them that is where event grid
is so let's talk about um what there is
that can uh emit sources and this will
just give you an idea of how
much event grid can integrate with azure
services so we have blob storage
resource groups subscriptions event hub
media service iot hub service bus azure
maps azure container registry signal r
azure app configuration azure machine
learning azure communication services
azure cash for redis
cloud events azure policy
and custom events so basically anything
you want to get in there and i'm sure
there's more data support for other
services but as you can see we're
limited for space
but it can
receive messages from a lot of places
for event handlers the services that
receive data it could be for serverless
code so think azure app functions things
like that
we have workflow and integration so
think service bus
logic apps buffering and
competing consumers so event hub storage
queue other services and applications so
i think hybrid connections like web
sockets or web hooks or even automation
so yeah there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the key
concepts for azure event grid so here we
have this fancy diagram at the top here
we have domains so these are used to
group event grid topics that are related
to the same application for easier
management then you have topics these
are the end points where events are
going to be sent to there's different
types of topics we have system topics
these are built-in topics provided by
azure services this is the most common
kind you're going to be using because
they're super easy to use we have custom
topics for applications and third-party
topics and for those third-party topics
they emit their own partner events
uh from third-party sasses to publish
events so they're similar to system
topics it's just that they're with third
parties um but uh yeah there's some
variation there we have events these are
the actual event data that occurs within
the service not visualized here but you
get the idea uh publishers this is the
service that published the event so you
cannot see them on this diagram but the
idea is imagine you have a publisher
here and they are uh they are the ones
where the event sources is coming from
okay we have event sources this is where
the event took place uh event
subscriptions these are the mechanism
that the routes uh that route the events
sorry about that there so over here you
can see subscriptions
uh subscription expiration so this is
where you set an expiration for the
event subscription you have event
handlers which is over here um you could
say consumers if you'd like
is the app or service that receives the
events you have event delivery this is
the delivery of events in batches or in
single events so it just depends on how
you want to
send those messages you have batching so
this is uh sending a group of events in
a single request and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at event
grid basics so let's get to it so the
first thing we're going to want to do is
we're going to search up subscriptions
because we're going to need to make sure
that
like in order for us to use event grid
that we have it turned on
and so we'll go into our subscription
and we're going to go under
resource providers
providers
ah there it is
and this is all the stuff that is
registered all the providers that are
registered so what we're doing is just
make making sure that event grid is
turned on because that one's not always
turned on by default and just make sure
that it's registered okay so you'll know
that it's registered because it'll have
a green
check mark here and it'll say registered
and so once that is done we can proceed
to create
a storage account because we're going to
integrate a storage account
into our event grid so what we'll do is
create a new storage account
and we're going to create a new resource
group i'm going to call this resource
group event grid basics
and we're going to name our storage
account event
event
grid basics
all right and yes you can have hyphens
you can't have anything else
and we'll just make sure we spelt that
right event
event grid basics i can't remember if
these are fully qualified domains if
they are you might have to add some
numbers on the end there but it is what
it is we're doing uh usc i mean it just
randomizes every time but this is where
you should probably set it to
we have standard premium we'll leave it
as standard and everything all seems
fine so we'll go ahead and create review
and create and then it's going to allow
us to review we'll go ahead and hit
create
and it's going to create the resource
group here we'll just wait for it to
finish uh deploying and then we'll go
into the resource
all right looks like it is finished
deploying so we're going to go ahead and
go to that resource we're going to go to
containers and we're going to create a
couple containers the first is the first
one is going to be called basic
we're going to leave it as private just
make sure it's basic not basics
and we'll create another container
called basic alt the idea is that we're
going to use an event grid in order to
move one file from one storage account
to another
and that's going to be facilitated by
log via a logic app because that's going
to be the easiest way to use event grid
so what i want you to do is search for
logic apps
up here
and we're going to go ahead and add a
new logic app
and what we want to do
is choose our resource group and we'll
just go event grid basics here
we are going to name this event grid
basics
um maybe we'll do lg to indicate that it
is a logic app or lg maybe uh l yeah lg
is fine like short for logic
and from here we have a workflow or a
docker container we're going to stick
with a workflow
just to knock on wood we're going to
just put in the same region as our
storage account so
east us we have standard consumption i'd
rather do consumption for this
so you pay only as much as you use
because we don't need enterprise level
serverless application here we just need
a consumption model we're going to leave
this to disable so that is totally fine
there's nothing else to do here so we'll
go review plus create
and we'll go ahead and create this logic
app and we just have to wait for this to
finish deploying
all right so that should have been very
very quick like under uh 10 seconds
there so we've gone into the resource so
just click go to the resource and so we
have this
very fun interface and so what we need
to do is start with a common trigger
there's a few different ways to get to
it but there should be something
on the front here
i don't know if they redesigned this
recently
so i'm just gonna search start with a
commentary oh yeah it's up here okay i'm
being silly um and so
what we want to do is uh because this is
an event grid uh follow along we want to
click on when an event grid occurs
and so this is the designer where we can
make things a lot easier for ourselves
and so we're going to have to first sign
in to authenticate so i'm this is my
tenant example training inc so we'll go
ahead and get connected there
let's give it a moment
we'll select andrew brown which is
totally fine
and now that is connected so that is
great so once we are signed in we can
click continue and we're going to go
ahead and
select our subscription here
and we need to choose a
resource here so
i guess in this case it's going to be
event grid
or
hmm
i could have swore yeah yeah i think
that's what we want to do let me just
double check here oh you know what it's
just not for some reason i'm i'm
searching it's not auto completing
properly okay i just wasn't sure there
and as far as i can remember this would
be probably an event grid topic
and then we need to give this a resource
name so
um
let me just think about this for a
moment okay
all right so i think i understand where
my confusion was it was because we click
continue and i never i didn't see event
quit anymore so i thought we had to
configure it when it was already
configured right so this is where we
were so we're not we at this stage like
event grid is already hooked up so it's
ready to be triggered so this is the
step that follows into it which is where
we want to do our storage account so
that's where i was getting
confused so we'll choose our
subscription here it's okay you know if
you never get confused just step step
back a couple steps and just double
check what you're doing happens to me
all the time so um what we want to do is
actually
connect storage uh storage accounts so
we type in storage accounts here
great uh we'll have that selected and
then we need to select our storage
account so this one's called event grid
basics
and then we're gonna have to enter in
um some additional information event
type so we want to have it happen when
we add something to
the container so the basic container so
we'll do blob created
and then from there we need to actually
filter out the information so we need to
add a new parameter and i think we'll
have to do it on the prefix filter so a
filter like whatever yeah so that's
probably a good idea
because then we could
place it into a particular place and i
believe that
there are very specific
filters that you can do
for this because
if i recall
there's like standardized ones yeah see
here like it's always going to be
forward slash blob services default
containers etc and you'll know that
because you know if you read the
documentation and you have to do that
stuff you'll figure that out so i'm just
going to type it by hand here blob
services
default containers and then we can put
our container name so basic
uh and i believe we have it without the
s there
so
uh services see i don't trust my writing
here so i'm just gonna copy paste it in
okay
and that looks good to me
so i think that is what it needs to be
so we'll go ahead and hit the next step
so the idea is anything in that folder
like when something's added to that
folder then follow up with this
operation right
um and maybe before we do that we should
probably um
you know observe
that this stuff works that's probably a
good idea so what i'm going to do here
is i'm going to make my way back over to
our storage account so just close this
tab here i'm going to open a new tab
and we're going to make our way over to
storage accounts
and we'll go to event grid basics
and we will go to containers
and we'll click into our basic container
because i want to just see that this is
working
and i'm going to need a file to upload
so let me just go grab an image really
quick
all right so i just grabbed an image off
the internet so i just have data here
but before we upload we probably should
save what we have because if we don't
save it we're not going to be able to
observe it so i went back to logic app
and we just hit save in the top left
corner
so we'll give it a moment to save and it
looks like it's saved now i'm just going
to go back over to here
if we can
look at some of the code that gets
executed i'm just trying to remember
where it is because once it executes we
want to um
see what happened right so what i'll do
is i'm going to go all the way back over
here and i'm just going to go and drag
or actually i'll hit the upload button
so i don't trust that that there and
i'll drag it onto here nope i still
don't trust it so what i'm going to do
is just click the files and i'm just
going to grab it this way and say open
and we'll do upload
and so that is now uploaded and so
there is somewhere where we can observe
um where stuff has happened so i'm just
trying to remember where it is
um
[Music]
i mean we could run the trigger
yeah we probably should run the trigger
right
run
i think it's running so we'll just give
it a moment okay
you know i was thinking about it it
doesn't make sense we shouldn't have to
run it because it should just happen
automatically i think it's on the
overview page
ah okay
so if we look here
we can see the run history and so and
there's also trigger history of when the
things are triggered so we could we
could manually fire it but doesn't make
sense so i think this is the run that we
just did if we click into here yes this
is what it is so here we can see what
what has happened so if we expand it
we can see the inputs right so it's we
have a blob created
um it might show some information so
here we can see data yep and it's a webp
file and so it's gotten this far through
and so that's a great way to kind of
like debug so you can
uh logic run app you can do it each step
but right now we are using um event grid
to do that integration right
we're just doing it through logic logic
app because it's a lot easier
so
now that we have that what we should do
is go back to our designer and we're
going to have to add the follow-up step
um so we have this
oh yeah okay so that's the first step
event grid doesn't show up there which
is weird but um so we have this step
here from our storage account and so the
next step what we want to do is put it
into
another container so that will be the
tricky part
um so i'm just trying to remember what
we do so we'll hit next step
and
um
i think what we need to do is initialize
a variable first because we're going to
have to get some way to grab
the name of the string because if we go
back to our run
over here
just give it a moment here
and we go into a run again here
we need to extract some data to pass
along because there are some limitations
in terms of how json gets passed along
or data gets passed along and so
what we want is we just want this part
of the name we want to say take this
name as the identifier so that when
we're copying stuff over it will work
and so what we'll have to do is store
that into an intermediate variable
so
we'll just type in variables here
and
i'm just seeing
oh yeah so they look like this because i
can remember they might be in the
built-in yeah that looks a lot better
and so we need a variable and it's
initialize variable
and we're going to name this file name
and this is a string of course
and now we need to insert the value
so in here what we need to do is write
an expression in order to extract that
information out
um so what we'll do is go to the
expression tab and over here you can see
we have all sorts of expressions that we
can use so i'm going to type in last
parentheses and then in there we'll do
split
parentheses
and then what we're looking for is
trigger body
and then we'll do question mark
square braces
single quotations subject how did i know
how to do that
i
looked it up i looked it up somewhere
and you know i just don't feel like
there's much reason to to teach this
part because
you mean if you really need to know you
can go here um and learn all about it
but a lot of times like if you need
something you can just say i need this
kind of function somebody's already done
it right because there's so many common
use cases so i probably search something
like how do i get the name out of the
the thing you know like for the blob and
somebody had that there but it makes
sense to me so let's hit okay here and
it should turn purple because it is dime
expression if you type it in here
probably won't work correctly you have
to type in here and then hit okay so it
shows up like that uh but you notice we
typed in like trigger body so if we go
back over to our run here
um
this is the body here so when they say
trigger body they're talking about here
and then it was just grabbing that
subject line there
all right
so that would be the second step and
that gets it into a variable but the
next part is we need to actually um
get the blob content and then insert it
and then create a new blob so we'll do
is hit next step and we'll type in blob
and see if we can find anything here
and from here we need to get the get
blob content using path version 2.
so i'm just going to scroll down here
and take a look for it there it is
based on the path
and we'll go down here and um
i guess it would be access key oh
because we're setting up a connection
for the first time
so
[Music]
enter name for connection
um
i know what the storage account is
but what is the connection uh connection
name i do not remember give me two
seconds okay there wasn't much to help
me here because what i remember before
was that you click it and you'd
authenticate it like the event grid but
it's not doing that so maybe we just
have to name it something
so i don't know we'll just say azure
storage account maybe it just wants a
name
maybe it doesn't really matter
oh yeah like there's sign in
that's what i want
so connection name yeah so we'll say uh
you know
storage account event grid
okay
because if we can just single sign on
let's do that that's super easy
and we'll click that there
okay so this is starting to look how i
expect it to look
and so we need the storage account name
i don't know why it's not showing me any
names here
but that's okay we'll just go over back
to our storage account here and it's
called event grid basics
so we'll type in event grid basics
event
grid basics
uh
that's custom value sure
i mean that's what its name is i'm not
sure why it's not auto completing
but here what we need to do is we need
to provide the path so it's going to be
forward slash basic
ah and so now there's our environment
very or that variable so we'll just
click that there
so that will make it super super easy
now notice that it is showing basic now
so i just clicked here the folder we
typed it in manually but we could have
clicked uh here and then put the
environment variable in or the uh this
initialized variable in here but i did
type that manually and it still did work
correctly so we are okay here infer the
content type sure why not
um it doesn't matter if they do
so this gets the content so now this
gets the path and so the next thing is
actually to create the blob
you can't like do an easy clone you have
to do at this um intermediate step
that's just how it works
um and so what we'll need to do is go to
our built-in ones here we'll type in
blob again
maybe standard
and this time we want to create a blob
so there it is
uh block bob no we just want a blob
and so what we'll do is
i guess we have to connect again i'm
surprised it's not showing the name yeah
it's just the name that's fine so we'll
go back over here
i just don't want to type it wrong so
we'll just copy paste it in
event grid basics
grid basics
enter custom value because it's giving
us so much trouble for no particular
reason
make sure there's no space on the end
there there now works fine
um in this case what we want is basic
alt
and the blob name can be the file name
which is totally fine
and the blob content will be the file
content
and i don't think we need anything else
so what we'll do is go ahead and click
off and we will save
alright so that's just the way we're
going to have to do it
so what we can do is go back to our
overview
and
we'll go back to our basic folder
and we'll delete data
say ok
and we'll go upload
we'll select our file again
we'll grab it
we will upload and then we will make our
way back over to
our logic app
close this tab here so we don't get too
mixed up
refresh the page
and it failed so it failed for some
reason so something has not been
configured correctly
it failed on the initialize variable so
something's wrong there so unable to
process the template language expression
in the actions initialize variable uh
inputs at line zero column zero
templating function split is not defined
as not valid so it's possible i just
spelt it wrong
so what we'll do is go back to our event
grid we'll go back to our logic app
designer here
initialize variable we will click it
and we probably just built it wrong
spilt
spilt what if we do lit spilt
split
so if that's wrong we'll just scroll on
down and we'll just take a look
i could have swore that it
auto-completed for us
oh you know what it is spelled wrong it
should be s-p-i-l-i-t
split
all right
and i'm just double-checking to see if
there's any other problems here
nope looks fine to me so go ahead and
say update we will save it in the top
left corner
we'll go back we'll delete our file here
we'll say okay
and we'll have to select a new file
we'll click open let's double check make
sure that's been saved it looks like
it's been saved we'll hit upload we'll
go back to our overview page
it's already running super fast by the
way
and we'll click into it and we'll see if
we get any other failure so there's
another failure that's totally okay
so we'll just expand it this request is
not authorized to perform this operation
using the permissions
so it does not like the permissions i
gave it
totally fine
so we will go back to our app designer
we will go to this second step here even
though it did select this properly
so we'll change the connection
i guess we'll add a new one
so we did 80 integrated oh let's do
managed identity you must enable managed
identities in the logic app to use
managed dna's authentication you must
grant
required access to the identity in the
target resource
okay
there is an identity tab so we can go
over there and take a look there quickly
i don't remember it being that hard to
do
a system assigned managed identity is
restricted to one person one person
resource is tied to lifecycle you can
grant permissions etc
etc um
can we just turn that on and hit save
well it can be granted access resources
protected by a z sure let's give it a go
all right so um it seems like we have to
assign some role stuff
so we can try and assign a role um
can we do the subscription level
contributor
okay
so there's a few different ways you can
authenticate so hopefully this will be
the easiest way to do it
we'll refresh here did it assign it
and i don't think it said it
all right so give me a moment and let me
see what i can figure up okay
you know just to make this easier i
think what we should do is just do the
access key because that seems like the
easiest way to do it i was just hoping
that we could have you know
just did a simple sign in here but it's
not a big deal so we'll hit change
connection we're going to add a new
connection
just say storage account
event
event grid
key
and so this is going to want the azure
storage account name so this one will be
the name of
the storage count if we can find it
it's called event grid basics
and then we need the azure storage
account access key
so
there's probably a tab called keys yep
and we will show the key and we will
copy the key
if i don't have to pass long keys i like
to not do that please check your account
info again
storage account access key should be a
correct base64 encoded string come on
give me a break here
i am doing what you asked me to do
so we will try this again
this thing just hates me today give me a
second okay
you know what it was really short so i
really don't trust it so let's just do i
just cleared it out there i didn't do
anything else what we're going to do is
go back here click the copy
and then right click
and paste that's so much longer okay
that has to be the right key we'll hit
create
and we'll give it a moment
okay great
so
that's for that one
um but this has to have the right
connection as well so what we'll do is
just change the connection
you have a few here eh um and the one we
want is
the one that's valid so we'll go this
one down below as you can see a few
attempts here
and we'll save it
and we'll go back
to our overview here i'm just gonna
close that tab out we're gonna close
this out we're gonna go back into here
we're gonna go into our containers we're
gonna go into our basic
we're gonna go ahead and delete this
we'll say okay
and we will upload a new file we will
choose the new file we'll choose data
upload it
we'll go back over here
and i want to see the latest run here
we'll give this a refresh
is it running
it looks like it's running it's hard
because this one looks like it just
failed and and now the the messaging is
getting really muddy here
what is it doing so we'll click off here
sometimes the portal is a bit funny is
it just triggering over and over again
did we make an infinite loop
uh oh
okay i think we have a problem here
well if we go here is it basic or it's
basic alt
this one's basic
so
what's the problem
we'll refresh
failed why did it fail
conflict
another active upload session exists
please retry after some time
okay
uh well let's just go take a look here
go back
it's here so it's it's here
so it clearly has worked why it's
triggering multiple times i don't know
um don't particularly like that
there we go let's go ahead and delete
this one here
and it's just it's just going over and
over and over again
so there's something wrong with my
workflow
so this looks fine to me
that looks fine to me
maybe it's triggering oh you know what
the the parameters out of here so this
is supposed to have a prefix here so
what's happening is that it's triggering
on any time a basic one is set up or a
basic alt one and it's just stuck in an
infinite loop which is really really bad
um so
we did do this earlier but for whatever
reason um
the changes still are not here
so what we'll need to do is set up that
prefix so what we'll do is type in
blob
services default
containers
basic
because we really don't want to trigger
it on any but that that container there
and uh
did it save it
it doesn't look yeah i mean it should be
there so what we'll do is go ahead
like why is it not filtering
oh
i guess it wants a filter based on name
but we gave it its name so
i'm not sure what else
we would have to type there
okay um
i'm just gonna put um dot
it's the prefix filter so data i guess i
don't know like
it's not letting me save okay there we
go we'll save that i just want to stop
the infinite loop there for a moment
so we'll go back over to the overview
and we'll just make sure we're not
running up our bill here
and i'm just refreshing i just want to
see that's not triggering anymore so it
stopped triggering which is good
and we'll go back over to here
and we'll look at this prefix filter
because i i remember having to do this
so a filter like sample etc etc so we'll
type it in again i guess
blob services defaults
containers
basic
it's very odd because like we typed it
oh you know what i probably did i typed
in the filter parameter here and we're
supposed to add it then put it in there
so it's just me getting confused by the
ui
silly me okay so what we'll do is go
back to the overview
and this time we just want to see
trigger once so go back to basic all
we'll go ahead and delete this we'll say
okay
and we'll go back to our event grid
we'll go in or
our event grid our basic our basic
container we're going to go ahead and
delete
uh data here again
and we're going to go upload one more
time
it's actually good that we had that
problem because i got to show you
uh why filters are so important um when
we're dealing with uh
the app logic there um or logic apps so
we'll go ahead and hit upload we'll go
make our way back over here we're gonna
give this a refresh
and now we have a new one and it only
happened once and that's what we wanted
to happen so we go back over to here
and go to basic halt there it is so
that's a means to which we can use event
grid to integrate stuff you can see
logic app is extremely useful for
developers
building all sorts of tools but we are
all done here
and what we'll do is make our way over
to our resource group
and we are going to just go ahead and
clean up so we'll go into event grid
basics
and we'll go ahead and delete this
resource group
there we go and it's going to go ahead
and delete there
uh yeah and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure event
hub so event hub is an event in jet
store that can consume millions of
events from anywhere and process them in
real time or micro batching thanks to
the auto inflate feature which
automatically scales the numbers of
throughput to meet your changing needs
so it provides an easy way to connect
with your apache applications and
clients here is kind of a overview
illustration of event hubs so the idea
over here is you have different
protocols so h-p-s-a-m-q-p
kafka for your event producers to then
uh enter into azure event hubs you have
partitions within your hubs you have
consumers uh and then there is the
received events the event receivers so
you know hopefully that gives you a
quick overview let's go dive a bit
deeper
[Music]
let us take a look at the pricing for
azure event hub but before we do i just
want to expand on a few initialisms so
we know what they stand for we have
capacity unit for cu processing unit for
pu and throughput unit for tu so across
here we have four different pricing
plans basic standard premium
dedicated lots of azure services like to
have a whole lot of
specialized plans uh built into their
services uh but as you can see as uh you
go right the more expensive it goes
uh but there's some key differences so
for azure event hub if you're on basic
you do not get capturing
capturing cost a bit more uh so i mean
we'll cost something at standard at
premium dedicated it's included if you
want to use apache kafka you're not
going to get it in basic if you want a
schema registry you're not going to get
that in basic if you need extended
retention you do not get a basic or
standard so hopefully that gives you an
idea of the differences of these tiers
[Music]
let's take a look at the key concepts a
lot of these will cover in future slides
so this one is a bit text heavy so do
not worry
but azure event hub helps you build your
big data pipeline to analyze logging
anomalies use anomalies users and a
device telemetry where you only pay for
what you use so some of the key concepts
here are name space so it is an endpoint
for receiving and distributing events to
the event hubs we have event hub where
your events will be delivered event hub
cluster which is a dedicated event hub
with 99.99 sla event hub capture this
allows you to automatically capture and
save streaming
events
we have uh event hubs for apache kafka
so this is compatibility with apache
kafka's
setup event publishers these are
applications or services that publish
events to event hub publisher policy
this is a unique id used to identify
publishers partitions are used to
organize the sequence of events in event
hub event consumers are applications or
services that read events from event hub
consumer group which are
the enable consuming applications to
each have a separate view of the event
stream stream offset which holds the
position of an event inside a partition
checkpoint is the process of
distinguishing between read and unread
events but let's go look at these all in
more detail
[Music]
let's talk about scaling because that's
a very important concept in vent hub so
the idea is that there's this feature
called auto inflate it's basically just
a check box here and will automatically
scale up to the maximum
to you so um
throughput units based on the traffic
demand it's not available for basic
pricing as we saw over there
we also this option of if we're in the
premium tier you're going to notice
there is no auto inflate because it's
already there by default and the unit is
different it's processing units so
you'll just slide that left and right
that's just kind of reflect what we saw
in the pricing
section okay
[Music]
let's talk about an actual event hub so
what we do is go name our hub and we got
a few options here we have partition
count so partitions are
our data organization mechanisms that
relates to downstream parallelism
required and consuming applications
sounds very fancy but it's just a way of
segmenting your data so that you have a
faster concurrent reads
you have retention message retention so
this is the period for which your events
will retain so that means that when
they're past that period they are poof
they are gone then you have capture so
capture enables you to automatically
deliver the streaming data in event hubs
to azure blob storage or azure data
lakes store account of your choice with
the ad flexibility of specifying a time
or size interval setting up capture is
really fast there are no administrative
costs to run it it scales automatically
automatically with event hubs throughput
units event hubs captures is the easiest
way to load streaming data into azure
and enables you to focus on data
processing rather than on data capture
so just a great way to offload into
azure blob storage or
azure data lake store there you go
[Music]
let's take a look at producers because
that is what is going to emit events
that will get into event hub so on the
right hand example we have some code
because the idea is that you will have
to instrument your producer to send out
events so here you can see we've created
a client we'll have to have a connection
string the event hub name so we know who
we're talking to
you would create a producer and then
here what we're seeing is a batch job so
they create a batch job and they push
some data on there and then they send
uh send uh send the batch and then when
they're done they close the client if
there are any errors we can get some
exception handling this is a javascript
example so a producer also known as a
publisher emits data to the stream
publishers can publish events using the
following protocol so https so most
azure sdks use https as this would
probably use underneath you have amqp
which is a very popular uh queuing
protocol kafka protocol so if you're
using kafka or you're using that
protocol then that's another way to get
in here and we just walked through that
example you can publish events either
one at a time or batches as we see here
on the right hand side there's a limit
of one megabyte regardless of whether
it's a single event or a batch beyond
one megabyte events will be rejected for
automation or for authorization
publishers use either azure ad with auth
2 issued jwt tokens or shared access
signature sas which is something we see
a lot in azure services let's just talk
about some other things so https versus
amqp for publishing events for amqk it
requires the establishment of a
persistent bi-directional socket in
addition to tls or ssl
mqamqp has higher network costs when
initializing the session amqp has higher
performance or frequent publishers
and can achieve much lower latencies
when used with asynchronous publishing
code https requires additional tls
overhead for every request so it's going
to be up to you to decide whether you
want to use https
or amqp protocol
for publisher policies event hub enables
granular control over events publishers
through publisher policies
and they these publisher policies are
run time features designed to facilitate
large numbers of independent event
publishers with publisher policies each
publisher uses its own unique identifier
when publishing events to an event hub
using the following mechanisms and i
guess there was supposed to be more
there maybe but
i think that's pretty much it because we
don't really need to know much more
about
publisher policies to be honest uh if
there's an opportunity if we do follow
along that is opportunity maybe we will
take a detour into that to see if it's
worth our time but as far as i'm aware
of i don't think it's that important
there we go
[Music]
let us take a look at a consumer so
here's an example of consumer code very
similar
kind of similar to the last one here so
we are uh creating a consumer client
and so here we need a connection uh
connection string container name where
we're gonna put this stuff looks like
we're going to put in azure blob storage
we're going to create that client and
then we have the subscription so the
idea is that
it was going to listen for data to
consume
okay
and then over here we can see that it
updates a checkpoint we'll talk about
checkpoints soon enough but let's just
talk about consumers in general so
consumer also known as a reader receives
data to process from the stream all
event hub consumers connect via the amqp
1.0 session and events are delivered
through the session as they become
available the client does not need to
pull for data availability so that's
that we'll next talk about consumer
groups
[Music]
well let's talk about consumer groups
here this is very tech savvy sorry but
there's not much to show
a consumer group is a view state
position or offset of an entire event
hub consumer groups enable multiple
consuming applications to each have a
separate view of the event stream and to
read the stream independently at their
own pace with their own offsets so in a
stream processing architecture each
downstream application equates to a
consumer
group there's always a default consumer
group an event hub and you can create up
to the maximum number of consumer groups
for the corresponding pricing tier there
can be at most five concurrent readers
on a partition per consumer group
however it's recommended there's only
one active receiver on a partition per
consumer group
some clients offered by azure sdk are
intelligent consumer agents that
automatically manage the details of
ensuring that each partition has a
single reader and then all partitions of
an event hub are being read from this
allows your code to focus on processing
the events being read from the event hub
so it can ignore many of the details of
the partition so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about offsets for azure event
hub so an offset is the position of an
event within a partition and so here's
an example a very ugly graphic from the
documentation but it makes our point
clear the idea is you have a partition
you have um
you have an event within the partition
there's all these little lines represent
event and that's where our offset is so
offsets enable a consumer or reader to
specify a point in the event stream from
which they want to begin reading events
you can specify the offset as a time
stamp or as an offset value consumers
are responsible for storing their own
offset values
outside of the event hub service within
a partition each event includes an
offset so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about checkpointing
uh there is really not a lot to say
about it um or to visualize it but it's
kind of part of offsets so checkpointing
is a process by which readers mark or
commit their position within a partition
event sequence checkpointing is the
responsibility of the consumer and
occurs on a per partition basis with a
consumer group responsibility means that
for each consumer group each partition
reader must keep track of its current
position in the event stream
and can inform the service when it
considers the data stream complete
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look at schema registry
something that is uh not uncommon when
we're looking at event buses there's
something similar in aws um and the idea
here is that you're able to enforce a
particular schema of your data
and this will help avoid um
uh things breaking for your consumers
and have a standard way of
expectation of what something is so
the idea here is skip registry provides
a centralized repository for schemas
this provides the flexibility for your
producer consumer applications to
exchange data without having to manage
and share schemas between them and also
evolve at different rates that's the key
thing there evolve at different rates
so here we have our schema group we have
a schema we'll talk about schema group
in a second and then you have schema
versions and then there's the actual
schema itself so schema groups are under
your namespace and can be accessed by
all topics event hubs under that
namespace so here you can see we're just
setting some options here and then
here's the schema itself so here we have
a very simple example where we have a
type of record and name ordered and we
have a couple of fields
but the idea again is schema registry
really does help you
kind of enforce what you expect data to
look like for your producers for your
consumers and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at apache kafka
so the reason we're talking about it is
just because
event hub has a compatibility mode for
it so apache kafka is an open source
streaming platform to create high
performance data pipelines streaming
analytics data integrations and mission
critical applications kafka was
originally developed by linkedin in open
source in 2011. kafka was written in
scala and java so to use it you'll need
to know how to write java and the idea
is quite simple we have producers we
have consumers we have topics there's a
cluster there's partitions looks similar
to event hub and other kind of streaming
platforms and kafka data is stored in
partitions of course that span multiple
machines because it's for distributed
computing you have producers
via the kafka producer api you have
consumers via the consumer api messages
are organized into topics producers will
push messages to topics consumers will
listen on topics so let's talk about
that kafka compatibility so event hub
provides an endpoint compatible with
apache kafka producers and consumers
apis for version one and above so
event hub kafka compatibility is
alternative to running your own apache
cluster so
you know we said that they're very
similar so eventhough calls them name
space kafka calls them uh clusters so
you can kind of see that there's that
translation over but the idea is that
when you enable this it will use all the
stuff that kafka is used to seeing
and then the idea there is that you
don't have to run a kafka cluster you
just run event hub
if you've already written code that
works with kafka that's the idea is that
you can drop in event hub as a managed
replacement now does
event hub work exactly like kafka i'm
not a hundred percent sure
so there could be some feature
differences um but in terms of uh
protocols or endpoints being able to
replace kafka with a vent hub if you
need to um that's why they have this
functionality here so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at partitioning or
partitions for event hub so vent hub
organizes sequences events sent to an
event hub into one or more partitions as
new events arrive they're added to the
end of the sequence this idea is that
you have those partitions older's on the
left mirrors on the right partitions
hold the following data about the event
the body of the event a user-defined
property bag describing the event
metadata such as its offset its
partition its number in the stream
sequence
service side timestamps at which it was
accepted partitioning allows for
multiple parallel logs to be
used for the same event hub and
therefore multiplying the available raw
input output throughput capacity you can
use a partition key to map incoming
event data into specific partitions for
the purpose of data organization and the
partition key is a sender supplied value
passed into an event hub so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look at event retention
for event hub so published events are
removed from an event hub based on a
configurable time based retention policy
and the default value and shortest
possible retention period is one day so
that's 24 hours for event hubs standard
the maximum retention is seven days and
we saw that um in the pricing page where
retention can be different based on
those things so for premium and
dedicated the maximum retention is 90
days if you change the retention period
it applies to all messages including
messages that are already in event hub
you cannot explicitly delete events the
reason for event hubs limit on data
retention based on time is to prevent
large volumes of historical customer
data getting trapped in a deep store
that's only indexed by tam's timestamp
and only allows for sequential access
which
doesn't sound too good if you need to
archive events beyond the allowed
retention period you can automatically
have them stored in azure storage or
data lake by turning on event hubs
capture feature which we talked about
earlier if you need to search or analyze
such deep archives you can easily import
them into azure synapse
or other similar stores and analytics
platforms so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this follow along we are going to
learn all about azure event hub uh so
what i want you to do is go to the top
here and type in event hub and we are
going to create ourselves a new event
hub
namespace so we'll go here and hit
create and we'll create a new resource
group as we always do called my event
hub
and then for the namespace name we'll
say
my event hub if it doesn't let you
do that you'll have to put some numbers
on the end i'm just putting some numbers
here because often these are taken up
doesn't matter what location is just
choose whichever one we're going with
basic because there's not a huge
difference between the pricing terms in
terms of feature sets that we want to
use today so go ahead and create this
namespace so we'll give it a moment
and we'll go ahead and hit create
and then we'll just wait for this
namespace to provision
all right so after waiting about a
couple of minutes there our namespace is
deployed we're going to go ahead and
create ourselves an event hub i'm going
to call this one
my hub we'll go ahead and hit review and
create
and we'll create
and these crate very very quickly so
we're not going to have to wait too long
we need to set some shared access
policies here so i'm going to go into
the hub here i'm going to hit manage i'm
going to call this
my sas
sas shared access policy and there we
will now have the ability to have a
primary key and connection key so we can
actually connect
to it so what we're going to do is go to
github and i want to create a new
repository
and we'll go ahead here
and we'll go down below go to exam pro
we'll say
my event hub
that's already taken because i've done
this before
so for mine i'm going to call it new
and we'll go down to private we're going
to use node.js so let's type in node.js
so that it ignores the node modules
you're going to want to have getpod or a
visual studio code installed on your
computer the easiest way is to get pod
because these environments are temporary
and it's free to utilize it so
if you can go get the chrome extension
or
if you don't want to install the chrome
extension all you got to do is attach
this to the end of the repo to launch a
github or get pod environment so give
that a moment to launch
and there we go so i do have some code
uh for this
so i'm just looking for it off screen
here
and
we're gonna need to have a couple files
here we're going to need a new file
called
send.js
and we're getting a new file here called
receive.js
i'm not typing the full word receive
because i'm always really bad at
spelling it so i'm just trying to save
myself some trouble
and
we're also going to have to initialize a
new
package.json file so there we go
and we're going to have to get
a couple things installed yeah so we'll
need mpm install
azure
event
event hubs
azure
storage blob
azure event hubs
checkpoint
store blob
save dev and make our lives a bit easier
it seems like i typed something wrong
here i'll just hit up
i forgot the forward slash here
and so we'll just go event hub
azure
javascript
because i believe yep
i kind of use this one but i modified it
to make it a little bit easier i think
this is the one i was doing
no i don't think so tutorial
might be this one
yeah it looks like this um so this is
just the javascript there so for send we
will grab this code here
we're not going to do exactly the way
they do it but pretty close
and then there is a receive code so go
down below and we'll grab this as you
can see there's a lot going on here
that will be our receive a couple things
we need to properly set so these will be
all environment variables so what we'll
do is go to the top here and we'll just
do constant
process
requires process that's going to allow
us to import our environment variables
so we'll just say
copy let's save that
we'll paste that in there as well
and then this is where we need to
replace all environment variables as you
can see i always have things pinging up
on me here so just close my teams out
and just line these to make this a
little bit faster
so default will be what we'll keep here
this will be our storage connection
string
say process env
storage
connection string
then this one will be
process env
container name
then we need
process
env event hub name
and up here we'll have process
env
event hub
connection string
and then we'll go over to our send here
we'll do something very similar so
process
env
event hub connection string
and then we'll have process env
event hub
name
so we need to set all of these i'm just
going to copy this for a moment here i'm
going to make a new file
file new file
sure it doesn't really matter we're just
using this as a quick scratch pad and so
what i want to do here is just
delete out this part
and we're going to do export on the end
here we'll take out this one here
and the idea is that we'll just set them
all here and then we will
make our lives a little bit easier when
we have to mask something
set these
so we do have the connection string
because we saw it over here
so we will grab the primary one it
doesn't matter which one primary
secondary
and that is for the
event hub
we called the
the event hub was called my hub i
believe
we'll just double check
what the hub was called yeah it's called
my hub up there
we'll need a storage account so what i'm
going to do
push this thing we get out of here get
out of here i'm not
i'm not trying to save a freaking file
there we go hit escape a bunch of times
and we'll go back here and we'll create
ourselves a new storage account i'll
actually make this in a new tab so we
can see what we're doing
so we'll go over to storage accounts
and we'll create ourselves a new storage
account we'll create this storage
account in the same name space so we'll
go down to my event hub we'll just say
my
or we'll just say my event hub 8888
again you might have to change it based
on your standards but um or like what is
available to you
we'll go ahead and go review
create
and for the container name
we'll probably just call container
maybe container one
we just have to wait for this crate to
grab that connection string
so this usually doesn't take too long
just a couple seconds
okay so there we are we'll go over to
access keys and we'll grab the
connection string from here i believe
this one should work
uh let me just double check
yeah i think this will work so what
we'll do is go back over here if it
doesn't we'll find out pretty soon and
we'll just generate out a shared policy
uh we'll go ahead and paste that on in
here
and just double checking that this is
the correct one this looks identical to
that one that can't be correct so we'll
go back here this is the storage account
so we'll go oh i have to actually hit
the copy button that's what it didn't do
we'll go ahead and paste that in and so
theoretically this should work so we'll
go ahead and copy these we'll drag our
terminal up a bit we'll paste these in
here
and
what i'll do is just double check that
they're here so we'll say env grep
event hub
so those are both set and then we'll do
storage
that one is set and we'll do container
that one is set so these are all in good
shape for our storage account we still
have to create the container so go here
and create a new container say container
one we'll go ahead and create that we'll
make our way back over here and then
instead of just having export we'll do
gp
env this is just in case we have to
restart the environment for any reason
so that these environment variables get
exported twice so we'll paste that in
there
i believe those are all set i had to hit
enter on the last one there
and let's see if our code works so we'll
do a send
um
actually we have to set up
two scripts here so that we can actually
call them so one called here is called
send
this will be node send js
and we'll have receive so rec just
because i always spell receive wrong and
i just don't want to have to type it a
thousand times we'll have that there so
now what we'll do is do npm run send
see if that works
it says a batch of three events have
been sent we'll go and confirm that over
an event hub if it worked if we go to
the overview it should show us some
messages were received
sometimes there's a bit of a delay
so we'll just give it a teeny tiny
amount of time we'll hit refresh here
because we know we sent them but while
we're waiting for those to kind of
propagate what we'll go back here is
just kind of look at the code because we
didn't really look at it
so the way it works is you are defining
a client and it will be the producer
client
um and then down below so we say okay a
producer is someone that produces events
it's very common in a messaging system
to have a producer and consumer we're
going to create a batch job and we're
going to add them all to the batch job
then we're going to send them all at
once and it's going to close and it'll
enable to complete and if there are any
errors it will alert us about it
so we'll go back over here and we'll do
a refresh
so i want to see
messages messages would normally show up
here so since i don't trust it i'm just
going to run it again i mean clearly
worked because there was no errors
and we'll go back over here and
not here but we'll go back here we'll
refresh
and i'm just waiting to see
something here
processing data this is like something
that's really powerful with them
event hub here so
still don't see the messages just give
me a second to debug this i've done this
lab like four times so it should work
but uh you know sometimes sometimes it's
trouble so just a moment
all right so i literally did nothing and
now it's actually showing up in the uh
messaging queue so you know or the hub
the funnel
so that's just something you have to
consider is that sometimes you just have
to be a little bit patient let's see if
we can go receive those messages now by
running the other
scripts so what i'm going to do here is
do npm
run receive
and it should receive the messages as
long as something isn't typed
incorrectly so we'll go back over here
we've seemed to introduce a little
mistake so i'll go ahead and save that
we'll hit up
and it should receive the events so i
should print the three out
so there we go
and so we are streaming this or the
consumer is technically um storage
storage accounts but if we go to the
storage account there's nothing really
uh um
intelligible in terms of what's in here
so like there are stuff in here
checkpoints
i guess it saved a checkpoint
i personally don't know what i'm looking
at so i'm not exactly sure what the
point of doing that i guess it's just
saying the checkpoint is like the last
point it wrote
but if we just take a look at the code
here quickly you can see it's called
consumer so we get a consumer client
there's a blob checkpoint store
then we have the consumer client we are
subscribing so it's saying hey are there
any events let's consume them if there
are no events throw a console log so
tell us about it iterate through them
then update the checkpoints so move it
to the next point um just say hey this
is where it is now and that's pretty
much all i want you to do we can go
ahead and save this code we'll say
eventhub code doesn't matter what you
name it there we'll sync the changes and
we'll go ahead and clean up
so we'll go back to our resource groups
we'll go to event hub
and we will then go
and delete this resource group
and we'll go here and
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure
notification hubs so the goal of the
service is to send notifications to
mobile apps in order to increase the app
engagement and usage you can use tags to
filter which apps or users that will
receive notifications and those apps can
be registered in azure notification hub
in two different ways
the first way is installation model so
that's where the app sends an
installation request to azure
notification hub including all the
information needed for the installation
to be completed this model is easy to
set up and maintain
and then from there we have the
registration model uh so this app sends
a azure notification hub registration
request with the pns handlers and tags
and azure notification hub responds with
the registration id uh it's great for
native or generic templates that can be
used in order to define
the message so um you know azure
notification hub in order for us to
actually uh show off how to use this
thing we'd actually have to set up a
mobile app and it's not easy to do so
this is something where we do not have a
follow along for i don't think it's a
big deal because i really didn't see it
on the exam but it is part of the
material so we definitely should know
what it does so we'll just continue on
here and learn a little bit more about
azure notification hub okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about the supported
platforms that azure notification hub
supports this gives you an idea of how
how it can be used with different uh
mobile frameworks uh because you know we
all don't use iphones there's androids
and other things like that so for
android we're gonna see support through
firebase cloud messaging if you do not
know what firebase is it's google's
cloud's platform as a service it's a way
of building out um
applications similar to uh it was
amplify or supabase but uh the component
for messaging is through that sdk for
cloud messaging this used to be called
google cloud messaging so if you go
through the documentation
you might see this this does not exist
anymore you have to use firebase cloud
messaging okay for ios we have the apple
push notification service apns and so
through that it's going to be
notification hubs for ios 13. and uh the
way that works is through objective c
sdk um i don't think there's support for
swift at least i could not find it but
this is only important if you are a
native mobile application developer
but basically the idea is the objective
sdk is how you would interact with it
there's also notification up for
zamarin i always say zamarin wrong for
ios applications samarin is
i'm assuming the x is pronounced like an
s i don't know why i just assume but um
that is a
uh a
technology a framework built by uh
microsoft that allows you to build out
native applications for a variety of
things like ios and android and things
like that and windows phone of course
for windows phone the way we're going to
communicate is through the microsoft
push notification service so mpns
for windows because i suppose you can
build a windows application not just a
windows phone this is through the
universal windows platform so uwp app uh
and from there that is the windows push
notification service of wns so you know
this is just to give you an idea of the
broad stuff and get you exposure to a
lot of these terms again i don't think
that's going to show up in the exam but
good to know for azure notification hub
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at how
message flow works for azure
notification hub so notice this tower
here so this is um the platform
notification service by your provider so
you're using apple they have their own
microsoft has their own et cetera et
cetera and the idea is that notification
hub is connected to that and that's how
notification gets pushed out so
notification i was just pushing to this
tower
and then this tower
pushes out to tablets that are
subscribed okay
let's go through the flow here because
there's some interesting things about
handles we need to know so the idea is
that your app says hey i want to
subscribe to push
to push notifications so it sends a
request to your platform notification
service and it's going to get back a
handle that handle's going to vary so if
you're using windows uh
notification service you get back a url
a uri and for apples you're going to get
back a token so then you have to store
that token into your application so it
comes back to your phone your tablet
whatever and then it goes okay to the
back end and then stores that token here
and then the idea is that you can then
use that token that whenever your app
wants to notify all devices that are uh
registered
for push notifications it's going to
then push it out
and with the handle it's going to go to
the platform notification service and
then that's going to roll it out and
then all your apps are going to
receive that information so hopefully
that makes it uh pretty clear how that
works okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at some key
concepts or components that are in azure
notification hub to just kind of cement
what we learned about the message flow
and just the service in general so azure
notification has these key concepts we
have routing this is the process of
selecting which registrations will
receive the push notifications we have
the id of broadcast all registrations
will receive the push notification a tag
registrations that contain the specific
tag receive that push notification a
great way to
narrow down who you want to notify there
are tag expressions so registrations
that match the tag expression will
receive a push notification so that is
an even further way of uh narrowing down
who we want to
uh receive a push notification there's
the notification hub name space so you
have to create a group of one or more
notification hubs in order to send stuff
out tags are used to label applications
so that they can be routed more
efficient efficiently which is what we
were talking about here just a moment
ago but tag and tag expressions you have
templates these define the format on how
the client will receive the push
notification
and it's platform specific um okay
each platform is this is platform
independent so platform specific i think
is probably a better word there
each platform has its own platform
notification service which is in charge
of push notifications so the idea is
that uh push notification hub or azure
notification hub is just basically an
adapter to all these a variety of
services that are offered by these other
uh telecom or notification companies
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at queuing so
both azure storage queue and azure
service bus have overlapping
responsibilities because they're they're
both messaging or queuing as a service
and so just before we jump into both of
these services i wanted to
distinguish the differences between
these so you can kind of identify the
use case for them so we have azure
storage queue this is a simple message
queuing services store large numbers of
messages then you have azure service bus
this is for broader messaging service
that uh supports cueing pub sub and more
advanced integration patterns so let's
talk about the storage queue side of it
so this can handle millions of messages
there's no guarantee of the order of
messages there's at least once delivery
which is really nice 500 terabytes max q
size 64 kilobyte message uh kilobyte
yeah kilobyte message um and 48
kilobytes if you're doing base64
encoding so that's the size it can be
after the encoding unlimited queues
unlimited concurrent clients uh at least
based access mode so we got 30 seconds
to seven days uh set for the entire
queue
and then on the right-hand side looking
after service bus we it can offer first
and first out which is uh very useful
guarantees the order of messaging be
being consumed that's what a first in
first out means at least once or at most
once delivery um we have one gigabyte to
80 gigabytes of max q size 256 kilobytes
to one megabyte so a lot larger than
azure storage queue we only have a
maximum of 10 000 max queues but that is
a lot of cues i don't know what you're
doing with ten more than ten thousand
five thousand concurrent clients uh lock
based access mode and that is um with 60
seconds can change settings per message
and it has dead letter uh support which
is very useful state managed support
message group support uh deduping
support purging uh queue support and
transaction supported so
um you know the thing is is that
it looks like service bus wins in all
categories but again remember that
storage queue is simple and but because
it's simple by design it can handle
millions of messages and if you don't
care about first and first out it makes
sense um so you really have to decide in
your use case there probably is a
pricing difference which we i think that
we do cover in this course but you know
hopefully you get an idea that these two
services do the same thing but in
different ways okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at azure queue
storage which is a simple uh message
queue that allows you to exchange cloud
messages it's used for application
integration between services and it
allows that via an authenticated https
endpoint or protocol and it can accept
messages of 64 kilobytes in size so the
q storage is a service or a product
underneath the azure storage account so
you first have to create a storage
account uh and then from there you
create your queue but you'll be using
the same access keys and connection
strings like the rest of the other
storage account resources
there are three ways of handling
messages for azure storage
azure queue storage the first is peak
and as it says it will retrieve or look
at a message in the queue without
removing or locking it you have delete
so that will delete a message
that is being processed and received so
that is a message in the front of the
queue uh but it gets locked temporarily
while it is being used okay um and just
to kind of give you a visual of how
simple it is to use this queue you can
uh in
the ui in the azure portal you can open
it up write a message set an expiry and
just say okay
but the way you're generally going to be
using it is not through
uh the ui because these are for
application integration that means
you're going to be
writing either sdk code or utilizing the
cli uh and i believe that azure queue
storage is uh one of the ones where you
can actually use cli we do cover that as
the difference between um the other
queueing service that you can use in
azure um but here's an example of the
azure sdk it's a python example so just
getting my pen tool out here it is a bit
brief but the idea is that we have our q
client we have our connection string url
which we're getting from our storage
account we're putting the name of the
queue and then we just send a message so
it's that simple and that is a python
example let's just talk about some of
the components within a queue there's
not a lot here
so it's not too complicated but the idea
is you have a queue this could be
accessed by using a url format of the
following so you'll have your storage
account here
qcor windows.net and then the queue name
um would this show up in the exam
probably not but it's generally good to
know just in case because azure exams
are very tricky
and then we have also this url here as
an example so
i think it's reflecting the example on
the right hand side here so the idea
here is that we have my accounts this is
my account and then we have images to
download so images to download would be
one particular
queue okay so just to kind of hit home
that url there
we have a storage account so this is
required
in order for us to make the queue as we
mentioned you have the queue itself this
contains a set of messages the queue
names must be in all lower case that's
just one of those
uh interesting um one of those
interesting use cases or edge cases
messages can be up to 64 kilobytes in
format so it's very small so this is
where you might want to use the other
queueing service uh within azure which i
can't remember but we do cover it when
we get to that section uh and there is
some um versioning that's a bit
different so if you're using uh before
2017 the ttl on it is a max of seven
days if you're using uh after 27 2017 um
it can be any positive number or
negative one indicating that they don't
expire and it doesn't say um i guess it
can be whatever number you want to be i
don't know what the maximum is but
i mean what's important to know is that
the old one gives you seven days so
you're going to be wanting to use the
latest version to have the most
flexibility the default time to live is
seven days if the parameter is not
specified which is totally fine let's
take a look at some of the cli commands
because uh you know what i'm making this
course is specifically for the az204 uh
which means developers so you're getting
lots of hands-on stuff so you should
really know these cli commands
we do cover them in the follow along
here but the idea is we have uh the az
storage because we're using storage
count message
actions so that's going to be
automatically for the queue
so we have clear so delete all messages
from the specified queue
uh delete to delete a specific message
get so retrieve one or remember messages
from the front of the queue
peak so retrieve one or more messages
from the front of the queue but do not
remove them do not change their
visibility do not lock them put so add
new messages to the back of the message
queue
update updates the visibility time of a
message so these systems are very very
very simple but they're also highly
scalable which is really great
um but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
learn all about storage queues so what i
want you to do is log into the azure
portal and at the top here type in q and
so that's going to show you it's going
to bring you to storage accounts because
it is not a separate service it's uh
underneath storage accounts so what
we'll do here is we'll create ourselves
a new storage account
so we'll hit new or create there give it
a moment to load and we're going to
create ourselves a new namespace i'm
going to call this one az204
um az204
azure storage
account
uh actually we'll just say um
storage account queuing or queue
we'll say okay
there this will be called uh az204
storage account queue
and it doesn't like
the hyphens maybe
there we go and we'll let it launch in
whatever region it wants to here it's
going to be e
east u.s for performance we'll stick
with standard we'll stick with a
redundancy of geo-redundant storage it's
not going to matter for those options
for using the queue we'll go to advanced
to see if there's anything interesting
there
nothing in particular i was just
checking if there's anything for the
queue so we'll go ahead and hit review
and create we'll scroll on down and hit
create and we'll give that a moment to
create
so
uh in order to
utilize the queue there isn't much in
the ui that we can do in the portal and
so we are going to need to utilize the
azure cli
so
um you know there's a few ways we can go
about this um we could launch up visual
studio code but since it's all cli
driven what i'm going to do is go ahead
and actually open up cloud shell and
that's the way we're going to interact
with it now this is your first time
spinning up cloud shell it might ask you
to create a storage account so just let
it do that
and now this resource is complete we'll
click into here
and on the left hand side we're going to
make our way over to cues
and i'm going to create a new queue i'm
going to call that my cue and we'll hit
ok
so
for this
you know there wasn't really a follow
along in the microsoft documents so i
just kind of made my own
and so for that information i have a
repository
and you'll find this throughout the
course
which is call i'm just looking up here
on the side here
the developer associate so some of these
are reworkings of microsoft ones or
they're my own creations so this one in
particular which is azure storage queue
is a bit more unique and so the things
that we're going to need to do is we're
you're going to need to have a
connection string in order for us via
the cli to connect it because all the
commands we're using like
put peak get all these things are going
to rely on it in terms of what we want
to run i'm going to type in azure
q
message cli because this is mostly what
you'll want to know how to use is how to
interact with messages there is a bunch
of different cli commands um for
azure storage like working with the
queue and stuff like that but i'd rather
just work with messages because that's
the only part that we can't do here and
that's where we need to understand the
difference between peak get
put and things like that so
the first thing we'll do is get a
connection string url and i believe that
is for the queue so we'll go into queue
here click into the queue
because sometimes it is
the access key that is um at the storage
account level and sometimes
like if you go here sometimes it is
so there's keys here sometimes it's the
cue
so i think
it is uh the q key that we want uh and
if it isn't we'll find out very shortly
here if we made a mistake so what we'll
do is we'll go back to our resources
here we'll click into the queue and in
the queue again and we'll look at access
policies and so we can add a policy here
nope you know what it was it absolutely
is the
storage account that we need so we go
down here and we type in access
and we have access keys
so here it is and between different
azure services sometimes this is called
access keys and sometimes it's called
something else we're going to discover
that as we do other follows just
understand this is not always consistent
based on
the ui but what we need is a connection
string
so we'll click show up here
and what we'll do is grab this string
and so what i want to do is type in
export
q connection string
equals and then double quotations very
important that you put those double
quotations
because if you don't this equals will
terminate here and it will only think
this is a part that is set here so i'm
going to hit enter and so that's going
to set us an environment variable uh for
this so if i did env hyphen grep and put
in this
this is how we can check if it was set
correctly
okay if you've never t have you ever
done this if you type in env that shows
all of your environment variables and so
all grep is doing is saying find the one
that's called this i could even do it
like this
right partially and it would return it
here so that's one thing the next thing
is we need the queue name so we named it
i believe my queue so if we go back to
our storage accounts here
and
let's just click back on here such a
pain sometimes clicking around here
we'll go to cues and we named it my cue
so i'm going to set export q name equals
and we don't need double quotations here
but i'm going to do it anyway my q will
make sure that is set correctly so we'll
type in grep
cue name and there it is
so some of the first commands we'll want
to use is things like put because put
will allow us to enter stuff in so we
said that there are these messages here
so we'll go to the put command here you
can see there's a lot of options when
you want to know what you need to put in
all i do is just copy the base thing and
paste it in
and then it'll just tell us
so i'll just give it a moment here
and so complains it says
we need um the queue name we need the
content
uh and i already know that we we need
the connection string url even though
it's not saying it there because it
might say hey you need actually down
here it says connection string
account name things like that
so um just to make this easier i'm gonna
go open editor here and this is a
terrible terrible editor but we're
working with uh like just some text here
it makes our lives a little bit easier
so what i want to do is just type it up
here
before we paste it and of course this is
all the repository but i'm just doing it
by hand and i recommend that you do it
by hand like i'm doing so that you have
a better chance to commit to memory so
we type in azure storage message message
put i'm going to do
a backslash so we can do multi-line here
we do connection string
equals and we set that as an environment
variable called uh
q
connection string when we do this dollar
sign that allows us to access the
environment variable
that we said earlier
and we did that is because we have to
run a series of commands and it was just
a lot easier to pass this in
consistently as opposed to passing in
that raw string every time so we need to
provide the queue name so this would be
q underscore name
and then we need to provide it content
so we'll say hyphen hyphen content
equals and i'm gonna say hello world
and so we will copy the contents there
i'm going to just type clear here so i
can see what i'm doing
we'll go ahead and paste that on in
there we'll hit enter
and uh yeah so it is now in the queue
now one thing that i was not able to
figure out was how do you observe how
many questions are in the queue i'm not
exactly sure so if we go into here i'm
not sure if we get any statistics
oh well we have a message right here so
we can see there is one in the queue but
what i was trying to say is that when i
was using the cli i was trying to find a
cli command uh to find that and i just
never did but it's nice to see that we
can see it visible here
in the actual console here i want to
have more than one message here because
i want to show you
how visibility works
and so what we'll do is just paste
command v there is no if you notice
right click there's no paste here which
is kind of weird and so i'm going to do
here hello mars
as our second one
and we'll copy this here copy it paste
it on below hit enter
and so now we have two queued up if we
refresh we can see we have two messages
in our cube we can even add a message
here if we wanted to so we could say
hello jupiter
and hit uh
[Music]
maybe i have to scroll down here
oh no it vanished i gotta do it again
maybe bring it down all the way down
here add message there we go hello
jupiter we'll say okay
and notice that we have some options
there where we can set the expires in x
amount of time or whether it never
expires and things like that
but anyway what we'll do is um
now we should probably attempt to peak
or get so what we'll do is go back to
the top here
because i think they list them out so
we have guests so retrieves one or more
message from the front of the queue and
then you have peaks it retrieves one
armor message from the front of the cube
but does not alter the visibility of the
message so when we say visibility the
idea is that when somebody accesses a
message
they're now looking at it right and so
nobody else can read it and the reason
why that happens is to avoid people two
people doing the same job by accident
but if we use peak that means that um it
doesn't become unvisible
um it will just remain the same so let's
do peak first
and so what we'll do is we'll just copy
this here
and paste this in
oh we have to control v there
and we'll just get rid of the content
line because we don't need to pass
content we still need the cue we still
need the connection string
and i'm going to change this to peak
and so what peak should do is it should
return us what's on the front of the
queue so this is the top up here
we'll go ahead and copy it then we'll
right click and paste down below we'll
hit enter and so we get hello world if
we were to hit up and run it again we
would still get hello world because it
has not been marked as
uh invisible right it's still visible so
now let's go ahead and change this to
get
oh we got to paste ctrl v
so we do get here
and
copy can
control c or command c depending on what
you're using and we'll paste that in
there and hit enter
and so now it says hello world as it did
before both times we ran hello world it
was always returning the same one
okay notice it says dq count is one so
we'll go here refresh
and notice that hello world is not
appearing now
right so it's because it's not visible
it's still there it's just not visible
right
um and so the next thing we can do is if
we
hit enter again
now types in hello mars
okay
and uh the next thing we can do here is
uh clear the queue if we want so that's
probably something that we should do
so if we were to go here and
copy this
type in clear
and hit enter
that should clear the entire queue
so hopefully that gives you an idea of
how the queueing system works
of course you can use the sdk so like if
we were to type in
azure storage queue
documentation
and we were to go to tutorials there's
probably samples there's probably like
examples i always go to javascript
because it's the easiest one to read
and if we go down to messages here
send a message
not really great that they don't have
this in line but the way it works is you
probably import the library at the top
so you'd install with npm install azure
storage queue you have the client the
credentials and then down below here
you're creating your message
i guess you have to create the client
queue first up here
and then you pass along your message
sent and then it says whether it's been
sent or not here you can see that
they're using peak
right very similar receive message all
very similar here
so hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea i think like forget or
sorry like um notice like it's called
receive message as opposed to get so in
the cli
uh we did get but this is really receive
right so just so that translates over
these queues are extremely simple but
they're designed to be extremely simple
when we look at service bus you'll see
that it's a lot more complex but one of
the key differences
at least pragmatically with service bus
and storage queue is that service bus
allows you to use the cli to insert
messages where when we do service bus we
have to write code using the sdk and we
will do that
but yeah that's all there is really to
this one that i want to show you what
we'll do is make our way over to our
resource groups
i'm going to just close off our shell
here we're going to look for the one we
just created here so this is azure
storage account cue
we'll go ahead and delete that
delete
and it should all be good of course
always double check five minutes from
now make sure that stuff is deleted
because azure is notorious for sometimes
not deleting things or you think that
things are being deleted but this won't
show up immediately it will take some
time to propagate through their servers
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at azure service bus so
azure service bus is a fully managed
enterprise message broker that allows
you to publish and subscribe to topics
and queue messages it can scale with
your applications with asynchronous
messages and built-in integration with
azure services so here is an example
of a service bus and so you know the way
it works is you have producers you have
consumers and so producers are sending
messages or events into an event bus the
event bus is designed to broker that
information so
pass it along to the ones that are
subscribed so these applications which
are consuming are subscribed to specific
messages and they pull data to um get
them into those and target end
applications some things we need to know
is you can handle single or batch
messaging load balancing messages topic
subscriptions manage uh managed sessions
and transactions with guarantees that it
compiles with industry standards and
protocols like the advanced message
queueing protocol so amqp
java message services so jms
and
other protocols there so they're just
saying like yeah if you're already using
very particular protocols you can
integrate with those let's talk about
key concepts for service bus so the idea
is that you have a namespace which works
like a server with nqs and topics you
have cues which contain the messages you
have senders who send the messages
receivers who receive the messages
topic which is a queue with multiple
receivers that work like a queue a
subscription is a receiver in a topic a
batch is a group of messages
a safe batch validates if each message
can be included in the batch
sessions allow you to use first and
first out and group your messages in a
queue
peak returns a message to the queue
without removing it dead letter q a
queue for messages that were unable to
be delivered through the normal queue
peak and lock so this retrieves a
message from the queue without removing
it and locks it so other receivers
cannot receive it receive and delete so
receives and deletes messages from the
queue
auto delete on idle so sets a time span
to delete the queue if not used
duplicate deletion detection history so
checks if the message was not sent
earlier before sending it a message so
there's a lot of stuff here
but don't worry we're going to kind of
cover it the most important stuff here
in the upcoming slides and in the fall
long okay
[Music]
let us talk about namespaces for azure
service but so simply put namespace is a
container for all messaging components
so cues and topics but there's uh you
know a few options here i don't have a
visual but there's some
text we have to go through here to
understand some of the things that
namespaces do so a single namespace can
contain multiple cues and topics and
namespaces are often used as application
containers so a service bus namespace is
a capacity slice of a large cluster made
up of a dozen of all active virtual
machines that you control
it may optionally span three
azs or availability zones in azure
you get all of the
the benefits of running the message
broker at massive scale in terms of
availability and robustness a service
bus is serverless messaging so you don't
need to worry about the underlying
complexity which is kind of interesting
because they're mentioning about
spanning across availability zones and
virtual machines but uh you know it's
just a component
that's you know you don't have to worry
about the management of it but you do
need to know a little bit about how it
works underneath but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cues for
azure service bus so there's two types
of uh messaging systems in azure service
bus why they didn't make these two
separate services i have no idea but
one is for messaging and one is for pub
sub and and the one that is for
messaging is called cues so cues are
used to send and receive messages
messages are stored in queues until the
receiving application is ready to accept
and process them messages and cues are
ordered and timestamped on arrival once
accepted by the broker the message is
always held durably in triple redundant
storage across uh multiple azs if
its namespace is zone enabled so if you
don't enable zone enabled at the name
space level you're not going to get that
kind of durability or redundancy service
bus never leaves messages in memory or
volatile storage after they've been
reported to the client is
accepted
and messages are delivered in pull mode
only delivering messages when requested
that's the key difference between a
queue and pub sub cue uh the receiver
you know the application has to pull say
hey are there any messages in the queue
and that's how they get them in a pub
sub model they just get it sent to them
like a
subscription like a newsletter
subscription to your door let's take a
look at the queue configuration itself
so you can see we can set the delete max
delivery count things like that the
queue size
important things to note is the ttl so
how long a message will stay in the cube
before it's removed from the queue or
removed or moved to dead letter q
you can enable dead lettering down below
you can enable partitioning here you can
set the lock duration very similar to
what we'll see for uh pub sub i think at
the subscription level but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
taking a look at topics so topics can be
used to send and receive
messages and the idea here is you have a
queue which is often used to
facilitate point-to-point communication
and topics are useful in publish to
subscribe so one-to-many communication
so if you want one-to-one communication
use cues if you want pub sub then you
use topics and both these options are
available for azure service bus so
topics are not available at the basic
pricing tier you need to have standard
or premium so if you're trying to find
that option for pub sub that's where
we're going to have it remember that we
said that
queues use a poll model well topics use
a push model so you don't have to
request it just gets pushed out to you
because they're subscribed to it like
having a newsletter delivered to your
door so multiple independent
subscriptions can be attached to a topic
and work in the same way as cues from
the receiver's side a subscriber to a
topic can receive a copy of each message
sent to that topic subscriptions are
named as entities and so here's an
example of sender and receiver you can
define rules on a subscription
a subscription rule has a filter that
specifies a condition for a message to
be copied into the subscription as well
as an optional action that modifies
message
metadata so let's take a look at what
the form is for topic so the idea is you
name your topic you have a max size
between one to five gigabytes you can
have a time to live so after that period
of time those those messages or event
data is just goes poof so it's just gone
you can
avoid duplication by turning on enabled
duplication or duplicate detection you
can enable partitioning and partitioning
is intended for scale so if you have a
lot of messages
you might need to partition
based on your volume okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look at subscriptions
for azure service bus so i just pulled
up the form here because a subscription
is just the um
the application that is receiving that
information so you just define one
in the interface here but there are some
values that i want to point out such as
max delivery count which can be between
one to two thousand uh this managed
session so with sessions enabled the
subscription can guarantee first in
first out so fifo delivery messages so
that is where that gets turned on you
can also enable dead lettering here
um and you can have a lock duration and
adjust that there which you know i
didn't highlight here but it's here
there but we will see these things a
little bit closer when we do the fall
longs but yeah a subscription is you
know
an application that is
receiving information getting pushed
information to it that it will use okay
let us explore the pricing for azure
service bus so they have three different
pricing tiers basic standard and premium
the more expensive tiers provide more
functionality which i would hope that
would always be the case for most
services but on the right hand side we
have our available pricing uh and you
can see it's based on
a metric so like mu's per per month and
things like that or operations per month
and so here is the chart so let's take a
look at what the differences are so i
highlighted topics in yellow to show you
that it is not basic it's not in the
basic tier you have to have standard in
order to utilize that and you know for
your purposes as a
person learning as a service bus you
absolutely need to
uh give topics and queues a go because
qs is the classic messaging model and
topics is pub sub and the only way
you're going to do that is by using
standard which we will do in the follow
alongs but notice in basic we don't get
topics transactions deduping sessions
for to send via no resource isolation
geo disaster recovery java messaging
support az support and then some of
those aren't supported in standard but
then in
[Music]
premium we get basically everything and
then notice like the big bump in terms
of the message size between basic
standard and premium so
again the thing i really want to
remember is that
in basic there are no topics okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at dead
letter q this is just a general concept
that is common for messaging's pub sub
systems
and is enabled in azure service bus for
both queues and pub sub but a dead
letter queue is a service implementation
to store messages that fail to deliver
and common reasons for failed messages
would be things like message that is
sent to a queue that does not exist
the queue length limit is exceeded the
message length limit is exceeded the
message is rejected by another queue
exchange
the message reaches a threshold read
counter number because it's not consumed
sometimes this is called a blackout
queue or backup queue sorry
the message expires due to per message
ttl so time to live
the message is not processed
successfully so dead letter queues hold
messages that uh that have failed to
deliver a dead letter queue could be
used for things like monitoring failed
attempts requesting failed attack
re-cueing failed attempts so try it
again or trigger a follow-up action so
maybe a remediation or a response so
very useful feature but there you go
[Music]
let us talk about azure service bus
command cli or cli commands because if
you are doing the az204 the developer
it's very important to know these these
commands because they may ask you them
so here i have a bunch of example
commands so just quickly looking at this
here we have creating a resource group
creating a service bus namespace a queue
an authorization rule
and so it's pretty straightforward you
know az service bus etc let's take a
look at
some commands we should know or sub
commands i should say so
when we say command the command is
service bus and the sub command is what
follows that so we have ones for geo
recovery alias so we want to set the geo
recovery for it we don't have an example
here on the right hand side for
migrations uh for namespace for queue
for topic and so on the right hand side
there we have one for namespace we have
them one for creating a queue
but you'll notice here that we don't
have anything that kind of manipulates
or adds messages to cues so the azure
service bus does not have cli commands
to send messages to the keyword topic
unlike azure storage queue which i found
out which was kind of interesting so to
send messages to the queue you need to
use an sdk like node.js so you'd install
it
and then you'd have to
write some code and we do do that in the
follow along but i just want you to
remember that
azure service bus you cannot send
messages to the queue or topics via the
cli
and you know that kind of sucks because
you know if you want to do some easy
test uh it's unfortunate that
functionality is not there but anyway
that's the difference between that and
azure storage queue so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to take a look at
service bus so what i want you to do is
type in service plus at the top here
what's interesting is that this is the
old icon they have a new icon so just
realize that there's some
inconsistencies there and that's not my
fault that's azure's fault
but the first thing we need to do is
create a namespace because a service bus
is kind of like you know storage account
where you can have a variety of
different kinds of storages well you can
have uh more than one type of messaging
system and so we have our traditional
one uh like event messaging similar to
storage cube but with first and first
out functionality and we have pub sub
via topic so what you'll do is create a
new service bus namespace
and i'm going to create a new resource
group and call this the az204
um
service bus
and we'll say message or sorry cue
because we're going to do a queue and
then we're going to do a topic
separately
and for this i'm going to call the
namespace
service bus queue to keep it simple
we'll let it launch wherever it wants to
launch and notice there are multiple
pricing tiers
depending on the tier affects the
functionality so if we do basic we're
only going to have access to queue we're
not going to have access to
um
topics and so this is totally safe and
fine to do
like even if we did premium it's fine
because it's based on your consumption
it's not based on um you know you're
just having it holding around so we'll
get the basic one here and we'll go to
networking i don't think there's
anything interesting there we'll go
ahead and review and create
and we'll let that create click create
again
and it's deploying as that is deploying
which will not take too long what i've
done is set up a private repository here
you'll probably see me use this
throughout the course it's literally an
empty repository because i already have
the code done i've been doing the
follow-alongs and documenting them here
in the free azure developer associate
but when you're doing follow-ons with me
you should do them with uh do them from
scratch and then if you need to you can
reference the stuff here so um i have
this separate repository i have a git
pod account which has a free tier you
can totally do this in your own visual
studio code on your little local machine
the reason i'm doing a git pod is i
always want to show you how to set up
the cli and those other tools
and when you launch git pod it gives you
a blank environment so i'm just going to
launch that up there as that's going
we'll go back here and take a look and
see if this is ready just hit refresh
here it is still going
but we already have our environment and
while that is going in the background i
want to go install the azure cli so we
don't even have a single file here i'm
just going to say readme.md so i can see
what is going on here
maybe we'll just dump things in here as
we go i'm going to go get the azure
cli
linux because this is running linux
ubuntu
here so something you should always
check is like
what linux version
am i running if you're on windows of
course this is going to be different but
even windows using the windows subsystem
linux is using ubuntu as well so what
i'll do here i'll go to the first link
nope that's not the one i want maybe the
second one
there's usually like a command here i
can run uh
which
linux version
am i running
let's try this one here
it's usually like
so maybe it says here cat proc version
it really does vary based on what you're
using and so here i'm going to go file
uh or sorry terminal new terminal
we'll paste that in there hit enter and
so here it says linux 513 ubuntu
11. uh 18 so
[Music]
i know that this is ubuntu
i don't really like that one there
um
let's try this instead
because this just doesn't read very well
there we go we're running ubuntu 2004 i
already knew that
um but i just want to double check and
the reason that matters is that when
you're installing the cli it might
matter what version you're using
so we're going to go here and i'm going
to go to linux and the instructions
might vary this one says 16 18 20. so
they're all the same here and we have
this one liner here that we'll install
and what i'll do here is drop it in here
and hit
enter not sure if this font is too small
so while that's going i'm going to see
if i can bump up our font here
i'm looking for the terminal font size
here terminal
let's just say 20 here
there we go
and so the azure cli should be installed
so i'll just type in clear so let's say
azure
or az to run it
looks good to me so we'll type in azure
login um i don't want to log in with
um that way i want to log in with device
so we'll do a z login device because
if you're on your regular computer you
can just click a button and go to the
browser but i'm not gonna be able to do
that so i'm gonna have to do a device
login
device
well i'll have to do it the wrong way
first to do it the right way
so hit enter because the problem is if i
go here it's going to go to localhost
because it's trying to launch in my
local machine
so it does that and that's no good and
so here it says do the az login use
device code okay so that's the one i
really wanted to use
so hyphen typing use device code enter
and that will give us a code so what we
do is we will need uh this link here so
i'll have to expand that
to here
and then i'm going to go ahead and grab
that code
continue
let's now go back this will authenticate
it'll just take a second here
close the tab here there we go maybe i
have to close the tab
uh and so now i'm authenticated so i
should be able to uh do whatever i want
um what i need to do next
is
create ourselves a message queue so
we'll go to the resource here
and notice here the entities it always
says q now if we had
uh other than the basic the standard
plan then we would see topics here
we'll go click into q click create a new
queue i'm going to call it my queue
we have some options here the queue size
can go up to five gigabytes the max
delivery count so this is the maximum
deliveries uh time to live that is how
long they live in the queue before they
are dropped out or they are dropped into
a dead letter uh a system there we have
lock duration so the set the amount of
time a message is locked for other
receivers you can enable partitioning uh
that's pretty complicated but we'll go
ahead and create our cue
and so this should be pretty darn quick
there is our q we'll click into it and
you'll notice that there isn't really a
way to view messages there's not a way
to
add messages uh here we have the service
bus explorer
which
i guess technically you can send and
receive here i had not noticed this
before at least it was not working for
me so i suppose we could send a message
here saying like hello world
this literally wasn't here last time i
checked here um
and we can go ahead and just hit
send
okay and notice here it says there's one
active message and we can receive it say
yes
and so
it says it received the message it's not
showing us the answer
so i guess there kind of is something
here i guess they're still working on it
but uh mostly what we're going to have
to do is do things programmatically
so that is why we have this account so
what i want you to do is open a new tab
here we're going to type in azure
service bus
documentation because we're going to
grab some code there modify it make it
our own so it's a bit easier to work
with so here i'm in the service bus
we'll go to tutorials
i'm not sure if this one is the right
one
azure service bus documentation queue
it's the same thing here
but this doesn't look right
what is service bus
i mean it is the right page but it had a
couple tutorials here
uh that i had here so we'll type in like
azure service bus uh tutorial
topics
sometimes things aren't where you think
they're supposed to be
okay i'll type in service bus
seems like the same page again
oh it was quick starts sorry so we have
tutorials here and then we have quick
start so under the quick starts this is
where i was finding uh the example code
that i thought was okay notice that we
could do everything via the cli um that
is not that fun but i mean this only
does the creation of it doesn't
necessarily do sending and receiving
messages notice so that we only can use
code so we'll use javascript because i
think that will be the easiest to use uh
so i already have node node comes
pre-installed on git pod you'll have to
figure that out for yourself on your own
machine or you can just use git pod as
well because it does have a generous
free tier what i'll do is go ahead and
paste on in
this command it doesn't seem to want to
paste today so i'll hit copy
and then we'll go back here and go right
click
enter paste hit enter and so what that
will do is install that library
if you're not very familiar with node.js
package.json is the package manager and
this is showing that this requirement is
there i want to install one other thing
uh called env this will make our lives a
lot easier
um
for
node it comes for different things but i
just wanted for
javascript here so then we'll do npm
install emv hyphen save
that's just a safe way for us to pass
along our environment variables and so
now both of these are installed so what
we'll do is we'll go back over to this
code and we'll scroll on down and they
have one called send and they have one
called receive so what i'll do is create
myself a couple files here so we'll have
send.js
and we'll have receive.js
and then what we'll do is go ahead and
copy this is the send code so we'll put
this in the send js file
and then down below we have the receive
code
and we will paste that on in there so
i'll just make this bigger and we'll
take a quick look here at what it's
doing so what this does is it imports
the sdk for service bus we need to set a
connection string we need to set the
queue name here is a bunch of messages
that we are going to be passing along
here we establish a service bus client
very common in all sdks to set up a
client first then we are creating a
sender and then here we are doing uh
create batch messages so it's a way of
sending messages in batch very
efficiently so we have a for loop here
and
uh so it says there's a batch
and then it says try to add the message
to the batch if it's not wait until it's
ready then send the message
okay so pretty straightforward for that
code receive is going to be similar
so connection string queue name create
that client create a receiver
and then from there we will set up a
handler for the receiver an error and so
then we'll subscribe and we will listen
for the message and handler so even
though
we are doing cues it's called a
subscription still so just don't get too
mixed up with that
what i want to do is just make sure that
we're passing our environment variables
in safely our configuration so this is
pretty standard or
good best practices when working with
any language the idea is you don't want
to hard code your values so i'm going to
do process env
and we'll do connection string here
and then we'll do
process env
cue name this is the way you grab
environment variables in javascript for
every language it's a little bit
different
okay
and i believe these are the same so i'm
just going to go ahead and grab that
there like this
and i'll paste that on in here
and i want to load environment variables
so i'll make a new file here called env
this is all part of that env dot thing
then we're looking at emv dot
i'm just pulling that up again here
or dot env you're gonna get the right
one
because we need this line here require
dot
uh dot env config that will load the
environment variables uh it'll load it
from that env
file so we will go above here and hit
paste
and then we'll go to the receive here
and do this as well
and in here we need to define these so
i'm just going to copy this so i don't
have to type it out by hand we will
paste that on in here and so i just need
the q q name
and connection string we'll just say
equals and then equals
so our q is called my q
and then we need to go grab the
connection string
so i'm just thinking here this is
probably yeah it's at the name space
level
and we'll go to shared access policies
notice it's called shared access
policies remember when we're doing the
storage key it was like called key
access so it's totally different
interface this is what i'm talking about
where
azure is inconsistent we're clicking on
the root manage shared access key
probably could create your own so it
doesn't have full privileges but for
this purpose we're just going to use
this one on the left hand side we have a
primary and secondary we're going to use
the primary one
and we will go back here and we will
paste on that value in
so i'll paste that in there notice we
don't have to do double quotations here
it should
already escaping double quotations but
we're doing the cli when we did the
storage accounts that wasn't something
that we could do um so we have these two
values here so they should get loaded
when we use them
and this should all be good so we'll
type in node send js and hopefully it
just works
fingers crossed and so it sent a batch
of messages to the queue so we'll go
back over to our queue here and see if
we can see anything
and we'll click into here
i'm just trying to see so there's 10
active messages that are here right now
and so what we'll do is we'll receive
all those messages so we'll go up and
hit node
receive js
and so this code is now receiving those
messages from
the service bus queue and we're just
going to wait here because it takes time
for whatever reason to
finish here but we'll give it a little
bit of time here to figure out that it's
done
still waiting
there we go and so
that's all there really is to it so
that is q and we will do this again but
next time with topics
so what i want you to do is make your
way over back to your resource groups
we'll find the one that we just created
which was uh this one here
az204 service bus queue
we'll delete this service group
hit delete delete and there you go and
as always double check to make sure that
you've uh for sure delete that stuff
and that's it for
service bus q will do topics next okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at service bus and
this time we're looking at topics so
what i want you to do just like before
is go to the top we'll type in service
bus
and we'll go to the service bus service
you can still see the old one is there
it should be deleting that's how slow
this thing is but we'll create a new one
and we will create a new resource group
and we will call it az204
service bus topic we'll say okay we'll
name this service
bus topic
and this time it already exists if it
does just dump a bunch of numbers here
on the end
because it's unique based on that so
that's not having a domain name if
somebody has it you're gonna have a
problem and so here i'm going to go to
standard because in order for us to use
those additional features we will need
to be on the standard plan so we'll go
ahead and hit review and create
and that'll take a little bit of time to
create but while that's going i'm going
to
launch my environment here so this was
the one i was just using a moment ago
with github and so what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to go back to our repo
here i'm just doing it off screen
because i don't want to expose all my
stuff here
and again if you want to you can do this
in your local
visual studio code i just want to show
everything from scratch every time so
here's my empty repo with git pod and so
i'll just close this one and it will
vanish all that code is now gone i'll
let get pod this will launch a new
environment it's trying to tell me to
open the last one nope i'm gonna make a
new one for this workspace here and
we'll get going here in a moment so this
namespace has been created so we'll go
ahead and hit create
and
uh i guess it's still making i thought i
already deployed it there but i guess i
didn't
okay while that's going we'll go ahead
and install the azure cli so we'll type
in azure cli linux because that is what
we're using here today
we'll go to linux here we'll scroll on
down grab this one liner here to install
it i'm going to open up my terminal
your terminal might be somewhere else
allow i'm going to go ahead and paste
that on in there that's going to install
our azure cli
as that's installing it will be done
here in a moment
let's see if this is done this is still
creating the
namespace i think
and this is still installing shouldn't
take too long
while this is going we can start
grabbing the code for this so for this
we'll type in azure um azure
service bus
documentation and this i found it under
the quick start
so we will go to quick start serve
topics and services because there's some
code here that i want under the
javascript
and we have one for
send to topic so we'll just grab that
name there
make a new file sent to topic.js
and we'll go down here to this other one
this is
receive from subscription you're going
to notice this is very similar to doing
a queue
the difference is that you can have
multiple subscriptions consume
the same stuff
our cli is done so we'll type in a z
login um
i can't remember what it is we'll hit
enter here i know this is the wrong way
but i just can't remember what it is i
want use device code that's what it is
so i'll go ahead and grab this
and i'll just hit ctrl c to exit out of
that and then paste that in there
and then we'll do it the way that we
actually want to do it so then we'll go
ahead and grab this for device login
we will provide the code as suggested
here
we will hit
continue we will close this
and it will say that we are
authenticated so we are now
authenticated we can use at az
or the azure cli
um
i don't know if we need the cli well we
have it anyway at least we had to
authenticate so at least that was out of
the way i'm not sure we're actually
going to use the cli in this one
um but what we'll do is go to the
resource here
and we want to create a topic this time
around and i'm going to call this my
topic
we have a topic size between one to five
you have a ttl
you can do
make sure there aren't duplicates we're
gonna go ahead and create this topic
okay so just like last time we need to
install a couple things
so if we go to the top here this should
be like an npm install here it is npm
install service bus
so we'll paste that on in there
we'll need our dot env so lookup.env
again and we will just install
npminstall.env
for environment variables hit enter
we'll create ourselves a new.env
file and we will need to look at what
environment variables we are going to
need so uh looks like we didn't copy the
send to topic content at least i didn't
so we will go back over to here and go
up here and get sent to topic
paste that on in there
we'll go all the way to the top and i'm
looking for what we need here so here we
have one which is
connection string whoops
do not mean to delete all that so we'll
hit process env
connection string
and we have to spell it right or it's
going to have a problem
and then we have process env
topic name
i think in this one it actually also has
subscriptions so we'll have to have a
third one so i'm just going to copy
these two over so i'm to
type it 100 times
and this one will be
process env subscription name you're
noticing i'm not having the um semicolon
that is optional in javascript so it
won't break anything if i don't have
them there
subscription name
and so these are the three that we'll
need i'm gonna just split this to make
my life a little bit easier and i'm just
gonna copy this here paste
not exactly how i wanted to paste it but
that's totally fine
i'm gonna copy
this i don't think we made a
subscription yet but i know we're going
to call it my subscription to make our
lives easy
so we'll say
my topic
my subscription
and we'll grab this in a moment so we'll
go back over
to
azure we got too many tabs open here
while we're here we might as well go
grab this code um before we go back to
azure so i'm going to grab this dot env
config that is going to load
our configure
configuration environments so we go to
the top here
paste that on in there for both files
again best practice never to hard code
your values always pass it in like that
with environment variables we'll go back
to our service bus the first thing we
need well we made a topic we're going to
need a subscription so if we go to topic
here
and click into it we can create
ourselves a subscription so we'll go
here we'll say my subscription
notice we have max delivery account we
have to set this between a value of 1
and two thousand i'm going to say 12 for
fun
we can set the idle notice here if we
want to
have first and first out we would check
box enable sessions we're going to leave
that alone
does not matter too much for our demo
so we'll go ahead and create that
subscription it is created now what i
need you to do is go back to the service
bus topic namespace
and from there on the left hand side
we're going to shared access policies
we're going to click into the root
manage shared access we're going to grab
the primary connection string key the
secondary would work too it's just and
second optional one because they always
give you a two
we'll paste that on in there
and if this is all correct this should
just work so now what we'll do is type
in
node
um actually we did want the cli
installed because i wanted to show you
uh that there was stuff in the queue
whereas with um storage queue uh when
we're doing azure storage queue i
couldn't show you because um i just
didn't know of a command i believe at
least i think that was the case but hey
we'll take a look and see what we can
see okay
um so
actually we didn't do it at any time i
wonder which one i did that for let's
just double check here i have um
off-screen here somewhere
[Music]
my instructions because i run it for one
of these maybe it was for the queue that
we did it
yeah i didn't do the last one but i did
an azure service bus q show and the idea
was to show you that there was a message
count ten so you could see the queue but
i think that since we saw it in the ui i
just wasn't too worried about it now did
i do it for this one i'm not sure yeah
we do a topic show so we'll do that for
fun
but first we need to insert our messages
which are part of the topic send i don't
think we read through these so let's
just quickly read they look very very
similar to the last one so you have your
messages that you want to send you
create yourself a client
you create yourself a sender you create
a batch message send message
like it's basically identical
like i can't even tell the difference
here except here we're supplying a topic
name so
um
i mean i see it here
ah here create sender the topic name is
specified there so i just imagine that
instead of providing a topic name you
provide the queue name and that's how it
knows the difference but anyway what
we'll do is go ahead and execute this
code we'll say node send to topic
js
okay so it sent the stuff now we didn't
do this last time so let's do it this
time around so we'll type in azure
service bus topic show
and here we'll need to set the resource
group so
this was called i don't know let's go
take a look here
what is our service group called
it is called az204
bring that down a bit here az204
service bus topic we need to specify the
namespace
name
so that's just called service
bus topic hyphen
because we couldn't get the number we
want and then we need to specify the
name so
i assume it's the name of the topic so
the top is my topic and i'll hit enter
and it says service business name is
misspelled
or not recognized by the service did you
mean service
bus
yeah i gotta spell that right hit enter
and that looks fine but i just want to
specify it as output yaml just hit up on
your keyboard if you want to go back to
those previous commands let enter so
this is a little bit easier to read
and so what we're looking for here is
just kind of like the message count
does it show us here is the description
count
i don't see it
so i guess it's not visible in the same
way as uh the queue is like if we did
this and we didn't do the last one it
would we just thought like that message
count there
but let's take a look at what we can see
in the cli to just see what information
or a ui that our portal so we can see
some information here so we have one
subscription here we'll click into here
um we have max size
incoming request 12.
um
yeah i don't really see it message count
max delivery count 12.
okay so i guess there was 10 and that's
the 12. so i guess that's where it's
being counted let's go run the other one
to receive i'm going to just double
check to make sure that we set those we
did that's all good
so we'll type in node receive
if you're wondering how i'm auto
complaining without typing that i just
hit tab on my keyboard so it's receiving
those
good and that finish i'm going to go
ahead refresh see if there's any
difference here
notice that the message count is zero so
when the topics were there it was held
in the subscription saying 10 is here
and they've yet to be delivered when we
ran it they were received and so that
number cleared out that's all we really
need to learn for um uh topics so we are
done with topics so let's make our way
over to resource groups
and we'll go over to our service bus
topic
go ahead and delete this here
there it is deleting we are all good to
go
um and you know just as always don't
ever trust azure to delete these things
go back and check in three four minutes
make sure it's deleted so you just don't
have things lingering around
but yeah there you go
[Music]
all right let us compare event grid
event hubs and service bus because these
all are event driven services for
application integration and use event
buses as a means to work with event data
but it gets confusing because i guess
you could say they all have overlapping
responsibilities so let's kind of clear
that up so we have event grid event hubs
and azure service bus so the idea is
that event grid is a serverless event
bus
and i would say that you'd probably want
it for azure service to service
communications the idea is that you just
have let's say
you know you're like integrating from
service to service so you're not
deploying necessarily fully custom web
applications uh or traditional
applications onto virtual machines it's
more for like uh cloud native cloud
first kind of builds
they're dynamically scalable they're low
cost at least one once delivery of a
message
for event hubs this is streaming data so
we get low latency can receive and
process millions of events per second at
least once per delivery of an event and
streaming you know because of the nature
of it is generally more expensive than
traditional things like
aq or a pub sub for web applications
which is what a azure service bus is so
reliable asynchronous message delivery
that requires polling and i guess
pushing technically for pub sub advanced
messages features like first in first
out batching sessions transactions dead
lettering temporal control routing
filtering uh duplicate uh detection at
least once delivery of a message so it
really sounds like and there's one
option here or optional order delivery
of message so it sounds like azure
service bus has it all but really it's
not it's not at the same scale as event
hubs and it's not at the same like level
of
um
like hands-off kind of approach that
event grid gives you with serverless
but you have all those options there and
you will use them all but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at the
introduction to redis so what is redis
well redis is an open source in-memory
database store and it acts as a caching
layer or a very fast database it has a
lot of utility but those are the two
most common
and one thing is that because it's in
memory
that data is highly volatile so there is
a chance of a data loss so even though
it is super fast within milliseconds
like five milliseconds 10 milliseconds
um you know it's not used as a primary
database but you know there are tools
out there that have made them more
durable uh so it really is up to you uh
but the other thing about redis is that
it's a key value store so uh it's not
like using a relational database um and
so it has its own type of data
structures data types so we have string
sets sorted sets lists hashes bitmaps
bit fields
hyperlogs geospatial indexes streams uh
and the ones in red i do want to go over
with you because i think they're worth
your time but the idea is that to use
redis you're either going to use
like a programming library they're
pretty much available in every language
um and or you could use the redis cli so
getting my pen tool out here for a
second here you can see we're logging to
the right of cli we're doing a ping to
the server it gives back a pong uh and
here we're setting a simple key value so
we say my key some value some value is
the string we are setting and so it is
that simple it's a very simple database
but it's super super fast but let's take
a look at some of those data structures
or data types so we can see uh how we're
going to interact with this database
all right let's take a look at our
different types of data types data
structures that we have available to us
in redis the first is strings the most
basic one the most important one because
everything is basically strings at the
end of the day here in redis strings are
binary safe so they can contain data
such as jpeg image serialized ruby
objects so they can represent different
things that can represent numbers which
is kind of odd and strings have a max
length of 512 megabytes to get a lot of
room there often you're doing a get in
the set here so you say get
uh you know get this uh key you get back
that string set this key with that value
so very simple to use um strings can
represent numbers and so now you have
these special functions for strings
called atomic counters so you can do
things like increment decrement uh
increment by certain amounts so very
very clear here so notice it is a string
but we can increment it and now return
11. and it interprets it as an integer
which is
interesting there so the most common
string commands would be things like get
set
append depend would just add something
to the end of the string or check check
if a string exists based on a key so it
exists you have lists so lists are
ordered collection of strings uh they're
not going to give you a guarantee of
unique uh
unique strings or unique uh elements
within that list there so you can have
duplicates but um
you do things like l push l range it's
kind of like having an array uh in other
languages here they're doing a range
notice it does negative one but it
actually returns all of them so that's
kind of a trick there to
uh get
all the elements in a range but you
could say like one to two and then it
would just return one and two
common commands for lists would be l pop
r pop l push l uh
uh pos was just for position so el pop
would uh remove the last element and
return it uh or on the left hand side so
the first one our pop would be on the
right hand side so if you did an l pop
and return hello you did an rpop will
return world and also remove it from the
list l push would add a new thing on the
end help uh pause is creating a position
so you provide a string it'll tell you
it's positioned in the list then you
have sets so
seems like they're like lists but
they're unordered so there's no
guarantee that if you request the stuff
in the list it's going to be in the
order that you expect it but
the advantage though is that things are
unique in the list so if you push the
same thing
you add the same thing to that set
like world twice it'll only be there
once that's when you need a unique
amount of things
in a collection there most common
commands here is s add so add a member s
members show us all the members s move
move a member from a from one set to
another s pop similar to
um
our pop uh like what we saw with um list
so just remove the
one or or multiple random members from a
set
we have
hashes so hashes represent a mapping
between string fields and string values
um redis was originally
coded in ruby so they're basically like
ruby hashes
but if you don't know ruby hashes
there's json objects probably seen those
before ruby hashes of course python
dictionary so the idea is that you set a
you say okay i'm making a hash i'm going
to set a field which is just a key it's
string field two uh and it's value there
so um pretty straightforward common
commands for hashes would be like h h
get to get a value hdl to delete a value
hm set to set multiple values hm get to
set or to get multiple values
um
h valves to get only the values h key
or probably keys to get uh
only the
the fields which are keys in this case
here we have sorted sets so these are
similar to um sets
but um
they have an associated score so when
you add something you use a zed ad for
this but you put it you give it a score
like here one one two
and uh these are really great for
leaderboards um or where you need to
score things and sort that way so common
commands here would be things like zed
ads to add something with a with a
certain score
z rem is for removing
z range is when you want to return a
range of elements in a sorted set score
zed rank would be return the rank of a
member in the sword set score uh uh
set sorted so it's not giving you i said
sort of stored but it's sorted so it's
not giving you its score it's giving you
where it's ranked within the list
and then you have z-score and so that
that you provide um
the
the value and it would tell you what its
score is so those are all the data types
that you should get some hands-on with
there are some interesting ones like
stream and things like that but uh
this is pretty much the core stuff for
redis redis is not hard to learn or use
um so you just gotta jump in there and
use it okay
[Music]
all right so we just took a look at
redis now let's talk about azure cash
for redis so azure cash for redis is
based on the popular open source redis
cash or data store it gives you access
to secure dedicated redis cache that
microsoft manages and that you can
access from any azure application all
major cloud service providers have a
managed redis
service or database because it's just
super useful and we'll talk about the
use cases here in a moment azure cache
for redis is suited for high throughput
and low latency requirements where the
same data is often requested so remember
those key three things to know when
you're supposed to use
reddit there are
serverless databases
um
like nosql databases sorry that
can operate extremely quickly
like with a guarantee of a certain
amount of time but
redis is just like super fast it's
faster than everything else out there
because it's in memory
azure cache for redis is commonly used
for these scenarios and i really do want
you to pay attention because these are
very common very practical and as a
developer you really should know these
so
the a very common use case is storing
session data if you have a web
application and it's deployed to uh
multiple virtual machines um a hard part
about having an application running
across multiple virtual machines or
containers is that um knowing what was
the last like where the where the
session is stored the actual uh state of
a user and so you can't have it running
on one virtual machine because then the
other ones won't know about it so you
need to store it somewhere else so redis
is a very common use case for that
storing cached html or json uh this very
common use case to speed up response
times another thing that we normally see
would be mem
uh
memory dme mdb
it's another caching solution
specifically for html um but yeah this
is something you put in front of your
web application to
speed up web pages or api calls another
one is a job or message queueing system
if you are in the ruby on rails world a
very common queueing system is called
sidekick and it uses
redis or another thing again in ruby on
rails if you want to use action cable
which is for doing pub sub like real
time like building a chat like a chat
system or a game that's backed by redis
um so those solutions aren't going to
change you can usually use redis for
those things another one is using it to
be in front of a database to reduce
recontention recontention means like too
many reads are hitting the database so
it's slowing everything down so you can
put a cache in front of that to improve
response times for fetching data to
just take uh take the load off the
database maybe you have a database
that's expensive to call
so it's going to save you money
and so you can put this in front of
cosmodb or azure sql very common
cases or any kind of database really
that returns data
and so this is actually called the aside
cache pattern something you want to kind
of remember uh where
it's going to sit in front of the
database so if the date if the data is
up to date um
and it's there in the the redis store
it'll take it from there if not it'll go
to the database and the database can be
proactive and send data to redis so that
it doesn't have to
do a hit or miss it can just have the
data there knows that it's there
just to kind of visualize this just to
see where those are
so i'm just gonna get my pen tool out
here so the first is like
where uh um
redis or azure cache redis is sitting
between your application and the request
so maybe you're hosting on azure app
services the idea is that before
um a request makes it into your
application it's going to check that
cache and so that can reduce the load on
your application improve the load times
if if there's things that are
computationally expensive
then there's your database so over here
between your application to your
database
it's going to hit the redis cache first
if there's data it will return it if
there's not it will go straight to the
database and then the other common use
case here is to have a fast database for
real-time data maybe for queuing
jobs um
video games leaderboards things like
that so
uh yeah that's pretty much it for azure
cashflow redis just gotta get some
hands-on experience with it but very
simple uh not too complicated very
useful
[Music]
you